hey this is andrew brown your cloud
instructor exam pro bringing you another
complete study course and this time it's
the exampro cloud developer environment
certification made available to you here
on freecodecamp so this course is
designed to help you pass and achieve
example issued certification and the way
we're going to do that is by going
through a lecture content doing follow
alongs within our own account uh doing a
practice exam so that we're preparing
for the day of the exam and also
utilizing cheat sheets so that you can
cram some last minute information so
that you're able to pass that exam and
improve on your resume and on your
linkedin you've got that cloud developer
knowledge so you can get that cloud job
or that promotion so i'm andrew brown i
was previously the cto of multiple
edtech companies with 15 years industry
experience five years specializing in
cloud i'm an awesome community hero and
i've published many many free courses
just like this one and if you ever want
to buy me drink i love coconut water i
want to take this moment to thank
viewers like you because it's you that
make these free courses possible and the
best way you can support more free
courses like this one is to buy the
additional study material so that is the
link there at the exp cd01 where you can
get study notes flash cards quizlets
downloadable lecture slides downloadable
cheat sheets prax exams you can ask
questions get learning support and it's
all free to sign up yeah just to even
get your prax exam cheat sheets so it
requires no credit card there's no trial
limit so there's no reason not to sign
up um and if there are updates to this
course look in the in the youtube
comments to see when there is an update
and this is where we would see things
like corrections additions modifications
to ensure that you're using the latest
version of this course and if you want
to keep up to date on upcoming courses
the best way to find out is to follow me
on twitter and share with me what you
passed and what you'd like to see next
so there you go let's get to it
journey asking the most important
question first which is what is the
cloud developer environment
certification so the cloud developer
environment or cde is a practical cloud
certification center round of the open
source developer tool get pod and here
we're going to learn about the benefits
of cloud developer environments over
traditional tools practical knowledge
utilizing a cde for the purpose of
application or cloud development
team-based collaborative uh features for
utilizing cds because that is the main
benefit of cdes advanced cde techniques
like custom containers pre-builds and
more the course code for this course is
exp cde 01 and the reason that is
important to know is because that's how
you know what version of the exam you're
taking so you always want to make sure
that you double check to make sure that
you are using the latest
course there and so exp is the
certification authority in this case it
is exam pro cde is the name identifier
standing for cloud developer environment
and one is the version of the exam we
also like to call this exam the get pod
essential certification or the git pod
course because it's so focused on git
pod but there's a reason why this uh
that is and we'll explain here in a
moment so who's the certification for
well consider the cloud developer
environment certification if you are new
to programming or scripting because if
you are working in the cloud you're
going to have to have an environment to
code and the best environment is in the
cloud at least in my opinion here
if you are a web application developer
role or you're transitioning into a
cloud developer role
it's a very good idea to adopt cloud
developer environments or if you're a
director of engineering or staff
engineer and you're looking to adopt cd
cdes to optimize the jillian and
productivity of your development team
because that is the main benefit of
adopting it is that you're going to get
increased productivity so before we look
at the roadmap we always do a roadmap to
show you where should you go after the
certification
but i need to break this down into three
types of certifications because this is
an exam pro certification and so we have
three types fundamental certifications
that's where we have a cloud concept
that is best taught with a large focus
on cloud agnostic knowledge so example
of that would be the cloud programming
certification we have technology
specific certifications like
a cloud concept that is best taught by
using a single technology in greater
detail and in this case that is what the
get pod certification is it's it's just
that you know we want to teach cloud
developer environments but it just makes
sense to use a single tool for that then
there are our role-based certifications
so this is where
you have done a bunch of fundamental and
technology-specific certifications and
then you are requiring to submit a
project to earn that role so an example
would be the exam pro's cloud developer
certification so let's take a look at
our roadmap and see where we can go
with the git pod certification so the
idea is we have that fundamental
knowledge that technical specific
knowledge and then the idea is that
we're trying to show that proof of
combined knowledge to earn that
role-based certification so this is all
based for a cloud developer or modern
application developer there's overlaps
with other cloud rules like cloud
engineers but let's take a look at the
cloud developer specific path here so
the idea is that you would start with
the cloud developer environment because
if you're going to be doing programming
or development you're going to need an
environment so it makes sense to know
inside and out a cloud developer
environment from there you would need to
know a variety of different programming
languages in the context of cloud
programmings working with sdks apis cli
things like that so that is the natural
path after the cde
from there we would look at application
integration so leveraging uh a host of
cloud services and integrating them into
your uh traditional or your modern
application and then cloud deployment
because that seems to be something that
is very important for cloud developers
is having not just the ability to
develop applications but to deploy and
it's not just deploying applications but
deploying uh integrated services as well
from there it's really good to
fundamentally understand virtualization
which is not a topic that
uh it kind of gets overlooked with the
cloud developers so that's where
application developers so that's why
i think we include it here from there
there is linux specific information
there's windows specific information and
for virtualization a natural path there
is containers and then serverless so to
me this is the scope of fundamental and
tech specific knowledge that
you should acquire to be a cloud
developer and then once you have this
knowledge you need to prove it some way
and so that's where we have this idea
behind having a cloud project to show
all the knowledge and practice so you
might be looking at saying wow that's a
lot of certifications well the great
thing though is that these
certifications are smaller in scope
and so instead of taking a big big exam
like how aws azure or gcp has you do
these are more focused so that you're
having a bunch of smaller wins and
you're getting better coverage um so you
can think of it like a movie versus
watching a high production long running
or like a
high production tv series it's just a
different approach to um
study okay so how long does it take to
pass for the cloud developer environment
so uh we have the beginner side and so
here i say 24 hours the idea is that if
you've never programmed before if you've
never held a web developer role it's
going to be on the greater side here 24
hours if you're experienced that means
you have practical working experience
with web apps
you have
held a web developer engineering role
we're looking at 14 hours and so in
between here this is where i say the
average hour is 20 hours now this could
be a lot faster if you just watch the
videos on two times it's up to you right
so like there is 14 hours of content
it's mostly because
of the the lecture or the lab content so
there's a lot of hands-on
but you know if you watch it uh on two
times then you know you're done in seven
hours if you're experienced so just
understand that you know it looks like a
lot of hours but it's not as bad as it
looks um it's 50 lecture lab content 50
practice exams
and then the recommendation here is to
study one to two hours for
10 days
okay what does it take to pass the exam
well the idea is you're going to be
watching lecture video memorizing key
information you're going to be doing
hands-on labs and there's a lot of it
so follow along with your own account so
you'll have to get a free gitpod account
and any other things that go along with
it and we make sure that we always make
sure things are free for you
so you can learn at the the lowest cost
or at no cost
and you'll have to do practice exams to
simulate the real exam the great thing
is on exam pro we have a full free
practice exam for you no credit card
required uh to get it so it's at exp
cd01
and that's where you're going to go grab
that
in terms of the content of the actual
exam it's broken up into five domains
and each domain has its own way which
determines how many questions in our
domain that will show up so we'll take a
look at the domains the first domain is
cloud developer environment concepts
which is seven percent uh get pod
integrations which is five percent
thirty uh uh domain three which is good
pod configurations is 35 percent get pod
workflows is 35 percent and 18 for get
pot io enterprise get pod oss so you
know when we engineered this course we
didn't just make it for people that are
going to apply
uh um uh
apply it for their work but just also
for that executive level that needs to
understand how to adopt it for their
team so that's what this category here
is for is understanding the ecosystem
for adoption
um and you know a lot of it comes down
to just knowing how to work with it as a
team and knowing how to configure your
environment to be productive in real
world use cases so
where do you take the exam well the exam
is taken online from the convenience of
your own home and this and the exam is
delivered via the teacher's seat anchor
system so teacher seat anchor is an
online secure exam system to deliver
certification exams similar to pearson
vue or psi online and ensures exam
credibility via their ai assisted
proctor so a proctor is a supervisor or
person who monitors students during an
examination so that way we make sure
that you're not cheating uh and that you
definitely have obtained the skills
yourself there um to schedule exam uh
what you'd have to do is actually sign
up for example so you keep seeing this
thing up here you do have to go there to
do the exam
but once you sign up you can go uh into
the course and click on the schedule
button and from there you can schedule
your exam it'll have all the information
there for the grading exam you have to
score at least an 80 percent we say
around 80 percent because this uses
scaled scoring skilled scoring just
means that we use a point system and so
the idea is that you know tomorrow we
decide to make it out of 2000 points
it's still going to be based on the
percentage of 80 percent so when you go
for the exam make sure you're trying to
aim for 85 percent on your practice
exams to make sure that you are
comfortable uh with the exam when you go
sit it for the response types um
first of all first off we have 55
questions
so all questions are scored there are no
unscored questions and there are no
funny questions so you know uh it
shouldn't be too difficult you can
afford to get about 10 questions wrong
there is no penalty for wrong questions
and the format of the questions are
going to be multiple choice and multiple
answer the duration of the exam is 1.5
hours so you get about 1.5 minutes per
question the exam time is 90 minutes the
seat time is 120 minutes and somebody
say the seat time we're referring to the
amount of time you should allocate for
the exam this includes time to review
the instructions show online proctor to
your workspace read and accept the nda
complete the exam provide feedback at
the end and this exam is going to be
valid for 36 months so that's three
years before recertification
so hopefully that gives you an idea of
what you are jumping into here
again the exam is not intended to be
difficult it's very practical if you
follow the content here it will be
pretty easy for you to do
but yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
looking at the question of what is cloud
native and now this is not a as
straightforward as you imagine because
there are a few different definitions
here so we're going to have to go
through a few little iterations here to
just kind of conceptually understand
what it is but cloud native at least the
way i describe it is an architectural
approach that emphasizes application
workloads that are portable modular and
isolate between different cloud
deployment models and cloud service
providers so that is what my definition
of it is but if you talk to cloud
service providers and we say cloud
service providers we're talking about
aws azure gcp
they describe it as a term meaning
everything built on their platform so
you know if you were not to use
on-premise and only to ever use aws they
would call that cloud native
but i would actually better describe
that as being cloud first so sometimes
cloud native and cloud first mean the
same thing depending on who you're
talking to then there's some models out
there that say that certain components
go into cloud native so modern design
automation micro services containers and
a bunch of backing services and then
other ones describe cloud native as
being four principles so micro services
containerization continuous delivery
which you could say is automation and
devops which could mean anything because
devops has so much stuff involved but
you can just see that there are a few
different things there i'm hoping that
we lean towards my definition because i
feel like that is a more comfortable one
there but if it does feel confusing
don't worry about it
it's not just clearly defined it's just
kind of like serverless where it's hard
to pin down but in the context of git
pod and cloud developer environments
cloud native means we'll be utilizing
microservice architecture modern
application architecture so think
function as a service such as containers
and kubernetes okay so hopefully that
and when i say that it's just the fact
that when you have cloud developer
environments they're going to be better
drivers or enablers for
modern architectures okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at two very similar but
also distinct roles or technical roles
that strongly benefit from cloud
developer environments or cdes and so
that is a cloud developer or a modern
application engineer and uh you know cds
can be used by any kind of role that's
working in the cloud but these two in
particular uh strongly benefit because
they're writing a lot more uh
programming code okay and also
interacting with cloud workloads but
let's talk about how they are
similar and also how they are different
so for both these roles they take a
cloud first approach meaning that
generally they're starting um you know
on a cloud service provider
you know in the case of modern
application engineer you can still be
doing that on premise but generally uh
speaking they're going to be focused on
using a cloud service provider first
in terms of like how the role is focused
for a cloud developer they're focused on
building out the product and the product
features whereas a modern application
engineer is architecture focused so
they're more interested in how to make
the underlying resources work and scale
and things like that
the cloud developer is specifically
going to focus on application
integration with cloud services so
that's what makes it different from a
regular developer is that interaction or
the interconnections with other cloud
services which enables you to basically
build microservices and for a modern
application
engineer they're architecting cloud
native workloads so that might be
setting up like a kubernetes cluster
writing infrastructure as code
setting up automation and things like
that uh and then you know just some
other things like things that you would
see that a cloud developer would do that
a modern application engineer does would
be things like deployment by knowing
some infrastructure as a code not a
priority for them but it's just
something they definitely know whereas
the modern application engineer has
things like automation scaling and
operations so just to reiterate here uh
it's like if you're taking a cloud-first
approach to building web applications
using cloud-native workloads or
cloud-based tooling that sounds like a
cloud developer and the focus is less
about the architecture and life cycles
and scaling and more about it being a
productive developer using cloud and
then on the other side of it we're
looking at the modern application
engineer
it's about thinking about how to
architect
applications using serverless containers
microservices there's a larger focus on
the underlying architecture lifestyle
life cycles and scaling not so much
about building out the web application
and it's less product focus so you know
i just want you to know these two things
because if you are entering cloud these
are the titles you should be trying to
cling on to if you really are invested
as a programmer okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at code editors versus
integrated development environments and
the reason why is because git pod
supports both and these usually look
very similar but they are also
dissimilar in a lot of ways and it's
good to understand
the trade-offs of using one over the
other so let's talk about a code editor
so a code editor is for writing computer
code and they will generally support
many programming languages with things
like syntax highlighting in recent years
code editors will include a community
marketplace for extensions that allows
you to add a variety of features to
customize your code editor for specific
workflows so the thing is back in the
day when we had code editors they were
very simple and the only way you'd have
like really rich functionality was via
an ide because it had everything there
for you but now things have changed and
things are a lot more modular and
flexible but notable creditors would be
things like visual studio code sublime
vim notepad plus plus textmate things
like that then we look at integrated
development environments so an ide is a
suite of tightly integrated programming
tools
under a single unified gui so an ide are
generally more powerful than code
editors and are specialized for a
specific language or framework or you
could say they are very opinionated for
a specific framework or workload so they
will include things like a terminal code
editor debugger compiler deployment file
management and all sorts of tooling
notable ids here would be jetbrains
eclipse xcode android studio visual
studio and in a lot of cases sometimes
it's the only way you can really develop
stuff it's really hard to develop mac os
applications without xcode
it's possible but a lot of times you
know
the technology is so
well designed for that use case you end
up using ides
but i do need to note that modern code
editors can be modified through a
collection of extensions to work nearly
the same as ide so that line is becoming
a little bit blurred
but let's just look at the uh overall
comparison so code editors are
multi-purpose modular light portable and
generally across platform when i say
they're portable like them which is a
code editor can be something that's used
in the browser
as a desktop app or even in the terminal
but then you have things like ides uh
these are special uh so
in contrast they are specialized
monolithic heavy designed to be used as
mostly desktop apps because they need a
full gui and may not be cross-platform
but we say as a desktop app um you know
that's starting to change because like
jetbrains is now able to use jetbrains
projector to run in the browser so you
know these things are starting to meet
in the middle but it's still good to
know the difference between these terms
but most people these days are using
code editors okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at the seven benefits of
cloud developer environments so i just
want to know this isn't like an industry
standard but these are the things that i
thought that were the most important
things to highlight about them so if you
are talking to someone trying to
understand why to adopt a cde into in
terms of your company workflow these are
the seven things you should be telling
them the first is context so you can
start a runtime system runtime system is
just a developer environment on the
context of your workload so pull
requests uh maybe based around an issue
a testing environment or a sandbox or q
a then there's mobility so easily move
to different workstations so whether
you're on mac to windows to linux um all
you need is a browser you can use
multiple kinds of version control
systems so maybe you're on github today
tomorrow you might want to use gitlab or
bitbucket things like that works with
different kinds of editors so maybe you
like visual studio code but you'd rather
use jetbrains so you have the ability to
move between them or you know maybe you
are on a laptop a chromebook or even a
tablet so you know there's a lot of
mobility you get there then we talk
about agility so quickly start up
developer environments no time spent
configuring your environment uh and so
that's a pretty clear one it's just the
fact that uh you've already put in the
work for the configuration either other
team member has or you have and the idea
is that it's going to spin up and start
that up right away then you have
disposability or they're being
disposable so always start from a clean
point discard long live credentials at
the end of a work session
what's really important to understand
here is just like or like a use case is
the fact that a lot of times you'll
install like uh
libraries and if you're working with
multiple projects you might install
different libraries they break other
libraries but here that's not a problem
because everything is in the scope of
that single project and you're disposing
things at the end always then you have
reproducibilities or or being
reproducible so you can go back through
your get history and launch the exact
state of a developer environment with
the required environment configuration
because as you are
changing your code you're also changing
like the uh configuration to set up that
environment and you'll have that history
there in your commits
then you have a
progression or being progressive so with
progressive versioning always start uh
you always start with an environment
with the latest stuff and that's poorly
worded there but the idea that i'm
trying to say there is like with git pod
you can have pre-builds and so every
change might discover breaking changes
because it will run the code every
single time and so as you encounter it
you can address and then upgrade those
to the latest version
right so that's the idea of always
staying on the latest then you have
collaboration so we were talking about
real-time collaboration here um so being
able to share the state of a developer
environment so hopefully you know that
is pretty clear about those seven things
context mobility agility disposability
reproducibility
being progressive or progressive
versioning and being collaborative so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
asking a very important question uh in
this course which is what is get pod so
gitpod is a company specializing in
cloud developer environments via the
gitpod open source software or the
gitpod.o which is the platform so it can
be a little bit confusing at first
because it's like is it the product this
is the company name or it's whatever but
we'll just go through here to make sure
it's crystal clear so get pod oss open
source software which is located on
github
is a developer environment as code if
you're wondering what i mean by that
it's that it's an open source kubernetes
application for ready to code developer
environments that spin up fresh
automated dev environments for each task
in the cloud in seconds and enables you
to describe your dev environment as code
and instantly start remote cloud or
cloud developer
environments directly from your browser
or your desktop id or even tablets if
you want which i have yet to try but i'm
sure it does work
as long as you have a browser you can do
it
and so the idea is we have getpod.io
and this i call it a developer
environment as a service
which is not something you need to
really remember but it's basically a
software as a service so it is a
cloud-based fully managed offering of
the open source software with a free and
paid tier uh and so hopefully that is a
distinction that it's a company that's
an open source software it's also a
cloud platform okay
[Music]
all right so i just wanted to get you
some exposure to git pod so if you went
to www.getpodio
this is the main website um here so you
can read all about it if you like but we
do of course cover everything that is in
here then there is the actual open
source git pod uh and so this is where
they have a variety of different
repositories uh so you can start reading
here and again we cover this within the
course but they have a lot of
repositories here and then there's the
actual platform itself which is git pod
io
if we click into here there's no app
it's just the naked domain uh here you
can see i've been launching workspaces
which we'll get into but you know again
just to get you a little bit exposure uh
to that gitpod ecosystem okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at getpod versus other
providers i think it's important to know
the options that are out there and maybe
to understand why i chose to do a git
pod course as opposed to making it an
agnostic course um but let's go through
it so the first is git pod code spaces
formerly known as visual studio online
if you try to find visual studio online
anywhere you just can't find it
it'll let me have like a marketing page
but always link back to github code
spaces so maybe both projects existed at
one point maybe visual studio online was
always github code spaces and was
rebranded we really don't know but all
there is is github code spaces so github
code spaces is proprietary online code
editor specifically for github so
understand that it's proprietary not
open source so um you know if you are
locked in there you're not going to take
that code editor into uh deployed on
your own infrastructure so just
understand that is one thing uh key
differences you pay based on computing
instant size so i believe that it's
metered billing so uh i mean that's nice
if that's how you like your compute to
be like i use this many hours i pay for
this many hours but you do have to
choose or right size your instance so
that
uh could be good if like let's say you
need something that's more powerful than
git pod provides but git pod like has a
really beefy instance and at a cost that
like it's just really really cheap so
you know even though you know metered
billing and uh being able to choose your
size sounds good uh you know this is one
of those rare cases where i prefer get
pod because i just don't have to think
about it it's like totally serverless it
doesn't currently have pre-builds right
now so you can have longer wait times um
i would imagine they would probably end
up adding this at some point so uh you
know even though i say there's not
pre-builds right now uh you know it
seems like github code spaces would add
that and a very huge key difference is
that it runs on a virtual machine so
when you are launching um a git pod it's
using docker right as a way of launching
its containers and so
um i mean
like i'm finding containers to be a lot
more flexible first i thought virtual
machines would be better because maybe
you need to install docker on a virtual
machine or or images but you can run
docker within docker so it doesn't
matter um and it's just a lot easier to
package like docker files for that kind
of stuff so i kind of feel like git pod
has the advantage there because it's
using containers okay um and the use
case here is only if you're using github
so if you're using git lab or code
commit or something else uh you know
you're not gonna be using github code
spaces so you have to understand that
your workflow is gonna be very tied to
github and this might cause friction for
larger companies that like are using
elazi and jira and they have everything
in bitbucket which is very popular so
you know just has to work
fit your workflow github of course is
the most popular version control system
out there and then visual studio code is
the most popular code editor so you know
for most people it's going to meet their
use cases but you know uh
i i just i still lean towards get pod
here uh then we have aws cloud nine so
this is an online code editor service
within aws
um
i liked it i liked it for years i still
use it for a lot of use cases
it runs on a virtual machine you can
only choose very particular types of
amis to run it on but i mean i guess
it's no different with um git pods
because git pod runs on debian ubuntu
like a debian like instance and so i
guess cloud9 technically has more
flexibility of what the virtual machine
is but when you're dealing with
containers you can have whatever you
kind of whatever you want i guess not
because in git pod you can only run
debian or ubuntu instances but um yeah i
guess there's more flexibility here with
cloud9
you pay for the online virtual machine
cost it has a free tier um
these case here is if you need a simple
persistent developer environment with
simple collaboration features you want
to take advantage of built-in enable
support within cloud nine for service
development
um it is easier to use than visual
studio code so for beginners especially
when you do aws stuff i'm showing them
cloud nine but like if you're serious
about your development you're probably
gonna wanna use something like visual
studio code and then that's where you're
going to be using git pod or code spaces
and things like that
then we have the google cloud cloud
shell editor this is an online coder
part of the google cloud shell the key
difference is it's free uh and it's free
to up to a certain point there's no team
collaboration features at least that i i
saw
and this is intended for experimentation
or rapid prototyping with gcp services i
wouldn't really consider it for
application development in a team
environment uh there's probably possible
limitations on performance of the
runtime environment i couldn't find
details about it and it has limited
hours per month i thought it was
like free 100 hours i might say this
somewhere else in the course saying like
google cloud shell gives you unlimited
hours but it's not true i found it was
like limited to 50 hours a month but
it's still really good um and it's
running visual studio code alongside
their shell so when you're in google
it makes things a lot easier and so you
know when i'm doing
google cloud workload stuff i will be
using that thing but when i want
something that's persisted like a
project i'm not going to be doing it in
the cloud shell editor i'm going to be
putting in a repository and launching up
git pod but a really great way to learn
google cloud because a lot of the
uh the console you'll click through
it'll say open in cloud shell and then
open the editor so you will come across
it but what i want to do is show you all
these three editors uh for real just so
you can see where they are if they
interest you but hopefully that gives
you an idea how they compare against
skip pod right again gitpod runs on
containers uh it's serverless billing
right um you know things like that uh
and it's it's using debian ubuntu okay
hey this is andrew brown and i'm in my
aws account here at the aws management
console and i just want to quickly show
you what cloud 9 looks like not so much
that you need to go do this but just so
that you can see what else is out there
so what i'm going to do is go to the top
here and type in cloud9
and we'll go over here
and we'll give it a moment here i am in
the root account so usually it doesn't
like you creating um environments here
which is totally fine
i have a couple old uh
ones here that refuse to delete but i'll
create a new environment we'll just say
cloud nine get pod test
kind of weird writing get pod in there
but i just want to show you that you
choose the instance size or type so you
can choose t2 micro small large other
instance type and you can go pretty big
here so that might be the advantage that
cloud9 gives you is that you can go like
super super big if you need to
um
and you know this is not the only kind
of environment that aws has so like they
also have in sage maker um
because you can think of it as a code
editor right like you have sage maker
studio which will run a jupiter lab but
that's really for ml we're talking just
about like general cloud development
here so that's the thing is like if you
really do need to do like
um you know
ml stuff you probably shouldn't be using
a cloud developer environment you should
be using something like sagemaker studio
or whatever the integrated
cloud services that are used by the
cloud service providers but anyway i'm
going to just choose a t3 micro notice
we have amazon list two amazon likes the
old one which is not recommended to use
anymore ubuntu
um and so those are our options i think
at one point you could just attach
whatever
any kind of
machine you want but then it wouldn't be
managed when shut down automatically
notice we have a 30 minute um
turn off after 30 minutes but you can
change it here to whatever you like
we'll go ahead and hit next we'll create
that environment and we're going to wait
for that to spin up because i just want
to show you what it looks like
it's generally really fast but i'll see
you back here in a moment okay all right
so after waiting a little while here it
has finally launched uh usually it
doesn't look like this i think there's
just a slight little problem with the um
editor or display it usually looks
really nice here but it's just telling
you here how to get started with um
cloud9 so this is based off of
i want to say like adam but maybe not i
think it may be oh sorry the ace editor
so we'd like up ace editor
i think that's what it's based off of
yeah so it was called ace and then uh
ace turned it into cloud9 uh ide it's
not really an id it's a cloud editor um
and then cloud9 was acquired by aws and
so aws integrated with a lot of their
services so when you go over to lambda
you're using cloud9 but it's a lot
simpler like they don't really have
extensions per se so
you can like explore aws resources
through here they have some source
control which um i believe is kind of
new i remember seeing this here before
but it's very dead simple there are no
extensions
uh you know so like whatever you want
it's like uh test.ruby
we'll open that up here and just type in
like um
[Music]
puts hello get pod
okay we'll save that down below ls and
i'll just run it here ruby test.rb so
it's really darn simple collaboration is
kind of nice i really like it um get pod
at least at the time of shooting this um
their features are not as transparent as
they need to be um but i know that
they're working hard to make that better
um but like here you can like invite
people you can see them you can see
where their cursor is so that's kind of
nice
they have a debugger
which is fine and there are like
serverless integrations but you know
nothing super complicated um but yeah if
you want to shut it down we could just
close the tab or i'll just go back out
we'll go back to the dashboard here
and i'll just close up this tab and i'll
go ahead and delete that environment
so nothing super complicated that is
cloud9 now over to gcp so we'll go over
here and theirs is up here in the active
act or cloud shell here so if you click
it uh generally you have to activate
cloud shell so what it's going to do is
spin up i think a virtual machine
underneath so we just have to wait uh a
while here and once we're there oh that
was fast
that was super super fast some like if
it's the first time you ever did it it's
really slow but like
because i think they're like making the
back like the storage for you but uh
it's super fast but if you click here in
the uh open editor it's gonna look just
like
um vs code because it is vs code
right so here it is
i don't know if there's any kind of
limitations in terms of the stuff that
you can install i actually never looked
at that for extensions
can you install extensions that's a good
question
so we have uh cloud code
apis
uh secrets manager kubernetes cluster so
i don't see the ability to install
extensions
so it might be just uh what you see is
what you get here i'm going to go ahead
and just create myself a new file here
so just say test.rb
okay so nothing super complicated you
know you know what uh visual studio code
is but uh that's that one there if you
want to close it we just hit the x there
all right and we'll take a look at uh
github code spaces all right i'm back
and so i just want to show you github
code spaces or at least attempt to do it
um and so the thing with github code
spaces is that if you've ever tried to
find it like under the buttons here and
you don't see displayed the reason why
is that it's part of i believe the
team's plan so you know if you are just
a regular user and you're looking to
utilize it that's not possible now could
you just go ahead and create an
organization and then be able to do it i
guess we could go find out so what i'll
do here is go over
uh to my settings and we'll look for
organizations
and i'm going to create a new
organization and notice here we can see
some options so in the free here
unlimited public private repositories
2000 automation minutes a month 500
megabytes issues and projects
so i don't think that it's here
um is it in here i'm just trying to see
here so we have
protected branches multiple reviewers
code owners
and that is the tricky part is just
trying to find the functionality so what
i'm going to do if we scroll down here
we might be able to see it so code
spaces
ah okay so in the free tier it's not
available and then the team plan that's
where it's going to start at up to 32
cores starting at uh 18 cents per hour
i'm very certain that i have a paid
teams plan somewhere so i just need to
go find it okay
so what i'll do is i'll come back here
in a moment and see if i can find it but
just understand that you got to be
paying and then you can pay additional
to use uh get uh hub code spaces so i'll
be back here in a moment okay
all right so i'm in uh my other account
here where i definitely have a team's
organization but i don't think it's paid
it used to be paid i think we moved off
of it because they made a free tier and
so now we don't have code spaces so uh
you know i think it's just gonna be a
bit too hard for me to show this and all
it would really show is that once you
launch it that you
have
this kind of editor and that you can
choose the different size there um but
uh you know hopefully that gives you an
idea of like the friction it it it
causes to get started with um code
spaces
but you know if you really want to know
more you can just read up on it here
okay but yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we were
talking about context-based developer
workflows because this is something that
you've probably already been doing but
it's just cloud developer environments
make it a lot easier to do so what is
context in the scope of a developer
workload well as a developer you need to
quickly switch contacts based on the
scope of the work you are currently
performing and this could be things like
reviewing pull requests
developing features manually performing
quality insurance so q a replicating a
version of production
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at context-based developer
workflows if you've never heard of it
it's okay you've actually probably been
using it this entire time
but this became a lot more important
once we started using modern
architecture so let's talk about what is
the context in the scope of a developer
workload well as a developer you need to
quickly switch context based on the
scope of the work you are currently
performing this could be something like
reviewing a pull request deploy or
developing features manually performing
quality insurance of q a replicating a
version of production for debugging
creating a temporary environment to test
the hypothesis so the idea is the
context is what do you need to do review
code develop feature q a all sorts of
options there and those environments all
need to be specialized for that context
so developers have always been using
context-based developer workflows though
cloud developer environments cdes makes
that much easier to do and specifically
for microservice or modern architectures
which have many more iso repositories
this is a big struggle for a lot of
people that are doing microservices is
just managing all the repositories
whether they have one big monolith or
not but again cloud developer
environments make it so much easier to
jump into those projects so cloud
developer environments become part of
the workflow developers can quickly and
safely switch contacts so i just kind of
want to add an additional illustration
about you know if you're using uh cloud
developer environments first versus
using local
developer environments how that might
change uh the responsibility or the
accessibility
of your code so
here you know the old way we would do it
is we would launch i'm going to get my
pen tool out here we would launch a
local developer environment we'd write
our code and then we would create the
repository locally and then push okay i
know there's a spelling mistake there so
just ignore that um but now you know
with um cloud developer environments we
create the empty repository first in
github so it already is there then we
launch our cloud developer environment
and then we write code and from there we
can actively commit our code and so the
great thing about that is that when we
take that approach like let's look at
the old way if we were doing the old way
some people will end up writing all this
code and they just never push it to a
repository remote repository they might
have created a local repository but it's
never made it online and so that means
that there's a longer time before code
can be collaborative or they have an
opportunity where they might or an
opportunity but there might be the
misfortune that they lose that code and
i can't tell you how many times that has
happened or it's the weekend you want to
pass that code off to somebody else but
like oh it's on my machine i never
pushed it
but if you're using cloud developer
environments
it's already in a online repository that
is the starting point and that is the
kind of behavior change that you have
when you use cloud developer
environments so there's a higher chance
of collaboration and less chance of loss
of code and that just makes it again
easier to do this context-based
developer workflows and one context
would be like starting a new project but
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at visual studio code also
known as vs code which is a free source
code editor made by microsoft for
windows linux and mac os if you're
confused why it says source code editor
that's just the language that microsoft
uses but you can just say code editor
and visual studio code should not be
confused with visual studio which came
before vs code and vs studio
is an ide an integrated developer
environment that's for doing more
low-level stuff
but anyway visual studio code has 14
million developers out of 24 million
developers worldwide who use vs code
making it the most popular source code
editor today and if you wanted to do the
math on that that's 58 percent market
share so at least half of all developers
are using vs code and the reason we're
talking about vs code is because that is
the primary editor that you will see
when you launch up a git pod workspace
so vs code is very popular due to being
free powerful works on all hardware lots
of courses orgs schools use vs code
because it's available for everybody so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
looking at the concept of docker so
docker is a set of platform as a service
products that use os level
virtualization to deliver software in
packages called containers so the reason
we're talking about uh docker is because
that is what uh getpod is using to run
their environments and you'll hear
kubernetes as well
but that's something that you don't
necessarily have to touch
but docker containers is something that
you might
encounter okay
so docker was the earliest popularized
open source container platform so when
people think of containers they
generally think of docker and we said
it's platform as a service product so
there's more
than one thing just called docker so we
have the docker cli so these are cli
commands to download upload build run
and debug containers we have a docker
file so a configuration following how to
provision a container docker compose
this is a tool and configuration file
when working with multiple containers
and that's something you may encounter
with some like quick start templates and
things like that docker swarm an
orchestration tool for managing deployed
multi-container architectures that is
not something that you have to worry
about um then you have docker hub a
public online repository for containers
published by the community for download
so this is going to be a place where you
source containers and we definitely
source things from docker hub using git
pod and then there's the concept of oci
the open container initiative because i
saw this term and it just pops up
everywhere you're wondering like what is
oci compliant what does that mean so
open container initiative is an open
governance structure for creating open
industry standards around container
formats and runtime so docker
established the oci and it is now
maintained by the linux foundation and
so docker has been losing favor with
developers due to the handling of
introducing a paid open source model and
alternatives like podman are growing but
that doesn't mean don't use docker that
just means like at scale you know some
companies like larger companies are
looking at alternatives but these
alternatives are oci compliant right
like pod men and things like that but i
just wanted to point that out because
you know docker can be a bit contentious
in the open source space but it still is
really good and solid and that is what
git pod is using okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at version control systems
also known as vcs so these systems are
designed to track changes or revisions
to your code and the most popular vcs is
git so vcs can also refer to manage
cloud services that host vcs so this is
why this term is a bit confusing because
really it means git but a lot of times
we are talking about git providers and
so get pod integrates with the following
git providers the first is github so
this is owned by microsoft it's the most
popular vcs offering due to its ease of
use and being around the longest github
is primarily where open source projects
are hosted and offer rich
functionalities such as issue tracking
automation pipelines and a host of other
features before github everybody would
put their stuff on sourceforge um but
sourceforge was very slow i think it was
svn based and it had a lot of ads and so
when github came out it was extremely
popular because you could put repos
there for free and had really strong
collaboration tools then came along git
lab so this was an emerging competitor
to github and at the time had unique
features such as ci cd pipeline improved
security measures i still think it's
easier to get a lot of things set up in
gitlab it takes care of that stuff for
you
but github has caught up with a lot of
stuff like github actions and and things
like that so they're pretty much on par
now then there's also bitbucket this is
owned by elazian and it was originally
only used for mercurial so mercurial was
a competitor to get but git became so
popular that bitbucket added git and
then mercurial became so uh unpopular
not that it's bad but just wasn't as
popular as get that they stopped
supporting mercurial so
bitbucket has tight integration with
atlatian's industry standard agile
project management software called jira
and so if you ever end up working for a
large organization they're very likely
to be using jira and because they're
using jira they're very likely to be
using bitbucket because there's tight
integrations between it it's just so
much easier so those are um you know the
git providers
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at version control system
permissions and to understand that we
need to know what oauth 2.0 is so walk
2.0 is an industry standard protocol for
authorization and the idea here is oauth
doesn't share password data but instead
uses authorization tokens to prove an
identity between consumers and service
providers so oauth is about granting
access to functionality as opposed to
something like open id which is about
providing who you are but the only thing
i really want you to know is that it
uses oauth and that's where these fine
grain permissions are going to get set
and that's how it works for uh get pod
because you connect your uh your your
version control system and then you you
as the user are going to decide uh what
you want to set there so within your get
providers you can see they're connected
so there is my username there are my
permissions and if you expand it you'll
see all the options there and it's going
to vary based on the provider so the
idea here is that for github we have
user email read user public repo repo
read org and workflow um so just
understand that that's going to be
slightly different for all the providers
and the key thing to remember is the
fact that get pod is not responsible for
these permissions it's on the get
provider and the user okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at the git pod editor
support so get pod is designed to be a
provider agnostic cloud developer
environment and one way we see that is
the fact that it supports integrations
for a bunch of different git providers
but another way that it's agnostic is by
having support for more than one editor
and so gitpod currently supports three
types of editors so we have vs code
browser so a editor within the browser
and this is the default experience
desktop vs code so opening a workspace
in local vs code so a desktop
application and jetbrain so a paid ide
that extends
the eclipse ide so if you ever use
eclipse you kind of have an idea what
jetbrains is there so what we'll do is
investigate all these three types here
but the key thing to remember is that
kit pod supports uh multiple types of
editors and i think they'll just keep on
expanding that because that is their
goal okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at jetbrains and before we
can talk about that we need to know what
is eclipse so eclipse is a free and open
source id created by ibm originally
intended for java through open source
projects have expanded to a variety of
languages so i think ibm authored it and
it's been managed by an open source
group now i remember using jetbrains
back in like 2001 specifically for java
so it's very interesting to see that
it's been around for so long and it's
still super powerful but then there came
along jetbrains and jetbrains is a
company specializing in creating paid id
so it's proprietary or an extension of
eclipse and so they just make the uh the
eclipse experience way way way better so
they use the same code base at least at
one point they did but they have grant
greatly expanded that feature set around
specific programming languages just
brains is easier
more productive more convenient to use
in eclipse just brains was formerly
known as intellij
and if intellij sounds familiar it's
because it kind of sounds like
intellisense which is this whole kind of
auto completion thing so
notice here as they're typing and
there's this auto completion thing that
was something i think that was invented
by microsoft originally or at least they
branded the idea of intellisense but
this was a a big selling point where
you'd be able to type and it would auto
complete you could click through stuff
now we're seeing that kind of everywhere
like code editors have support for that
through uh extensions but one at one
point that was a big deal okay so
jetbrains has a variety of ids
specialized for different languages or
frameworks so let's just go through the
list we have phpstorm uh which is for
php golang for uh go land for go the go
language uh intellij idea or idea which
is for java data grip which is for sql
or databases in general pi chart for
python ruby mine for ruby web storm for
javascript c line for c and c plus plus
writer for net and this isn't the full
list i know they have something for
developing ios applications and
something for data science other things
like that
but the reason i'm listing these ones
out for you is because these are all uh
in the scope of what
gitpod is trying to have support for now
what's interesting is a thing called
jetbrains projector and this is a tool
that allows you to run jetbrains id
within a browser i don't particularly
know if getpod is using that and that's
how you integrate with it because i just
haven't uh given jetbrains with vs code
a go
but i just want to say gitpod allows you
to integrate with jetbrains to use it as
your gitpod workspace editor there's an
asterisk there because at the time of
right now it's in beta and some of these
are coming soon so these are all on the
roadmap and so i just want you to be
knowing about this because probably in
the future these will be available to
you okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and i was
saying that there is uh support for get
pod to use your desktop version of vs
code so you can open git pod workspace
in your local vs code if you open up
either file or go to the get pod
command palette you should see an option
that says open a vs code there's also
this option says open in vs code
insiders and insiders is just the vs
code unstable release version so it's
like the latest version but you might
not want to be using it unless you're
like they'd like to have the latest
features but you don't mind if there's
bugs or things like that so some vs code
extensions do not work in the browser so
opening in local vs code may give you a
better developer experience um and you
know you know some people prefer desktop
apps so that could be a reason there but
i ran into an edge case with my
co-founder where uh they use ubuntu and
they could not use the vs code vim
extension the browsers uh
specifically on their linux laptop right
so in this case they had to launch in
local vs code and then they were able to
use it so it was interesting to see that
edge case but it seems like you know a
lot of support on mac or windows so
there that could just happen okay and
also when i was using this on my windows
machine where i'm using windows
subsystem linux
it actually prompted me to install a
bunch of things like
docker and kubernetes and things like
that whereas on my mac it didn't ask for
any of these things so it's possible
that you have to have docker and salt
which would make sense because um it is
running containers so there would have
to be some way for it to do it uh and
one thing i noticed is that you cannot
open a shared running workspace that has
been shared with you so only the owner
can open that workspace locally
so that's just a thing there and i think
i repeated a couple times in the course
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at the get pod browser
extension and this provides a
convenience button within the version
control hosting provider and this button
prepends the gitpod url prefix to the
current url and this getpod browser
extension is available for firefox
chrome microsoft edge and brave and so
it's important that you remember that
because i will ask you on the exam which
browsers it's for so just to kind of
show you what that convenience button
looks like in the different providers
here is github and there is the button
here is bitbucket and there is the
button here is gitlab and there is the
button so nothing super complicated here
but it's a lot easier than having to
remember to type in the gitpod url so
it'll definitely save you some time okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at get pod browser
bookmarklet so what is a browser
bookmarklet well it is a browser
bookmark but instead of pointing to a
url it executes arbitrary javascript
code and so the idea is that transform
is a bookmark into kind of a smart
bookmark so you'd have this javascript
code which we'd get from the gitpod
website you'd place it in the url
box when you make your bookmark and then
when you click that button it would work
just like pressing that get pod button
assuming you were on a particular page
like a git lab or github page so the get
pod browser bookmarklet when clicked
will open in the current github gitlab
bitbucket just what i just said there a
moment ago and the reason for it is that
it acts as an alternative to the browser
extension for when the browser extension
is not present for specific web browsers
so i didn't test it but i assume that
it's not for safari because safari is
not a chromium-based browser probably
opera as well would be in that category
there could be cases where you have
computer workstations that does not uh
allow the installation of browser
extensions because you know some
organizations they have a bunch of
computers and every time you shut them
down they always boot up a fresh image
so you lose your extensions or they just
they don't allow you to install
extensions uh as a as a security measure
so that you know people are installing
malware in their browser or it could be
that developers are extending the launch
behavior for more intelligent action so
you could probably take that javascript
code and add some extra stuff in there
maybe you want to um put in some
environment variables and so that gives
you a bit more flexibility over the get
pod button but there you go
hey this is andrew brown and what we're
going to do here is look at git lab
integration so what i'm going to do is
create myself a new git lab account so
in the top right corner we save get free
trial i kind of swore these to have a
free account here so i'm going to do is
double check here and yes they do have
one so i'm going to say free
and here we have two options where we
have gitlab sas or get lab self managed
so sas is the one we want that's going
to be just like when you utilize github
so we'll go here and click sign up for
free and i'm just going to fill in my
name so we got andrew
brown and we'll just say
exam pro co
andrew exam pro co and then we need a
password so i'm going to generate out a
password
here paste that in
and before we proceed here i'm just
going to save this in my password
manager to save myself some trouble
so just give me a second here so
gitlab.com
exam pro co
i'm going to put that password in there
okay and hopefully it will take it i am
definitely not a robot at least i don't
think i am you notice there's a bunch of
options down here but i'm going to just
keep it simple by using email we're
going to go ahead and hit register so
now it wants me to confirm my email so
i'm just going to open a new tab off
screen here i'm going to make my way
over to my email
i'm going to try to do this as quick as
i can here
and so i have a confirmation email here
from git lab
okay so here it is and i'm going to go
ahead and get uh click confirm your
account and so here it is confirming my
account
and we will just expand that here and so
here says your email address has been
successfully confirmed please sign in
and so what i'll do is grab my password
here so i'm going to copy my password in
here paste it on in sign in
and it's going to ask me some
information i'm just going to say
continue
cool you'll be using this for the time
being it'll just be me okay because it
looks like i guess there's some few
different options here
um i don't need to opt anything uh would
you like to create a project join a
project we'll just say create new
project
and i guess we need an organization name
so this is really just for
git pods i'm just going to say exam pro
exam pro co
and we're going to write git pod because
i'm going to be doing a bunch of repos
here and i figured we could do that the
group
and any public projects can be viewed
without any authentication so we'll say
create group because we'll make it
public facing
and so now we have an opportunity to
create a project this is quite the
lengthy setup but i'm going to make this
public here and what we're going to say
here is
get pod hello world
as an example here
and i'm going to go ahead and create
this
and we'll just give it a moment to set
up okay
and so it's all set up so we'll say okay
let's go
and so now that is there the next thing
i want to do here is connect uh to get
pod so what i'm looking for here
um is a button for the github project i
mean i guess this is the project here so
this is not necessarily repos
so
just give me a moment here and i'll
think about what i need to do okay all
right so i'm back and i was just kind of
looking around at what there is to do
here so what i want to go do is create a
new repository
and so we'll click that there
and then from here
we have an option over here repositories
on the left hand side so
um
let's go over here and click on
repository
and so now i'm over here and you can see
there's initial commit
by a fellow here
i assume he works at git pod
so senior product uh a designer for
growth at gitlab um there and so here we
can see that repository it's been
unusual that it's like a commit on the
behalf of somebody else but that's
totally fine but the great thing is we
have our get pod button you will not
have this unless you have that stuff
installed i also noticed like web ide
here never looked at that so i'm just
kind of curious what's going to open up
here
i'm just curious because it's like you
know there's git pods so i was wondering
if git lab had their own offering
so i can go here and it's pretty
simplistic so it's not really like a
full
full-blown developer environment i was
just really curious but what we'll do is
go back over to our hello world project
i'm just going to go back here because
maybe there was two here
so let me click into gitlab is that the
one we were looking at yeah so that was
the one that we saw here
and then here is the public one that i
made it's a little bit confusing again i
don't use git lab on a day-to-day basis
so i'm just kind of learning uh just
like you are here but i guess if we
click the
icon at the top we can start seeing the
projects more clearly and so this is the
one that i created that i care about
this is new i don't know what this uh
this is i guess this is created by
default for you
and so we'll go over to
uh repository
it's not really showing me a lot of
information because usually like github
will set something up for you so what
i'm going to do is just add a new file
so let's just say add a readme file
okay and we'll just say hello world
we'll go ahead and commit that
and we'll just say commit
and so now what i'm hoping is if we go
back to
our project here we'll get something
that looks a little bit more normal
okay yeah and so there we go so just we
had to get that initial file on there
and so now we have that opportunity to
uh use git pod of course you'll need the
browser extension for that installed if
you don't we're going to just do it the
old-fashioned way so i'm going to go up
here in the top type in http colon slash
get pod uh dot io forward slash pound
okay and that will open up that
environment for us
notice that i don't have a get pod
account here as of yet so what i'm going
to do here is say continue with gitlab
just because that's what we're using
right now and here it's going to allow
us to authorize so we're going to say
authorize
and we'll just give it a moment to check
out that repository but essentially when
we did that when we authorized that that
should have created a new account for us
and so here is um our project here which
is all great
and so essentially what you'd want to do
is um kind of set up your environment so
i really don't like the look of this
it's kind of hard on my eyes so i'm
going to go down to the bottom left
corner we're going to go to color theme
and i'm going to just switch to
something that is dark so we'll say
um
actually i like monokai quite a bit so
i'm going to go to that um like in terms
of the editor or the coloring there and
so we have this open
um and if we just want to kind of set up
a new file here i'm just going to go get
pod
yaml
okay
and we'll just set up something
initially so we have tasks
and i'm assuming that's how we do it
just trying to do for memory so we have
name we're going to say hello world
okay and then from there we'll just hit
space base
and it's the command that we want and
i'm just going to say echo
actually we don't have to put double
quotations there we'll say echo
hello world and i don't think we need
exclamations
exclamations here i'm having a bit of
trouble because i keep on thinking this
is a vim keyboard so one thing i want to
go do is go install
um the vim
the vim hotkey here so we'll go vim
uh vimvs code
it's this one that i want to install so
we'll say install here
okay and we'll go back and so now that
works as normal as i would expect it to
and so i believe that this is uh correct
with the exception that we just should
have a colon here and what i want to do
is just go ahead
and commit this so we'll go back here
and i'll just say uh hello world
commit
okay
and we will add that file and we will
hit commit
we'll sync those changes we'll say ok
and so now if we go back to our original
tab here and we just give this a refresh
we should now see in our repository
this new commit but what i want to find
out is will this change uh take effect
so
you know we can just close this tab i
just want to show you like if you have
uh get pod gamble open and you're always
trying to figure out how to make your
way back
um and by the way i might just bump up
the font here i don't know if this is
going to work let's just see if i can do
that
um here
it's not really bumping so sorry
everything's going to be really small
what we can do is go down to the command
palette here and if we want to get back
to this repository quickly we can just
go to open context and that's always
going to bring us back here to the
project or repository in git lab
but what i'm really interested in is
actually going over to getpodio because
whether or not you notice you actually
created an account so if we were to go
over to the dashboard so it opens opens
and up us up to the getpod.io
and so now you can see we have a new
account if i go over here and we go to
settings
you can see that for integrations i have
git lab and this is where our
permissions live so we go here
and
if we want to change these we can go
ahead and just change those things but
the goal is we're going to hook up
github and bitbocket just so that we can
see what they all look like
but just to kind of complete what we're
doing with this project here what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to go
ahead just close this tab here and close
that out and i'm going to go back here
and i'm just going to go and type this
in again
okay so let's say https colon four slash
support slash getpod.io
pound
and from there it says invalid git pod
yaml should be an object so
clearly i've made a mistake so we'll say
continue with the default configuration
actually that's the first time i've made
a mistake with a github configuration
file and i think it's just because i
created from scratch normally i go out
and i find a reference but that's not
what i did here so if this is a problem
what i'm going to do is just cut that
out and we're going to open up a new
terminal and i'm just going to delete
this file here
okay
and instead we're going to just do
gp init to initialize a new file so i'm
not exactly sure what i did wrong there
i'm just going to paste that back in
because it looks correct to me
oh it's because i did that okay
so that's what i really wanted to do but
i'm just going to go ahead and do that
we'll get rid of these ports
and we'll just say okay let's
fix this get pod
yaml file okay
we'll sync those changes we'll say okay
all right and so from there what we can
do is go back to our project so i click
back on the git pod yaml down below open
in the dashboard
oops uh you know what i want to go to
open in the context here
and then we'll close our old tab and
again we're just going to go and type it
in here i will start using the get pod
button here but i just kind of want to
keep doing this so you kind of see what
it is that we're typing so that you know
it just becomes kind of muscle memory
for you okay
so what i'm expecting this time is for
our command to work and if that's great
what we'll do is proceed onto github and
bitbucket and get that all connected
into a single account
okay so it's just loading up here
and our echo works so this is all in
good shape okay so
uh this is good so i'm just gonna go
back to our context i'm just going to
close back out the old one and so that's
pretty much it that we need to know for
git lab again it's not super complicated
but let's take a look at how we do it
for github and bitbucketnext okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are on
bitbucket so we'll go ahead and create
ourselves a new account here because
it's good to learn all three providers
because there's a high chance that
you'll end up using one of each at some
point so here it's suggested we want to
add jira i'm good i'm just going to hit
next and i probably already have a
bitbucket account because i have jira
not necessarily a separate bitbucket
account here but we'll see what happens
if we try to sign up so it says i
already have an account which is totally
fine i'm going to log in here it's not
like a lot that you're missing here in
terms of the setup process
you know all these things are the same
right you sign up they send a
confirmation email here it's going to
ask me for
a
a username so i'm going to say exam pro
co
and we'll see if it takes that and it
does so we're all good here and we're
going to come in here and see what we
have so before you drop in a bit bucket
tell us some stuff i want to skip this i
don't care about any of that kind of
stuff
and let's see if i have any repositories
in here
and i have one for delithium.js as a to
do again that's coming from
jira
but we don't actually have any
repositories so let's go ahead and set
up a new one here
and so
what we'll do is create a new project so
the project name is going to be called
getpodhello world
and
oh this again this maybe exam pro co
get pod and then the repository will be
uh get pod hello world
and we can make it public or private it
doesn't matter i'm gonna leave this one
private in this case
do we want to read me sounds great what
do you want the main branch to be called
we'll call it main include a git ignore
file sure why not and we'll go ahead and
create this repository
so we are here and notice in the top
right corner there is our get pod button
and again i'm not going to click it for
the time being i just want to keep doing
this at the top here so that again it
becomes muscle memory for you to know uh
what to type just so it's uh there but
uh what we can do is go to the top here
and type in https colon forward slash
forward slash get pod dot io
forward slash pound and hit enter
it says authorize with bitbucket.org so
it already knows that we're logged in
with our github
account this is something to be careful
with because you want to make sure
they're all connected to the same
account
or you'll end up with multiple accounts
which might be annoying so i'm going to
say authorize with bitbucket.org here
it's going to ask me a bunch of options
i'm fine with all this we're going to
say grant access
okay
and we'll give it a moment to start this
environment so you can see that public
repos private repos the process is very
similar sometimes you just have to grant
access to be able to do things
and we'll just wait here for this
environment to set up
there we go and so here it is same
experience everything's the same and i
think i learned my lesson from last time
and so when i opened up this terminal
i'm just going to
create a git pod file there and while
i'm here what i'm going to do is i'm
just going to bump up my font because it
might be a little bit hard for you to
see
and so i'm just going to bump this up to
like 22
okay while i'm here i'm going to change
this to 2. okay
and what we'll do is just go ahead and
close that and so now i'll type in get
gp init
all right and so we'll get that down
here this is still really small that's
kind of bothering me so i'm going to go
down below
go to settings
and
i'm looking for terminal editor font
size we have text editor
font size
terminal maybe
there we go
that's a lot better okay and so
uh from here we can just do the same
thing so i'll go ahead and delete this
out
we'll change this over to
hello
world and then down below this will be
hello world here as well
and as per usual go to the left-hand
side here and i'm going to just go ahead
and add that file and say uh add
a knit
uh git pod file
and we will commit that to our repos
repo save the changes
and as it's going we'll go down below
again clicking on this get pod button
here and we'll open the context to see
uh that commit there and so there it is
there
and again there's really no easy way to
like like to completely terminate a
workspace and reopen it you can stop a
workspace so down below we have the
command palette here but also in the top
left corner you can go here and we have
similar commands i'm probably going to
keep going up here now because this is a
lot shorter but if you stop it that's
not sufficient enough because we want to
terminate and start a new one in order
to iterate on this gitpod yaml file so
what i'll do is i'll go ahead and close
this tab out and i'm going to go to the
top here again type it in so it's
http colon s
colon colon get pod dot io colon colon
forward slash forward slash what am i
talking about and we'll hit enter here
and so you know again it should just
work as per usual so we'll just give it
a moment there to spin up and just make
sure that is working correctly
and there it is so there you go that's
working fine oh it says command not
found so clearly i've made a mistake if
i go back here um i think it's because
i'm using single quotes instead of
double quotes
okay but that doesn't really matter per
se but i'll go ahead and fix that so
change quotes
from single to double okay
but what i want to do is go ahead and
check um the dashboard here so we'll go
there
and from here i'm going to go to my
settings
and we'll take a look here again at
integrations
and we'll just see like
there are clearly different um settings
or permissions
uh per one here okay so just understand
that it's not one to one across them
it's going to be really dependent on the
get provider
so yeah i guess that's
two out of three and so the next video
we'll go look at github okay
[Music]
all right so now we're on the github
website to sign up for our last get
provider that is currently supported uh
with gitpod and so in the top right
corner i'm going to go to sign in
because i already have an account and i
do have one with the android exam pro
co but interestingly enough i never use
this account because i have an older one
but that is totally fine so what i'm
going to do is just go ahead and grab
the password for this
and we're just going to go paste that in
there
whoops we'll try that one more time here
okay i must have grabbed the wrong
password that's totally fine we'll sign
in
oh it's not giving me anything today
we'll try this one more time
there we go okay so it was a bit tricky
but i'm in there and you can see i
already have a follower even though i
don't know why they're following me but
that's totally cool and apparently i
have a very simple example over here
python docs hello world so not a lot
going on in this account which is
totally fine so what i want to do is
create myself a new repository and by
the way if you're creating an account
for the first time it'll probably ask
you a bunch of extra things to ask you
know so
you know whatever whatever is going to
be there that's fine and i guess my
username is exam pro hyphen dev so
that's probably what i called it when i
first created this account and so we're
just going to say git pod
um
hello
world
as per usual let's make this one private
and we'll go ahead and add a git number
file
and we'll say readme file down below
and
it's private so i shouldn't have to
choose a license but we can go here and
just choose none
oh it really wants me to choose one here
oh for ignore okay so like ruby
ah we'll just ignore it we don't need
one that's fine
we're not doing anything serious here
and so now that we have it open again i
know that button's there but we'll come
to it soon enough so i'm just going to
type in https forward slash forward
slash get pod
io forward slash pound enter
and here it says something went wrong
and it just means that you have yet to
connect that account so we'll go ahead
and say authorize probably not the best
wording but that's just what it is and
you'll notice that github has like the
most robust um permissions out of all
the three you can drop down here and
have a lot of options so i'm going to
say authorize get pod i o
okay it's going to say repository not
found it might be private so please
authorize get pod access so again uh
nope it's not a bug it's just you got to
go ahead and hit grant access
and so it says okay what kind of
accesses do you want to give it we'll
say authorize goodpodio
and so what we'll do here is just open
up the dashboards on the top left corner
we're going to say open dashboard
and we'll make our way over to settings
i just want to show you again the
integration so this is what it looks
like
for github
this is what it looks like
for
bitbucket this is what it looks like for
gitlab so you can just see it's slightly
different for each one
and same routine here i'm curious to see
if it's preserved my font size and it
totally did i think this is all
happening with sync settings so down
below see where it says settings sync is
on so this is on by default and that's
what's
causing all these settings to remain
available if we turned it off i think
it'd probably end up resetting i feel no
reason to turn off settings links to
show that so we'll just leave it as is
but what i'm going to do again is open
up a new terminal so in the top left
corner we're going to go terminal new
terminal
and we'll go ahead and type in
get pod so gp and type in init i'll open
up that new file there and we'll just go
ahead and delete that out as per usual
and we'll say hello world
and it's interesting this has single
quotes so it should have worked for the
other one i'm surprised it didn't work
and it was double quotes
but we'll try with single quotes again
we'll go back over here we'll add that
file we'll say uh add a net getpod.yaml
file
okay
and we will hit changes sync the changes
we'll say okay open the context so here
we'll say open context
and so there is that getpodganimal file
updated
so that's pretty straightforward for
integrations
and so i think the next thing i would
like to do
is to show you how to install the
bookmark extension
and how to use the bookmarklet so i'm
not going to close all this stuff i'll
close this tab here we don't need that
and
from here i'm just going to
go to my chrome extensions
okay so we'll say chrome extensions
and i'm just going to uninstall it so
here i have git pod i'm just going to
remove it okay
and we'll go back here and so now we
don't have that button
whoops uh let's refresh that one more
time
yep so that button is gone
and so i'll show you how to install the
extension next okay
hey this is andrew brown and welcome
back to another follow along here and in
this case what we're going to do is set
up the browser extension so what i'm
going to do is make a new tab here we're
going to go get pod i o now you just
type in browser extension
and so from here we'll go to this page
here it's under the documentation under
here
and so if we scroll on down we can see
that we have support for chrome and
firefox and we probably should try out
another browser but we'll just do this
for chrome for the time being
and i'm just going to go ahead and add
to chrome
we'll say add extension
okay and so already in the top here it
seems like it's uh turned on
up here
and so if you want to know where that is
we type in chrome forward slash sports
extensions and here is where you can see
it go to details i don't think there's
anything interesting here but you can
see there is some white listed stuff
here sometimes extensions have
additional options down below but uh
nothing uh super exciting here so we'll
just go ahead and close that and so now
what we have is this nice button oh
sorry i got a refresh wrong button sorry
and so again we can hit the get pod
button and so that's just going to save
us the trouble of having to type in git
pod io i don't know if you saw it but
i'll close it again but watch here very
close i'm going to click it and notice
it has that extension in the front there
so there's a workspace already running
so that's fine we'll just say okay let's
take that one we don't need to spin up
another one
and so
um
you know here's that environment notice
it's saying
bash hello world cannot be found
and i'm not sure why we're getting that
there must be something wrong here
it has the single quotes oh because this
is not name
okay
that's our problem so i kept on having
that init there and it was actually
trying to run it as a command so that
makes sense we'll say fix init commit or
fix uh name of
task there
and we'll commit that
and so now i can just close that tab out
and from there i can just hit the button
again and that's a lot nicer because you
know every time you type it in at the
top it overrides that page where if you
click that button opens in a new tab
and that is a lot nicer
oh and by the way i didn't want to open
a running workspace i want to hit that
button and create a new workspace
okay because we want to see if that git
pod yaml uh will work this time around
so we'll give it a moment here and we
can see there it is it's still saying
that did not commit that file
still says init
okay we'll save that maybe i did not
commit it
fix
name of task
add that again
we will save that we'll sync those
changes we'll go ahead and close that
tab we'll hit the button again
and now we have two of those
environments so you can only run so many
environments in parallel and for the
free tier which i believe that we are on
we're going to hit that limit very soon
if we keep doing that but again those
environments will shut down after three
minutes if you want them to shut down
right away
um
you can go into your workspace and
terminate them i don't think there's an
option to terminate from here there's
only the option to stop
right which i think they should have a
terminate button but um you know that
might be something in the future
and so here it's did is this not
updating
am i crazy did i did i not launch a new
one so i'm going to go here and refresh
this page
it's still saying that okay
what am i doing wrong here
so we go here
name
save
right
we go over here on the right hand side
we're going to add it
i'm going to see what's been changed
init to name right and we'll just say
fixed name task
and i want to
commit
i'm going to go back here
refresh
and
there are no stage changes commit if
this happens because usually there's a
sync button i press it right away
so i'm just going to do git status here
get pushed maybe
okay there we go so usually you hit that
sync button i'm so used to clicking it
so fast but just make sure that you push
it and then we'll go back here give this
a refresh
okay i must have not been pressing that
sync button if i go back to that video i
never knew what that that prompt was i
assumed it was like push or pull but if
that doesn't work for you just do the
push there and now i'm very confident if
we open this up it's going to have the
behavior that we want
okay so we'll just give it a moment here
and there we go okay so just be be uh
be wary of that i'm just going to want
to see if that actually prompts let me
say hello world again
we're going to add that and just say
minor change
and we'll save that yeah sync changes so
you really have to press that so this
action will pull and push and pull
requests two bits from origin so say
okay
and so that's probably what i wasn't
doing
um but yeah so we saw it for chrome now
let's go take a look at firefox i'll be
back here in a second all right so i've
opened up firefox which is a different
kind of browser and what i'm going to do
is go ahead and sign into my github here
so what we'll do is just
type in
the username here is exam pro dev and
then i'll just put the password in there
we'll sign in
and i do not need that saved there so
we'll go into here and so notice we
don't have that button so on the gitpod
website we go to docs and on the
left-hand side we are looking for
configure
or maybe it's getting started
oh integration sorry and then under here
we'll go to browser extension
and from there we'll click firefox and
we'll add that extension
we'll say add
and so now that extension is available
so we'll say ok
so let's go ahead and close that tab i'm
not sure what happens if we click here
so firefox prevented the site from
opening a pop-up we'll say options and
say allow pop-ups for gitpodio
and so it brings you to the login page
which is nice
but what i'm going to do is just close
out these tabs here and our button now
up here so we'll go ahead and hit click
get pod
and so we have the option so how do you
want to log in we're going to say github
and we'll just see what this looks like
i'm not going to be doing everything in
chrome but i just want to show you
uh you know that experience okay
so
there we go so we have hello world which
is uh very good same experience right
it's not going to be anything different
um you know it's just a different
browser
um
and so you know i just want to point out
that uh this will work in other ones as
well so maybe we'll take a look at
microsoft edge next okay
all right so now i have microsoft edge
installed this is the um i don't know if
it's still the default browser but it's
the browser made by microsoft and it's a
chromium based browser so this extension
work with anything like chrome
microsoft edge braving it's
chromium-based and so what we'll do is
go ahead and sign into our github
account
so we'll go here and we'll just type in
exam prodev
because we just want to see if the
experience is slightly different and
then from here we'll just type in get
pod i o
and from there we'll go to docs
and we'll go to integrations
and since we know that it's a chromium
chromium browser i'm assuming that if we
go here it should work
so it says you can now add extensions
from the the chrome web store to
microsoft edge which sounds really great
and so i go down below here and i'm just
looking for
a place to add i don't see a button here
so allow extensions from other stores
microsoft does not verify extensions
installed from third-party stores to get
um extensions verified go to microsoft
edge add-ons so let's go check out the
add-ons because this is the chrome store
and i'm sure it will work from here but
i'm just curious if it's in here
because it seems like if this is the
official way maybe we should go here and
see there
so let's say git pod
dot io
and so i don't see it in here and so if
git pod if you're watching maybe you
might want to get this in here and i'm
assuming this is um
extensions because i see grammarly in
here okay but let's go ahead and just
say allow extensions from other stores
so it's permitted and so now we can say
add to chrome we're technically not
using chrome we're using microsoft edge
and so now we have that button there
notice that we actually get a button
whereas in chrome we don't if we do that
brings us just like how firefox does
and so what i want to do here let's see
if it's the same thing chrome
uh extensions does that work ah it's
edge extensions which is fine so here
you can see it we turn on and off look
at the details very similar but we'll go
back over here and i want to go to get
pod hello world and we'll click on get
pod
and we'll have to log in with github
same story you know
and sure we'll launch the existing
workspace no reason to launch a new one
this one will launch really fast because
of it
and it's the same experience so yeah i
mean we could look at brave as well but
i think the process is going to be the
same
brave is just another browser that we
can utilize okay but uh there you go
okay i decided to do brave just for fun
and so here i have the brave browser
open and we're gonna make our way over
to github
and just see what we can do here and see
if the process is any different i'm sure
it's the same it'll be super unexciting
but let's do it anyway okay
so we'll say exam pro dev we'll go ahead
and paste that on in there
and so from here we can go to our
repository
oh and we need the extension right so
we'll type in git pod io
and from here we'll go to whoops docs
integrations
browser extension and we will click
chrome because it's a chrome based one i
don't know if like brave has like brave
add-ons
like their own extension store maybe
um
we'll go to extensions here
so maybe go to the web store here and it
just goes to google chrome so that tells
us that you know they don't have their
own store like microsoft does here or
add-on place you know we'll just say add
to brave we'll say add extension
there it is
looks the same
we'll go ahead and see if that button
exists there we'll refresh
we'll hit get pod here we'll say github
again
we'll continue with the same workspace
so it just runs a bit faster
and there we go so we've launched it in
chrome
within
firefox edge and brave
i don't have safari on this computer but
can we do safari on windows safari
windows
right
i think there is one so if there is
we'll give it a try but i mean we pretty
much exhausted all the browsers here so
you know if there's safari and i can
install it here i'll in the next video
will be seeing if we can install with
safari okay
[Music]
okay i'm back and
i was thinking about using safari but we
can't install it on windows anymore
and it'd be too hard to record on my uh
my mac computer so what i'm going to do
is just use opera instead and opera has
been a browser for a very long time i'm
not sure what they've been doing with it
but i have a strong feeling that we will
not be able to install
the chrome the chromium extension on
opera unless it actually is using chrome
underneath but let's go find out so the
first thing is
let's just go to get pod io
okay and
we'll first see if it it we install that
chrome extension and then we'll go log
into our github as per usual so we'll go
to docs we'll go to integrations
and from here we'll go to
extension
and i think that it won't work here so
we go to chrome
oh
is
is opera
is opera a chromium browser let's go ad
extension see i didn't think it was
based off of chrome
well that messes up my whole example and
git pod you're going to have to say that
it works with
wells and other chromium browsers so i
guess they kind of
got all those edge cases i was hoping to
find one that's not chromium-based and
so now i really think that i really do
have to try it on safari to find out if
there is a use case there so i guess if
we go over to
our github now
i'm so disappointed that that that that
actually worked okay
um but we'll just type in exam pro
dev
we'll put the password in there
and we'll go see that there's a button
yeah the button's there great so what
browser
browser that is not chromium-based
uh windows
is there anything
see i don't know anymore like what's
pale moon best browsers that are not
based on chromium
pale moon web browser
never heard of this
really
film is an open source
browser
let's give it a try so what i'll do is
i'll just be back here in a moment and
we'll take a look at pale moon okay
because i just want to see a browser
that's not chromium okay
all right so unfortunately github does
not work with palemoon and neither does
gitpod and so unfortunately we can't use
this cool new browser but we'll have to
do is go back to opera and pretend that
this extension never worked and that we
have a reason to use the bookmarklet um
and so what we'll do is just bookmark
this here in the top right click here
edit say launch and get pod and then
we'll have to put that javascript here
so we'll type in get pod bookmarklet
all right and from here we have some
javascript we'll go ahead and copy that
make our way back here right click edit
if it seems like i'm going fast it's
because i've shot this video like four
times
and so i'm just hoping that it works
smoothly this time around but so we have
our button we'll go ahead and click the
get pod it might prompt us if we need to
authorize so just give it access if you
do and as that launches i'm going to go
ahead and copy this code so we can just
take a look at it
and so here we are i'm going to make a
new file here but you can see that it
worked no problem right um
but i just kind of want to show you the
javascript
because it's really really simple
like you know it's just looking or you
get lab github get bucket and then open
this thing and so if we wanted to extend
this this is just javascript you can do
whatever you want with it so if we want
to do something fun like get pod and
vars
we can actually embed environment
variables into our url so down below
here we kind of have the syntax here for
doing that
okay
and so
i pretty much how that knows how that
works so we would just type in something
like
my env equals production
or maybe development
that'd make more sense
we'd have a four slash because that's
how it works
and we go ahead and save that and then
we would go ahead and copy that just
make sure that's saved i'm going to
close that environment close this one
we're going to right click edit
and just paste in the new contents i'm
going to make sure that that is there so
i don't have to triple check and so
we'll hit save and now if we launch get
pod that environment variable should get
passed along so it's just like a kind of
cool way to modify it there's probably
more interesting things that we could do
so you could technically maybe write
your own contexts if you wanted to
but of course git pod only supports
particular context so let's see if our
environment variable shows up here so
we'll just type in grep
my env grep is just a way of searching
okay and there it is we can type in echo
and type in my env
and there it is so there you go that is
the bookmarklet for when you cannot
install chrome extensions whether your
browser does not support it or whether
your admins have locked down your
browser because it's a workstation or
what have you but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at git pod configuration
files and so this allows you to
configure a workspace and so we say
workspace we're saying configure a
developer environment
when at first launch
so the gitpod configuration file is a
yaml file that must be named period
gitpodperiod.yaml so the period or dot
that's in the front there tells linux
that it's a hidden or secret file and
that's not so important but what's
important is that you remember to have
that dot or period in the front and it
needs to be present at the root of your
git repository you can only have a
single gitpod yaml file so you can't
make a bunch of folders and then
put a bunch in there thinking you're
going to customize all those folders
it's just a single one and so here's an
example of a
gitpod configuration file we're going to
see a lot of different kinds throughout
this course but this is a very simple
one where it's installing dependencies
using yarn for javascript it's opening
up port 8000 and then it's going to
allow us to view the website inline in
the code editor so the following can be
defined in the gitpod configuration file
and so we're going to go look at a quick
list of the configuration options and
then we'll deep dive in upcoming videos
on all these options so the first is
checkout location so where gitpod checks
out the project's code which will
default to workspace git config so
defining a workspace git configuration
github dot pre builds configure the
gitpod github app specifically for
continuous pre-built and you can do
pre-builds with get lab and bitbucket
it's just that github has some
additional options here we have image so
define custom docker image this defaults
to git pod forward slash workspace full
we have ports so define ports exposed
for public access tasks so define a list
of terminal windows to be open and
associated scripts to be run when
launching a new workspace vs
code.extensions a specified list of vs
code extensions to install when
launching a new workspace workspace
location so which path gitpod considers
the project's workspace default
directory and this will default to
workspace i could really use a comma
oops
i could really use a comma right here
but yeah those are the settings and we
will look at them in greater detail okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
looking at how do we actually initialize
a get pod configuration file so to
initialize a git pod configuration file
there are two approaches the first is
very simple create a dot get pod yaml
file from scratch and just start filling
it in that's the way i generally do it
but they do have this convenience
cli command called gp init and this will
generate a
sample.gitpod.yaml file so this is what
it looks like
i don't find this particularly useful
but you know if you find this easier to
do than right-clicking and creating a
file it's up to you but i just wanted to
know that both options were available
but in either case you need to commit
this dot
gitpod.yaml to your codebase because um
you know it's not going to stick around
if you don't and we'll learn that as we
look at the iterative workflow okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and what we're
going to do in this follow along is look
at how to initialize a github
configuration file of course we have
done this in a previous follow along but
let's just do it again for good measure
to make sure that we know how to do it
so i'm going to go ahead and create a
new repository i'm going to say git pod
and i'm going to call this uh
init so this will be to
initialize
a get pod configuration file
and then from here we can make it public
or private doesn't matter i'm going to
make it
private
and we'll go ahead and add a readme file
and we'll create that repository
so here is our repository and i have the
chrome extension installed so i'll go
ahead and hit the get pod button
all right and so our workspace has
started now so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to open up terminals i'll go
file up here the hamburger menu
i always say file but it's actually
hamburger menu terminal new terminal and
we'll give it a moment here to load and
so we'll just type in gp init and so the
gpinit command is used for setting up an
initial gitpod file and that's all there
really is to it again you can of course
just right click and create that file
you want and the key thing to remember
is that you need that period in front of
the git pod there for it to work
um but you know we can go ahead and just
save this file and commit it
just say commit
initialize
a git pod yaml file and that's all there
really is to it okay
so we'll just say okay
and we'll go back here and just refresh
here
and we could launch this again just to
see the results here but you know not
much to here to see but just remember
that's gp init
[Music]
so when you're developing your gitpod
configuration file it is standard
practice to keep terminating and
launching new workspaces until you get
your ideal configuration so let's kind
of visualize what that workflow looks
like so the idea is you're going to have
this git pod yaml file you're going to
either be creating it or modifying it
and once you're happy with its current
state you're going to go and commit that
to your git repository once that is
committed you're going to terminate the
current workspace so that could just be
uh
telling it to
delete or just closing out the tab and
then you're going to launch a new
workspace and you're going to observe
the start task did it do what it was
supposed to do we need to tweak it and
if it is uh requires more tweaking we're
going to go back and modify our git pod
yaml file again and go through this
entire process until we're happy with it
and then we can just start using our
developer environment as expected but
what i really want you to know and this
is what created a lot of confusion for
me initially is that stopping and
starting an existing workspace will not
produce the desired results since the
before and init commands for a star task
will not be performed so uh there is an
execution order there's three things
it's um before init
and command and so the only way to
really make sure that your start tasks
like to be able to debug them or or to
develop on them is to always
terminate and launch a new workspace
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and in this
follow along we're going to learn about
how the iterative workflow works when
you are
trying to update your gitlab
configuration file many times to get to
the state that you want it to be in uh
because there is some confusion between
starting and stopping and terminating
and i want to make that very clear so
what we're going to do is create a new
repository here we're going to call it
get pod iterative
workflow
and i'm going to make it private for fun
we're going to call it a readme file of
course you can make it public but
you know doesn't really matter i'm not
going to launch gitpod right away i'm
just going to go ahead and add a file
just to save us a bit of time because
you know there is the stopping and
starting of those workspaces it takes
time and i just want to set up one with
uh tasks and we're going to just have a
task
for um
each state so we're gonna we're gonna
need it's before
a knit
and command and i'm just gonna do an
echo in each of these ones
okay so we'll do this
init
echo before
all right so we have our three this
should all be fine we'll go ahead and
commit this file and now what i can do
is start up this environment and i'll
see you back here in a moment okay all
right so after a short little wait there
our environment has launched and notice
that it's ran before a knit command so
what is going to happen
if we um stop this environment so over
here we can do stop workspace
and what we'll do is we'll see what runs
here so just give it a second sometimes
it takes a moment to kick in for
it to stop so just wait
and it looks like it's starting to do
something
there we go so it's going to stop
sometimes when i stop it might say
superficially like oh this workspace is
gone so just don't worry about the
getpod errors they're not always 100
accurate and they don't always happen
but you know just have confidence of
what you are doing
so this is going to stop and once this
is fully stopped
um and that doesn't usually take that
long we're going to start it up so i'll
just wait here a moment so i can show
you that i'll press the start button
again so here we go and we'll go ahead
and open this workspace again and i'll
see you back here in a moment when the
environment has started up again okay
all right so after a short little wait
here it has launched again and notice
that it's running the before and command
so if we go back into here we have
before init command so anytime you
launch
a a regular workspace it's always going
to run
uh before a net command for the first
time but any restarts it's always going
to run before and command and you're
going to get used to this because when
we start looking at the execution order
steps between pre-builds and without
pre-builds you're going to start to see
this pattern
but what i want to do now is just to
completely terminate the environment and
so you know if you want to terminate you
can stop this current one if you're
worried about lots of parallel
environments running but what i normally
do is i just go ahead and close the tab
and in three minutes that environment
will shut down on its own um i don't
know if gitpod really has an option for
um terminating it terminate yeah i think
you always have to stop at first so if i
go here
i can i can delete it okay so if i want
to i can delete it here but again this
is nothing i ever think about i just um
close the tab and it goes away which is
really nice but what we'll do is we'll
launch a new environment so we'll just
click the get pod button
and see it thinks that this one's still
running we're gonna ignore it hit the
new workspace button okay
and sometimes i forget what i'm doing
and i might relaunch an existing
workspace so you just have to be uh
considerate and think about you know
maybe i did this maybe i did that okay
and so i'll see you back here when this
is started okay
all right welcome back so you can see in
the case that we terminate it it runs
before init command all right and so
this again is really important because
if you are trying to develop this and
you're doing multiple iterations you
really want to know that in it's not
going to run every single time so you
really always always always want to
just close the tab and then launch a new
workspace okay and so you know hopefully
that's clear and saves you some trouble
so there you go
[Music]
so the most important part to a git pod
configuration file in my opinion are the
start tasks because these define a list
of terminal windows to be open and
associate scripts to be run when
launching a new workspace so here is an
example
of um and this is actually my marketing
website uh
of a kit pocket configuration file and
so what's happening here is we have
three tasks defined we have one called
html so that's going to be running or
building out html files we have this
next one here for generating out
javascript and css and then it's going
to continuously watch
uh
for changes and then we have a
task that will serve the website so we
can view it and then down below here
we're opening up port 3000 and then
we're going to
open it in the browser so when you have
that and uh
you start up your workspace you're going
to see these three tabs and notice that
the names match so we have html
js for css and serve and over here you
can see that it is a running
http server over here so a start task
has the following properties you have a
name so the name
that will appear within the terminal as
we can see there
the before command so a command that
will run once at the launch of a new
workspace
the init command a command to run once
at the launch of new workspace expects
to terminate and i ran out of room here
but this one expects to terminate as
well but we will repeat that multiple
times in this course then we have the
command command which is confusing to
say when you say that out loud but
that's what it's called and that runs at
the launch of a new or existing
workspace and can be continuously
running so an example of here we have
that hp server it of course continuously
runs and then the npn run watch that is
something that continuously runs then
you have env so this allows you to set
environment variables scoped for the
task and we have the open mode so how
the terminal windows should be opened
whether it's going to be
tab after tab before split right
split left okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown we are taking a
look at execution or steps for tasks and
so a task has three possible steps in
its execution order uh and you could say
steps so you could say command i'm going
to call them steps because there is a um
a step called command and then i'm going
to be saying command command that gets
confusing but we have before init and
command and so let's just kind of talk
about their application so for before
you're applying light configuration of
the environment before init or command
step runs and that will make sense when
we start seeing like how these run with
pre-builds or no pre-builds then we have
a knit so for heavy configuration
environments so compiling resources
installing packages
and then commands so starting
continuously running servers like a
database or web server
if that doesn't make sense don't worry
because we're going to look at these in
a few different ways and i was very hard
to kind of describe what these three
boxes are
but you know i think we'll just go
through that iterative process and we
will understand uh gen absolutely before
the end of this course what goes in
before a knit and command so there is no
guarantee of the order of the execution
for start tasks and so when i say that i
don't mean that
like there's a guarantee that i'll go
before a knit or command but when you
have a collection of those
like more than one task there's no
guarantee of that okay so you can uh
have terminals depend on the completion
of other commands via the sync await and
sync done and we will definitely look at
that in the course here uh there is a
guarantee of the execution order as uh
for before a net command for a task so
for the individual execution of
this
we just saw that will always be the same
okay so the execution order varies uh in
the case of when launching a new
workspace without pre-builds and then
when launching a new workspace with
pre-builds and we will look at those
right now okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and what i want
to do in this follow along is just to
kind of look at a practical example of
execution doorstep so you can kind of
understand the context of when you put
something in the before the init and the
command and it's not like a perfect
science
and i think you just kind of have to
figure your way through it and look at a
lot of examples but i'm just trying to
think of one where i know somebody is
using
um git pod in a more complex use case
and one would be something like forum so
i definitely know forum has a git pod
gamble file i think i was saying to them
earlier this week it was not working
properly but they may have fixed it
since then but we're not interested
really whether or not it uh like the
application works but more so the fact
that how are they using it like those
execution order steps so notice they
have a docket.yaml file in a
gitpoddocker file if you don't know what
form is form is this platform that
allows you to host your own
um
form essentially if you ever heard of
like dev.t.o like this here
this is what this is so the great thing
is we can go ahead and hit our git pod
button and we'll just wait for this to
spin up and then once it's there we'll
see if it actually is working as
expected if it doesn't it's fine but
what we're really interested in is
expecting that git pod yaml file okay
all right so after waiting a little
while here the environment has spun up
and so what we'll do is just take a look
at what is going on there's a lot of
things popping up asking me to do stuff
and so here we can see that we have two
tabs on the right hand side so we have
form server bash open site gp
so what we'll do is go on the left hand
side here and take a look at the get pod
yaml file as soon as i can find it here
um
and if i can't find it that way we can
just hit control p i believe and just
type in dot git pod yaml
okay this is not specific to git pod but
this is how vs code opens files anywhere
so instead of me having to look through
all these things i can just do that so
that is the file that i'm interested in
so we'll do is open it up and so here we
can see that they are specifying a
custom image which is totally fine it's
not going to make this too confusing
they have a lot of ports open so 3000 30
35 5432 that's for postgres i'm not sure
what this is for this is for the the
ruby on rails web server this is for
redis just because i know these port
numbers i just don't know what this
one's for so we'll go here and we have
some tasks and the first thing they have
for this task is the form server
and they have a before and a knit and
command and so in there before what
they've decided to do is start up the
redis server uh then they are doing an
await ports they're waiting for 5432 to
happen and then they're doing sleep i'm
not sure what the sleep is for
okay and so that means that um
until port is open then proceed forward
which is fine
and i'm not i'm not sure what a single
ampersand means unless i just remove
that by accident i don't think i did so
that kind of interested in what that
does
um again assuming that you know i didn't
just introduce that mistake which i
don't think i did and then we have this
git pod init sh so they're running
initialization script so this could have
a bunch of stuff in it let's just take a
look there
get pod
init sh
so here
they are copying environment variable
installing a couple gems running been
set up and that's kind of nice where
it's like okay maybe you have a lot that
you want to run here so you just
abstract it out into there and then here
they run the bin startup command
okay and then down below they have open
site so it looks like they just do this
to force uh get pod to open it up and
this is kind of nice um i didn't know
you could do this so i think when i did
the follow along i had something a lot
more complicated so i'm gonna have to go
back and
borrow that because that is definitely a
lot easier all right so this one really
just opens up the site and this one is
doing this now what's interesting is
that they started the redis server here
because what they could have done is
they could have just made a separate
task here called redis server
right and from here
what they could have done is done this
on the
um
like command step
right and so
that's what i would have done i would
have said redis server and then if i had
a ruby on rail server i would have done
ruby on rails
okay
but that's not what they did so they
decided to put in the before command and
that's totally valid so that's just me
trying to say like
it's not a perfect science you have to
decide if you want to put something in
the before or if you want to make it a
separate tab for me i prefer to break it
all up into separate tabs and before is
really designed for um
you know like if you had to change ruby
versions or things like that at least
that's what i think it's for
but just understand that you know it's
gonna vary for that kind of stuff
and so you know hopefully that gives you
kind of an idea for execution or steps
we're going to iterate on this quite a
few times so we'll get it by the end of
this course okay
and by the way we are done here so we
can just go ahead and close that tab i'm
just going to go back to my homepage
there and we are done
[Music]
so let's take a look at the execution
order steps when launching a new
workspace without pre-builds and what's
important here is that all steps will
run within the current workspace so
we've got before init and command so
let's talk about what we're going to use
these commands for so before
is great when we want to customize the
terminal install global dependencies and
we expect the commands to terminate so
an example here
for the before would be something like
rvm or nvm so you're switching to the
ruby
ruby version that you want to use or the
javascript version that you want to use
so that's kind of an example there
and so for net we are downloading and
installing dependencies compiling source
code running your test suite and again
we expect our commands to terminate so
examples here would be bundle stall yarn
install rake db create so what's
happening here is we are installing ruby
dependencies javascript dependencies
creating our database for a ruby on
rails application possibly
um and then we have our command so
the idea here is you're going to start
your continuous continuous running
servers you're going to run your build
scripts to build assets and this last
command can be continuously running so
here we are starting a rails server so
hopefully that gives you an idea what's
going on here but the reason why
these ones have to terminate is because
of pre-builds because
these will get pushed onto pre-builds
and you know you can't have something
continuously running or the pre-build
will never end but we'll talk about that
in the next slide okay
[Music]
so now let's take a look at the
execution order steps when we are
launching a new workspace with
pre-builds enabled so not all steps are
executed in the new environment so on
the left-hand side it's going to look a
little bit different we're going to have
our pre-build environment which is only
going to run the before and init then
we're going to have the new workspace
that's going to run the before and
command and so the idea behind having
this pre-built environment at where it's
running the before knit commands it's
going to
create a snapshot that will be then used
later on when we launch our new
workspace environment to reduce our boot
time
so looking at our previous script there
we would do the before here so changing
our ruby version and then here we would
install our dependencies create our
database
um and then down below in this new
workspace this is when you start a new
workspace with a pre-build it's going to
run the before and command so just
describing what we're doing with the new
workspace here the developer saves time
because they don't have to wait for the
length of the inits compile independent
libraries so that's just me redescribing
what i just said here after talking
about the reduced boot time so here we
would do the before again and then we'd
run our command
so it's really important to think about
the fact that these are isolate
environments because
as you develop your git pod
configuration files you're going to have
to realize that
you know stuff is not going to carry
over to the next uh workspace so if you
do this rake db crate and it populates a
bunch of data
and you need that in your uh workspace
it might not be there
okay
so or like if you cd into
if you cd into a particular directory
right
um and you think that you're going to be
seated in that directory when you're
over here you might not be there so
that's something that you'll have to
play around with it's not too bad you
start to get uh get the idea but i i had
a script that i was using that was uh
before pre-build and it worked fine and
then when i moved to pre-build i had to
take in consideration that these are
isolate environments here and not
everything carries over okay so there
you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
talking about gitpod configuration files
and specifically how to write multi-line
tasks so if you want to perform a series
of commands within a task step there are
several options available of course you
can do it as one line and the way you
would do with one line is you'd have to
use double ampersand i bet you could
also probably use a a semicolon but
double ampersand is probably going to be
recommended if you're not familiar with
double ampersand the idea is that if
this command fails then it's not going
to run the next command okay but if you
wanted the next command to run
i suppose you'd have to use a semicolon
to denote the next line okay so if you
want to do multi-line what we can do is
use this
closing angle bracket and then followed
by the next lines you're going to have
to have double ampersand the reason why
is that when you use this uh closing
angle bracket it's going to take all
these lines and it's going to remove all
the new lines and treat it as a single
line so it's pretty much like writing
this but multi-line okay
and then we have this other one where we
use a pipe and the pipe will
add a new line so these will be
sequentially um
these will run sequentially in order and
generally in this case you probably
wouldn't use double ampersand because
it's not going to play well with that
new line and if you're wondering about
this like
angle bracket and pipe and you might
think that it is actually get pod
configuration file specific but it's
actually just yaml's multi-line syntax
so if you investigate on how yaml
multi-line works that tells you what you
can do here and there's actually more
you can do
um but you know i'm not going to show it
to you here because it's just start we
start again the weeds and it's not use
cases that are useful but just
understand that if you learn a bit more
about yaml you'll learn uh how you'll
have more flexibility with the git pod
configuration file okay
[Music]
this is andrew brown and this follow
along i want to show you about
multi-line strings uh within git pods so
when you are creating tasks you can make
your life a little bit easier so i'm
going to do is go ahead and create a new
repo here and we're going to call it git
pod multi-line and i will go ahead and
make this a private repository
and so from here we will go ahead and
launch a new git pod and so i have this
tab open here called yaml
hyphen multi-line info because i want
you to understand that this multi-line
syntax is not specific to git pod but it
is part of
it is part of yaml which is the language
we use and so here on the left hand side
we have an example where it says replace
new lines with spaces keep new lines so
this is the difference between
the
closing angled bracket and using a pipe
okay
so you know when we have a pipe it says
keep new lines so every new line that
you use will stay there replace new
lines with spaces meaning that it'll be
treated as one block of text so let's go
take a look and it looks like our
environment is ready i'm going to go
ahead and open up a new terminal as per
usual and we're going to run the get pod
knit command to initialize a new project
so
um there of course are a few ways we can
do this so the first is the fact that we
can just have and we're going to keep
playing with echoes because echoes are
easy
but we could say like hello and then
ampersand ampersand world
so this is a linux thing the double
ampersand and what it means is it says
oh nice it actually shows up here so get
puck config a shell came in oh you know
what it's actually auto completing this
but double ampersand is a way of
um
running more than one command at a time
so it'll say okay i'm going to run this
command and as long as it doesn't fail
as long as it doesn't exit go run the
next command
okay so that would be that one there
and there's also uh the case of um and
you know what i'm going to do these all
under commands because i just want to
make sure this runs every single time
what i'm going to do is put command here
for this one i'm going to do another one
here where we're going to try to do a
semicolon so this uh this is something
you can do in again this is not specific
to git pod or yaml but like when you're
writing bash scripts
you just send a semicolon to say this is
a the next command we want to run
all right
so we have this one where it should run
both
this one where it should run both and
the next one should succeed and then
here we will purposely introduce an
error so maybe if i just do
x like that which is not a real command
it should fail and not run the second
one
all right and so this is multi
um these are multiple examples let's do
one with a script so maybe we can load a
script so we'll just say um
hello world
okay so this might be another way that
we could do uh mult multi-line kind of
scripting here so we'll just say hello
world
as a file we'll say sh for a bash script
and then we'll do echo hello
world i don't know that will print out
to the screen but we'll see what happens
there i'm sure it will still work
and we'll just say sh we'll have to make
that executable down below so i'm going
to type in chamod u plus x
hello world if you're wondering like
what does that mean it means make this
executable so that we can run it like
that
and so
we have semicolon double ampersand
double ampersand with a a purposeful
error and then we also can do
uh this way so that is the um angled
bracket and so we are going to want to
uh do hello here
and then ampersand ampersand world
because if we don't do that
if we don't put the double ampersand
when we're doing the double angle
bracket what's going to happen is this
is going to translate
into this right and that would cause an
error because it would think there's no
you can't have a second and third
argument think it's called echo and
these are arguments to echo that
wouldn't work so that's where we need a
double ampersand whereas if we do this
okay
we can do that and this is going to be
the equivalent of basically doing this
up here where it's like this is a line
and that is a line of execution
so i think this is everything that
should work i'm not sure what kind of
problems we're going to run into but i'm
going to just close out the rest here
and we'll go ahead and commit this to
our repository here and the great thing
is because these are all commands
uh we can start this over and maybe it
might be smart to give these names
so i'm just going to go here and say
name this will say semi semicolon
okay we'll go to the next one here and
this one's going to be
double ampersand
we'll go to the next one here
and we'll say
double maybe just double amp because
it's getting too long here double amp
fail
i wonder if we could just do this
you know
i don't see why i can't be named that
that might just be easier
okay and this would just be double
ampersand and then we'll do semicolon
here and then this one will be um
bash script
and you know i didn't do a shebang here
i don't know if that's going to cause a
problem i'm going to put a shebang in
there just in case i'm going to say
where is um
sh or bash
okay a shebang just means tell the
script to run a particular way a shebang
is the um
is this thing so say run in the context
of that so i'm just doing that just in
case and so we will name it that
and then here we will do this multi-line
so you can say multi-line multi-command
is what we're learning here and so these
are all the variants that should be
possible here
and i'm hoping they all work the first
time around here because that would be
really nice but this is our file right
so these are all the different kinds of
cases you could do
and so we'll go back over here and we're
just going to go ahead and whoops add
these two files so we'll add that
and i want to stage that as well we'll
just say
commit
multiline
we'll go ahead and add that there
all right and so now that's all
committed and in order for this to
execute we can terminate this
environment or just stop and start it
since we know how it works so we know
command will run again so that's what
i'm going to do i'm going to
stop this environment
and then we'll let that shut down and
then we'll start it back up and
hopefully they all just work first try
i'm writing quite a bit so i'm not sure
if i'm making any mistakes there
okay so we're ready to go here it says i
didn't uh commit a change maybe i didn't
so if it doesn't run that's fine but i
think that it will because the file is
in there
okay so looking here it looks like it
didn't execute those so i guess the
problem here is we're really going to
just have to um make sure these are
committed so let's say git push here
okay and then we will stop it again
see i'm surprised that i would have
thought that it would have executed
even if it wasn't committed if it was
just lingering changes but we'll see
here we'll open it again we'll see if
that's the case
all right and
did it work
so it didn't do
anything new
so i'm kind of surprised
i'm just double checking to see i don't
have any syntax mistakes so i'm really
surprised that stopping start didn't
work in this case
maybe it's because none of these uh
these are initialized so probably if we
had
completely terminated and started it
again and maybe start and stop it would
do it again so i think that's what i'm
going to do i'm going to just
um because the thing is is that when you
stop and start it's it's redoing the
state right so if those if those
terminals don't exist it probably
doesn't have anything to launch into i
think that's just an edge case that um
until now because i'm trying this now i
didn't realize which is totally fine so
we'll go ahead and close this tab we're
going to just refresh here as a sanity
check to make sure that stuff is in
there we're going to go launch get pod
again okay
and this is the reason why it's not
working unparsable get pod configuration
yaml cannot be read block mapping entry
a multi-line key may not be an implicit
key so the problem is
the problem is i have invalid yaml so if
that's the case i need to have a way of
validating my yaml so maybe we'll say
like validate yaml
vs code maybe there's like a plug-in
so there's this um i kind of feel like
this would already have it but let's go
take a look and see if we can find it
here
like do we already have yaml installed
because this is already installed see
it's already installed
and so i'm not sure
there probably is like a validate right
enable or disable this feature validate
it seems like it should be validating it
and
i already forgot what the error was
so let me just take a look here
i wonder if it's just the indentation
here
okay i'm just going to carefully look at
this here
for this we don't really need the name
well i probably have the names i don't
know these are messing it up so
sometimes using single sometimes using
doubles
i'm just going to do this here
and so i think it was that indentation
so what we'll do is we'll recommit this
file here
all right so
fix get pod gamble file and that could
have been the reason why it wasn't doing
that but i still think that um those
terminals aren't going to launch unless
you um
already have stuff open there so while
that's going i'm just going to read here
a little bit okay
so here's validation detect whether the
entire file valid is is is valid
so like see here they have like hotkeys
so that you know if you're making a
mistake but like
there's nothing there that was telling
me that it was valid or not so
yeah there's something going on there
but uh oh maybe we'll just um we got to
stop this workspace so what we'll do
now this is saved we'll go back here
we'll give this a refresh we'll make
sure that our git pod yaml has been
updated with the indentation we're going
to launch this again we're going to see
what error we get if we get any error at
all
so looks like we don't have any trouble
this time so great so let's go take a
look and see what our results are
so the first one is our first task here
where we're using the semicolon
and it is saying here um hello world so
we can use a semicolon works just as we
expected it to then we have the double
ampersand so again double ampersand
means if this one fails the rest will
not complete so that worked as well then
we go here we'll notice that it failed
on the first one and then it didn't
continue on to the second one so that is
really good that's what we expect
and i guess like if we did the semicolon
one i really didn't show that there i
should have done this
like fail
and maybe we'll rerun it just so we can
view that afterwards then we have the
bash script so it's using the bash
script that is over here so that is
another way we could do it
then we have the multi-line this way so
that was valid so that worked out fine
and then we have uh this one here so i
just want to show you that if you take
these two out this is going to fail
okay so i'll just write fail and maybe
we can just add it in as an extra one
whoops
so what we could do is go here
i just want to show you if you do this
one this one will definitely fail okay
if we take that out like that
it should and we'll go back up to our
semicolon one and this one should fail
as well so
we will give that a go one more time and
um
i'm going to terminate just just in case
so we'll just say
update gitpod yaml file with more
examples
of multi-line
i don't care if it's over the length
it's fine for me we'll sync those
changes very important to sync
we'll give it a moment to sync great
we're going to close it again and we'll
just look at those edge cases there just
one more time okay
and so it's just launching up here
all right so we have a few edge cases so
let's go this one
so this one said hello x command not
found but notice that it executed world
so it didn't stop on the first one so
you go here look it stops on the first
one but with a semicolon it won't so
that's a consideration for you and then
we did the multi bash one and it we have
hello echo world so it didn't um
it didn't crash but it treated like this
was the entire string so you can kind of
see you kind of got a wonky result so
hopefully that shows you how multi-line
works and there's obviously a lot of uh
options for you there and we'll just
close that off and we're done multi-line
[Music]
so let's talk about awaiting tasks
within git pod configuration files so
get tasks all executed in parallel so by
default there is no guarantee
of the order of execution of the overall
tasks okay but there are a couple of
ways we can force a guarantee of the
execution order and the first way is
when we want to wait for command and so
get pod has a cli and they have two
commands called sync await and sync done
so here we have an example
again it's a ruby on rails app um and so
if we look through here let's just try
to find where we see synco wait so
we have this rails app that is starting
up and then we have webpack and it says
sync await for bundle okay
so it's waiting for this command up here
to finish because if bundle install is
not done we should not run
um this command here right and the same
thing for redis and for sidekick until
this command up here runs should it
proceed
but the way it knows that it's done is
that you run this
sync done over here okay so
just erasing all that stuff because i
know it gets kind of messy but the idea
is the idea is going to stop and it's
not going to proceed until this has been
triggered okay and that goes for all the
tasks and so that's a way that we can
force
the order of these tests now there's
another way and this is where we want to
wait for a port so this is where we use
a weight port and it doesn't have like a
a weight or like done port or thing like
that but the idea is that let's say we
have end-to-end testing that we want to
implement and we want to run those tests
but it has to have a running server on
port 3000 so the idea is that it's not
going to run npm run tests until there's
something running on that port and so
when you start up npm run dev it's going
to ask you hey do you want to
open this port you're going to open that
port it's going to see that it's running
and then it's going to run your tests
and so those are our two options there
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and in this
video we are going to take a look at um
uh things where we can await for things
okay so what we'll do is create a new a
repository i'm going to call this one
get pod await since we can await a port
or wait a command and so down below we
will go to private and we will choose
your readme and we'll create this
repository
and we'll go ahead and launch this uh
workspace we might pull up the
documentation here so like a waiting
command
get pod here
and so if we go over here
i'm not sure if it'll show up under here
because that's where these commands show
up like a white port and things like
that
so here we have gp await port 3000
things like that
so
i'm not sure if they show an example
here
but we definitely saw one earlier when
we were looking at form so if we just
want to go back to form for a second
which um had an example of a command i
believe or maybe it was a port
i don't think it had command a
which is not a big deal um i have an
example within the the course here so we
can down below this has a gp await port
so not necessarily the other one but
let's go over here and so something we
can do we'll just go and open up our
terminal as per usual we're going to
type in gpinet to initialize a new task
so we don't make any mistakes here
and so
what i'm thinking here is
let's do a weight command and
what is it called a weight
uh sync await
and sync done that's what we want to do
apparently they have a real world
example so let's take a look here
actually i want to do a ruby on rails
application
so here's an example where they have a
ruby on rails application and they're
kind of waiting for that those kind of
steps i don't know if they have like a
quick start for this um probably would
have been good if there was like a get
pod example here but uh what we'll do is
we'll just kind of make up our own
example from this all right so what we
want to do and i think ruby's installed
here if i type in ruby v it is great so
with ruby you have a thing called gem
files
okay and that's just a way of doing uh
versioning
and gem files are done via bundler so
bundle generate gem file
i'm not sure what the command is i
usually just write it by hand and copy
out code but i wanted just this kind of
information
so that's all actually all i wanted for
the file i thought maybe like a
generation command allow
and so here what we can do is install
some gems
uh very popular gem would be something
like pry that's for like debugging
we don't necessarily need to use it for
anything it's just the fact that it's
going to be here we're also going to
need a now we don't need a docket ignore
file it's totally fine so what i'm going
to do is do a bundle install here oops
bundle install and that's going to
install our dependencies here then we're
going to get a gem file so we can commit
that to our repository
but the idea is that
i want something
to wait on the gem file first
so
and i wish i kind of had an idea of some
kind of
gem that would have been useful for this
case but
actually you know what would be useful
it would be sinatra so instead of doing
pry i think we'll do sinatra
sinatra sinatra is a micro framework for
web applications for ruby sinatra
it's a really great way of learning how
to work with web servers ruby not the
singer but the singer is fine too
and we'll go here and so this is the
most simplest example of a sinatra
application so if we go over here
and we
paste in our sinatra application into a
new file here so just say
server.rb we'll just paste on that code
and so we'll need to put sinatra in here
instead we don't need the pry and
there's some way to start it up on a
different port
i haven't done this in a while so i'm
not sure
um
[Music]
documentation i thought this would have
been like
different port different port
port support sports how do we change the
port
okay
sinatra ruby port change
okay so down below here set port so you
can't you just set the port like that
note that this is another way to bind to
socket so configuration is what we're
looking for
so
here it is okay so here we can change
the port
and i'm going to set this port to
[Music]
stop pasting right now so we'll say set
port 80
80.
just going to double check to make sure
that is correct
the syntax there's a comma in between
okay and so that is the port there
and we have our gem installed which is
great and so i'm gonna actually have to
do a bundle install again because i
actually got rid of pry
we'll give that a moment there to
install
and so what i want to do with this um
task here
is
i want to have one i mean like you
wouldn't do this generally because you
could do it all one command but i'm
going to do one where i install the
dependencies
so we'll say bundle here
and then this one will be like
[Music]
server run
all right and so here what i'm going to
do
is init
and i'm going to just say bundle install
and then for this one down below
instead of a net we're going to just do
command
and here we want to run sinatra so it
has to run in the context of bundle exec
because that's how it knows it's going
to run
that there and we'll do server.rb
and so this one we want this to be open
on port 8080
all right
and
that looks fine i think i might want it
to
also open as well so
let's go over here we saw this in forum
earlier which i thought was really cool
i didn't know that you could use it this
way so i kind of want to give that a go
here
and we'll just say command
and so the idea here is i want this to
open this on port 8080
um
i'm just trying to think of there's
anything else i need to do
because this isn't going to this server
is not going to go to that url so i
might have
to also do
this
which is i need like a forward slash
here i'm not sure how would i how i
would join that
so i'm not sure let me see here i what
if i could do this
what's this do
okay but can i do
this
i'm not sure if we can just do that like
that
so just to make our lives a little bit
easier what i'm going to do is go over
to the server here and just change it to
frank says here
because that'll just be a lot easier for
our example
and um so we have the port open it's in
preview this one's going to launch it so
just open it up
open preview here
and i'll just put this on the same line
here we don't have any issues there and
so i think this is what we want
um but the problem is is that there's no
guarantee that the bundle install is
going to happen
before the server runs and so let's just
go even though i know this is going to
break i want to go ahead and add all
these files here
okay
just say like init file
and i'm just going to double check to
make sure that actually serves something
this is going to serve text which is
fine and so what we'll do is commit all
that
sync the changes
and while we're waiting on that what
we'll do is go ahead and close this tab
here and we'll go ahead and relaunch and
we'll see what happens
all right so here we are and so let's
just see what has happened here
um so we go to bundle install it did the
bundle install which worked out great
and notice here it says bundle install
to install is missing gems so could not
find sinatra 2.10 stuff like that so it
it's possible that this ran
after this so this might have executed
first because this is a very lightweight
would take two seconds to run and this
would take a little bit more time to
install so i just wonder if we were to
go back and execute this command would
it work so it is working so that is
where this sync awaits going to be very
useful for us this didn't open up for us
here unable to connect to the vs code
server error in the request
i think this is also because the port
wasn't ready
all right so what we're going to do here
is we are going to go back to our gitpod
file here
and we're going to use this sync await
thing
so here um
and we probably use port as well but um
it's gp sync await
so what we'll do is say gpsync await
and for this we want this to wait for
the bundle so i'll go here put this on a
new line
and we'll paste that in on there so that
will just cause it to block
and the way we decide that it is done is
we would go up here to the init
oh by the way we need to oops
i have i put the caps key on by accident
um
but we will need to make this multi-line
and then we'll have sync
done and we'll just say bundle
or maybe like bundle
this would be bundle
to be specific we should say bundle
install so it's just waiting for this to
finish first before it does that and so
this should kind of resolve our issue at
least one of our issues so we'll go back
here we'll add this here assuming i
wrote this all right we don't know until
we do it so
add sync
await and sync done
and we'll go ahead and save that there
we'll go back over here
and
um
we will sync those changes we'll say
okay
what i will do here
now that i've synced the changes we'll
just go ahead and close that tab and
reopen and see what happens there
because we do have an init there so if
we were to stop and start we wouldn't
get exactly what we want
all right so it's starting back up here
so let's go see i actually all worked
which is great if we go over here to
bundle all that worked and then that
executed and this happened to work
okay but if we keep on running this
there's probably a chance that this
might not
work because
the port isn't ready
so i was kind of hoping that this would
fail and i think the only way we could
make this fail probably is if we just
put it in a sleep here
so what i'll do and i think sleep is for
every single second is i'm going to just
write sleep
and put 10 seconds okay and so that
should sleep long enough that we should
see this fail
so we'll go back here we'll add it so
sleep a while
and i wanted to say like hey this port
isn't ready what what are you doing you
know
so go back here
and then from there we'll go back close
that tab we'll open that up again
and we'll give it a moment and we'll
spin up here in a bit
great so
now that we are here um let's go take a
look and see what's happened and it
still
worked so it's it it's still executing
well actually down below here it says
unable to connect to vs code server so
i'm wondering if it's because we have um
uh this option here
right so
it's opening
because when the port became available
it opened
so i'm thinking i'm just going to go
ahead and remove this
let me take out the on open because this
would notify by default
so what if we put this to ignore say
ignore here
again i just want to see that this
doesn't open and then we have this here
and then if if we take if we put in the
port await it will work properly
so say uh one more time
i mean clearly this is airing out so
that's no good but it's still open and
that just because git pod is is smart
so we'll go there and we'll go ahead and
close that we're gonna reopen our git
pod here
and uh so that errors out which is
totally fine that's what we kind of
expect to happen and now it's not
opening up the preview so now i think we
have our opportunity
to uh put in the um that other command
which is the port await
so what i'm going to do is go grab this
command here
and we're going to go down below
and we're going to expand our command
here whoops
and so my expectation is that it's not
going to run this command until the port
is ready see i don't know if we need
like a double ampersand but i'm pretty
sure this waits until the port is open
so i'm going to say port 8080 here
and what we'll do here is go back
and we'll add this here we'll say
update get pod yaml
and we'll save that and we'll save those
changes
and um what we'll do is we'll go close
this tab again and we'll launch it one
more time
great and so what we're going to see
here
is this is a waiting till the port is
open remember this is sleeping right and
look now it works so we made a great
example where we're using both a weight
port and a white sink so there you go so
that's that's what you'd use with those
things and uh we're all done here so we
can go ahead and just close your tabs
and that's it
[Music]
so to understand git pod ports we need
to take a look at computer networking
ports
so ports and and that's the short way of
saying just ports acts as a separate
channel for communication protocol so
you have more than one program using the
same protocol and tcp the protocol we
use for websites and web server has 65
535 ports and some ports are designated
for specific types of communication and
others are undesignated where we can use
them for whatever we want so for
designated uh ports ones we absolutely
should know is port 80 so hcp
443 for https 22 for ssh and the way
these are used is the port number is
will follow an ip address or domain name
separated by colon so here's an ip
address and we have port 8080 and so we
have the ip address here and the port
number there in a web browser you can
write the port number in the address but
generally you won't see it for websites
because it just shows up by default so
if you're doing http colon
slash it already knows that it's port 80
and if you're doing https colon slash it
already knows that it's port 443 so
that's why you don't see them there
usually so there are many undesignated
ports which can be used to view or serve
web applications for the purpose of
development uh and the popular
development pro
ports being 3000 3001 80 80 8000
8081 and so 3000 and 3001 is very
popular to break ruby on rails why is
there 3 000 ones just because like if
you're using 3000 you need a second
server you have that that's why you see
it with 8081 or 8001 as well 80 80 8000
are very popular in the uh
with javascript uh web servers but these
are the ones you normally see and
probably what you should use because
there's a lot of synergies with a lot of
technology that are already defaulting
to these ones
so when we're talking about ports in
common language it's common to say
things like i'm listening on port
you know or i'm serving on port
what have you right so just understand
when you're saying listening or serve
it's pretty much the same thing
um
and same thing with like opening port or
exposing port means the same thing just
so you understand uh you know those
there okay
[Music]
so now that we know what computer
networking ports are let's take a look
at git pod ports so in order to view
websites or web applications in a web
browser running a workspace tcp ports
need to be accessible and gitpod allows
you to open ports so you can set ports
in your dot git pod yaml file your git
pod configuration file and so there we
are opening up port 8080 in that example
uh and so then once your workspace
launches you can go to the remote
explorer and you remember what the
remote explorer is because i definitely
will ask that as an exam question but
once um the port is uh uh open then you
can go over the remote explorer you can
see that there's a port there so here we
see port 3000 it's open it's private
there's like a button to open in the
browser or inline in the code editor
but if you don't define ports ahead of
time and that's totally fine if you
don't if you start up a service on a new
undefined port gitpod will prompt you if
you want to open the port and so you
just press the button and we'll open the
port and even after that it'll probably
ask if you want to launch it in the
browser um but yeah that's all there
really is to it gitpod cannot use ports
that are lower than uh 1024 so common
ports like port 80 443 ssh you cannot
open those ports and really you
shouldn't be because this is a developer
environment and port 80 443 or for
serving production
websites or web servers and i just want
to reiterate you don't have to define
ports ahead of time you can open new
ports on the fly okay
[Music]
so let's take a look at some of the
configuration options when we are
defining ports so we can do a port range
so three thousand two eight nine nine is
nine this example here of course we can
have a single value as we saw in the
previous video uh we have opening
behavior so this is where we define on
open it has four possible values so
notify which is the default and when it
says show the notification it's that
notification that says hey how how do
you want to handle this port do you want
to
uh open it in a preview do you want to
expose the port like what do you want to
do with it so we have the open preview
option so open the preview on the right
open browser so open in a browser tab or
ignore so don't do anything
then you have port visibility and so by
default it's going to be set as private
and so we have private which is the
default this only allows users with
workspace access to access the port the
reason i highlighted that was actually
for my own notes because i don't know
exactly what that means but we'll find
out in the follow along because i want
to know like does it mean that only i
can use it or if we like if we have a
team and somebody's within my team only
team members can access it so that's
something we'll have to explore then
there's public so allow any everyone
with the port url to access the port so
there's an example of visibility so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at port forwarding so what
is port forwarding or also known as port
mapping is an application of network
address translation a nat that redirects
a communication request from one address
and port number combination to another
and that's basically the wikipedia
description but uh to simply put
port forwarding sends traffic from one
port to another essentially acting as a
port alias so using the getpodcli
command forward port you can send
traffic from one port to another so
here's an example of me uh forwarding
the port at 8080 to 80 oh sorry i said
forwarding 80 81 to 8080 okay and so
some programs will start on a hardcore
coded port and will not let you change
the port so port forwarding is a way to
work around this issue so that's the
major advantage of port forwarding
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and welcome to
another follow along this time we're
going to be looking at all about git pod
ports of course we did cover a weight
port but we might just cover it again in
here just because we are going more
thorough into the
port section of the course so i'll go
ahead and type in git pod ports i'm
going to add a readme it can be private
and what we'll do is go ahead and type
in git pod ports here
and just pull up the documentation just
in case we need it so we can set ports
within a range we can set a single port
uh things like that and then we have a
bunch of different kinds of um
things that can happen like the modes
that should happen so what we're going
to do here is launch this new git pod
okay
and we'll just give it a moment here but
you know just looking over the on open
ports you have notify so show the
notification by default open preview
open in the preview on the right open
browser so open in the browser tab
ignore don't do anything so we'll
explore
because this is part of ports and so i
guess we can cover all these options
here for fun
and so as always we'll go up to our
hamburger menu we're going to go over to
terminal new terminal and we'll go ahead
and type in gpinit
and from here
we're going to need some kind of server
so i'm going to go server.b
and we're going to go grab sinatra again
so we'll say sinatra ruby
and from here
i'm going to go grab this code right on
the page that makes it really easy
and we'll say allow
and then we're going to need a gem file
so just say gem file
and i'm just going to say like a net gem
file
bundler because oh there is a bundle in
it
generates a gem file well let's let's do
that because i'm getting tired of um uh
looking up the first command here
so we'll say um bundler init
all right and so that's where we get
that uh that front line that we wanted
there
okay and this is useful too to have the
github thing here so
but we'll just go here and say gem
uh sinatra sinatra
okay we'll do a bundle install whoops
bundle install i like doing bi it's my
shorthand for that and so now we have a
very simple web server i'm going to
modify this slightly because i want it
to take in environment variables so i'm
going to just go here and make a double
quotation this is interpolation in ruby
and so i can just do env square braces
and we'll say message
and we'll say says
oops
i'm able to say port
so say frank says
from port
okay and so that way we'll be able to
pass that along and kind of set that we
also need to set our um port here so
we'll say
port colon and then we'll just do env
for passing along a environment variable
um we should probably make this a little
bit more flexible just say app port
because i don't know if there's like any
underlying port so let's just do that
just in case
and from there we have a simple
application and so that should work no
problem and the way we can test that is
by typing bundle exec actually before
that we have to set our ports so we'll
just say
port
and i will just put a space here or
maybe double ampersand
and we'll say
uh
ruby server
and so that started up on port 8080 just
double checking here to make sure that
it's not just the default port here
so that's starting up on port 8081
i don't think it's oh you know what it's
because i'm not setting app
port like this
okay still not taking the right port so
i'll take out the double ampersand
and there we go so sometimes you got to
play with it a little bit so that is how
we're going to be doing that so go over
to our git pod gamle file and we don't
know which port we want to have open as
of yet
well actually we might want to set them
all there
um so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to go up here and we're going to do a
bunch of different ports
because i want one for each of the types
of things we can open here so we have
notify open preview open browser ignore
i'm going to go just grab these for here
so we can save ourselves some time we'll
drop those in there and from here
we'll have port
port 8001 port 8002
port 8003.
and we'll have this on notify which is
the defaults
we'll have this one on preview
open preview then we'll have this one on
open browser
and then we'll have this one on ignore
okay
so there we have all the the cases there
and then up here we're just going to
have our ports we'll say 8000
and our command we do need to initialize
this stuff
so
what we'll do because we need to have a
i think that's going to do bundle
install so up here we'll just do bundle
install
and we'll do an init here and we did
learn this um
a moment ago where we had the bundle
install and then we
oops bundle install and then we had our
gp
sync await
and we'll just say bundle install here
because we these are all gonna have to
wait for that stuff to be installed for
them to work
and we'll take out the command here and
then we're gonna do our app port so
we'll say app
port equals a thousand
bundle exec
rubyserver.rb
and from here we also want to wait so
let's say gpsync
done
i guess this would actually be the
weight just so that one would be the
done
so we go down up here or over there
and so that's going to be on port 8000
this one's going to be on port 8001
this one's going to be on port 8002
and this one's going to be on port 8003
all right
so we have a bunch of different uh ports
there so that will give us a four and
they all are going to launch in
different ways
so that looks pretty good hopefully i
didn't make any mistakes because we did
write quite a bit here
um but that's okay so what we'll do is
go over here
and we'll commit all these files
and they look like they're all committed
so we'll say
set up a bunch of servers
and we'll commit that sync the changes
we'll say okay
and then from there what we can do is go
ahead
and we have a get get uh yeah there's a
lock file there so that's great so we'll
close that off and we'll go ahead and
reopen that okay
all right so there is should be a string
uh
so i really wish i knew how to validate
the yaml beforehand
so like i don't know what vs code
extension i need there but like maybe
there's like yaml validate
i can see like in this linter here maybe
i get this nice ad on the right hand
side so i'll reopen that up and we'll
just see if we can spot the problem
let's say that's like my only
frustration it's probably there is a
tool involved and i just don't know you
know
so i say copy and then i'll paste this
in here and we will then say go
says it's valid yaml yaml so there's
something that
it doesn't like
so we'll have to just closely look at
this here so we have a net that looks
fine we have the command here
that looks fine
so i'm not sure what it doesn't like
so we'll do a sanity check and we'll
just kind of simplify it so i'll just um
go here and comment this out for the
time being
and same with here
okay so
oh you know you know what it is
it's probably um this because it starts
with a number
so i'm just going to do this and maybe
that will fix our problem because i
think it's it's like equating as a
number as opposed to a string
and we probably just wrap it as a string
whoops maybe not those
but that's probably our problem so we
will try this again
it's good to know
fixed names of tasks
we'll sync those changes
we'll say okay
and from there what we'll do is close
this tab we'll go back here we'll say
get pod
and so we'll wait here so frank is open
up 48 000 so this looks like it's
working correctly let's go ahead and
close some of those tabs so here's a
thousand here's a thousand one two three
and so one is opened up in here
um but like the other ones didn't open
up so maybe you just can't have multiple
ones it's like one or the other but like
i would have thought that um
if this was set
here open browser it would just
automatically open up a page maybe
that's not the case
but if we go over to the remote explorer
here we just kind of hover over here
it seems like we can open it in preview
or this kind of stuff so i'm not really
sure why that doesn't work as we think
it does but it's not really a big deal
and i don't even know if we ever saw
that open as the browser uh like that
before so
anyway that kind of gives you an idea
like this one probably prompted us and
we didn't notice as we clicked through
there just kind of showing you how you
could set them all let's now go switch
this to a range so instead of doing this
we can say port 8003
and i'm just going to switch them all
over to open browser i just want to see
if they actually do open here and so
this will allow us to do a port range
okay so that should work no problem
open up a port range
we'll go ahead and commit that we'll
sync those changes we'll say okay
and by the way like i think down below
here it actually shows you what ports
are open so if you click this down below
i know it's hard like look where my
mouse goes all the way down here you can
uh see the open ports but they're also
going to be down here in the road
explorer and you can make it public or
private and things like that over here
these are all private right now
um so what i'm going to do here is just
close this tab
relaunch this and then we're going to
see make sure the range ports works of
course it's going to work malicious dude
anyway just to make sure
so there we go we have
a bunch do those pores open
which are good again browser didn't open
so
i don't know what the point of
this is
like if it doesn't open right away i
don't understand but um or it could be
you know what it probably is oh
so it has been this entire time we just
have to say always allow the pop-ups and
redirect okay
and so now probably if we were to
relaunch this they would all open up so
that's what i'm going to do i'm just
going to do this one more time
i'm going to make a new workspace
because we need to run the init again
actually probably don't we probably
could have done a start it would have
worked because they're all commands but
that's fine
and so
okay so basically because it changes the
girl every time it keeps on blocking at
a
so i think like what you'd have to do is
probably have like a wild star in here
so let me just take a look okay
so i think what we could do is we could
probably
go up
here and say add and then do wild card
and then do that
should allow us to do wild card
maybe like this
there we go we'll hit add
and now i'm going to do i'm going to do
it one more time and i think we can just
i'm going to just kill it even though i
probably can stop stop it uh stop and
start it again
and i'm just going to say new workspace
and so now they all open so that's
probably a good thing that we did there
for chrome and i guess i just never
noticed that and that kind of makes
sense now
but anyway so that is port ranges
um
you know there's a few other things we
probably can do let's just take a look
here so we did that there's private and
public i guess we never set that for the
ports
and so we could explore that as well i
would probably have to go get another
account set up here to show you
um but maybe we can just will this down
to two so i'm going to just take this
down back to two
and we can say
private
but i guess it'd be visibility
visibility
which would be private
public
and i'm just gonna get rid of that port
there we'll see go back to port one and
then this one will be private
okay
and so just looking at this here that
should work no problem i'm gonna go
ahead and commit that so public and
private now
we'll go ahead and save that we'll save
those changes we'll say ok
and from there we'll go ahead and close
that
and we will
reopen the git pod and as that's going
i'm going to have to open up another
browser so i'm going to go get firefox
here
so just give a second for firefox to
load
okay not now
nope just let me browse please and so
i'm just going to go off screen and log
into my github so i have more than one
github account and i have more than one
git pod here so
that will just take me a moment you can
see these ones opened here
and i'm just going to sign in off screen
here and i'll see you back here in a
second okay
all right okay so i have um firefox open
here on another github get pod uh
picopod account and so what i want to do
is see what i can share so if our
servers are running they are here they
both are
one is public and one is private and so
the one that is public let's go see if
we can bring it over here
so i'm gonna go ahead and paste that on
in here
so port 8000 works fine
and then we'll look at port 8001
and so i can't see port 8001 and so one
thing that's interesting is that
if
you have private they suggest here that
um only allow users with workspace
access to access this port
okay and so
what does that mean does that mean if
somebody is in the same project or does
that mean if you're just sharing it with
them so that's something we're going to
have to find out
so what i'm going to do in my gitpod is
i can actually create projects
here
and so i can create a new project
i don't list i don't think this will
allow for collaboration so i might have
to go to this one so
my new project here
and then from here i need to add a
member so i'll go here and give them the
invitation link which is on the other
side here
and then they're going to have to go
accept that
so i'm over here now
and
did i accept it i didn't see like a step
to accept let's go back and refresh
it didn't
oh looks like in my firefox i'm in this
account
you know what i think it's because i'm
logged in the same account so what i'm
going to do is just log out here
because my github is another account
here and so what i'll have to do is just
kind of like launch any kind of
repository here this will take two
seconds
and i'm just accepting the
authentication there
okay and so now i'm going to try to
invite
myself again
so copy that
and we're just going to paste that there
and so i i just instantly clicked it and
i was added so there's no like do you
want to be a member
uh which i think maybe they need that
but that's fine it's not a big deal
and so we'll go back over here
and so now if i just refresh here
i want to find out um is this one do we
saw this pod running yes we do
so if we go back over here on this other
screen here
this is i think the private one the 8001
does that work
no it does not and that's totally fine
so what i want to do now is i just want
to go ahead and create a new workspace
or sorry project
and we'll say
um
or did we already have a project here oh
it's right here new project
oh sorry this is a team i called it my
new project i should have called this um
my new team so i'm gonna go ahead and
delete that team because that's just too
confusing
and we'll go here i'll say uh my team
my
i guess maybe these are unique names i
didn't know that so my
team exam proco
okay there's no way that that name
exists and so we'll go back over here
i'm going to invite members and that
kind of makes sense why they might have
like the block lists which i didn't know
about before
and so now i'm a member of that again so
we'll go here and we'll give this a
refresh
so i'm a member we'll go back over to
projects we'll make a new project here i
don't know why there's this
e1777 but i want to choose
any repository here the one i want
actually it's not any repository i want
this one here
so let's go back over here and let's see
why this isn't showing up search
repositories we'll say git pod
it's only showing
oh you know i said on gitlab so we'll
switch back
and we'll say github
and we'll authorize
and we'll authorize all
so now we can go and bring in the repo
we want which is
the ports repo
and so if we go over to
the workspaces here there are no
workspaces so now what i want to do is
just close this off and i want to launch
this
under here okay and if you do launch it
from here i'm pretty sure it's going to
open up in this workspace but just to be
sure i'm going to go do it from here
so yeah it is in the same workspace but
i'm going to launch a new one anyway
because i want to see again if i share
it with this account that's a member can
they see it
all right
so we'll go here and so 8001 is the one
that is the private one and so we'll
make a new tab here we're going to paste
that on in there and so they still can't
see it so just because you're a member
doesn't necessarily mean you can see it
so now what i'm thinking is that it has
to do with like sharing your screen
so what we'll do is we'll go over here
and we'll go to the share
and we'll say share
and now we're going to copy that to our
clipboard
and we're going to go ahead
and
paste this on in here
okay and so now i'm sharing so i have
access over here i'm going to refresh
see if i have access here
i don't which is fine but what i will do
is go to the left hand side here because
these servers should be running
remote explorer
this one says it's private so i'm going
to open this in the browser
oh uh we'll say
is preventing this to open we'll go to
options here
we'll say always allow whoops
and so now it's showing up i don't know
if there's like a difference between
this one and that one if we go back over
to
the one here
we open that in the browser
we go back over here
okay so there's a bit of like
finickiness with this but you can see
that you know if you are sharing you
have access but just because they're a
member of that workspace doesn't
necessarily mean you can share that
private one so that's just kind of one
of those uh harder edge cases that i
kind of want to show you
so that you just know what's going on
there
so now that we've figured out how to do
um
a lot of stuff let's do port forwarding
that'll be the last one here so imagine
you have a project
where you have a whoops
that's saying this this doesn't exist
oops
go ahead here and go back here so
imagine you have a project where you
don't have control of the actual
ip address and it's not showing me
anything here i'm gonna have to relaunch
this it's being funny
okay
and yes i want to just open the existing
workspace here
and so
that's great and so um it could be a
case i'm just going to stop the server
here for a moment
where you need to
like we're not going to have this port
so if we don't specify any port it's
just going to start on port
8080 right so if i go bundle exec here
and actually i think we should probably
do this in our code
i'm just going to make a third one here
that's to a fixed port so i think it
starts on 8080 so we'll go here
and i'm just going to say default
i'm not going to specify any port
and then we'll go ahead and commit this
and we'll see if we can use the port
forwarding okay
so sync those changes we'll say okay
we'll wait a moment i'm going to close
that tab we'll relaunch that
i'm not sure why it's doing a pre-build
because we don't have pre-builts turned
on at least i don't remember turning
them on
but for fun we'll take a look here so if
we go here to our project reports
oh it is doing a pre-build okay
so i guess as soon as we make a project
it becomes a pre-built i for some reason
i thought like prebuilds you can turn it
on and off
and maybe you can but i don't see the
option there so
um the only problem with that is that if
it does a bundle install no it should
still work so that should be fine
yep so it's doing the bundle install
that's the pre-build
and here down below you can say don't
wait for pre-build i didn't know you
could do that but we'll just give it a
moment
i'll just see you back here when this is
done launching okay
okay so i'm just like sitting here
waiting for this to finish but i think
the thing is that it's already done
because it exited out of here so i think
if i just close that off and we go over
here we can see the pre-build is ready
and so now if i go and try to launch a
workspace
it should work so we'll go ahead and
we'll just say new workspace and because
that pre-build is there it should load
really really fast
um but yeah i guess i was just waiting
there for no reason
i will just give it a
moment there we go so that was pretty
fast um and so i'm expecting uh this one
to go to the default one so if we go to
this tab here
we're gonna notice that it's going to
start on it's starting
oh you know what because these are all
waiting for the bundle install eh
so none of them are going to finish
okay
so just to make our lives a bit easier
because this section is not about
teaching you about how to do pre-builds
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to go ahead and delete this
project if it's possible so we'll go
back up to the top here i'm just going
to go ahead and remove that project
okay and so that way that'll just make
our lives a lot easier so if i just
launch this it won't do pre-built stuff
and it will work as expected
so we'll give it a moment there
and so this one because it will do a
bundle install here
this should now
work properly
this task ran as a pre-build
oh
boy um
so i guess the thing it's not a big deal
i think the thing is that i just need to
modify this file because now if i modify
it i don't know if it will just like
stop using pre-builds
so what i'm going to do is just delete
out these commands here
and we'll go here and just say um remove
weights
because this will happen in the
pre-build right so we'll say this
assuming that it's going to do another
pre-build even though i've deleted the
project so there technically should be
no pre-built now
and so i might have to recreate the
project which is totally fine we'll just
work our way through here and see what
happens okay
so we'll close that and i'm going to go
back here and just do git pod
because i don't know what it's going to
do
and so we have bundle install missing
gem so now it's not doing pre-builds
okay
so in this case that's where we want to
revert this file back to what it was
so i'm going to go back and write it in
because i don't want to go back and
create the project so i'm going to say
sync
done bundle install
await
sync await sync await and so this server
is going to start up over here and
that's fine i just want to have one for
the port forward so
port forward there's not not going to be
anything going on here i'm just going to
say like command
echo
hello
and what we'll do is go ahead and commit
this file so we'll just commit that
update
and we'll sync those changes as per
usual
and we'll give it a moment then we'll
just go ahead and close that reopen this
and get pod
i think we'll have an easier time
all right so it's almost open here
and this is not even with pre-built it's
pretty fast but again it's going to
depend on your use case
so um here we saw
these two open because the ports already
open they have the mode set up this
server is running
right so and this is running on port
8080 but imagine that you didn't want it
on port 8080 you wanted on something and
you know what to be honest a better
example for this would have been port
80.
so i'm just going to do this
sorry i know i'll keep on modifying this
but if this is an accessible port that
doesn't make it a very good example
let's just say open on port 80.
and actually before that happens i'm
just going to start it up manually to
see what happens if it actually does
permission denied so i'd have to go here
and do like sudo
um
so we can't even start it on port 80.
i think we'll just stick with what we
have here so we'll go back and we'll
just start it back up again
okay and we'll just do port forwarding
so if we wanted to open up on a
different port so we'd just say
gp
port
or a ford port
want to forward port 8080 to
8999 maybe
and i think it's going the wrong way so
um port 80 is already in use okay maybe
we'll try that again it's just confusing
because to me it looks like
traffic coming from here should go there
but i guess that makes sense because if
traffic's incoming from port 888 send it
to 8080. okay to me the direction just
confused me but it's actually correct
and i'm just confused so um if that port
is open
let's go over to remote explorer here so
now we see port 888 and so if we open
that up we can see that it is forwarding
to port 8080 so there you go that's
pretty much all we need to know about
ports of course there was a lot here but
i think it was just worth making sure
that we were very thorough
with our investigation here so we'll
just close off all those tabs and we'll
see in the next video okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at git pod custom docker
images so git pod supports custom docker
images so you can configure your
workspace exactly to your needs and this
is really important if uh you know
there's security reasons like you need
to really lock down what it is that's um
within that container or you just have
uh wildly different use cases like maybe
you're doing
uh web3 development or
machine learning and you just can't find
a quick start template so that's where
you have to start making your own docker
file so git pod supports uh debian
ubuntu based docker images but it does
not support alpine the reason it does
not support alpine is that images do not
include alpine images do not include lib
gcc or lib
stdc plus plus which breaks visual
studio code if you don't know what
alpine is it's just like really really
really small image and that's why people
or os and that's why people really like
alpine
but i always found them very hard to set
up
debian ubuntu a very very popular
hopefully we'll see support for things
like uh centos and things like that
later but this is the ubuntu logo that's
the debian logo and there's alpine
crossed out if that kind of helps cement
that information but you should remember
that it does not support alpine there
are two ways
to specify
i know it says specific but should say
specify an image okay so you can
reference an image from a container
repository like docker hub
if you can specify things outside of
docker hub i have not tried but i assume
that they all go to docker hub so here's
an example where we have an image and we
say node buster we know that's going to
go to docker hub then you can reference
a docker file contained within the repo
and so what you do is name a file called
gitpod.dockerfile
i don't know if you could just
call it dockerfile and then reference it
there but this is what it's always
called so
it's probably best practice just to
follow along there and then here we have
a very simple um docker file that does
basic basically does nothing but it's
just an example of us configuring our
own so for git pod images uh it's
recommended to not specify a tag or use
latest to make sure you're you
automatically benefit from the security
patches and fixes uh we release we
really mean git pod so you see i kind of
copy paste there from the documentation
but what they're talking about when
they're talking about tags is that when
you have um like this image here you can
do like colon latest or you can put a
version number stuff like that they're
just saying don't specify a version
number or a type just don't specify
anything or type colon latest okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
looking at the get pod workspace base
image so gitpod workspace base base is a
docker image that has a bunch of common
tooling installed and so you can find it
here on docker hub or you can get find
it on github so those are the two paths
there and so this thing if you start
digging into it it really relies on
something called build pack or build
pack uh
depths and the reason i went digging was
because i just wanted to know what was
installed on it so this is a docker
image for a collection of common build
dependencies used for installing various
modules it is similar to heroku's stack
image which includes a large number of
development headers packages needed
by various things so npm install gem
install pip install curl
wget git
and a whole lot more
so
what's the purpose of the workspace base
well it extends from build pack uh
depths with a bunch of additional
tooling and so we have a lot of stuff
like zip unzip h-top uh jq which is
great for working with json less
locals nano
sudo
vim
all sorts of useful things and so this
is a really great base image but we're
going to talk about the full image next
because that is generally what we see
a lot of people using okay
all right so let's take a look at the
get pod workspace full image so uh every
workspace launches by default with a
standard docker image called workspace
full and so just like base there's one
on uh docker hub and github so very
similar and workspace full extends from
workspace base but it's going to be
adding some additional stuff so the
gitpod workspace full image comes
pre-installed with a variety of commonly
used programming languages libraries and
system packages but really talking about
that coming from the base image but just
to kind of list the languages here we
got docker go java node.js c c plus plus
python ruby russ php homebrew tail scale
nginx and several more
so when you're developing your own
custom docker images you can either
extend the workspace full or if you need
something lighter the workspace base but
we will obviously open these up uh these
these images up to kind of look at their
docker files and kind of figure out what
they're doing okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and in this
follow along i'm going to show you how
to set up a custom docker file if you
notice i tried before it didn't work so
this is going to be my maybe third
attempt to do it so what we'll do is
type in gitpod custom
or gitpod custom docker file
and from there we'll go down below
choose private add a readme we'll go
ahead and create that repository
then once there we'll hit the get pod
button so all we're going to really be
doing is going through the basic custom
docker file here just to go through the
motions of it we can use hyphen base we
can use hyphen full it's just going to
be dependent on the use case so if you
use get pod fold image your docker
support built in your you get docker
support built into your environment so
full sounds pretty good to me so we'll
need a file here called dot get pod
uh docker file now does it have to be
dot get pod you probably could specify
dockerfile because it references it um
via the file so i'd imagine you can name
whatever you want but it's just good
habit to follow what git pod has there
so i'm going to type in gp init and from
here we have a file i don't need any of
that content we're going to have image
and then i think it's like type
or file okay so we can do file here and
then from there we'll just do git pod
docker file
okay and so now the next thing we want
to do and maybe we might want to put one
task in there for fun tasks and we'll
just say um command we'll just say
echo
hello world okay just something for fun
and so in this docker file we're going
to be now writing whatever format a
dockerfile is so do from getpod forward
slash workspace and again this could be
base but we're going to do full because
you get the full power docker that way
and from there we can do run brew
install fzf now what is f is that f i
have no idea so i'm kind of curious
myself so i'm just going to type that in
command i just don't know what it is so
this stands for
fuzzy finder
so f c f set f is a general purpose
command line fuzzy finder it's an
interactive unix filter for command line
that can be used with any files so i
mean that sounds really interesting um
how it's used i don't know so i mean it
might be just interesting to see if we
can figure out how it works but um i
think this is it so
run brew install fzf if you see brew and
you're thinking isn't that a mac thing
well i think there's a debian or ubuntu
like compatibility for having brew so um
yeah i'm not really sure let's see
ubuntu
brew
so homebrew on linux so i guess they
have a linux distribution and so that's
how we're able to do that normally i
would be like doing yum or apk install
app get installed for debian ubuntu but
just to kind of clarify that i'm just
double checking to make sure everything
is okay there looks good to me so i'm
going to go ahead and commit all this
and say
build custom
[Music]
docker image
okay and hopefully all that is correct
so we'll go ahead and commit that sync
the changes we'll say okay
and what we'll do is close that tab out
we're going to double check to make sure
those files are committed
they look like they are good we'll hit
get pot and hopefully we don't get any
errors
it's very easy to make errors at least
for me because uh you know i'm just
error prone
but notice that it's building the
workspace so there's a little bit more
work it has to do that's building that
image
so this is where you might see
pre-builds come into play where
you know you want this to launch faster
because you know docker files just take
forever to build
uh and i say forever but i mean they
take a little bit of time right so just
imagine if you always had this that
really makes sense why pre-builds uh
become so important
but i'll see you back here when it's
done okay
all right so i think this is done i
can't really tell because it says
building image and says exit exit so
i'm going to
uh risk it i'm just going to close this
tab and try it again so i'm going to go
ahead and launch the git pod
um
yeah so it already has this one running
so i'm just going to click into that so
maybe i'll just jump into the
environment so yeah it was ready uh just
understand that sometimes that happens
uh you know if if you feel like you're
waiting too long just have the
confidence to go okay i think i think it
is working but for whatever reason the
feedback loop is not working as expected
so if this worked correctly we should
have fzf installed so if i type f set f
it does appear so that's great and let's
just see how it works so i know i
watched a short little video on it and i
know that if you do this it's a fuzzy
finder so you can apply it to anything
you can pipe anything to it but like
it's great for like going through and
finding files this one is a little bit
more complicated so it's not really
showing me the one the simple one that i
wanted to uh use here
well let me see here just going to the
top here um
so
ah like
it's basically this so we copy this i'm
not sure about the selected part but we
go and we paste that in like allow and
hit enter and
i mean we can search our files so
i guess it's only showing not or like
invisible files so maybe i need to go
find some files here
um
media is there stuff in there no
just trying to find anything
okay so here might be something that
might work
so i'll hit up but they're not files
they're kind of folders eh
okay so see i can start typing utm and
so it's just a fuzzy finder an easier
way to find things can be used for all
sorts of things but that's how you build
a docker file so just realize it is a
bit slow
but that's the whole idea behind
pre-builds right
now if we were to launch this again
would it try to build every single time
i think so let's go ahead and just see
that and i don't care about seeing this
complete i just want to see if it is
going to build that every single time i
believe it would right
so we just give it a moment here
it's pulling the container image if it
doesn't that's great
right
that's what it looks like it's doing so
it looks like if you build it once
uh it's not gonna build it every single
time you launch a workspace
and then i guess my next question is is
like i guess it would know anytime
there's a file change i guess that you
would have you'd have to commit it to
the repository so that's how we would
know
so
that's fine so let's say i make a single
change here
small change
maybe just add another small change here
i just want to see like will it still
pull the image will it be smart enough
or is it any time there's a
change
small change sync
uh we'll go ahead and close that git pod
give it a moment there and so i just
want to see is it going to try to build
the image
it doesn't look like it
so it's really seems like it's smart
about that
and then what we'll do once we launch it
i'll just try to make a very minute
change
um i don't write docker files on a
regular basis so
i'm not even sure what we could install
i mean maybe we could do wget even
though it's already installed in that
file
okay yeah so i didn't rebuild it but
what we'll do here is i'm going to do
like run on a separate line
i assume it must be smart enough to know
run brew install wget again i don't care
if this works like i don't care to see
it all the way the end just the fact
that it's going to start a build step
so add wget which probably already is
installed
but we just need an extra line in there
so we're just gonna do whatever
okay good
and we'll go back over here and
we will hit the get pod button and so
i'm assuming this time it will know
yeah there we go okay so it is building
the image so it is pretty smart there
and i really like the fact they did it
that way
um
if you're looking for those we've seen
those works workspace full images before
but we're like git pod workspace full
docker hub might be something we want to
search for so here this is where they're
basically hosted you know so
just understand like whatever you want
you just take that name and that's what
you're putting in the image if you're
doing um
if we're going back to here like let's
say you already have an image hosted you
just do that right
you probably can put tags there as well
but again it has to be a debian or
ubuntu base so i'm not sure if it shows
yeah here it is on github we've got
images and we can go find the full one
here and from here we can see the docker
file and we can see this one's based off
of the base so if you wanted to kind of
like crawl through and that's what i was
doing to kind of understand what's going
on there you can go to the base and then
open that one you can see this one's
based on the build pack depth depth full
call
[Music]
f-o-c-a-l i'm not sure what that stands
for we can go over here
and then from here um
like this sometimes i don't know where
to find the baseball but there is some
kind of like base soccer file here that
would tell us where that comes from or
be written up
so i'm just kind of looking around for
it i'm not super good with docker i've
been using it for years but every single
time it just takes a lot of work here
there are a bunch of tags underneath so
maybe the tag shows up here it does
so we click into that one ah and here's
the file
and so you can see this one's based off
full call scm
here it's installing all the libraries
and you can just keep crawling back
until you find everything to see like
what's installed so we go to this one
here
and then this one's based off the curl
one like
it's just a little a little loopy how
this works we'll go to the curl one and
uh so now you can see it's ubuntu uh
focal right so then we can go from this
one
so you just see that you see that it's
ubuntu right so we go into this so that
i guess that stands for full focal
[Music]
great that is not easy to say so we go
back and we go to docker hub
again just if you've never done this
before right
and so from here we might type in a full
call if it even shows up so then it's
here this is the latest
and so this is from scratch
um
and this is add this binary or this uh
this thing so it looks like i don't
really know this too well but it looks
like what it's doing is it's saying okay
take this um
uh
archive which might be in the same
directory here yeah it is take this
archive and utilize that as the
installation for it right
so that must be like the way like
setting up um ubuntu like you know
somebody was to like have a disk or uh a
key or download the program i think it's
executing the program so uh you know
hopefully that kind of tells you how
that stuff works but yeah that is how
you do
custom docker files okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at git pod quick start
templates so quick start templates are
git repositories that you can use to
launch an example environment or fork to
get started for a variety of different
run times so here's the search you're
going to notice a bunch of languages a
bunch of frameworks like ruby on rails
things like that and so once you click
on one of these it's you can it will try
to
create a fork of course but you can just
go straight to the um
github repository and there you'll
generally notice that it will have like
a git pod yaml file and a docker file
and you can open it up and see how they
are doing it
but it's pretty useful
the quick start template generally
contains a custom docker file that may
extend the base or full so i tried to
like go through a bunch of these and say
okay what is the pattern here but it
seems like some are workspace based some
are full some are
um
get pod workspace there's like another
one
um or some are docker compose so they're
i guess a little bit all over the place
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and this follow
along i want to explore the quick starts
that comes with git pods so what we'll
do is type in quick start
templates here and what we'll do oops we
gotta put in get pod here because
there's all sorts of quick starts based
on different cloud products but we go
here we can see we have some popular
templates we can search for a variety of
things so if we want ruby on rails that
is an example maybe if we wanted uh
larvarelle that might be an example
maybe if we wanted django do we have
django in here
not yet but if we don't have django
maybe we have flask yeah there we go so
maybe we have flask uh maybe we got next
yes there we go and so it might be fun
to just kind of launch these and see
what they look like and we maybe there's
even a wordpress in here there we are
okay so we got all the major frameworks
and you know i want to emphasize that
this is languages and frameworks and all
sorts of things well what we're going to
do here
is go ahead
and launch these so each of these have a
template so if i go here i can just say
git pod um
rails template and you know what we
don't even need to actually
i'm not going to clone those i'm just
going to open these up in a new tab like
this
and then just click on it like that
so that's the rails one now i have to go
back here and find all of them again so
we'll go here
and we'll open up that like that
okay so we got the wordpress that one
then we'll look at the next gs one
all i want to do is kind of just explore
these and just see kind of like what is
going on with them you know
and we said flask
okay
click on through that
and larvarelle
and so the thing is is that
we have quite a few repos here
i think i have one two three four five
so we're not going to be able to open
these all up at once because we can only
have four in parallel but uh we don't
need to do that all at once so that's
fine so i'm just going to close some of
these i'm not closing them but i'm just
going to launch them one at a time so
let's do larval first
that's quite a big one so this will be
one that we launch
we'll go ahead and close that tab
and while that's going we'll go ahead
and launch the next js1 we'll just do a
couple at a time okay
and i'm not really sure how many
workspaces i have running maybe we'll
just kind of like
optimize our time here if we go over to
our dashboard
and we go to workspaces none are open
there
we have
two running workspaces which is fine so
i think we can just keep going here
we'll do the flask one and then we'll do
the wordpress wordpress one and then
we'll just leave rails up on on the side
there
and so we're just gonna wait for all
these environments to go green i'll see
you back here in a minute okay all right
so after a short little wait
our four repositories are ready so we'll
start on the left hand side with lar
varell if you don't know what lavarelle
is it's a php framework that's similar
to ruby on rails
um and so let's just see what they have
done here to kind of provision this so
it doesn't hurt to go through get pod
yaml files to kind of learn something so
here they're loading a custom image and
probably all of these are going to be
loading custom images and so we're
opening up port 8000 for the large rail
server and then it's also starting mysql
so it's all here in one place for you
and so down below
i mean both the ports are open but in
the init step you can see that they are
creating a database example they're
going to copy the env file over here
into one there then they are updating
the environment variables with some
default configurations over in here so
some settings that are probably
mandatory that you need to update
then they're doing a composer install an
npm install a php artisan key generate
could any of this go into the before i
don't know this seems pretty much
correct to me and then you have the
command that's starting up the 8000 on
um for the public directory so let's go
open up the gitpod docker file and so
here you can see that there's just the
thing that says workspace mysql so if we
wanted to understand what the contents
of that is we'd have to go look up that
one there so maybe we will in a bit here
so just say workspace github if we can
find it
sometimes i find these easy to find
sometimes they don't
oops
uh like that
so like if we go to the get pod repo
because it might or github github
get pod repo there might be something
interesting for us to see there maybe
not but we'll try anyway so we'll say
git pod here
and we'll go to the repos here
and we will search for workspace
so these are workspace images see i
don't know if they're all in here they
probably are so we're going to mysql
this is probably the file that is
launching here because i'm just curious
how what is it what is it doing and so
it's extending the workspace full and
then it's just installing mysql so a lot
of these are going to be using probably
workspace full underneath
okay
then we have next.js
so in here we'll take a look at the uh
the gitpod.yaml file here and so
we have a single task it says npm
install npm run dev so very very simple
and it's not even using um a custom
docker file because it just uses node
and i guess everything we want is here
so that's really simple and nice
then we have flask running here so if we
go over to this one
um
we have one that's starting a before
task so it's setting or it's exporting a
couple of flask options we're doing our
pip install we're initializing our
database we're running it and then they
have that extension installed for python
for that highlighting so that's nice and
simple
and then the last one here well we still
have ruby on rails we might as well open
that up while we're waiting
um we got to go back to our limit here
we've reached one so we'll go ahead and
close
uh this one here so we'll say
stop and we'll stop this one and we'll
stop this one i just don't want to touch
the wordpress and so if we go over to
the wordpress now we didn't see a
website because this one's a little bit
more complex in terms of its setup there
is a port open i don't know if this will
work because we probably have to pop in
the database nope here it is we can
create a wordpress and so if we go here
on the left hand side and go into the
git pod yaml this one's kind of a
curious case because it's not using a
docker file image it has a docker
compose and so basically you're running
multi-containers within a container and
so we open up docker compose we can see
here that it's starting up mysql then
it's starting up uh wordpress and these
have separate images so see this one is
using the mysql image this one's using
the wordpress latest and so you know you
saw with the other example with larvarel
it just ran it as a monolith within the
container like like a virtual machine
would and so you have both options here
and
both are valid this might be really
useful if this is actually what you use
to deploy so this would be more like one
to one with your production environment
so that is kind of interesting there
um
let's go back i guess we didn't relaunch
this so we'll go here and we'll just
launch a new ruby on rails file there
and we'll give that a moment
but you can kind of see that's kind of
interesting like all these files are a
little bit different you can learn a bit
but the great thing is like you can just
clone these or fork these repositories
and kind of build off of them so it's a
really great starting point for a lot of
different kinds of projects
so
yeah we'll just wait here for the ruby
on rails thing to start and we'll look
at this last one and we'll just wrap it
up here for quick starts okay all right
so after a short little wait here we
have ruby on rails my favorite uh
framework that's why we made time for it
but here you can see it's loading its
own custom image file uh it has ports
open on 3000 5432 means meaning it's
running postgres here we have our
initial bundle install yarn and saw rick
db create and then running the server
and then we have a nice extension here
for ruby if we open up the docker file
we see again it's workspace postgres so
you can imagine it's going to probably
be similar to the mysql one if we go
over here
we go down to postgres and we click into
the docker file yeah it's the same story
um it's gonna be extending workspace
full
so that's pretty straightforward there
um
and yeah we're pretty much done here so
yeah that's all we want to do for quick
start so i'll just close that stuff off
and i'll see you in the next video okay
[Music]
so let's take a look here at docker
compose which is a feature of docker
but what's interesting is you can run it
within git pod and so the reason why
this is interesting is because you can
run containers within containers or
technically docker within docker if
you've ever seen the movie inception
with leonardo dicaprio where he goes uh
deep into dreams a dream within a dream
that's what we're doing here it's kind
of crazy
so let's talk about what docker compose
is so it's a tool for running
multi-container applications on docker
defined using the compose file format so
we're not just running a single
docker container running multiple
containers at the same time so a compose
file which is going to be named docker
hyphen compose yaml which will sit at
the root of your directory
is used to define how one or more
containers that need to be running and
the communication between them to run
our application and so within our gitpod
configuration file
we can run docker compose poll and up
commands to get multiple containers
running so there they are of course we
don't see the docker compose yaml file
here in the slide but we will see it in
the follow along so it will make sense
there okay
[Music]
so something i want you to consider is
that you can build container images and
virtual machine images within containers
and so if you're looking for some open
source tooling or things that might work
uh within a gitpod workspace
we have hashicorp packers so this is an
open source tool to build golden images
for virtual machines or docker or maybe
build a
which is an open source tool to build
oci compliant images of course there are
other
tool tools out there so for instance
there's dazzle which is made by get pod
i don't know a lot about it i don't know
if we're going to
actually uh give it a try within the
course but that's something that builds
out container images with some advantage
around layers okay
[Music]
all right so we're going to learn all
about get pod environment variables so
before we do we need to define what are
environment variables commonly referred
to by developers as and vars is a
variable whose values is set outside of
a program and it's composed of a key and
pair so here's an example within bash
this is generally how you do it so you'd
write export to set the environment
variable you have the key so
very
common to set it to be all uppercase
it's just tradition so that's what we
normally do equals followed by a string
and if we want to print it we could do
echo is one great way of doing that
there and so environment variables can
be set in four ways for your git pod
workspace you have the git pod cli the
gitpodio account settings environment
variables the gitpod url and
getpodconfiguration file per start task
so we will jump into all those variants
okay
[Music]
before we jump into the four different
ways we can set environment variables
let's talk about the defaults in prefix
for uh get pod so the default
environment variables are set by getpod
automatically every time you launch a
new workspace so
there's a lot of them but two that
really stand out are getpod workspace id
so this is a universally unique idea
uuid associated with the workspace and
then the getpod workspace url the unique
url for the workspace if you want to see
them all we'll do this in the follow
along you can use um the batch command
env to print them all out and then you
have a pipe followed by grep to say
filter out the ones that start with get
pod underscore because they're all going
to start with git pod underscore and to
talk about that prefix it's a reserve
prefix so environment variables
beginning with the git pod underscore
are reserved for internal use by gitpod
and are overwritten on every workspace
startup so if you attempt to set
something with your own like getpodandru
uh it will get ignored or will not be
accessible uh if you try to override one
that's existing that's just not gonna
happen okay so just be aware of that
[Music]
so one way we can set environment
variables
for git pod workspaces is within the
gitpod yaml or the gitpod configuration
file at a per task level so here is an
example
of a
gitpod configuration file and here you
can see we are doing env colon
and then we're following up with a key
and a pair and we can put as many as we
want in there
and so that's going to set for the next
time the environment launches notice we
have the dollar sign this is not get pod
specific that is just how bash scripts
work
and so you can do that to access the
value there
okay and so the environment variables
will be scoped only for
that terminal so that task that spins up
and other terminals will not have that
environment variable set and i was i was
very certain to test that out and we
will look at that when we do it in the
follow along okay
[Music]
so another way we can set
environment variables for get pod is via
the gitpod url so right after the hash
or pound there we can just start
specifying multiple ones there separated
by a comma
you probably don't want to be putting
sensitive
things in there because you know there's
potential for those to be exposed like
it was access keys and secrets but it's
really nice to be able to do that so the
environment variable set in the url will
be available in all terminals within
your workspace so like where you have
per tassel scope for the um
uh you know per task right whether you
set it in the git pod yellow file this
these are going to be everywhere okay
[Music]
all right so another way to set
environment variables is setting them
through account settings so if you go
there you'll have account settings
environment variables and this is ideal
when you need to pass along variables
that are sensitive so something could be
sensitive it would be like interbus
credentials so from there you can open
up a new nvar and set its name its value
and its scope and that's the thing
that's interesting here is how scope
works
so in order to set environment variables
for specific workspaces you need to set
the scope
and so if you wanted to show up for
everything
you could do what it says here which is
provide a wild card for both uh wild
card forward slash wildcard but let's
look at some of the following patterns
that we can set and it's going to be
basically owner repo or an alternative
way of saying oregon project but this is
based on what is in github get lab
bitbucket right so that's what you want
to consider not to be confused and this
did confuse me with um teams because you
can have
or teams and projects within um get pod
and it's not based on that okay so for
example we have exam pro for slash exam
pro marketing it's going to make the end
bar available to a repo called example
marketing owned by exam pro right and
actually mine on
github is exam pro co with all capitals
right which is like this over here i
just wrote it lowercase for some reason
over here then we have um and i'll just
clear some of the drawings here but then
we could say
we could have a wild card on the end
here so wild card repo so make nvars
available to all repos owned by get pod
i o
um so maybe it's for across all repos
and then you could have the
wild card in the front as well and so
this is really useful um it says for
it says because i haven't used it yet
for all forks right so you know it could
be like get pot i o and then there's
like andrew brown at forward slash form
so that that stuff propagates there
so the scope is case insensitive so when
you enter the pattern it will be down
case so see how i'm upper i'm entering
this with title case here exam pro co
um it will just down case it to exam pro
co like all like all the letters uh down
cased so you know you don't have to be
too sensitive here when you're writing
that stuff in it's just going to fix
that for you okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and this follow
along we're going to look at all the
options we have for environment
variables because there's a lot of ways
that we can set them so what i'm going
to do is go ahead and create a new
repository we'll call this one git pod
env i'm going to go make that private as
per usual and we'll go ahead and add a
readme file and we're going to launch
ourself a new environment so we'll go
open up get pod here and while we're
waiting i probably have some code
already laying around from one of our
previous
repositories here so i think i'll go to
the ports one here because we're going
to probably just set up sinatra as per
usual
and that will be the means for which we
pass a long port so we'll give that a
moment to open and as that is going i'm
going to go over to the getpodio website
because what i want to show to you is
under your settings over here this is
where you're going to find environment
variables now i probably would prefer if
this was scoped at a per project level
but i mean of course you can launch
project like things that are not within
a project so i guess it makes sense that
it is global
but you know maybe in the future they'll
add it at a project um namespace there
which is totally fine but this is where
you're going to be able to set one place
for environment variables another place
will be in the url in the goodpod url
the cli and i think there is a fourth
option in the get podgaml file so what
we'll do here is we'll just get set up
and so as per usual i'll go to the
hamburger menu and we will launch a new
terminal and we'll wait a moment here
type in gp init so that we have a
get pod yaml file that we cannot mess up
which is something that i have a bunch
of trouble with but what we'll do is
create a new file here called server.rb
and we will go ahead and grab the same
code so it is just this very simple code
you've seen us grab it a few times from
the sinatra website if you if you're
looking for you just go to sinatra
sinatra ruby right and here and i'm
pretty much just grabbing that code okay
so and then we're putting this port here
with the app port again requiring
sinatra we'll go ahead actually we'll
type in bundle init to create our gem
file for ruby
and i'm just going to delete ah that can
stay in there that's fine we'll just
type in gem
cinatra
and then i'll do a bundle install so we
install sinatra our very lightweight
ruby web server there and so that is now
installed and so
i'm just thinking about this for a
moment um
because it's installed i'm just trying
to think like what would be the best
approach
um so what i'm going to do
is
we'll do the get pod yaml file last
because we can set environment variables
in here but i think that's something
that we can wait for but we will need to
kind of set up this file so i'm going to
do a
bundle
install and you see me do this as a
separate task but i'm just going to make
my life easy by just doing a bundle
install here
and then we'll do a bundle
exec
ruby server.rb
okay
and so there is no port number being set
here so it's going to be whatever it is
i'm just going to get rid of the ports
because we'll just let it launch and
then from there we'll just expose ports
as we go
but i'm just thinking here for a moment
about what i would like to do
let's do it from the url first so that's
what i want to do i want to see if i can
change the port number via the url so
what we'll do
is i'm just going to make sure this
works
okay
just make sure that the server starts up
it does no problem there so we'll go and
do is uh commit these this uh these
files here okay
and i'm just going to say uh initial
repo
we'll go ahead and commit that save
those changes we'll say okay
so this should be everything that we
need to get going
so now i'm going to go ahead and just
close that and so
we're going to go back to example dev
and we're going to look for that new
repository that we just created
env
and so from here i mean we can click
this link but i'm just going to right
click and copy the link address just to
save myself some trouble we're gonna go
ahead here oops
copy uh copy link address
and again we'll paste it up in here and
so what we'll do is set the environment
variable up here so i'm gonna do app
port
equals
um
eight
eight eight eight okay and we'll put a
four slash in there and so that means
that sinatra should start up on port
eight eight eight eight because we are
injecting environment variables that way
so we'll see if that actually works
assuming i wrote that correctly but i'm
pretty sure i did it's not like that
hard to do
and we'll give it a moment here
and it started up on port
888 so passing via the get get pod url
wasn't too
uh troublesome here
and so another way that we can uh
set environment variables
i mean there's something with the the
the get uh get
uh pod cli here so here is control user
defined persistent environment variables
and i haven't really done much with this
yet so let's see what it does
i'm not sure we'll say help
and we'll just go up here and see what
it says so this command can print and
modify the persistent environment
variables associated with your user so
to set the persistent environment
variable to foo bar so we would just do
that so we'll do gpe env
and we'll just say
app port equals
and hit enter
and so that just sets the port number so
i'm assuming that's all it does
okay so we would do
echo here
[Music]
because here it's saying this if i go
here is it just because i've already set
one so maybe it's just because it's
already been set so it can't be
overwritten because it's interesting
that it's it's doing this here
so i'm gonna try this again one more
time
and it's doing eight eight eight eight
eight
so let's go take a read up on what that
does we'll say get port
or um get pod
um
cli
and if we go here
we'll look at env because it just might
be that we can't overwrite it so
uh with gpe and v you can set an api
endpoint environment variable that is
accessible for the project even if you
stop the workspace and start a new one
to delete or unset environment variable
uh do that so i mean it just looks like
it sets environment variable so but the
thing is that we sent through the getpod
url so it might never be able to unset
it
so what i'm gonna do just to rule that
out i'm just gonna open up a new
workspace here
and we'll try to set it and then see if
it actually prints out
all right so it's just starting up here
and it's starting on port
8765 which is
interesting because
i definitely um
did not set it so maybe what it did when
we did that is it actually set it up
over here so i'm just curious if we give
this a refresh oh
so that's what that does okay
so that's really curious
all right so because i thought it was
just going to be temporary like you just
did it within the actual workspace but i
guess what it actually does is set it up
in your account settings and here you
can see that it's setting it for the
scope so we have at port 8765. i was
going to show you this separately but i
guess if we did it that way we don't
have to do that there but just make note
that you can do
wild cards here so if you wanted this to
be set for all projects so maybe you
always do port 3000 and you're always
using app port or something like that
you could do that or if you wanted it
for every single fork you could do that
so i could update that it would still
apply
but that's interesting i did not know
that
um so
i mean
that's great now let's take a look at
what we would do if we set it up in the
git pod yemel and i don't know which one
would override so like there's one set
in here but would get pot yaml have more
presidents i don't know so what we'll do
is just type in env i'm going to go here
and do app
port
and we'll do
probably colon and here i would just say
seven seven seven seven
uh you gotta be kind of careful because
sometimes these are reserved ports but i
don't think so i just again i've never
seen someone do that so
maybe like four three two one might be a
better idea and so what we'll do here is
just save this and see what happens
let's see if it actually overrides with
this port or sorry this environment
variable
so uh commit
env within
getpod file okay
and we will save that
will
sync those changes
and what we'll do is just close this
and we'll go ahead and relaunch that
and then we'll see which takes over and
we might even go to the extreme and also
set in the get pod url and see what
happens so here it's starting on port
four three two one so even though we
have set it
um in here it looks like the git pod
yaml is gonna have higher priority here
so now what i wanna do is close it out
and we're going to then set it in the
url and see which one it takes
i'm going to assume it's always going to
be the good pod url configuration file
first
so or environment variable sorry so
we'll copy this address up here i'm
going to go ahead and paste it on in
here
and so what i want to do is just say app
port
equals four four four four
four slash
and so i want to see if it picks up this
one
again i'm going to assume it's going to
be the 4321 because the github yaml
should be uh high priority
that's how i would code it and so it is
four three two one
okay
so now i guess the next question is is
what happens if i remove
this
and we do the url is it gonna pick up
the one from the account settings or
just going to pick up the one from here
so just say remove env
sync those changes we'll say okay
and we'll go back here and
we will just copy the link address again
we will paste it on in there and here
i'm going to say app port equals 444
forward slash
this looks okay to me we'll hit enter
we'll see what it picks up
and it's eight seven six five so um
unless i did it wrong but i don't think
i did
um it looks like that the priority is
um
git pod yaml then account settings and
then the url
is last in terms of priority okay
so i mean that's pretty much all we
really need to know about environment
variables there are environment
variables that are set for um i guess we
could look at also
the gitpod prefixes so if you type in
env
and you go grep
gitpod
you can see all the ones that are set by
getpod there so if we just scroll up
here for a second
they have repo root so that's the root
of the repository so that might be
useful if you need to reference it an
elix writer segment so i guess they're
using segment which is a
analytics tool the workspace id the
interval which is whatever i assume it's
how often it checks i guess that might
be for the timeout because it says three
zero zero zero and i know that it's like
30 minutes so maybe if we were to extend
our time that would increase
the context url so that's just where it
was referenced to the instance id so i'm
assuming it's the underlying container
or something like that
the url
thea i think he has something to do with
eclipse i'm not really sure
context so we have a bunch of stuff here
so you know
nothing that you would really be trying
to utilize but um you know there's a lot
of stuff here you can see my email uh
they get podcasts but um
and you can't obviously override these
so i'm not gonna go bother to show that
but just so you know you cannot override
those values
um or set something with get pod
underscore i i'm not sure let's actually
go take a look and see if that's
possible so what i'm going to do here
i'm just going to make up one like
underscore andrew and just confirm is if
you're able to set it i like i would
think that it's just if there's ones
that they decide to set you can't set
ones with those but
i just want to see what happens so we'll
copy this link
and we'll just paste it up here
i'm going to just say something like get
pod andrew and i'm going to say equals
brown and we'll do a forward slash it's
my assumption that
it will get set but it can get overrided
and we'll give it a moment here
and so we'll just kill the server and
what i want to do here is just type in
env get pod underscore
andrew
uh oops we gotta grab that
okay so it seems like if you set
something with get pot underscore it
just gets wiped out won't even exist uh
but yeah there you go that's environment
variable so just close that stuff off
and we might just want to delete that
out there and we are good
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
looking at the open mode configuration
option when we are defining our start
tasks so open mode allows you to
configure how the terminal should open
relative to the previous task so here's
an example of me writing a git pod yaml
file and i have a bunch of different
tasks and they all have a variety of
different open modes and so what you're
looking for here and i know it's hard to
see but it's this box over here so
you're going to just see some
interesting things where
some are split and so when you click
into this one it's showing all four of
those and so hopefully i can show that
better um in the follow along here but
there are four different options we can
set so we have tab after so opens in the
same tab group right after the previous
tab tab before so it opens in the same
tab group
left before the previous tab split right
so splits and adds the terminal to the
right and split left so splits then adds
the terminal to the left okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at vs code extension so
what is the vs code extension well it
lets you install features themes
programming languages
uh support debuggers and other tools to
your vs code editor to support your
development workflow and so you know if
i wanted to install something i'd open
up the extensions panel or explorer and
from there i could install something
like vim that's something i really like
for my keyboard there and so vs code
extensions are added to a github
workspace in three different ways so you
have built-in extensions these are
extensions installed by default by git
pod the open vsx registry so this is a
community marketplace for extensions
user extension so these are extensions
not in the open vsx registry or we're
just saying like extensions that have
been installed by the user okay and so
vs code extensions are named dot v s i x
um i assume it stands for visual studio
integration extension i don't know if
the i is for i could not find out but
they are vsix
and so it is essentially just an
archived file so if you were to rename
this to a dot zip you could actually
open up the archive and view the source
files so there you go
[Music]
so git pod comes pre-installed with many
vs code extensions and you can view the
pre-installed extensions by searching at
sign built-in within the extensions
panel here so just notice this icon here
where it looks like
four little blocks and one is broken off
here if i type in at sign built in in
the search at the top these are all the
ones that are coming pre-installed and
there's a lot as you can see here almost
looks like
about 80 that are installed if you count
up the numbers there and so i just went
through it and mostly what's interesting
are the is the feature support that's
installed because that's going to change
the behavior and so here are ones that i
thought were notable or interesting to
show select git github get pod web grunt
gulp image preview microsoft account
merge conf conflict things like that but
you know if you want to know what's
being sold just take a look there you
might learn something new and improve
your uh workflow okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown and we're taking a
look at the open vsx registry so it is a
vendor neutral open source alternative
to the visual studio marketplace and
gitpod uses vs code extensions from the
open vsx registry as opposed to the
visual studio marketplace and so this is
kind of a a screenshot of the home page
of the openvsx registry which is at
openhyphenvsx.org very simple you just
search the name
and you can find whatever you want the
question is why are they using openvsx
registry as opposed to the visual studio
marketplace well
this vsix files downloaded from the
visual studio marketplace should not be
installed
in gitpod because microsoft prohibits
the direct use of their marketplace by
any non-microsoft software even though
most extensions are actually open source
and not developed or maintained by
microsoft so this is kind of one of
those weird things where you know
microsoft is not being as open as they
could be uh for their own self-interest
and so the openvsx registry is there to
ensure that
um you know organizations that are
investing into cloud developer
environments aren't going to run into
licensing issues and also to make uh the
market uh fair and competitive so
that's kind of really interesting and i
looked it up like where this was hosted
and it's actually eclipse
that is the one that is behind this and
eclipse has been an open source id for
forever and so it's really great that
they are doing this for the community
so when you search extensions uh within
the gitpod vs code ui extensions panel
it will search extensions in the openvsx
registry so if you can find it on the
openvsx website
then you're going to find it in here as
well
and for ones that you cannot find in
here
or
ones that you need to install directly
that's where you're going to be
installing them yourselves which we'll
talk about
soon enough okay
[Music]
so when you are exploring the extensions
panel and you're quickly looking to
install some extensions you can right
click on this little cog here um right
here and what it will do is it'll open
up a context menu it's called a context
menu because it's opening
a menu within the context of what you
clicked that's it's just a general uh
programming term and so you'll have this
option to say add to git pod yaml so if
you click that that will just populate
your document for you
which will save you the trouble of
populating that yourself
um but uh you just have to remember
you'll have to commit that uh code to
your repository for it to persist okay
[Music]
all right so let's talk about user
extensions so there are two ways to
install extensions beyond the built-in
extensions the first is for all users
for a project so git pod configuration
file extension vs code.extensions is
where we are going to set that value
which we'll see here in a moment or
there's the second case where you're
only installing for the current user and
that's we're going to be using the vs
code settings sync feature which we'll
see in the next video so down below here
is an example of a gitpod configuration
file where we're setting vs code
extensions and so we're installing ones
that are from the openvsx registry by
giving them their name and then down
below we're specifying a url of a i
assume it has to be public-facing
self-hosted vs code extension i think
that this can also be a local file path
because when you try to import a
vs ix file um within the gitpod
vs code interface it actually
first looks locally so that would be
interesting to
uh find out but you know probably in
practicality you're going to always have
it uh online somewhere so anyway um for
the extensions i just want to show you
that if you were to open up the open vsx
registry you can see the name there i
know it's hard because it's orange but
that kind of helps you understand what
thing you are pulling in and putting
into that file okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at a feature of vs code
called settings sync so this is a
feature to sync your configuration such
as settings key bindings installed
extensions across your machines so you
are always working with your favorite
setup and so with the desktop version of
vs code the one you install locally not
the one in the browser part of git pods
you need to log in to a github or
microsoft account to store the sync
settings which is a json file so if you
opened it for the first time it says
sign in with microsoft sign in with
github but with git pod when you turn on
the settings syncs feature you're not
going to be choosing an account to log
in because you already are authenticated
with something like github gitlab or
a bitbucket but the settings data i
believe will be stored on the gitpod
servers and your configuration will
persist across all your workspaces and
when we say that we're talking about all
the getpod workspaces not necessarily
the ones on your local machine okay
that's something else so you can set
extensions within your dot git pod yaml
file which we'll learn in this course
however some extensions which are
designed for developers personal
preferences should not be set here and
instead settings things should be used
so a very good example here would be the
vs code vim changes keyboard mode okay
because this could greatly impact other
developers so i use bim i really like
vim and so i
had applied this here and then one of
our other developers said hey i don't
like using vim i want to turn this off
so it doesn't belong here and so that's
the reason i'm bringing this up and also
just to describe how setting syncs works
a little bit different okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and in this
follow along we're going to take a look
at
vs code extensions or
in the context of get pods so what i'm
going to do is just make a new get pod
and
there's not really anything special
we're going to do in this one it's going
to be more focused around the extensions
but we got to launch something so whoops
did i just launch an existing
environment i'm going to go ahead and
just create a new
repository so we can just play around in
something new and so i'll just say git
pod ext for extensions we'll make it
private as per usual create the new
repository
and we'll give it a moment here and
we'll go ahead and hit the get pod
button so what i'm going to do is just
go over to open vsx registry and we'll
just take a look at what this is so you
saw me talking about it and um
it looks a lot cooler in dark mode but
it's not flipping over to that right now
so we're in light mode but this is a
vendor neutral open source marketplace
and basically there's the other one
which is the vs code marketplace right
and there's a problem because you know
these marketplaces look really similar
there's a problem in the sense that
um microsoft has problematic licensing
or rules around this thing and that's
why this one exists
so this isn't the problem this is more
so the problem or at least what
microsoft has done with this which is
kind of unfortunate but um the great
thing is that you know if you are
somebody that is creating
um vs code extensions you can just put
them in both marketplaces but if you
could just put them in here honestly um
and so i believe this repository is
managed by clips if i just try to find
it here yeah so this service is operated
by the eclipse foundation if you don't
know
clips they are kind of a big deal
because they've been around for
such a long time uh which is really nice
here
and so the source code for open vsx is
managed by the openvsx team which is
very cool as well and so they have this
i don't think i've ever actually looked
at this but let's just take a look here
so yeah so there's that with uh eclipse
okay
but anyway so here are all of our um
extensions but the great thing is is
that if you are over here
in the extensions panel here anything
you search is already going to look here
so if i look up something for
ruby
okay so we might have like
this one here
the reborn nix dot ruby
and you go over to ruby over here
and this one's not installed but i'm
gonna go ahead and install it i wonder
if it will pull up where it's from
let me just see
here marketplace so if we go click the
marketplace
yeah it takes us to openvsx this version
of ruby extension was published by
openvsx this user account is not
verified from the publisher
uh of this extension okay but anyway so
here it is and so uh you get an idea of
of what that is and so when you install
these extensions gitpod is going to
already have
um
they're going to have
the sync turned on it's here in the
wheel so
the great thing is once you install
something you like it's going to persist
um to other things but if you're working
on a ruby project you might want to just
uh include that into your getpod.yaml
file so what i would do
is just create a i'd say get pod open in
vs code
and we would say whoops i actually want
to do that i want to sorry open a new
terminal
and i'm just going to initialize a new
file
and within here we're going to do an
extension i can't remember what it is so
i'm just going to look it up so get pod
extensions
like the syntax for it
and there it is so i'm just going to go
ahead and grab that little part there
we'll go ahead and paste it on in there
allow
and so we know that this extension is
called this and it's already in the
uh open vs code or the open registry
there and so we can just do that i'm
just going to double check to make sure
that's the correct syntax notice you can
also put that sign version on it if you
want or you can specify a vsix file
which maybe we'll try to do this one
here
but i guess to really test this we're
going to need a secondary account where
we don't have this already installed
so what i'll do
is um
maybe i can make a snapshot for this
because we haven't done any snapshots
yet
but anyway so i'll just create a new
ruby file here we'll just say hello dot
rb
and we'll type in puts
so
hello world
and we'll go ahead and just make sure
that works not that it matters but we'll
just run it for any reason
okay so that works fine and so we kind
of have this little basis of a
thing using that extension so we'll go
ahead and
run or commit that so
initial commit
and then what i'm going to do here is
i'm going to go ahead and create a
snapshot so we'll say git pod share
workspace snapshot now i could share
this in real time but i figured it'd
just be easier to take a snapshot and
then would be our opportunity to give
that a go
and i have firefox still open here on
the side here so i'll just share it with
this account over here
so down below it created the snapshot
i'm going to copy that url i'm just
going to paste it on it over here and
see what happens
notice that this person isn't
technically in the same project or
anything i could just share it with
anybody
and so here is that project um
and we'll give it a moment here
we'll have to look at snapshots in a
little more detail when we get to that
section but what i want to find out is
is this extension installed here on this
version here with firefox so now if i go
over to ruby
is it installed
it is installed okay so this firefox uh
uh one is my other
uh my main um
getpod account and i did not install
this so you can tell that it came along
there with the getpod.yaml file didn't
like say hey we installed it other than
the fact that we checked it but that is
uh good to see
i think it can be interesting if we can
try to bring in a vsix file
so that will be something we'll give it
a go here so maybe what we could do
um maybe there's like something a little
bit more obscure that we could uh
install
just go back here
i was trying to think of something that
probably isn't installed
like maybe this thing here
okay don't know what it is
but what i'll do
yet another client cool but what i'll do
is i'll go over to the extensions here
and we'll just see if we have it
installed yet
just in case it's not good so what i
want to do is see if i can download this
and then reference it so we'll hit
download
and we're going to download that vsix
file and i'm just curious because they
say that you can rename these files
right you can rename these files
and from there if you rename them with
zip you can open them up
so that's what i'm going to do i'm just
doing this off screen here by the way
just because i have so many things here
i'm just going to maybe expand that here
there i'm just showing you the file i'm
going to go here and rename this to
zip
okay
we'll say yes
and i'm just going to open it up
and then here in winrar we can see the
contents of this file
and
i'm kind of interested in its contents i
might go ahead and actually download
this
into our git pod
that's what i'm going to do
so what i'm going to do is go back here
and we're just going to copy the link
address here
and from here i'm just going to do
curl
maybe wget i prefer wget
and we're just going to download that
file within this here
so if we go over here we can see the
vsix file
and so now uh what i can do is i can
just copy this
and then we're going to type it again
and just change it over to zip
and then i think i can just type unzip i
always forget what it is but we'll try
it and it did it just unzipped the
contents there so
we have this file here an xml file that
describes something
and then we have
the manifest file so i guess it
describes
its manifest
and then we open up the extension here
is a bunch of stuff so it looks like you
can set uh the icon here
looks like it's just javascript though
we opened up this package so
there's like a readme about it
i get i've never made a extension so i'm
just kind of poking around here to see
what there is
so probably like this code is
pre-compiled out so i can't imagine like
the developer works this way so this is
like a compiled uh version of their
their source code so you probably
wouldn't want to uh
like
um unravel this so it's not like it's
showing all the details of it but you
know just curious to kind of open that
up but anyway now that we have the that
there let's go see if we can actually
specify now if you want to install this
locally i'm pretty sure if we go to
i saw it the other day here
i thought it was up here in the top
right corner people gotta go extensions
ah here we go let's see consult install
from vsix and so here we could specify a
a path
all right
but i don't know if this would actually
take this from a
a local a local path here because they
don't show that in the example over here
see how it's a url so i think that we
would have to um host that somewhere so
to speak so what i'm going to do is i'm
just going to go ahead and
commit this
all this stuff uh we'll just say git add
all git commits
hyphen m um
ext code
the only problem is repo is not public
facing
and if it's not public facing i'm not
sure how it's going to pick up that
extension
so
maybe what i should do
and we can commit all this stuff i don't
care what i'm going to do is just create
a new repository here that's public
facing
get pod whoops
get pod exe example
and we'll make this one public
but this time around i'm just going to
upload a file so here we could say
upload an existing file
and so i'm just going to drag that file
on in
okay i'm just renaming it back to what
it was so we'll go there
and so now this file is uploaded in this
repository
in a public repository and so now what i
want is just the raw version of this
file so
maybe we just
yeah we grab this link here so we go
copy link address and we go back over to
here
and get rid of this thing here get out
of here it won't get out of the way i'm
not sure how to get rid of context menus
that are like that
that's really annoying
okay there we go it just closed on its
own i didn't do anything so i'll paste
that on in there and again i don't know
this is going to work but i'm just going
to try it anyway and so what we'll do is
just
update our commit here so
try and install
http yak
okay and we'll save changes we'll say
okay
and i kind of lost where we are so i'm
going to open up the context here
and we'll close the old tab and we'll
just hit get pod and we'll see if that
actually installs while it's going let's
go let's go take a look at what this
actually is get another client quickly
and easily send rest soap graphql or
grpc request directly in your editor
so i guess it's like kind of a little
convenience thing
yeah i've never heard of it
sounds cool though
um and so this has started back up and
so what i want to know is is this
installed so we go to our extensions
and i think that it's installing this
but we'll take a look here http yak
and click that it is now installed so
there you go that's uh that's kind of
interesting there
um
another thing that we can look at is the
built-in extension so if you type in at
sign built in
this is all the stuff that is um
installed by default for you
and so there's quite a bit quite a lot
of interesting stuff here so you can
just like scroll through and kind of see
the information so you got features lots
of themes
and lots of supported programming
languages but you know
is what it is and everything's really
snappy too with all the stuff installed
so
it's really great um but that's pretty
much all i really wanted to show for
extensions
so we'll just close all this stuff and
there we go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at get pod workspaces
which represents an ephemeral isolate
runtime system running within a docker
container on a kubernetes cluster so
there's a lot going on there and so i
just want to take an opportunity to
describe in brief a lot of these terms
so first of all what is a container this
is a runtime environment that includes
configuration for os so operating system
memory disk and network access what is
docker so this is an open source
container containerization platform to
package application or workloads
into containers we have kubernetes so
kubernetes is a open source container
orchestration to coordinate and maintain
many container images and then we have
ephemeral which means lasting a short
amount of time and then a runtime system
a piece of software that provides the
programmer a more convenient environment
for running programs in our case the
runtime system is intended for
development in practicality you need to
remember all these terms not so much
just the fact that workspaces
are ephemeral so they only last a short
amount of time and they're for
development and they use containers okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
talking about the underlying git pod
resource size because this is a question
that my co-founder came to me and said
what is the power under the hood for
these workspaces and when i looked into
it i discovered that gitpod does not
allow you to choose the power of the
underlying instance and that might sound
like a negative but it's actually a very
strong positive because they're
abstracting away a decision for you so
you can just focus on the business value
and that is what we call a true
serverless offering okay and so
you could say gitpod is a serverless
cloud developer environment
so the underlying computing power is
unknown but we generally know the limits
of an individual workspace because if
you go into the
discourse the um the forms for git pod
we've seen
engineers at gitpod describe what limits
there are
and so the generally known limits is
like
v7v cpus
12 gigabytes of ram 30 gigabytes of disk
and you can see there are some um
explanations as to what that is but the
idea is that you shouldn't really have
to worry about it it's the idea is you
just pay a fixed cost and whatever size
you need is available to you
um but you can always self-host right so
if you do need more direct control of
the underlying computing layer i think
that would be an option where you would
have to self-host but there's so much
you can do with git pod and you don't
have to worry about
picking what virtual machine you need to
launch it just works okay
[Music]
okay let's talk about workspace
lifecycle or just features of a
workspace so the first is workspace
timeout so after a period of inactivity
a workspace will be stopped the default
timeout is 30 minutes timeouts can be
extended to 60 or 180 minutes with the
unleashed plan and there is a few
caveats that we're missing there but
that's okay we have a slide dedicated uh
or video dedicated just to timeout okay
then we have our
ephemeral storage so this is storage
that will be on a virtual disk available
to the workspace when a workspace is
stopped the data on the affir
affair remote
storage is persisted and saved
so when a workspace is deleted or
terminated the data on the storage is
lost so only the data located in that
for slash workspace is going to be
persisted so
anything out there when you stop it
there's no guarantee that it's going to
be there then we have garbage collection
so git pod allows for a certain amount
of stopped workspaces to remain for
reuse
and this is really useful if you ever
have to go back a few versions there i
don't know if it stops at 200 but i just
know that we have a range selection of
50 to 200 so it's my assumption that
there's nothing beyond 200 why you need
more i don't know but i'm just stating
that is there for you so gitpod will
begin deleting workspaces beyond a
certain number uh uh uh based off of
days of non-use so currently it's
hardcoded for 14 days so if you have
like 50 or 30 workspaces and you haven't
touched them for 14 days they're gonna
get permanently deleted and you won't be
able to spin them back up and i mean
generally the idea is that you don't
really want to be leaving workspaces
with code lying around for that long so
i think that's okay
[Music]
okay so let's talk about the underlying
life cycle and phases for a workspace to
distinguish from light like when i said
workspace lifecycle earlier i meant
let's just say like features but that's
what the documentation called it so now
we're actually talking about the actual
life cycle of a workspace here so when a
workspace is created it will go through
a fixed life cycle separated in phases
these phases are currently not
observable by the end user within
getpodio
however i would imagine that if you are
doing self-hosted git pod
open source version so on a managed
kubernetes cluster this information
would be somewhere available in the logs
we might discover that as we do the
self-hosted
follow along to see what we can see
there but
it's still useful to go through these
states so we understand what's happening
under the hood so the first is unknown
so indicates an issue within the system
and that it cannot determine the actual
phase of the workspace we have preparing
so this is where it's building the
docker image for the workspace pending
the workspace does not yet consume
resources in the cluster creating the
workspace is currently being created
initializing the phase in which the
workspace is executing the appropriate
workspace initializer running so the
workspace is able to actively perform
work either by serving a user through
thea or as a headless workspace
interrupted the container should be
running but it is temporary and
available it should
it should self-resolve or
running or just running or stopping
sorry and so stopping that's when the
workspace is currently shutting down
then stopped uh the workspace ended
regularly because it was shut down so
again uh you know we might not see this
until we do the self-hosted section here
but i always think it's useful to kind
of pull this information
up up front here so we know what's going
on
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at workspace instance
types so within a workspace cluster
several types of workspace exist the
first is regular so when a user launches
a workspace with the visible code energy
ui this is considered a regular
workspace or just as we call it a
workspace
other types of workspaces are
headless because there is no code editor
ui for the user to interact with the
first being ghost so ghost workspaces
are placeholders in the system they are
used to scale up nodes ahead of time and
are replaced by regular workspaces when
needed they are a custom implementation
of preemptable kubernetes pods then you
have pre-builds and you will encounter
this in the git pod i o
and so prebuilds are triggered
automatically or manually performing the
before init execution order sets within
a get pocket fiction file task so a
pre-build will generate a snapshot and
upload their log output for later
consumption i haven't figured out where
that log output is but it says that they
do it and then builds i had to surmise
are when a user manually takes a
snapshot for sharing a workspace uh
you know via a snapshot okay so there's
that i think it's called snapshot but
when you open up the
getpod
command palette there's like an option
to
do that there and again these are those
headless workspaces okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
looking at timeouts for getpod
workspaces and there's five things i
want you to know so when you stop an
instance the workspace will shut down
instantly deleting instance will delete
the current state of the workspace
stopping it will persist the data okay
then when you close a browser tab the
workspace will shut down in three
minutes this is really great to know
because i i never knew when i closed the
browser tab what would happen there but
it reached out and said don't worry
andrew after three minutes it will shut
down so that's nice to know uh then
there's the case where you might leave a
browser tab open so by default after 30
minutes it will turn off but if you need
beyond 30 minutes what you can do is
upgrade to the unleashed plan and that
allows you to set a need new default of
60 minutes or you could just say one
hour there
and then there's a case where you can
even have it even longer than that so
maybe you need a timeout because you're
doing like a long build so you can boost
the time of the current workspace up to
three hours when i say up to i think you
just choose three hours uh and uh that's
again with the unleashed plan so here's
kind of an example where somebody has
the default to 60 minutes and for
whatever reason they need to extend it
so they press that button
and the idea behind boosting is it's
useful when you have a computational
task that is going to take a long period
of time so you're going to be inactive
maybe you need to leave for lunch and
ensure it remains running so you're just
like okay i'm going to press that button
like maybe i'm going to meeting and i
have and i just want to make sure my
workspace doesn't shut down for whatever
reason so it's not interrupted uh so you
know those are the five cases that i
want you to know okay
hey this is andrew brown and what i want
to show you here in get pod is a a
feature of the unleashed plan or
actually two features so what i'll do is
make my way over to settings
and go over to plans just to show you
that i've temporarily upgraded here so
we can show you timeout and three hour
timeout boost now i don't think there's
an option to choose from 30 minutes to
one hour once you are on this plan it
just is one hour timeout uh and it's not
something you have to really worry about
because you have unlimited hours at this
time so it's not something you have to
like try to conserve where you are
trying to worry about this meter up here
but let's showcase what the three hour
timeout boost looks like so what i'll do
is go back to my workspaces here you can
do this with anything just launch
whatever you can here so i'm just going
to open something that i was recently
working on so that was gke
i'm not sure if this one was even
successful i think i might have been
making a video for it and it didn't work
out which is totally fine but i'll just
launch it anyway again doesn't matter
which one you launch i just want to show
you how do you do that timeout boost
and i was saying like that timeout boost
is really good if you have some long
running tasks uh and you know that
you're going out for lunch and you just
want to make sure that that that thing
keeps running so um i believe that it's
down below here so i'm just looking for
it if there is a boot so down below here
see it says workout timeout 60 minutes
click to extend and so you can do it
here i'm not going to click it just yet
but i just want to see if it shows up
under the command pal so i clicked on
the get pod logo in the bottom left
corner it says extend work space timeout
so what i'm going to do is click the one
in the bottom right corner i know it's
really hard to see but just know that
i'm clicking it it says work timeout has
been extended to three hours now would
that be reflected anywhere i'm not sure
so we'll just go to get podio we're
gonna go look at this workspace
and there's no reflection that we know
that it's currently being extended so
you just have to know
if we go back here let me just see here
what happens if i hover over it so it
says 180 minutes click to extend can i
extend it again i doubt it
okay let's go over here again
so yeah it just says 180 min so 180
minutes is is three hours so the thing
is you would just assume that you would
keep this tab open and if you saw the
the little yellow icon you know that
it's still there so let's see what
happens if we close this
okay and then we reopen it
i just want to see if that yellow little
icon still stays active so that you know
that it's still there so we're opening
it up again here
and yeah it's yellow so if it's yellow
that's how you're going to know that
it's extended to three hours um so yeah
there you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about the workspace
directory so when you launch a workspace
the contents of your git repository will
be copied to a directory or folder
called forward slash workspace so here
you can see um i have a project called
exam pro marketing it's my marketing
website and so i've opened i've opened
up this git pod and you can see that
that folder has been cloned into that
workspace directory so when a workspace
is stopped the contents of only
workspace is saved so when you start the
workspace again it's going to have that
content still there and even in the um
the get pod i o it'll even tell you what
changes are there like you have 132
files changed so you have some kind of
indicator between different
um stopped workspaces the difference
there so here's an example
of a git pod configuration file because
we actually can change some of the
defaults here so you can change
what gitpod considers the workspace
location and in some cases with legacy
go link projects you might need to
change the checkered location there's
not really any reason to ever touch
these options but it's just the fact
that they are available to you i
wouldn't even know outside of that
golang project use case why you'd ever
touch these things but they are here
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at context and get pod url
so a context represents a state within
your git source code and with a get pod
url you can quickly load an environment
for a context so here we have the git
pod url it starts with this gitpodio
forward slash pound and then it's
followed by uh a url and that is what
gitpod is going to try to figure out the
context of when it launches
our workspace so the first is repository
con contacts and so this is just you
provide a repository it's going to open
it up for you to work in then you have
branches
or branch and commit contacts so this is
really useful if you are doing feature
branch uh workflows or that's how you do
that kind of stuff or you just have any
kind of branches that you have there
when you have commit contexts that's
when you are digging back in your old
code maybe you are trying to revert code
back to a previous state or there's a
deep rooted issue and you're just trying
to rule it out by going to a specific
version uh there so here is a branch and
here is a commitment message with its
sha
there that's the code on the end
then you have issue context so feature
development or bug fixing so this is
where um you know like github
has a project management tooling
and you can say okay somebody opened up
this feature this bug this whatever
request and you can then open it
in the context there
then you have pull and merge request
contacts so this would be for like code
review before merging for deployment and
so here we have a pull request and so
get pod url support github get lab
bitbuckets so if they have integration
they're of course going to support the
get pod url for that okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
share snapshot workspace so this will
let you take a snapshot url of your
current
workspace at any time and share them
with others so the way that would look
like is you drop down file you go to get
pod share workspace snapshot you can
also also open it up in the command
palette and from there
it will start to create
a snapshot and so i think this would
show up as a build phase underneath in
kubernetes we talk about those
underlying phases somewhere in the
course here
and from there
it's going to say okay it's generated
you can go copy that url to your
clipboard and that's what it looked like
so notice it has the pound
snapshot forward slash and then a big
long uuid
uh there and so
that's pretty much the process not too
complicated so anyone clicking on such a
snapshot link will get a complete clone
of your workspace including the state
of the workspace and the vs code layout
so workspaces created from snapshots are
treated as restarts so you can configure
them to launch differently than if you
had created a fresh workspace from git
unlike sharing running workspaces
snapshots workspaces are full copies
this means developers can do whatever
they like with the content no access to
your credentials or environment
variables are shared and we will double
check to make sure that is true um but
yeah that's that's share snapshot
workspace okay
[Music]
so the other way of sharing uh git pods
is via the share running workspace which
allows multiple developers to
collaborate on a single workspace in
real time and the flow here goes as
follows turn on sharing for the current
workspace copy the current link to the
uh to the workspace share the current
workspace with other developers so the
idea is there'll be a share button down
below you press it you turn it on you'll
get this link
and then you'll just share that with
other developers so a shared running
workspace cannot be opened in the
desktop vs code unless you're the owner
of the shared running workspace so if
you are used to using the desktop vs
code and somebody shares a workspace
just understand that there are those
limitations but i have to be
very careful here to tell you that when
you share a workspace you are literally
giving access to someone else to act as
you within your workspace they can
access sensitive information such as
access key secrets stored in the
environment variables uh the commits in
the workspace will show up as you
instead of the guest developer they can
share that link with other people and
you wouldn't even know it uh it is not
easy to tell who is currently editing in
your current workspace so it's generally
recommended to avoid or be very careful
when sharing a running workspace and
it's just that it's just the state of
this this feature for the time being so
getpod has made sharing available to you
they're going to continue to develop
this so that you have more visibility
over time but just understand that there
might be some limitations there so if
this is the future just review this and
see if it's still true
because some of these might have been
mitigated by the time you were watching
this video but just in case uh be on the
side of being wary okay
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at getpodcli so this
allows you to perform a variety of
utility commands useful for day-to-day
use in your gitpod workspace so
getpodcli comes pre-installed in your
workspace and is accessible via the
terminal so let's take a look at the
commands that we have available to us so
notice that it always starts with gp
okay so that is the name of the cli but
we have help so help about any command
and knit so create a git pod
configuration for this project env
controls user defined persistent
environment variables url prints the url
of this workspace open opens a file in
git pod
preview opens a url in the ides uh
preview
forward port so make a port available on
0.0.0.0
that is exposed to internet
but you know i don't really understand
what they're saying there because the
way i've been using it is just to
forward one port to another and we saw
that in
that section earlier when we're covering
ports so maybe it has more than one
purpose here we have a weight port so
weights for a process to listen on a
port sync a weight so awaits an event
triggered using the sync done
and then sync done notifies the
corresponding sync await calls that this
event has happened so a lot of these
we've actually already encountered in
the course so i'm not going to cover
those again here
but we will cover the ones that we have
yet to
explicitly
talk about okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the
get pod cli open command and this will
open the target file in the code editor
so the idea is you're gonna say gp open
and then give the path to the file that
you want to open
and so here i'm just doing gp open gem
file and then it opens the gem file
there and so that's just a
very convenient way of opening files
okay
[Music]
all right let's take a quick look here
at the gp url cli command which will
return the gitpod workspace url so there
i type in gpurl and then i get that
there and i just wanted to show you that
if you type in env and you do a grep
getpod workspace url that's going to
return
uh the same value so i'm just showing
you that it's a convenience for
uh getting the getpod workspace url
environment variable okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at the preview command for
the getpodcli so gpreview command can be
used to open a web url in line with the
vs code editor so here you can see me
using the gp preview command
using some fancy
bash scripting with it to open up the
current uh machine and so you know you
can see that it's completely in line
within the code editor so you can use
echo
echoing out the gpurl and modify the url
to include the port number and so
originally when i was doing this and you
can see this in the example here that i
was doing this like weird sed thing uh
because i didn't realize you could just
do this down below so you could do gp
preview and then do gp url 3000 i was
doing like some weird stuff there
but i found another repository that had
a more convenience method so
um once i discovered that i had to go
back and reshoot this video so i just
want you to know that that's the way you
would do it this one down below the ones
above here is totally acceptable as well
but this is what you'll probably want to
do and what i'll be showing uh in the in
the follow alongs okay but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and in this
follow along i just want to cover some
of the cli commands i haven't really
been using that much like open url and
preview
just so that you know what to use them
for so i'm going to go here and type in
git pod cli and we're going to create
ourselves a new private repository out
of readme file and we're going to go
ahead and get this going here
and we are going to launch ourselves a
new git pod here and we'll give it a
moment
and i really don't think if you go to
the cli here and they really should add
this in the documentation
but i don't think that the preview at
least i didn't see it had a very good
example
so it says gpurl8080
oh i guess they did and i just never
noticed
so that's okay i'm going to go back to
the preview you're not going to notice
it but i'm going to reshoot the cli
preview to show this more condensed
example
but what we're going to do here is
create ourselves a new folder called
oops i want a folder not a file a new
folder called public
and in that folder we're going to create
a new file called index
dot html and within that we're going to
say hello world and then from there we
are going to go and open up our terminal
and i'm just going to
install
hdb server globally
okay and then we'll just say http server
and leave it where it wants to be and
say port 8080
and so it's going to ask us if we want
to open that port i'm going to say make
public
and
from there
i didn't see it pop up
but we'll go over to our remote explorer
here left-hand side and just make sure
that the website is working there it is
so
you know if we wanted to open up let's
say we close this file here and we
wanted to open that file from the cli
i'm just going to type in clear here
what we could do is type in gp open
and then i could type in relative to
where i am so public
index html and it's going to open that
up
oh sorry it's gp not gh i'm thinking
github it'll be that'll be the way we
can open up files and that's for the
convenient when you're trying to
uh when you can locate things easily
through here and you want to open them
up
in the top
there and then we'll take a look at
clear so i'm going to see if we have two
bashes running we don't so i'm going to
at this top one here can i rename this i
can so we'll go here and just say like
http server here
and i'm just going to start up our
server again so we'll say http server
port 8080.
and then down below here where we have
our little playground i'm going to just
type in gp
open 8080.
oops uh sorry i meant to say gp oops
clear
gp url 8080.
and so notice what it did is that if you
just type in url
it's going to give you the plain jane
url which is actually just the url up
here if you put in 8080 it's going to
add it over here and so then what you
can do is take this url and you can
paste it up into here which is great
and so now we could use the gp preview
which will
open something over here so if i was to
do something like and i don't think it
will work in here but i'm going to just
type in google.com
okay for whatever reason it doesn't like
things that are outside the scope of
this project but just showing you an
example of opening that window there
what we could do is type in get
gp preview and then do this so this is
like a bash thing for encapsulating uh
stuff and we just type in gpurl88
and so now we can open it up here and so
that would be the convenience way of
doing that so you know that's gp open
gp
url and gp preview if we just want to
look at all them that are there i think
we've pretty much used everything the
other one we haven't used is stop
um so
i guess for fun we can just do it so
we'll just do gp stop
and that will that should stop this
environment so we'll give it a moment
see what happens
is it stopping it doesn't look like it's
stopping
oh it did okay so there you go so that
is all the cli stuff uh covered okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at the get pod palette
command so the github palette commands
is a series of commands you can use
within vs code to perform git pod
actions and so this is in the command
palette within vs code but if you click
the little orange button in the bottom
left corner you'll get all the possible
commands let's just quickly go through
them to see if there's anything that you
might like to use uh during your
workflow and through the follow alongs
you'll see me using some of these
because they are useful okay so the
first is stop workspace so stops does
not terminate but stops the current
workspace open settings so opens account
settings for the current uh gitpod user
open access control so it opens git pod
integrations page open context it opens
the context this is really good when you
need to go back to the repository i use
that one quite a bit open dashboard so
opens the gitpodio
platform default page so it's going to
take you to projects documentation
follow them on twitter which doesn't
hurt to have that in there i suppose
open community chat so that's going to
be on discord open community forum
that's going to be on discourse
report an issue that just takes you to
github issues
upgrade subscription this isn't going to
upgrade your plan if you click on it
it's just going to take you to the plans
page so you can choose a plan so don't
be afraid to click on that extend
workspace timeout so only works with
specific plans
share workspace snapshots so this is
when you create a snapshot and it
returns a snapshot link for sharing
share running workspace so turns on
sharing i don't i generally don't do it
from the command pal there's like a
little share button down below
um open in vs code so open the workspace
in your desktop uh version of vs code so
the desktop vs code
or insiders and that's just the beta
version of vs code it's just another one
okay so that is the command palette or
palette commands for get pod okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and in this
following we're going to just take a
quick look here at the gitpod
palette commands so if you're not
familiar with a command palette within
visual studio code it's a way of
executing a lot of
easy
scripts i suppose you could describe it
as so the way you would access that is
you go to the hamburger menu here in the
top left corner and you go to i believe
view you'll see command palette notice
it says control shift p so i'm going to
type that instead and if we type that we
have a bunch of different commands here
that we can enter in and this is really
dependent on what extensions you have
installed or just uh you know the
defaults that come with it
i don't use visual studio code a whole
lot so i don't even know what the most
common ones are but i do know that there
are git pod ones if you type in git pod
these are the ones here and notice that
there are a few extra things here that i
typed in that will not appear if we just
go click on the other area so just
notice that you might have some
advantage there if you just type it in
but we click off and you open that
hamburger menu again there are some of
them the most commonly used ones here uh
down below but if you want all the
command uh palette or or get pod uh
palette commands if you click this
orange button down below here it'll pop
them up okay so you know just so you
know how to get to those
again if you click any of these and
you've seen us do this a bunch of times
within the course i go to open context
it'll open up where this repository is
things like that but i just wanted to
make sure you understood uh what command
palette was and how to access all the
get pod command palettes okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at teams and projects
within gitpod io so gitpod team allows
you to invite people to collaborate on
your project
and so you can create multiple teams and
and uh one thing i notice is that if you
try to name your team
uh something like marketing it won't be
permitted because getpod is utilizing
something called the big username
blocklist so just understand that there
might be some limitations around the
naming you might have to be clever
but probably you won't run to the issue
i just choose to choose the name
marketing i just happen to hit that
block list
within a project you can have members
and sign them roles and so you have two
uh types of roles member and role
and then projects has the main
advantages of allowing you to utilize
pre-builds and i want to point out that
you have a personal account and you can
think of it as a team of one and so
within your personal account you can
create projects and that in turn will
allow you to use pre-build so pre-build
is not exclusively uh for just teams
okay just understand it's specific to
projects
[Music]
so let's take a closer look at um get
pod uh roles so within a gitpod team a
member can be signed either the owner or
member role but the key difference
between an owner and a member is that a
member cannot manage team members or
delete the team and so this is the full
matrix here and while i'm just getting
my pen tool out so we have manage team
members delete
delete team invite team members add
projects remove projects add project
view branches view pre-builds trigger
pre-builds and so at this stage of the
product you just have those two roles i
would imagine in the future they'll
probably open it up so you can choose
exactly what you want but for the time
being that is what we have and it works
pretty well
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at pre-build so pre-builds
is a continuous build server that will
run every time you push code to
repository so here is an example of a
bunch of pre-builds that are happening
for a workspace and so these are
really convenient let's talk about what
a pre-built workspace is so prebuilds
will execute the before internet
commands within your
kidpod.yaml files on a git commit and
produce a snapshot and we saw that
earlier in the course when we were
looking at execution order steps where
we have kind of a visualization there
the snapshot can be launched uh which
will save your development team time
waiting for lengthy builds
okay um the idea here is you can trigger
pre-builds automatically so a pre-build
will trigger on the default branch for
pull requests and merges from the same
repository i have yet to see options to
allow you to kind of customize that i'm
sure they'll do that in the future you
can also trigger pre-builds manually so
a pre-build can be manually triggered by
adding the pound pre-build to a git pod
url if that's one way you want to do it
i also think that there's a tab in a
project that lets you do it like
configuration or the file itself but i
don't think that would be a way that you
generally do it if you wanted to do it
you probably use the get part url uh
prebuilts have a timeout of one hour of
the combined time of the before init
before failing so if you know if it
takes too long it will just fail here
you can see i have a failed example uh
in that page there so they took too long
for whatever reason get pod does not
cache artifacts between pre-built each
pre-built is a clean environment um
what's interesting is that they do have
something with dazzle which will
actually
cache layers and stuff like that so i
think that you know this
might be an option in the future that we
might have that functionality but there
you go that's pre-builds
[Music]
so with tailscale you can automatically
and securely connect your gitpod
workspace to other development resources
whether in the cloud or on-prem such as
a production database behind your
company's firewall so the idea here is
that you have your laptop it's going to
connect to um tail scale and through
tail scale you'll have a secure
connection to git pod when you're on the
go so let's just define some of these
terms like vpn so a virtual private
network or vpn extends a private network
across a public network and enables
users to send and receive data across
shared or public work networks as if
computing devices were directly
connected to the private network then
the question is what is wireguard so
it's a simple yet fast and modern vpn
that utilizes state-of-the-art
cryptography and so then we have tail
scale so tail scale is built on top of
the uh the point-to-point open source
wire guard protocol which powers an
encrypted mesh network or tail net
gitpod has an official partnership with
wireguard so if you need to have
point-to-point vpn access um then just
so you have a secure connection this is
what you can use okay
[Music]
this is andrew brown and this follow
along we're going to learn all about
projects and the features underneath it
so probably cover pre-builds as well so
what i've done is i have a one git pod
account here and i have another one over
here on the side i'll just pull it up
here i had to do this one in firefox and
in the course we might have set up a
project before i'm just connecting here
uh to my my gitpod account here so here
is one i know they're both named andrew
brown but they're on different emails
here and so the idea is i want to create
a project and then once i'm in a project
we want to kind of explore the feature
set that is there okay
so uh from the chrome account here what
i'm going to do is drop down the top
here and go to new team we're going to
name that so i'm going to name this uh
my
get pod
team or maybe exam pro code team and i
might have named that one previously in
another video that's totally fine
and so now that i have my team i need to
start inviting people so we'll make our
way over to members and from here you
can see i have the exam pro co i'm gonna
go ahead and invite one and grab this
link and i'm gonna go over here to my
other browser firefox we'll paste that
in there
and now i've been added so there's no
prompt to say hey do you want to be in
this group it's just if you uh click
through the link you'll be added to it
so we'll go back here and we'll just
close and we'll give it a refresh
okay
give it a moment
and so if i want to change them to a
oh sorry a member i can i don't see why
you'd want to switch yourself out from
owner um i don't know what happened if
you did that because if you had two
members that could be disastrous but i
don't even want to try because i just
don't want that to get stuck
um and so
there's this option here remaining owner
so i think maybe you're not allowed to
at least remove one but again i'm not
going to test that functionality there
they have a filter here again owner
remember there's only two roles there's
not much going on there let's take a
look at settings
under here all we can do is delete the
team
i imagine the future will expand that
and then we have workspaces
so as we add projects here that will go
there so let's go ahead and add our
first new project
and so uh here we have a
um you actually have to select the
context here so uh this is where you
might select a different uh repository
so up here it says get repository git
lab so you can change this out to git
lab or github i guess bitbucket is not
an option here as of yet
but i'm going to switch over to github
and so now here are all of our
repositories that we could collaborate
on so here i might want to launch up
hello world i might have like a hello
world one in here so we'll select this
one here
and from there we can go ahead and
create that new workspace
all right and so here's student
pre-built so as soon as you use
as soon as you use
projects uh pre-builds are going to
happen so i don't think there's an
option to turn pre-builds off it's just
like if it is a project it will always
do pre-builds
and in that case you might run into
some
scenarios there or some issues there um
but we'll we'll address those maybe in
this follow along here um but anyway so
uh this project has launched which is
really great uh and that is running but
now if we go back to get pod so we'll
open up our hamburger menu here and go
back to our git pod dashboard
and we go under the workspaces we can
see oops notice here i'm not in um
the right project so we go here go to
project so there it is so we can see
that we're on main it started a few
seconds ago it has pre-builds
and if we go to view all
we can just kind of look at some of the
options here so here a pre-build was
successful
and we go to configuration here and so
we have some options here so
configuration already exists in git
run a pre-build or open the new
workspace to add the controls so i
suppose you can edit this and then run
or pre-build i've never found any reason
to do this um but i guess it could be a
way of like forcing a pre-build for you
to test things
we'll go back to our branches here and
apparently you can do things with
branches as well
um so i'm not exactly sure what we would
do here
but um
i guess like we could just go ahead and
create a branch and see what happens so
we go get check out hyphen b um
we'll call it development here
because i'm just trying to think like
how that would affect workflow maybe
staging might be a better branch it will
say get push
and then we'll have to push upstream
here which is totally fine we'll say
allow and hit enter
okay we'll make our way back over here
and if we give it a refresh i'm going to
see if that registers that other branch
okay and so i guess from here this would
be a great opportunity for you to launch
a new workspace so this will do
pre-builds always the main branch will
always do it
and so i guess here
we can run it manually
so i don't know i don't know if you push
to a branch if it will actually trigger
it i'm not sure if that pre-build is
running i don't see it running let's
just give it a refresh here i i don't
feel like i clicked it so we'll go back
here one more time we'll say run
pre-build
okay so i don't see anything happening
here
unless it's delayed or something but
from the documentation remember you can
only really do it for the main branch so
maybe that functionality is just not
there yet but we can launch a new
workspace for that staging environment
that or maybe there's nothing to
pre-build because
it is forked off that other one so maybe
it's based off the the main pre-build so
what we'll do is we'll just make some
super my new change to the code here and
then maybe that is what we need to
trigger it so i'll go over here and
we'll just say hello world and we'll
just add an extra exclamation mark here
and what i'll do is i will go back to
um
we'll commit that here
so we'll add it and say minor commit
because i'm really curious if the
pre-build will trigger
and uh we will go back here
to uh this oops i guess we'll have to go
back to
the dashboard and then close that tab
and so now what i want to know is it
going to trigger
that pre-build because i don't think it
will on this branch here right so we go
over here no pre-branches or pre-builds
what if i do run pre-build
okay
ah so now it's running so i think that
was the case was the fact that i had
forked it
and or not forked it but i had created a
branch but it was like there was no
difference between the main ones so
there was no reason for it to run a
pre-built now will it run and pre-build
every single time i'm not sure so again
we will go ahead and launch
this new workspace
and we'll just make a test see here if
it
automatically runs
because maybe once you've done one
pre-build it will just keep triggering
but as far as i'm aware it shouldn't i
think it would just be it wouldn't do
that so go back here add another
exclamation mark whoops or net sign
that's totally fine too it doesn't
really matter and we're going to go
ahead and commit that into exclamation
and we'll say okay
and we'll give it a moment to sync we'll
say okay
just making sure it syncs because it's
doing this funny thing here so i just
don't have confidence that it's doing
what it's supposed to be doing
and while we're waiting on that i'm just
going to open up the dashboard again
here
and i'm also going to open up the
context
because i just want to see did it push
that change right so i go over here
and we have uh we need to go to the
staging branch right we are in staging
no
so i don't know it's acting kind of
funny here so what i'm going to do is
just launch it again
and that's the nice thing when these
environments are
temporary you can just keep launching
new ones so i'll just launch a new one
we'll give it a moment
here and so um
if we go over to
[Music]
our uh our code here again i'm just
going to try one more time to change
this
and we will go back here we will add
this file we'll just say minor change
and we'll commit this
and we'll sync the changes again
okay and that worked no problem this
time so i'm not sure what the issue is
before but that's okay and so just to
confirm back in the staging here i'm
just going to double check to make sure
that change has been applied remember i
haven't told it to manually run so
that's what i'm really interested to
find out here so we'll go back and open
our dashboard
and we are going to
wait for that to load we'll click into
that it says ready
a few seconds ago i'm gonna go to
pre-builds there's only two here so i
think again like if you want to build
these minor ones you're always going
like the other branches you're gonna
have to go here
and trigger that though it's not saying
there's anything new
there's no available actions
we'll go back over to pre-builds here
it would probably help if i had a
different name but that's four minutes
ago so
um
yeah i'm not sure
we'll give you a refresh here
so a few minutes ago so for whatever
reason i can't seem to trigger
a new pre-build so but anyway i guess
the thought is like really the the stuff
you're going to be focusing around is
the main branch okay
um so i think that's pretty much it with
projects not super complicated but i
think i might want to just run through
pre-builds a bit here and just look at a
scenario where i ran into where i was
confused and like there wasn't an issue
but i just wasn't uh realizing that the
pre-build was the part that was kind of
difficult okay so i'll just make that a
separate video we'll just pick up here
in a second okay
[Music]
all right so what i'd like to do now is
just to kind of show you some friction
you might run into pre-builds because
uh you need to kind of adjust your
script to work in a pre-built
environment and it's not hard it's just
thinking about pre-builds personally i
would recommend if you can to always
have a pre-built environment or a
project-based environment so that when
you engineer your git pod yaml file you
don't have to rework it but let's see if
we can run into that case so maybe a
good example would be just to try to
build out a very simple project that has
sinatra and we've done that a few times
so maybe we can just pull from our
existing examples so what i'm going to
do is just go to
getpod.gitpod.com here and i'm just
going to kind of look through
some of my examples here
um we'll go show more
so we have google play drive init cli
example
website
is this the one where we use uh sinatra
no this looks a lot more complicated
that's me forking the website so that's
okay we'll just start from scratch it
only takes like a couple seconds to do i
just can't seem to remember because it's
been a few days it looks it's for you it
seems like i just i just recorded this
but a few days since i made the sinatra
one so what i'm going to do is create a
a new repository here i'm just going to
say
pre-build
sinatra
sinatra pre-build example
and i'm going to make this private
and we're going to go ahead down below
and
add a readme file i'm going to create
that repository we're going to give that
a moment to get created we're going to
go ahead and launch that git pod we're
going to go to sinatra
ruby just so that we can get a little
bit of code here to work with and that's
all we're going to really need so i'll
go back here and give it a moment to
load we're going to go ahead and make a
new file i'm going to call this
server.rb whoops
server.rb
uh
rename
we're going to go ahead and paste that
on in there so we'll say allow
and so we're requiring our sinatra we'll
need a gem file as well actually i'm
going to use bundler to do that so we'll
go to new terminal and we'll say bundler
init
and that will give us a gem file to
start off with i need sinatra so i'll
copy the contents there down below we'll
just type in jam sinatra so that's fine
we'll do a bundle install to install
sinatra
and so once we have that there
we're going to just take out the that
part there so we don't have to worry
about it and so now we need to create
our gitpod file so we'll say gpinit
that'll get us a starting script here
port 3000 is okay for me i'm fine with
that and so i need a few things here i'm
just looking off screen to uh this code
here to see
what it is that we can do here so i
don't have to forget um but we don't
need a before command because we don't
really need to change the ruby version
uh rvm list so we are using ruby version
2.7.4 which is fine
um
but what we might want to do is to run
something so it might do things like
bundle install something we definitely
want to do
and for the command we're going to want
to start this uh the servers up saying
bundle exect
ruby
um
it was a
port
3000 i can't remember how we set the
sinatra ports
build the docks here
ports
uh configuration settings ports port
sports ports
it's like set port like that eh
so we'll just say whoops we'll go back
to our code over here
where's the code oh we're in hello world
whoops
so go back to this one up here and we'll
go into our server file here
and we'll just say
set environment
actually it's setport
and that's where we do the 3000 right
so
what i'm trying to get at is that um
let's say we want to actually set the
we'll just say env
and we'll just say app port here
and as an example we might want to
set the um
in here the port number so we might go
like
export
port app port
and actually i don't even know what it
starts on by default so that's not going
to check first just case it starts on
that port by default server.rb here
so this starts on port 8080. so let's
say we want it to be on this port it's
going to look at like export
environment variable
as an example here
i always forget how to do it so i just
double check i always feel like there's
like a dollar sign i'm missing
so it's export name equals whatever okay
so we'll go back over here
and so this would set the app port there
and so this app down below should pick
it up right if i just do
server.rb
that should
technically work port 3000 that's
totally fine
so what i'm going to do now is just
restart this app and i'm going to just
put that there so that doesn't error out
but i'm going to commit these
okay
so attempt to or sorry just initial
commit
okay and then we'll just sync those
changes we'll say okay we'll give it a
moment i'll close up some of these other
tabs here
and so what i'm hoping for
and we'll open up the context here what
i'm hoping for here is that when i
uh launch this git pod it's just going
to work right it's going to do the
bundle install it's going to export the
environment variable of course we could
just set the environment variable in the
task but i'm trying to stage an example
where when you move over to pre-build
you have to kind of consider how that's
going to change
so give it a moment
and it's opening the tab it's good it's
starting on port 3000 and it works right
so
this part here
whoops
um
this part here worked right so what i'm
saying is like when we move this over to
prebuilds this init step is going to run
but the problem is is that it's not
going to carry over the state over to
this one so it might install but i my
expectation is this export option won't
be there or another thing it might be
like cd into the directory so one thing
that we might do that might be a better
example would be to make whoops to make
a subfolder here so we might make a new
folder here and we'll call it um
you know application or sorry project
here
and from here i might take these files
here and just move them
into yep let's say move it's okay
we'll take the gem file here and move it
into this project here
okay
and actually i might call it app instead
so we'll say rename app
and so instead of doing this you might
say like cd
app right so we're going to cd into it
first
and so let's see if that works
because again i'm just trying to stage
that example to show you what i'm
talking about because i remember that's
where i ran into seating where i thought
i would be already seated in so if we
see the init will it do in the command i
believe it will
so uh small changes here
uh put things in a folder
and we'll go ahead and commit that we'll
say yes
we will sync those changes we'll say
okay
and
what we'll do here is we'll wait a
moment and i'll go back over to this
i'll close this tab out and we'll launch
git pod again and that should cd into
that directory and work and then we will
go then make it a project and see how
that changes with the pre-builds
all right so we're waiting here a moment
so it's working so it definitely seeded
in and so
i don't know if it shows sometimes it
shows the script of what it ran so if
you look at the script this is what it
did it said cd app bundle install export
and then it did the the next thing which
was the command so it's treated like in
one go in the same environment so now
what we're going to do is we're going to
go make our way over to get podio
and i want to make this actually a
project so i'm going to make a new
project here
and then i want to choose this project
here when it when it gets a moment here
and we're going to choose the um
it's on git lab again so that's fine
we'll just change that to github
it really likes to default to that
gitlab which is totally fine and this is
called sinatra
so we'll type in sinatra here we'll
click here
we'll select
uh we'll create a new workspace
and now it's going to do the pre-build
and so my expectation is this is going
to fail right because
when it goes through there it's going to
cd
in the one thing and the other one's
going to start not in the cd directory
so give it a moment here
all right and so notice it says could
not locate gem file or bundle okay so if
we scroll on up
you can see um
we are seeing that there's stuff that it
ran the pre-built services cd app
bundle install export stuff this is
stuff that happened in a separate
environment right it didn't happen um
i'm just trying to see if it shows it
very clearly yeah so these are the
pre-built logs that it ran
right but the thing is is that um
that was in the pre-build environment
we'll bring back up the slides here to
make it more clear okay so
here
right it ran before and init so it did
it went cd into the app directory and it
set the environment variable and then
when it became over here it's starting
from scratch so it's not in that cd
directory
and i don't even know the environment
variables there let's see if that
persisted because that might be
interesting so i'm just going to say env
grep and we'll say app
port
okay
and it looks like it is set because it's
saying it right there uh let's just just
say echo app port
uh maybe dollar sign
it goes to show like i've been doing
links for years i can remember this
stuff so it's not set so the environment
variable got set in the pre-build
environment and it's cd into that
directory and that's where before
becomes very useful because it's going
to run twice
right so
this is where we would take our script
and
um the bundle install is totally fine
there but we'll just go and we will add
a before step
right
and we will just take the cd out of here
and the app out of here
okay and so the idea is that that's
going to run
both times in each environment right so
this should technically fix our problem
we'll go ahead and save this file and
we'll just say fix pre-builds
and we'll commit that
we'll sync those changes we'll say okay
we'll give it a moment
great we'll close our tab
and i'm going to open up uh getpod again
and so you notice the pre-build's
happening so it showed us a screen if
our pre-builds had already occurred we
wouldn't see it apparently you can stop
waiting for pre-build which i would
never do that but there could be a case
where you have a very very long
pre-built you just want to get into the
environment
so we'll give it a moment and see if
that fixes our issue
apparently there's a way to trigger
pre-builds from the url it's not
something that i have found a
requirement to do if you're really
interested you could look it up
but there's that while we're waiting
there we might want to look at pin
projects it's something i haven't done
with gitpod yet
so
you can i guess not projects but
workspaces
so as far as i understand if you append
a workspace it will remain there longer
i believe so that is one advantage there
is that if you have an environment that
you want to stay you can just pin it
okay and i don't think it will get
deleted see unpinned workspaces that
have been active for 14 days will
automatically be deleted so if you have
pain and environment and i don't know if
you can pin multiple ones can i pin this
one can i pin that one i have a feeling
there's not like a pin limit so you
could pin as much as you want i wouldn't
probably recommend that
but that might be something you need to
do i haven't found a used to pinning so
far
here down below it says exit so i have a
feeling that the pre-build is done
sometimes it gets stuck on the screen so
you can just close that out and go back
over to your projects here
and
just launch it again okay if you ever
see that it's not a big deal just
because it's ready right so
it's not perfect right like you just
have to kind of like and there's no
different than like using aws cloud
service providers you just have to kind
of be watching and aware and just being
like okay i've waited too long let's see
what we can do here and have confidence
so we're waiting a while here for this
to start up
and um let's see what we have so it says
here
uh could not find sinatra gems so bundle
saw to the install missing gems so
it didn't work
as we thought it would
we are seeded into the correct directory
we'll do grep um
or we'll just maybe echo it so we'll say
echo
app env or app port
so the port is set so that definitely
fixed it
why the install failed i don't know
because it did run it up here as you can
see
and sinatra 2.1 is installed
um
[Music]
let me do bundle install here
you know it probably is
it's my script so if you go over here
because i changed it maybe into the cd
directory
because here it cds into it right but it
would cd into that one as well so that
shouldn't affect it
let me just try running bundle exec here
bundle exect
ruby server.rb
okay so that runs no problem
there's nothing to change
so i don't really trust what happened
there so i'm just going to throw this
environment away and launch a new one so
we'll open up the context we'll close
this out we're going to wait a moment
here we're going to go ahead and launch
a new one i'm just going to see we're
going to make a new workspace there
we're going to see if it works this time
around because i'm not sure what it's
complaining about
but once you're used to using pre-builds
and you have the environment working
it's usually not a problem but sometimes
there's a bit of friction moving from a
non-project to another one and that's
why i say like if you start with a
project it's a little bit less painful
someone says this task ran as a
workspace pre-build could not find
sinatra
um things like that so
run bundle and salt to install the
missing gems
so i'm just going to scroll up here and
just see what it ran
so again there shouldn't be
a problem so i'll go back over here
allow
yeah so it's acting like the gems aren't
installed is the gem file there
the gem file lock is there
hmm
this is what i'm trying to figure out
like
hmm
i'm not sure i'll be back here in a
second okay all right so i had a little
bit of time to think about it and you
know what i think is happening
is that when you install ruby gems
they're not installing within this
workspace directory and since anything
outside this workspace directory gets
blown away i think that's the reason why
i'm having this issue now if you're
using node node installs in the current
directory so here like if i wanted to
fix this problem i would just have to
look up like okay how do i install uh
the gems in the current directory if i
want those to be cached and in place so
i think like for ruby workflows it
doesn't take too long to install gems
but i think in this case for like ruby
you have two options you can install
based on the vendor so like uh bundler
install gems in current directory or
something like that
so i could do this
right and that would probably solve my
issue
um or
you know i could do
you know something else but that means
when i run the uh
bundle install i think i'd probably have
to specify
um where those gems are but you know the
simple solution here would just be
saying okay
every like to this and put this here
right
but it really depends like if the bundle
install takes really really long time
then maybe i would want to
move my gems to a vendored like
directory like doing the path so it's
really going to be up to you and the the
constraints of your language but i think
that is the reason that is happening
there so again not a big problem i move
that there and we're okay but yeah i
think we're all done here and uh you
know hopefully you understand how
pre-builds work okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at get pod pricing so for
good pod they have four
uh possible plans available to you so we
have the basic uh which is free personal
at nine dollars usd per month
professional twenty five dollars usd per
month and unleashed at thirty nine
dollars just d per month of course
always make sure you double check the
prices because they may have changed
but you know generally they should be
this if you go look online um they don't
have uh the option to pay annually at
least i did not see
through the checkout process there but
if you do need annual maybe just contact
their team again i don't see anything
describing like an annual discount i
know some organizations care about that
kind of stuff that's why i mention it
but goodpod is really uh
nice and easy to reach out to so you
know they probably can make those kind
of accommodations for you
but let's take a look at what changes in
terms of the feature set for these plans
so no matter what plan you're using you
get unlimited private and public
repositories which is really nice in
terms of the amount of workspaces you
can run in parallel uh it's four for
free and personal
i don't feel like i'd ever be running
more than one workspace at a time
but you know maybe you have more than
one tab open and you're toggling between
uh maybe
different domains
of a microservice app so that's totally
possible
so that's something to consider for
professional you have eight parallel
workspaces unless you have 16 parallel
workspaces
in terms of timeout it's by default 30
minutes between basic and professional
and on unleash you extend it to one hour
as the default right so every time it
launches up it will do that
um
then the next thing is how many hours do
we get per month of
of runtime or consumption so for the
basic you have 50 hours for personal
it's a hundred hours a month uh and for
professional it's unlimited hours and
then just for the unleashed plan you
have the option to do a three hour time
boost so what they're saying here is
that imagine you are
just you're just about to go for lunch
and you are
running some kind of operation that you
know is going to take a long time to run
so you know you don't know it's going to
finish but you have to let it run for a
long time and so this is your
opportunity to boost it so that your
workspace doesn't time out after an hour
and so that is the reason for that
option and so that could be extremely
useful okay
so let's take a look at some of the
other um
uh plans they have that are outside
these four here so there's the pro open
source so this is a special plan for
professional open source developers with
unlimited hours on any public repository
so you know this is just to help out
people that are developing open source
to help them reduce costs because it's a
lot of work to give out uh open source
stuff uh right so then there's a student
plan so this is a a special plan for
students so you provide an email
with your
domain of the institute educational
institution so it'd probably have to be
edu
or what have you but the idea here is
you get at least for nine dollars a
month which is really nice then there's
git pod for startups so this is eligible
startups that can get unleashed plans
for up to two years on git pods and
there are some particular requirements
so you do have to read into that but if
you are startup that is a great
opportunity for you there then there's
get pod self hosted professional so
these run get this runs the github
platform on your own uh private networks
or managed uh uh like manage kubernetes
clusters within your own aws azure
account what have you and this is at 35
dollars per month starting with the 11th
user okay
[Music]
so let's talk about how you can monitor
your hourly usage so as you use git pod
you consume in a lot of amount of hours
based on your plan and so if you go to
the plans page it will show you this
remaining hours things and so here you
can see i have 78.5 hours for the
remainder of the month and so this is
the way you could keep track of your
current usage is there any way within
the getpod workspace
i didn't find it um but if there is i'd
love someone to tell me but this this is
great too so just if you want to keep on
top of that okay
[Music]
all right so this follow along what i
want to show you is where you can track
your current usage so here i'm on git
pods to go to getpod.io it should
generally bring you here to projects and
so what we can do is make our way over
up to here in the top right corner or i
think this goes the same place as long
as you're in your personal account but
if you go to the top right corner and go
to settings and if we go to the
left-hand side to plans uh what we'll
see is this kind of bar meter here so it
says open source but this is actually
the basic plan so there's a bit of
inconsistency with the naming here i
believe you know if we go to
uh maybe here if we just open this in a
new tab
um it doesn't show here if we go here to
this pricing tab so this says basic
right and so it says 50 hours and just
going over here notice it just says open
source so
for whatever reason there is just that
minor inconsistency but understand that
is the basic plan but if you notice here
it says upgrade your plan to get more
hours parallel workspaces those
remaining hours 43.6
and so i've been using this quite a bit
and it hasn't been running out which is
really nice um is this present anywhere
else no so i was looking through like
the get pod interface or command pals
and things like that to see if it would
be displayed somewhere else it isn't uh
anywhere else uh as of yet um i'm i
could imagine that they might want to do
that in the future but for the time
being uh this is where you're gonna have
to find it but honestly like again i'm
just running this and never really
noticed so if you are
hitting this limit then you probably do
want to upgrade because you're using it
very seriously but there you go okay
[Music]
so git pod also offers team pricing so
team pricing
or a team plan is for organizations to
pay on behalf of their team members to
centralize billing to a single account
so the idea is you say i need x amount
of members
uh for this type of plan and that will
be for your teams and so you can also
set the currency there's nothing else
that is um available around team pricing
it's just a way of centralizing your
billing maybe in the future they'll add
more particular things just for teams
but for the time being this is what it
is okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at self-hosted git pods so
get pod oss or
open source that's what the oss stands
for allows organizations to self-host
their own gitpod platform on their own
private networks so getpod is built on
top of kubernetes and the short form of
communities is k8 so and it has
deployment instructions for
a various amount of managed k8 services
so to list a few we have google
kubernetes engine so gke
lightweight kubernetes so k3s elastic
kubernetes service so eks azure
kubernetes service aks
rancher kubernetes service rks but i
think that it's going to work on
anything that has kubernetes so
um you know if digitalocean has an
offering or walter has an offering
or you're running your own kubernetes
cluster you know on a virtual machine i
imagine that you could probably do it
for self-hosted offers um what you're
going to get are the public and private
repos integrations will get lab github
and bitbucket unlimited pre-built shared
workspaces snapshots admin dashboard so
basically everything if there's
something that's not in there i'm not
sure what is not being listed but it
seems like everything you can get podio
self-hosted is offered in two tiers the
open source so the first registered
users are free and then professional
exceeding 10 users you need to pay for
professional plan so to upgrade to
professional you need to obtain a
license and one question i have and i
have this question because this is the
same thing with
terraform cloud where they have
something similar after you exceed a
certain amount you are paying
but the thing is do you pay for the
first 10 users i don't know i could not
definitively answer that question for
you i'm going to lean on the side that
yes when you are when you
cross over to the 11th user you got to
get your professional key you're going
to be paying for 11 users which i think
is fair because it's not like it's going
to be super expensive and at that point
you should be able to pay for them but i
don't definitively know okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
looking at get pods security so gitpod
employs a variety of security controls
and security best practices so let's
take a look at this so the first is
compliance if you're not familiar
compliance it's basically compliance
programs that are industry standard or
best practices and you have like a
third-party company that does a
testament to say yes this company is
meeting those requirements and then they
get a certificate to prove it that they
they are doing that stuff so one thing
is get pod is sock to compliant and so
this ensures your service providers
securely manage your data to protect the
interests of your organization and
privacy of its clients so this is a
really good thing to have it's also
really
expensive so you know that they're
taking security very serious a lot of
times you'll see the iso 2701 with this
as well but you know this is good the
other one they have is gdpr so
the gdpr is guidelines for the
collection and processing of personal
information from individuals who live in
the european union um so basically
everybody is being gdpr no matter where
they are in the world because it's the
internet and anyone can be from uh from
europe coming onto your website so this
is pretty common so it's good to see
that they just mentioned that there uh
so we have environment isolation so get
pod workspace or pre-builds run on a
secured single-use container separate
user
uh pid mount and network namespace for
each gitpod workspace stress test
namespace layering implementations by
third party company kin volkswagen
companies specializing in kubernetes so
i think namespace layering is very
important because it just it is virtual
iso isolation between clients okay
then there's the fact that git pod is
open source so open source allows for a
faster security feedback loop allows git
pod partners customers or the community
at large to identify disclose or
contribute fixes to critical exploits we
have authentication and authorization so
gitpod uses version control systems
single sign-on and you can apply
granular or fine-grain permissions based
on the providers integration options so
they're basically offloading that uh
that concern over to get lab github
bitbucket and you know those are very
large companies so you know their
practices are going to be very very good
uh we have integra or sorry
encryption so they have at rest
encryption so all data including
workspace backups and environment
variables are using advanced encryption
standards so
aes256 and then we have uh in transit
encryption so git pod uses transport
layer security so tls so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
talking about the security vulnerability
disclosure policy so if you believe you
have discovered a vulnerability privacy
issue exposed data or other security
issue relating to gitpod you can report
it via the security vulnerability
disclosure policy and you can read all
about it here it's a big document if you
want to have a fun time to read the
policy outlines the steps for reporting
to gitpod they pretty much say like hey
if you do report it you can do it and
you're not going to get in trouble
because a lot of people are concerned
that if they find a problem and they
report it that they're going to get in
trouble for doing that
just because and so you know they kind
of outline that and just also give you a
lot of extra information there to report
you need to email getpod providing as
much detail as possible to security at
getpod.io
some companies will have a form
and the language of this document
suggests that they do have a form but it
turns out it's just email so i imagine
they might have a form of the future but
it's you know email's fine too so there
it is okay
hey this is andrew brown and i'm just on
the get pod website because i just
wanted to show you here at i o forward
slash security the kind of stuff that
they have here so they just say like who
is using get pod so you know it's safe
how many uh developers
companies are using so you understand
the scale of it
some of their principles uh that they
are uh considering or they are
implementing i should say uh so they're
secure by design uh about their
compliance the things that we already
covered in the lecture content
but the thing that i just wanted to show
you here is the security vulnerability
disclosure policy because there is a bit
more there that just couldn't fit on the
screen so there's a bunch of stuff here
that you might want to read about the
interesting part is like safe harbor a
lot of people are concerned that you
know if they report a problem that they
might get in trouble for it but getpod
saying uh you know if you find a
vulnerability and you share with us
don't worry you're not going to be uh
getting in trouble for it uh and we just
want to make sure that you understand
that so that we encourage people to
submit things as you can see here it is
at security at getpodio if i click on
this there wasn't a form before
still no form it's just going to the
same place here so maybe eventually
they'll have a form but honestly all
forms do just kind of give you some
additional fields here you can just
basically write whatever you want in
there i guess they uh have
thanks some contributors here like sneak
and get lab and stuff like that but uh
yeah that's pretty much all you really
need to know for security okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at get pod support so get
pod has a wide range of
support options and so we're just going
to quickly go through the list here so
that you're aware of them nothing super
exciting but just making sure you know
what's there the first is documentation
so technical documentation describing
the various features of git pod we have
a change log so historically release
changes so it shows you features and bug
fixes there's a community form which is
just a discourse form uh with community
and official support we have the discord
server so this is a chat server to
interact with community members and get
pod employees in real time we have the
get pod road roadmap so this is a github
project which is basically a kanban
board showing planned and upcoming
features based on annual quarters there
is a status page so this is an atlatian
status page showing up time and service
interruptions for the underlying
infrastructure so like maybe the k-day
the kubernetes customers running goodpod
workspaces and the gitpodio platform
that's probably what it's for
we have git pod or is our github issues
so open tickets for bugs or feature
requests directly on the open source
project
account settings so change email
settings notification settings nothing
super exciting there
obviously you can change your plans so
that's another option as well and then
there's the sales support form so send
an email to gitpod's sales team about
self-hosting educational discounts
reselling or other gitpod does not have
a paid tier support or direct toll-free
number for individuals however
enterprises may inquire about additional
levels of support after contacting sales
because if you're a bigger company
they're probably going to roll out the
red carpet for you but they just don't
say like explicitly hey this is the tier
that we offer and things like that okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are on
the support page here ford slash support
because i just wanted to show you some
of the varieties of support that you can
utilize so the first thing is we have a
status page here so if we go ahead and
open that up we're going to see it's
kind of an uptime uh here they're using
the atlatian status page so a pretty
common one here to just kind of show you
uh what's going on here so if you look
at workspaces we see operational here's
some part partial outage um and more of
some part of the outage here you can see
the duration here
um says in the u.s region so clearly
they're operating in multiple regions
here i've never ever ever experienced
any kind of problems uh working with uh
getpod but it's really nice to see they
have the status page
here a workspace stuck stuck in stopping
okay so you can see that there's some
information so that's kind of
interesting
um you know if we go to contact support
i don't know if this is just email so oh
we have a form here so you can see
report reviews billing educational
discount verification supposed to get
pod looks like some of the context
changes a little bit here so you go
ahead and fill that in and send that
over
um we have the change log we just go
ahead and open that up so this is going
to tell you what they've been adding to
the product so here on october 14th we
have introducing teams and projects so
these are basically linking to blog
posts just talking about what has been
released down below you can see the
fixes and improvements so it's not just
features but it's also bug fixes there
if you open that up you can see that it
is all on github so again it is an open
source project so that's really great
there too
um if you go to the community forum that
is in discourse
now i've yet to sign up for oh sorry
this is discord um and i do actually
have that this is over
[Music]
um i'm just gonna pull it up here in a
moment so this is over here i'm not sure
what i'm looking at here but um you know
here is the get pod so i'm actually
sitting in this here as well and talking
as i work on this course i've been
updating the uh build in the open here
so they're very active and this is a
great way in real time to connect with
um get pod employees developer advocates
uh and get help there or get directed to
different kind of support options um
the
uh the form is really good too this is
community form this is discourse
oh i thought i clicked this does this go
to the right place let me click that
oh i think i found a bug i think i found
a bug so in this case what i'm going to
do is just take a screenshot here
and i think someone just has a miss link
here so we'll go down below and we'll go
to support i'm just going to say here
you know i think this is supposed to
link
to the discourse
but it's going to the discord
and that's a fair that's a fair issue
there just because like discourse and
discord are very similar so it wasn't me
what happens if i go here
no see that goes to the chat so that's
going to the wrong place
unless i got rid of the discourse
get paw discourse
let me try this again
discourse form
oh okay so i think maybe they retired it
which is totally fine um honestly
it doesn't say here but honestly like i
found that like i didn't really have a
use case for the discourse i'd rather
just be in the discord where is real
time
i'm not going to go back to my course
and update that because i'd rather just
leave this in here just to kind of show
that that is uh a edge case there so i
probably what's going to happen is
they'll end up
um just changing that wording here to
discord and then that confusion will be
gone but there was a discourse at one
point uh and i was pulling some kind of
information from it but um you know
honestly again i prefer just to do
everything on discord let's go take a
look at the getpod roadmap so this is
just a project here
we go over here to the top notice get
podio roadmap if you go here you can see
all of their
getpod repositories did not know you
could put a readme there that's really
nice but down below you can see all
these here right
and so if we go back and go to the
getpod product roadmap you can kind of
see what's being worked on at the
current moment so we are in uh q4 and so
we see introduced project level
environment variables team pricing jet
brains remote development support image
layers faster workspace startups which
honestly they're really fast to begin
with but if they can make them faster
that's great and future stuff so that's
a great way to just kind of see what is
coming
down the road
in terms of git pods so that is really
nice as well
we saw the status page if you want to
report a bug it's going to probably take
us to the github yeah that goes there so
if we open that up i think it might just
pre-populate some text for us yeah so it
has some nice boxes for us
um this is not the discussion these are
just forms so that looks really good so
we'll go back here and um we'll go all
the way back
and then you get your self-hosted thing
or your account settings not so much to
look at the account settings as we've
seen this quite a few times in this
course so really they're just like
talking about like notifications like
what do you want to turn off which there
aren't a lot of options there or
managing your plan right there's not
really support within the get pod i o
per se you always have to reach out to
the discord and stuff like that click on
help this just goes back to the support
page but that gives you an idea of the
level of support and honestly it's a lot
it's really great so and i said this
also you know in the in the lecture
content but you know if you are an
enterprise i would imagine you just
reach out and you know if you're if you
are large i'm sure you'll get a direct
phone call with git pod and they
probably would create some kind of
custom um support plan for you uh but
they don't you know they just don't say
it here on the pricing okay so i just
talked to them i said yeah if you're if
you are an enterprise would you do some
kind of deal and they're like yeah of
course we would do something you know um
but they just don't show it as a as like
a lot of places we'll have like a fifth
box they like contact us okay but there
you go all right so i just want to show
you the support in action so it's
actually really great that uh this uh
this happened because i can just show
you like i just went here into the
discord i opened a ticket it became a
thread i went into here you can see
pauline said check out the announcements
over the announcements and i i assume
that it was rolled into it and so we go
over to our announcements here
and you can see that uh you know they've
said that they've um they've they've uh
you know
have archived the discourse and so now
they want to make the discord the future
home and again i think that is the right
place for it so i'm really happy with it
if you're looking for the old stuff
because there is some stuff in there
that is good but probably by the time
you watch this video you might not be
interested but they did go and archive
all the old stuff here so it is still
accessible it's just read-only on the
wayback machine but yeah it was a great
opportunity to see that in action so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at git pod open source so
get pod open source is a combination of
open source projects built by get pot
and so you know when i was looking at
the uh github repos i just noticed that
there's more than just one and so
there's one called uh
worfd
and this is a kubernetes native
continuous integration system we have
leeway this is a heavily caching
uh build system for go yarn docker
projects dazzle this is a experimental
docker oci image builder its goal is to
build independent layers where a change
to one layer does not invalidate the one
sitting above it and then there's open
vs code server which is a fork of
uh the vs code
project there and so
you know we don't really need to know
much about these here um but this is the
one that we really care about because
this is pretty much
what powers get pod i o okay that's what
git pod io's it's it's a um
a managed version of this and so we're
going to give extra attention to that
one okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and i just want
to
poke around here on the get pods
team or organizational page that is on
github so that's at github.com forward
slash get pod hyphen io and it just goes
shows to show like how much stuff
they're doing with open source so they
have 159 repositories that you can see
who in their organization is there if
you want to reach out or just kind of
learn more about git pod
you can even sponsor them if you want
because again it's open source projects
so that is an option to you
get pod does make money on their
platform side but you know helping in
either way can always help out uh there
is projects i think this is like a new
feature of github which i don't really
understand as of yet so here's a project
and they have a bunch of itemized items
like a roadmap here don't fully
understand it but that's kind of
interesting there when we
go into the repositories and there is a
lot you can see all sorts of things i
think the reason why there's so many is
because all of their templates live here
so we looked at the quick start template
so just understand that's why it's so
large but the main one here is get pod
here at the top so we'll open that up
and we'll take a look at the website
here um
and we'll just go and take a look so
here's git pod so git pod automates the
provision of ready to code developer
environment so this is going to be for
the actual platform right so i believe
that when you want to
self-host this is the repository you're
going to be using
this is the same experience you get when
you go to getpod.io so it will give you
that gui and also this interface here
this thing the underlying thing is based
off um the open vs code server which
we'll look at separate uh in another
video because i actually want to show
you how to run that on your own um but
yeah this thing is here how you use this
i don't know i guess we'll have to look
that look at that if we do show the
self-hosted git pod option i'm going
over to the website basically anything
that you see on the website in terms of
the documentation you can absolutely
contribute to so like let's say we go to
get pod i o uh forward slash docs i
believe
and we go to some page like configure
here um if you go and click edit and get
pod
this will launch this environment if you
look up here you can see
well it went too quick there but you can
see it's loading up the website here so
we'll just give it a moment
okay
and actually this might be a great
opportunity for us to correct that uh
discourse option right because uh they
no longer have discourse which is
totally fine and it's discord so maybe
through here we can help with that
language so we saw it on the support
page
and i'm just wondering how we could go
find that so
[Music]
and you know i'm not that familiar with
it but i'm good enough that i can kind
of make my way around here
so if i go to
let's say
contents
there's probably a global way we can
search
so we'll go here and i'm going to go to
find in files and we'll just type in
discourse
we found the discourse logo support ts
so i feel like it is here
okay and
if i go over here
oh look it's oh no it's not missing it's
just me so this is community forum if
you're looking for help with common
requests connect with our community on
discord
okay and then so from here i'm going to
just change that so
use discord instead of discourse
okay and then we're going to go ahead
and commit that
and we will sync those changes the thing
is is that we can't push to main we'll
need to have our own fork which is
totally fine so i'm hoping it'll pro up
prop up and say hey you need to
have your own fork so is not accessible
please grant necessary permission so
let's say open access
um
so i guess we kind of have to make our
own fork here i think that's what we're
going to have to do
so what i'm going to do here is go back
and i'm just going to go and fork this
uh here so where's my fork here we go
fork
but just kind of show you like how you
can contribute to get pod which is kind
of interesting so now we have the
website ourselves and we're going to go
ahead and just close these out and
reopen this here
now if you're watching this of course
you don't have to do this um but just
because i've would have already made the
change but it doesn't hurt to go through
this process to show you so again i'm
going to go to the top left corner here
we're going to go file um and we're
going to say find in files or whoops
edit
find in files
discourse
we'll go to support here
and there are a few here that still say
discourse but we really want discord
so we'll just switch that over to
discord i'm going to go over here to the
right hand side and did i save that file
i did
there we go so we'll just say
change wording from discourse
to discord
and we'll save that
and we will sync those changes and we'll
say ok and before we open or like we
submit our pull request we should
probably open a ticket so here on the
main one
we'll go over to issues we'll open up a
new tab
and i'm just going to open a new ticket
here and we're going to file a bug
report i'm going to open up get pod io
forward slash support here
actually i want to keep that other tab
open so just keep it there for a second
and
oh sorry we want to go to get pod io for
slash
support and i'm just going to take a
screenshot here
okay we'll go back over this ticket
and
um
so i'll just paste that in there so
we'll just say
um
gitpod is no longer using
using um discourse so the wording
here needs to be changed
to discord
all right um and sometimes they'll say
like show the example so what we'll do
is just go ahead and grab that link here
paste that on in um
it requires all the other ones here i
don't like that they i mean this is not
uh git pod but like they've kind of
forced these parameters
so say um
github support page should say
discord instead of
discourse
okay and then i'm just gonna grab
flamingo emoji i'm gonna be like the
worst person ever and just kind of like
phone it in
whole point of those boxes to make sure
you do it right so we'll just say that
we'll put in those
anything else
okay
and we'll go ahead and submit that
ticket because i just need an issue so
when i submit it i can tie it to that
right so now i have this
pound 7113 and so what i'll do is go
back to mine and so now it says uh you
know your branch is up to date
and i want to go to pull requests here
um
you know what i didn't make a fork
that's what i should have done so if i
go back over here we're going to stop
this here i'm going to go get checkout
hyphen b
and we're going to say
discourse old wording
and then i'm just going to push it
allow
and this is a good habit to put the id
name in there but i didn't do that which
which is totally fine
and so we'll see if it allows us to just
push
seems to be doing some kind of
diagnostic i'm not exactly sure why
not sure what that is for but what i'm
going to do is go back and refresh here
because i did this recently but it seems
like there's been a few changes here and
so i'm just not exactly familiar with it
just yet
so it looks like the branch was pushed
if i go back here and give this a
refresh
the branch should show up um
[Music]
so say old and notice like that some
people are putting the numbers in there
so that's a good thing to do but we'll
just say uh disc discourse old wording
and so i want to
uh
merge this in so i think if i go back to
the original git pod here
and
uh we make a pull requests
let's say new poll request here
and notice this is main and main so
compare main
and um i want to do it for mine so we'll
say old
uh compare cross forks we'll click there
okay i could probably done it from here
again it's just it's always a little bit
confusing you just have to kind of be
doing this on a regular basis if you're
not doing open source on a regular basis
it can get confusing so
compare the base to here i think we want
the one on the right hand side here so
we'll say old
um get pod or discourse
oh i have to change this to my
repository
so oh and i'm in i'm in the wrong one
i'm supposed to be in website
okay so we'll go back here lots of
mistakes on my part here but not a big
deal because usually it'll it'll pop up
sometimes and say hey do you want to
make this pull request or something but
we'll say a new pull request
and
it's not showing my old ones but what
we'll do is compare across forks again
and i'm going to say for that branch
there discourse
oh i'm not choosing my darn branch
there we go okay
let's just me creating so much trouble
so i don't want to do it against maine
because that's not proper you're always
supposed to do it from a feature branch
or whatever kind of branch you want to
call so we'll call discourse here
there it is
and so now what i'll do is go ahead and
create a pull request
we have some text in here and so what i
want to do is link the related issue so
it fixes if we go back to did i open
this in the right place
oh i opened this to the wrong place
oh
sorry
this is supposed to be
open on the website okay
all right that's embarrassing so now
what i got to do
i'm rolling my eyes if you can't see it
but what i got to do is go back to the
website here i can do the second take of
this so this is the take you're going to
get for this video
but
we'll go ahead and we'll open this issue
again we'll say
doc feedback
okay this is a lot easier to work with
here
um
so we'll type in https forward slash
forward slash get pod i o four slash
support
i'm just gonna go grab that again so
we'll say
get pod i o forward slash supports
okay and we'll just paste that on in
there like that
and we'll just say um
uh gitpod no longer
uses discord or sorry discourse so the
text here
needs to change from discourse
to discord because that's where it does
actually redirect to
and uh
change wording
from discourse to discord
we'll submit that
and so there is our ticket now we have
our issue so we'll go back to our pull
request and we'll say this fixes that
so we'll go over here they'll link to
that um
renaming
discourse to discord
on support page
there are still
other lingering cases
but i was just showing
this for the purpose
of a video demonstration
okay so we'll go ahead and create that
pull request
and so there i've contributed to the get
pod open source
um so you know hopefully that gives you
kind of an idea of like the ecosystem
here and why it's valuable because you
don't have to wait on get pod you can
start to take action or dig into things
but uh yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at openvs code server so
openvs code is a version of visual
studio code that runs a server on remote
machines allowing access through a
modern
web browser so git pod and github code
spaces uses the same architecture at
scale so open vs code server can be run
on a linux machine so a virtual machine
or on a docker
as a container so here's an example if
you wanted to start it on a virtual
machine and here's an example of you
wanting to start it on docker and
actually uh when git pod first came out
before they had the i o offering this is
what i would use to try to launch uh my
own um vs code on aws and it worked i
just wasn't able to figure out how to
make the space the the server turn off
reliably where gitpodio has clearly
solved that in a very intelligent way so
just to clarify you have the vs code as
open source you have open vs code server
which is a fork that's built on top of
the vs code open source code base then
there's the open vs code which is used
within git pod and other tools which
that's where we get gitpod.io the gitpod
platform okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at openvs code server and
so this is a fork developed and
maintained by getpodio so here you can
see the original fork is vs code by
microsoft and so this one was modified
uh just to give you a bit more
flexibility
and the key thing is is that this is
what gitpod is using so if you want to
run your own uh openvs code server it's
not too hard uh but you know if you
really do just need an environment to
work with your team strongly recommend
just using the getpod
platform itself but you know for
whatever reason if you want to know how
to do this i figure it doesn't hurt to
show you how so there are two ways to
run it via docker and linux linux is the
easier way to get going so that's what
i'm going to show you here today so i'm
here in my aws account and i'm going to
make my way over to ec2 and you can do
this for anything whether it's azure or
gcp or any platform as long as you can
run a virtual machine but i'm just going
to use aws because that's what i'm most
comfortable with so i'm going to go
ahead and launch a new instance here i'm
going to choose an amazon linux 2
instance which is generally recommended
i'm choosing a t3 micro here but any
size will do these small sizes work uh
pretty great here and uh the key thing
that i need to do here is make sure that
i have an i am role that has permissions
to sessions manager i'm just going to
open this up really quickly if you're
not familiar with this stuff here
i just want to show you if you go ahead
and create a role
all i'm doing here is typing in ssm
whoops uh maybe uh sorry create a role
here i thought i already clicked it
and so you'd say for ec2 you go next
and we would go ssm here
and in here we would want to get access
for um
amazon ec2 role i think this one is old
so you have to use this one instead
which is not a big deal i think i'm
using that anyway so you create a role
with that permissions and that's what we
are attaching here
uh as our role that's gonna allow us to
use sessions manager so we don't have to
use um ssh keys or things like that but
once you have that there we'll go over
to our security groups we're going to
have to open port 3000 i think that's
what it runs on default actually i think
it's port 8000
so we will open that up um and we'll go
review and launch we'll say launch we
will launch with no key pairs so proceed
without a key pair because we do nee do
not need one here
and we'll give it a moment to launch so
we'll go
here and click on the instance itself
and so it'll take a little bit time to
launch they're not too long but what
we're going to need to do is go get the
latest uh downloads if you just open
this up in a new tab under linux you
scroll on down you'll notice we have arm
64 arm hf x64 x64 is for the i guess the
intel chip and these are arm chips so uh
since we launched a virtual machine
that's uh on the x64 architecture that
is what we're going to be using so here
i'm just copying the link address
because if you look at it it's a raw raw
link directly to the tar atar is like a
zip file or an archive
but once this is running and usually we
wait for the two status checks to pass
but i'm just going to go ahead and
connect because i think it will work
we're just going to connect with
sessions manager that's why we set up
that i am role with
ssm the
simple systems manager access to
sessions manager and so this is going to
open up a black screen
and from here i'm just going to type in
sudo hyphen ec2
user just because oops sudo su hyphen
ec2 user just because it always starts
us off as
a different kind of user and we want to
be the ec2 user here what we can do is
type in wget space and we'll go ahead
and paste that link in and hit enter
that's going to download that tar there
i'm just going to type in clear just to
clear my screen to make things easier i
know the font's a little bit small so
i'll try to bump it up here
um and so if we just have to untar it so
i always forget what to type here so
let's go ahead and copy that and we'll
paste that in there
and we will follow up with openvs code
server hit enter
and that's going to expand the archive
so we can go cd into that directory and
now it's just as simple as running this
period forward slash server sh so sh is
a bash command or bash script and so if
we do period it's equivalent of saying
like sh
like if you did it like this
but uh it's more popular to run x cable
like that so we'll hit enter and that's
going to start on port 8000 and here
it's going to give us a web uri so we
want this part of the url
whoops i didn't mean to click it through
there hold on here it doesn't make it
too easy to click but if we just
a shrinker font there go back to our
instance we want that public ip address
i'm going to go ahead and grab that
paste it on in here and then i just need
the end so just go ahead and grab that
and try to copy it it doesn't make it
easy to copy so you might have to open
your browser like this and
we'll go back over here paste that on
there and it should hopefully work
fingers crossed
um
porta 8000 cannot be reached so just
double check make sure that is correct
looks okay to me
we grab the public ip address so that
should be fine
oh i think we stopped the server by
accident
okay
i'm just seeing if it changed yeah it
did change i'm just gonna click that
again
okay so we just got to be really careful
there because i guess it's very finicky
still running okay good
and i just need to delete out
this part of it here yeah we know why
it's forbidden that's totally fine
okay and i think it's working we'll just
give it a moment
there we go so here's vs code it's or
openvs code
uh and so you know that's a way of
self-hosting i mean the thing is is that
you have a lot that you need to solve if
you do this like how are you gonna
persist uh your data so like you don't
lose it or how do you back it up how do
you make it intelligent so that it knows
to turn off when you are not uh using it
i guess there's a lot of things here you
also notice that it's a little bit
different from the one that uh um get
pod uh uh gives you so like notice it
doesn't say get pod on the bottom or
have the command palettes and things
like that so this is really just being
able to run
the um
open vs code server okay like if you
needed this kind of editor here um but
anyway you know it is something you can
do and it's part of the get pod project
so i just wanted to make sure
uh that i showed you there let's go
ahead and shut down this ec2 instance so
we'll go ahead and just terminate that
instance there so let's say terminate
and
i'm pretty confident that it's
terminating so i'm i'm confident that is
going to be destroyed not worried about
it so yeah there you go open vs code
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown your cloud
instructor exam pro bringing you another
complete study course and this time it's
the xampp pro cloud developer
environment certification made available
to you here on freecodecamp so this
course is designed to help you pass and
achieve
example issued certification and the way
we're going to do that is by going
through a lecture content doing follow
alongs within our own account
doing a practice exam so that we're
preparing for the day of the exam and
also utilizing cheat sheets so that you
can cram some last minute information so
that you're able to pass that exam and
improve on your resume and on your
linkedin you've got that cloud developer
knowledge so you can get that cloud job
or that promotion so i am andrew brown i
was previously the cto of multiple
edtech companies with 15 years industry
experience five years specializing cloud
i'm an awesome community hero and i've
published many many free courses uh just
like this one and if you ever want to
buy me drink i love coconut water i want
to take this moment to thank viewers
like you because it's you that make
these free courses possible and the best
way you can support more free courses
like this one is to buy the additional
study material so that is the link there
at the exp cd01 where you can get study
notes flash cards quizlets downloadable
lecture slides downloadable cheat sheets
prax exams you can ask questions get
learning support and it's all free to
sign up yeah just to even get your prax
exam cheat sheets so it requires no
credit card there's no trial limit so
there's no reason not to sign up
and if there are updates to this course
look in the in the youtube comments to
see when there is an update and this is
where we would see things like
corrections additions modifications to
ensure that you're using the latest
version of this course and if you want
to keep up to date on upcoming courses
the best way to find out is to follow me
on twitter and share with me what you
passed and what you'd like to see next
so there you go let's get to it
journey asking the most important
question first which is what is the
cloud developer environment
certification so the cloud developer
environment or cde is a practical cloud
certification center round of the open
source developer tool get pod and here
we're going to learn about the benefits
of cloud developer environments over
traditional tools practical knowledge
utilizing a cde for the purpose of
application or cloud development
team-based collaborative features for
utilizing cds because that is the main
benefit of cdes advanced cde techniques
like custom containers pre-builds and
more the course code for this course is
exp cde 01 and the reason that is
important to know is because that's how
you know what version of the exam you're
taking so you always want to make sure
that you double check to make sure that
you are using the latest
course there and so exp is the
certification authority in this case it
is exam pro cde is the name identifier
standing for cloud developer environment
and one is the version of the exam we
also like to call this exam the get pod
essential certification or the git pod
course because it's so focused on git
pod but there's a reason why this that
is and we'll explain here in a moment so
who's the certification for well
consider the cloud developer environment
certification if you are new to
programming or scripting because if you
are working in the cloud you're going to
have to have an environment to code and
the best environment is in the cloud at
least in my opinion here
if you are a web application developer
role or you're transitioning into a
cloud developer role
it's a very good idea to adopt cloud
developer environments or if you're a
director of engineering or staff
engineer and you're looking to adopt cd
cdes to optimize the dealing and
productivity of your development team
because that is the main benefit of
adopting it is that you're going to get
increased productivity so before we look
at the roadmap we always do a roadmap to
show you where should you go after the
certification
but i need to break this down into three
types of certifications because this is
an exam pro certification and so we have
three types fundamental certifications
that's where we have a cloud concept
that is best taught with a large focus
on cloud agnostic knowledge so example
of that would be the cloud programming
certification we have technology
specific certifications like a cloud
concept that is best taught by using a
single technology in greater detail and
in this case that is what the get pod
certification is it's it's just that you
know we want to teach cloud developer
environments but it just makes sense to
use a single tool for that then there
are our role-based certifications so
this is where you have done a bunch of
fundamental and technology-specific
certifications and then you are
requiring to submit a project to earn
that role so example would be the exam
pro's cloud developer certification so
let's take a look at our roadmap and see
where we can go
with the gitpod certification so the
idea is we have that fundamental
knowledge that technical specific
knowledge and then the idea is that
we're trying to
show that proof of combined knowledge to
earn that role-based certification so
this is all based for a cloud developer
or modern application developer there's
overlaps with other cloud rules like
cloud engineers but let's take a look at
the cloud developer specific path here
so the idea is that you would start with
the cloud developer environment because
if you're going to be doing programming
or development you're going to need an
environment so it makes sense to know
inside and out a cloud developer
environment from there you would need to
know a variety of different programming
languages in the context of cloud
programmings working with sdks apis cli
things like that so that is the natural
path after the cde
from there we would look at application
integration so leveraging a host of
cloud services and integrating them into
your
traditional or your modern
application and then cloud deployment
because that seems to be something that
is very important uh for cloud
developers is having not just the
ability to develop applications but to
deploy and it's not just deploying
applications but deploying uh integrated
services as well from there it's really
good to fundamentally understand
virtualization which is not a topic that
uh it kind of gets overlooked with the
cloud developers so that's where
application developers so that's why
i think we include it here from there
there is linux specific information
there's windows specific information and
for virtualization a natural path there
is containers and then serverless so to
me this is the scope of fundamental and
tech specific knowledge that
you should acquire to be a cloud
developer and then once you have this
knowledge you need to prove it some way
and so that's where we have this idea
behind having a cloud project to show
all the knowledge and practice so you
might be looking at saying wow that's a
lot of certifications well the great
thing though is that these
certifications are smaller in scope
and so instead of taking a big big exam
like how aws azure or gcp has you do
these are more focused so that you're
having a bunch of smaller wins and
you're getting better coverage um so you
can think of it like a movie versus
watching a high production long running
or like a
high production tv series it's just a
different approach to
study okay so how long does it take to
pass for the cloud developer environment
so
we have the beginner side and so here i
say 24 hours um the idea is that if
you've never programmed before if you've
never held a web developer role it's
going to be on the greater side here 24
hours if you're experienced that means
you have practical working experience
with web apps
you have um held a web developer
engineering role we're looking at 14
hours and so in between here this is
where i say the average hours 20 hours
now this could be a lot faster if you
just watch the videos on two times it's
up to you right so like there is 14
hours of content it's mostly because
of the the lecture or the lab content so
there's a lot of hands-on
but you know if you watch it uh on two
times then you know you're done in seven
hours if you're experienced so just
understand that you know it looks like a
lot of hours but it's not as bad as it
looks um it's fifty percent lecture lab
content fifty percent practice exams
and then the recommendation here is to
study one to two hours for
ten days
okay what does it take to pass the exam
well the idea is you're going to be
watching lecture video memorizing key
information you're going to be doing
hands-on labs and there's a lot of it
so follow along with your own account so
you'll have to get a free gitpod account
and any other things that go along with
it and we make sure that we always make
sure things are free for you
so you can learn at the the lowest cost
or at no cost
and you'll have to do practice exams to
simulate the real exam the great thing
is on exam pro we have a full free
practice exam for you no credit card
required uh to get it so it's at exp
cd01
and that's where you're going to go grab
that
in terms of the content of the actual
exam it's broken up into five domains
and each domain has its own weighting
which determines how many questions in
our domain that will show up so we'll
take a look at the domains the first
domain is cloud developer environment
concepts which is seven percent uh get
pod integrations which is five percent
thirty uh uh domain three which is good
pod configurations is 35 percent get pod
workflows is 35 percent and 18 for git
pod io enterprise get pod oss so you
know when we engineered this course we
didn't just make it for people that are
going to apply
uh um
[Music]
apply it for their work but just also
for that executive level that needs to
understand how to adopt it for their
team so that's what this category here
is for is understanding the ecosystem
for adoption
um and you know a lot of it comes down
to just knowing how to work with it as a
team and knowing how to configure your
environment to be productive in real
world use cases so uh where do you take
the exam well the exam is taken online
from the convenience of your own home
and this and the exam is delivered via
the teacher's seat anchor system so
teachers see anchor is an online uh
secure exam system to deliver
certification exams similar to pearson
vue or psi online and ensures exam
credibility via their ai assisted
proctor so a proctor is a supervisor or
person who monitors students during an
examination so that way we make sure
that you're not cheating and that you
definitely have obtained the skills
yourself there
to schedule exam what you'd have to do
is actually sign up for example so you
keep seeing this thing up here you do
have to go there to do the exam
but once you sign up you can go uh into
the course and click on the schedule
button and from there you can schedule
your exam it'll have all the information
there
for the grading exam you have to score
at least an 80 percent we say around 80
percent because this uses scaled scoring
skilled scoring just means that we use a
point system and so the idea is that you
know tomorrow we decide to make it out
of 2000 points it's still going to be
based on the percentage of 80 percent so
when you go for the exam make sure
you're trying to aim for 85 percent on
your practice exams to make sure that
you are comfortable uh with the exam
when you go sit it for the response
types um first of all first off we have
55 questions so all questions are scored
there are no unscored questions and
there are no funny questions so you know
it shouldn't be too difficult you can
afford to get about 10 questions wrong
there is no penalty for wrong questions
and the format of the questions are
going to be multiple choice and multiple
answer the duration of the exam is 1.5
hours so you get about 1.5 minutes per
question the exam time is 90 minutes the
seat time is 120 minutes and somebody
say the seat time we're referring to the
amount of time you should allocate for
the exam this includes time to review
the instructions show online proctor to
your workspace read and accept the nda
complete the exam provide feedback at
the end and this exam is going to be
valid for 36 months so that's three
years before re-certification
so hopefully that gives you an idea of
what you are jumping into here
again the exam is not intended to be
difficult it's very practical if you
follow the content here it'll be pretty
easy for you to do
but yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
looking at the question of what is cloud
native and now this is not a as
straightforward as you'd imagine because
there are a few different definitions
here so we're going to have to go
through a few little iterations here to
just kind of conceptually understand
what it is but cloud native at least the
way i describe it is an architectural
approach that emphasizes application
workloads that are portable modular and
isolate between different cloud
deployment models and cloud service
providers so that is what my definition
of it is but if you talk to cloud
service providers and we say cloud
service providers we're talking about
aws azure gcp uh they describe it as a
term meaning everything built on their
platform so you know if you were not to
use on-premise and only to ever use aws
they would call that cloud native
but i would actually better describe
that as being cloud first so sometimes
cloud native and cloud first mean the
same thing depending on who you're
talking to
then there's uh some models out there
that say that certain components go into
cloud native so modern design automation
micro services containers and a bunch of
backing services and then other ones
describe cloud native as being four
principles so micro services
containerization continuous delivery
which you could say is automation and
devops which could mean anything because
devops has so much stuff involved but
you can just see that there are a few
different things there i'm hoping that
we lean towards my definition because i
feel like that is a more comfortable one
there but if it does feel confusing
don't worry about it
it's not just clearly defined it's just
kind of like serverless where it's hard
to pin down but in the context of get
pod and cloud developer environments
cloud native means uh we'll be utilizing
microservice architecture modern
application architecture so think
function as a service such as containers
and kubernetes okay so hopefully that
and when i say that it's just the fact
that when you have cloud developer
environments they're going to be better
drivers or enablers for
modern architectures okay
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at two very similar but
also distinct roles or technical roles
that strongly benefit from cloud
developer environments or cdes and so
that is a cloud developer or a modern
application engineer and you know cds
can be used by any kind of role that's
working in the cloud but these two in
particular strongly benefit
because they're writing a lot more uh
programming code okay and also
interacting with cloud workloads but
let's talk about how they are
similar and also how they are different
so for both these roles they take a
cloud first approach meaning that
generally they're starting um you know
on a cloud service provider
you know in the case of modern
application engineer you can still be
doing that on premise but generally
speaking they're going to be focused on
using a cloud service provider first
in terms of like how the role is focused
for cloud developer they're focused on
building out the product and the product
features whereas a modern application
engineer is architecture focused so
they're more interested in how to make
the underlying resources work in scale
and things like that
the cloud developer is specifically
going to focus on application
integration with cloud services so
that's what makes it different from a
regular developer is that interaction or
the interconnections with other cloud
services which enables you to basically
build microservices and for a modern
application um uh engineer they're
architecting cloud native workloads so
that might be setting up like a
kubernetes
cluster writing infrastructure as code
setting up automation and things like
that
and then you know just some other things
like things that you would
see that a cloud developer would do that
a modern application engineer does would
be things like deployment by knowing
some infrastructure as a code not a
priority for them but it's just
something they definitely know whereas
the modern application engineer has
things like automation scaling and
operations so just to reiterate here uh
it's like if you're taking a cloud-first
approach to building web applications
using cloud-native workloads or
cloud-based tooling that sounds like a
cloud developer and the focus is less
about the architecture and life cycles
and scaling and more about a being a
productive developer using cloud and
then on the other side of it we're
looking at the modern application
engineer
it's about thinking about how to
architect applications using serverless
containers microservices there's a
larger focus on the underlying
architecture lifestyle
life cycles and scaling not so much
about building out the web application
and it's less product focus so you know
i just want you to know these two things
because if you are entering cloud these
are the titles you should be trying to
cling on to if you really are invested
as a programmer okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at code editors versus
integrated development environments and
the reason why is because git pod
supports both and these usually look
very similar but they are also
dissimilar in a lot of ways and it's
good to understand um the trade-offs of
using one over the other so let's talk
about a code editor so a code editor is
for writing computer code and they will
generally support many programming
languages with things like syntax
highlighting in recent years code
editors will include a community
marketplace for extensions that allows
you to add a variety of features to
customize your code editor for specific
workflows so the thing is back in the
day when we had code editors they were
very simple and the only way you'd have
like really rich functionality was via
an ide because it had everything there
for you but now things have changed and
things are a lot more modular and
flexible but notable creditors would be
things like visual studio code sublime
vim notepad plus plus textmate things
like that then we look at integrated
development environments so an ide is a
suite of tightly integrated programming
tools
under a single unified gui so an ide are
generally more powerful than code
editors and are specialized for a
specific language or framework or you
could say they are very opinionated for
a specific framework or workload so they
will include things like a terminal code
editor debugger compiler deployment file
management and all sorts of tooling
notable ids here would be jetbrains
eclipse xcode android studio visual
studio and in a lot of cases sometimes
it's the only way you can really develop
stuff it's really hard to develop mac os
applications without xcode
it's possible but a lot of times you
know the the technology is so
well designed for that use case you end
up using ides
but i do need to note that modern code
editors can be modified through a
collection of extensions to work nearly
the same as ide so that line is becoming
a little bit blurred
but let's just look at the uh overall
comparison so code editors are
multi-purpose modular light portable and
generally cross-platform when i say
they're portable like them which is a
code editor can be something that's used
in the browser
as a desktop app or even in the terminal
but then you have things like ides uh
these are special uh so
in contrast they are specialized
monolithic heavy designed to be used as
mostly desktop apps because they need a
full gui and may not be cross-platform
um but we say as a desktop app um you
know that's starting to change because
like jetbrains is now able to use
jetbrains projector to run in the
browser so you know these things are
starting to meet in the middle but it's
still good to know the difference
between these terms but most people
these days are using code editors okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at the seven benefits of
cloud developer environments so i just
want you know this isn't like an
industry standard but these are the
things that i thought that were the most
important things to highlight about them
so if you are talking to someone trying
to understand why to adopt a cde into in
terms of your company workflow these are
the seven things you should be telling
them the first is context so you can
start a runtime system runtime system is
just a developer environment on the
context of your workload so pull
requests uh maybe based around an issue
a testing environment or sandbox or q a
then there's mobility so easily move to
different workstations so whether you're
on mac to windows to linux
all you need is a browser you can use
multiple kinds of version control
systems so maybe you're on github today
tomorrow you might want to use gitlab or
bitbucket things like that works with
different kinds of editors so maybe you
like visual studio code but you'd rather
use jetbrains so you have the ability to
move between them or you know maybe you
are on a laptop a chromebook or even a
tablet so you know there's a lot of
mobility you get there then we talk
about agility so quickly start up
developer environments no time spent
configuring your environment
and so that's a pretty clear one it's
just the fact that you've already put in
the work for the configuration either
other team member has or you have and
the idea is that it's going to spin up
and start that up right away then you
have disposability or they're being
disposable so always start from a clean
point discard long live credentials at
the end of a work session um what's
really important to understand here is
just like or like a use case is the fact
that a lot of times you'll install like
libraries if you're working with
multiple projects you might install
different libraries they break other
libraries but here that's not a problem
because everything is in the scope of
that single project and you're disposing
things at the end always then you have
reproducibilities or or being
reproducible so you can go back through
your git history and launch the exact
state of a developer environment with
the required environment configuration
because as you are
changing your code you're also changing
like the configuration to set up that
environment and you'll have that history
there in your commits
then you have a
progression or being progressive so with
progressive versioning always start uh
you always start with an environment
with the latest stuff and that's poorly
worded there but the idea that i'm
trying to say there is like with git pod
you can have pre-builds and so every
change might discover breaking changes
because it will run the code every
single time and so as you encounter it
you can address and then upgrade those
to the latest version
right so that's the idea of always
staying on the latest then you have
collaboration so we were talking about
real-time collaboration here um so being
able to share the state of a developer
environment so hopefully you know that
is pretty clear about those seven things
context mobility agility disposability
reproducibility
being progressive or progressive
versioning and being collaborative so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
asking a very important question uh in
this course which is what is gitpod so
gitpod is a company specializing in
cloud developer environments via the
gitpod open source software or the
gitpod.o which is the platform so it can
be a little bit confusing at first
because it's like is it the product this
is the company name or it's whatever but
we'll just go through here to make sure
it's crystal clear so get pod oss open
source software which is located on
github
is a developer environment as code and
if you're wondering what i mean by that
it's that it's an open source kubernetes
application for ready to code developer
environments that spin up fresh
automated dev environments for each task
in the cloud in seconds and enables you
to describe your dev environment as code
and instantly start remote cloud or
cloud developer
environments directly from your browser
or your desktop id or even tablets if
you want which i have yet to try but i'm
sure it does work
as long as you have a browser you can do
it
and so the idea is we have getpod.io
and this i call it a developer
environment as a service
which is not something you need to
really remember but it's basically a
software as a service so it is a
cloud-based fully managed offering of
the open source software with a free and
paid tier uh and so hopefully that is a
distinction that it's a company that's
an open source software it's also a
cloud platform okay
[Music]
all right so i just wanted to get you
some exposure to git pod so if you went
to www.getpodio
this is the main website here so you can
read all about it if you like but we do
of course cover everything that is in
here then there is the actual open
source git pod
and so this is where they have a variety
of different repositories
so you can start reading here and again
we cover this within the course but they
have a lot of repositories here and then
there's the actual platform itself which
is getpodio
if we click into here there's no app
it's just the naked domain uh here you
can see i've been launching workspaces
which will get into but you know again
just to get you a little bit exposure uh
to that gitpod ecosystem okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at getpod versus other
providers i think it's important to know
the options that are out there and maybe
to understand why i chose to do a gitpod
course as opposed to making an agnostic
course um but let's go through it so the
first is gitpodcodespaces formerly known
as visual studio online if you try to
find visual studio online anywhere you
just can't find it uh it'll let me have
like a marketing page it'll always link
back to github code spaces so maybe both
projects existed at one point maybe
visual studio online was always github
code spaces and was rebranded we really
don't know but all there is is github
code spaces so github code spaces is
proprietary online code editor
specifically for github so understand
that it's proprietary not open source so
um you know if you are locked in there
you're not going to take that code
editor into deployed on your own
infrastructure so just understand that
is one thing uh key differences you pay
based on computing instant size so i
believe that it's metered billing so uh
i mean that's nice if that's how you
like your compute to be like i use this
many hours i pay for this many hours but
you do have to choose or right size your
instance so that
uh could be good if like let's say you
need something that's more powerful than
git pod provides but git pod like has a
really beefy instance and at a cost that
like it's just really really cheap so
you know even though you know metered
billing and uh being able to use your
size sounds good uh you know this is one
of those rare cases where i prefer get
pod because i just don't have to think
about it it's like totally serverless it
doesn't currently have pre-builds right
now so you can have longer wait times um
i would imagine they would probably end
up adding this at some point so uh you
know even though i say there's not
pre-builds right now uh you know it
seems like github code spaces would add
that and a very huge key difference is
that it runs on a virtual machine so
when you are launching um a git pod it's
using docker right as a way of launching
its containers and so
um i mean
like i'm finding containers to be a lot
more flexible first i thought virtual
machines would be better because maybe
you need to install docker on a virtual
machine or or images but you can run
docker within docker so it doesn't
matter um and it's just a lot easier to
package like docker files for that kind
of stuff so i kind of feel like git pod
has the advantage there because it's
using containers okay
um and the use case here is only if
you're using github so if you're using
git lab or code commit or something else
uh you know you're not gonna be using
github code spaces so you have to
understand that your workflow is going
to be very tied to github and this might
cause friction for larger companies that
like are using elazi and jira and they
have everything in bitbucket which is
very popular so you know just has to
work
fit your workflow github of course is
the most popular version control system
out there and then visual studio code is
the most popular code editor so you know
for most people it's going to meet their
use cases but you know uh
i i just i still lean towards get pod
here then we have aws cloud nine so this
is an online code editor service within
aws
um
i liked it i liked it for years i still
use it for a lot of use cases
it runs on a virtual machine you can
only choose very particular types of
amis to run it on but i mean i guess
it's no different with um git pods
because git pod runs on debian ubuntu
like a debian like instance and so i
guess cloud9 technically has more
flexibility of what the virtual machine
is but when you're dealing with
containers you can have whatever you
kind of whatever you want i guess not
because in git pod you can only run
debian or ubuntu instances but
yeah i guess there's more flexibility
here with cloud9
you pay for the online virtual machine
cost it has a free tier um
these case here is if you need a simple
persistent developer environment with
simple collaboration features you want
to take advantage of built-in enable
support within cloud 9 for service
development um it is easier to use than
visual studio code so for beginners
especially when you do aws stuff i'm
showing them cloud nine but like if
you're serious about your development
you're probably gonna wanna use
something like visual studio code and
then that's where you're going to be
using git pod or code spaces and things
like that then we have the google cloud
cloud shell editor this is an online
code editor part of the google cloud
shell the key difference is it's free uh
and it's free to up to a certain point
there's no team collaboration features
at least that i i saw
and this is intended for experimentation
or rapid prototyping with gcp services i
wouldn't really consider it for
application development in a team
environment uh there's probably possible
limitations on performance of the
runtime environment i couldn't find
details about it and it has limited
hours per month i thought it was
like free 100 hours i might say this
somewhere else in the course saying like
google cloud shell gives you unlimited
hours but it's not true i found out it
was like limited to 50 hours a month but
it's still really good um and it's
running visual studio code alongside
their shell so when you're in google
it makes things a lot easier and so you
know when i'm doing uh google cloud
workload stuff i will be using that
thing but when i want something that's
persisted like a project i'm not going
to be doing it in the cloud shelter i'm
going to be putting in a repository and
launching up git pod but a really great
way to learn google cloud because a lot
of the um
uh the console you'll click through
it'll say open in cloud shell and then
open the editor so you will come across
it but what i want to do is show you all
these three editors for real just so you
can see where they are if they interest
you but hopefully that gives you an idea
how they compare
against skip pod right again git pod
runs on containers uh it's serverless
billing right um you know things like
that uh and it's it's using debian
ubuntu okay
hey this is andrew brown and i'm in my
aws account here at the aws management
console and i just want to quickly show
you what cloud9 looks like not so much
that you need to go do this but just so
that you can see what else is out there
so what i'm going to do is go to the top
here and type in cloud9
and we'll go over here
and we'll give it a moment here i am in
the root account so usually it doesn't
like you creating um environments here
which is totally fine i have a couple
old uh
ones here that refuse to delete but i'll
create an environment we'll just say
cloud9 uh get pod test
kind of weird writing get pod in there
but i just want to show you that you
choose the instance size or type so you
can choose t2 micro small large other
instance type and you can go pretty big
here so that might be the advantage that
cloud9 gives you is that you can go like
super super big if you need to
um
and you know this is not the only kind
of environment that aws has so like they
also have in sage maker
because you can think of it as a code
editor right like you have sagemaker
studio which will run a jupiter lab but
that's really for ml we're talking just
about like general cloud development
here so that's the thing is like if you
really do need to do like
um you know uh ml stuff you probably
shouldn't be using a cloud developer
environment you should be using
something like sagemaker studio or
whatever the uh integrated um cloud
services that are used by the cloud
service providers but anyway i'm going
to just choose a t3 micro notice we have
amazon list two amazon links the old one
which is not recommended to use anymore
ubuntu
um and so those are our options i think
at one point you could just attach
whatever
any kind of
uh machine you want but then it wouldn't
be managed when shut down automatically
notice we have a 30 minute um
turn off after 30 minutes but you can
change it here to whatever you like
we'll go ahead and hit next we'll create
that environment and we're going to wait
for that to spin up because i just want
to show you what it looks like
um it's generally really fast but i'll
see you back here in a moment okay all
right so after waiting a little while
here it has finally launched uh usually
it doesn't look like this i think
there's just a slight little problem
with the editor or display it usually
looks really nice here but it's just
telling you here how to get started with
um
cloud9 so this is based off of
i want to say like adam but maybe not i
think it may be oh sorry the ace editor
so we'd like up ace editor
i think that's what it's based off of
yeah so it was called ace and then uh
ace turned it into cloud9 uh ide it's
not really an id it's a cloud editor um
and then cloud9 was acquired by aws and
so aws integrated with a lot of their
services so when you go over to lambda
you're using cloud9 but it's a lot
simpler like they don't really have
extensions per se so
you can like explore aws resources
through here they have some uh source
control which um i believe is kind of
new i remember seeing this uh here
before but it's very dead simple there
are no extensions
uh you know so like whatever you want
it's like uh test.ruby
we'll open that up here and just type in
like um
puts
hello getpod
okay we'll save that down below ls and
i'll just run it here ruby test.rb so
it's really darn simple collaboration is
kind of nice i really like it um git pod
at least
at the time of shooting this
their features are not as transparent as
they need to be
but i know that they're working hard to
make that better but like here you can
like invite people you can see them you
can see where their cursor is so that's
kind of nice um they have a debugger uh
which is fine and there are like
serverless integrations but you know
nothing super complicated um but yeah if
you want to shut it down we can just
close the tab or i'll just go back out
we'll go back to uh the dashboard here
i'll just close up this tab and i'll go
ahead and delete that environment
so nothing super complicated that is
cloud9 now
over to gcp so we'll go over here and
theirs is up here in the active act or
cloud shell here so if you click it uh
generally you have to activate cloud
shell so what it's going to do is spin
up i think a virtual machine underneath
so we just have to wait uh a while here
and once we're there oh that was fast
that was super super fast some like if
it's the first time you ever did it it's
really slow but like
because i think they're like making the
back like the storage for you but
it's super fast but if you click here
the open editor it's going to look just
like
vs code because it is vs code
right so here it is
i don't know if there's any kind of
limitations in terms of the stuff that
you can install i actually never looked
at that for extensions
can you install extensions that's a good
question
so we have uh cloud code apis
secrets manager
kubernetes cluster so i don't see the
ability to install extensions
so it might be just
what you see is what you get here i'm
going to go ahead and just create myself
a new file here so just say test.rb
okay so nothing super complicated you
know you know what
visual studio code is but
that's that one there if you want to
close it we just hit the x there all
right and we'll take a look at
github code spaces all right i'm back
and so i just want to show you github
code spaces or at least attempt to do it
and so the thing with github code spaces
is that if you've ever tried to find it
like under the buttons here and you
don't see it displayed the reason why is
that it's part of i believe the team's
plan so you know if you are just a
regular user and you're looking to
utilize it that's not possible now could
you just go ahead and create an
organization and then be able to do it i
guess we could go find out so what i'll
do here is go over
to my settings and we'll look for
organizations
and i'm going to create a new
organization
and notice here we can see some options
so in the free here unlimited public
private repositories 2 000 automation
minutes a month 500 megabytes issues and
projects um so i don't think that it's
here
um is it in here i'm just trying to see
here so we have protected branches
multiple reviewers code owners
and that is the tricky part is just
trying to find the functionality so what
i'm going to do if we scroll down here
we might be able to see it so code
spaces
ah okay so in the free tier it's not
available and then the team plan that's
where it's going to start at up to 32
cores starting at 18 cents per hour i'm
very certain that i have a paid teams
plan somewhere so i just need to go find
it okay
so what i'll do is i'll come back here
in a moment and see if i can find it but
just understand that you got to be
paying and then you can pay additional
to use
get
hub code spaces so i'll be back here in
a moment okay
all right so i'm in uh my other account
here where i definitely have a teams
organization but i don't think it's paid
it used to be paid i think we moved off
of it because they made a free tier and
so now we don't have code spaces so uh
you know i think it's just going to be a
bit too hard for me to show this and all
it would really show is that once you
launch it that you
have
this kind of editor and that you can
choose the different size there um but
you know hopefully that gives you an
idea of like the friction it it it
causes to get started with um code
spaces uh but you know if you really
want to know more you can just read up
on it here okay uh but yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we were
talking about context-based developer
workflows because this is something that
you've probably already been doing but
it's just cloud developer environments
make it a lot easier to do so what is
context in the scope of a developer
workload well as a developer you need to
quickly switch contacts based on the
scope of the work you are currently
performing and this could be things like
reviewing pull requests
developing features manually performing
quality insurance so q a replicating a
version of production
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at context-based developer
workflows if you've never heard of it um
it's okay you've actually probably been
using it this entire time
but this became a lot more important
once we started using modern
architecture so let's talk about what is
the context in the scope of a developer
workload well as a developer you need to
quickly switch context based on the
scope of the work you are currently
performing this could be something like
reviewing a pull request deploy or
developing features manually performing
quality insurance of q a replicating a
version of production for debugging
creating a temporary environment to test
the hypothesis so the idea is the
context is what do you need to do
review code develop feature q a all
sorts of options there and those
environments all need to be specialized
for that context so developers have
always been using context-based
developer workflows though cloud
developer environments cdes makes that
much easier to do and specifically for
microservice or modern architectures
which have many more iso repositories
this is a big struggle for a lot of
people that are doing microservices as
just managing all the repositories
whether they have one big monolith or
not but again cloud developer
environments make it so much easier to
jump into those projects so cloud
developer environments become part of
the workflow developers can quickly and
safely switch contexts so i just kind of
want to add an additional illustration
about you know if you're using uh cloud
developer environments first versus
using local
developer environments how that might
change uh the responsibility or the
accessibility of your code so
here you know the old way we would do it
is we would launch i'm gonna get my pen
tool out here we would launch a local
developer environment we'd write our
code and then we would create the
repository locally and then push okay i
know there's a spelling mistake there so
just ignore that
but now you know with
cloud developer environments we create
the empty repository first in github so
it already is there then we launch our
cloud developer environment and then we
write code and from there we can
actively commit our code and so the
great thing about that is that when we
take that approach like let's look at
the old way if we were doing the old way
some people will end up writing all this
code and they just never push it to a
repository remote repository they might
have created a local repository but it's
never made it online and so that means
that there's a longer time before code
can be collaborative or they have an
opportunity where they might or an
opportunity but there might be the
misfortune that they lose that code and
i can i can't tell you how many times
that has happened or it's the weekend
you want to pass that code off to
somebody else but like oh it's on a
machine i never pushed it
but if you're using cloud developer
environments it's already in online
repository that is the starting point
and that is the kind of behavior change
that you have when you use cloud
developer environments so there's a
higher chance of collaboration and less
chance of loss of code and that just
makes it again easier to do this
context-based developer workflows and
one context would be like starting a new
project but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at visual studio code also
known as vs code which is a free source
code editor made by microsoft for
windows linux and mac os if you're
confused why it says source code editor
that's just the language that microsoft
uses but you can just say code editor
and visual studio code should not be
confused with visual studio which came
before vs code and vs studio
is an ide an integrated developer
environment that's for doing more
low-level stuff
but anyway visual studio code has 14
million developers out of 24 million
developers worldwide
who use vs code making it the most
popular source code editor today and if
you wanted to do the math on that that's
58 percent market share so at least half
of all developers are using vs code and
the reason we're talking about vs code
is because that is the primary editor
that you will see when you launch up a
git pod workspace so vs code is very
popular due to being free powerful works
on all hardware lots of courses orgs
schools use vs code because it's
available for everybody so there you go
hey this is andrew brown and we are
looking at the concept of docker so
docker is a set of platform as a service
products that use os level
virtualization to deliver software in
packages called containers so the reason
we're talking about uh docker is because
that is what uh getpod is using to run
their environments you'll hear
kubernetes as well
but that's something that you don't
necessarily have to touch
but docker containers is something that
you might
encounter okay
so docker was the earliest popularized
open source container platform so when
people think of containers they
generally think of docker and we said
it's platform as a service product so
there's more
than one thing just called docker so we
have the docker cli so these are cli
commands to download upload build run
and debug containers we have a docker
file so a configuration following how to
provision a container docker compose
this is a tool and configuration file
when working with multiple containers
and that's something you may encounter
uh with some like quick start templates
and things like that docker swarm an
orchestration tool for managing deployed
multi-container architectures that is
not something that you have to worry
about um then you have docker hub a
public online repository for containers
published by the community for download
so this is going to be a place where you
source containers and we definitely
source things from docker hub using git
pod and then there's the concept of oci
the open container initiative because i
saw this term and it just pops up
everywhere you're wondering like what is
oci compliant what does that mean so
open container initiative is an open
governance structure for creating open
industry standards around container
formats and runtime so docker
established the oci and it is now
maintained by the linux foundation and
so docker has been losing favor with
developers due to the handling of
introducing a paid open source model and
alternatives like podman are growing but
that doesn't mean don't use docker that
just means like at scale you know some
companies like larger companies are
looking at alternatives but these
alternatives are oci compliant right
like pod men and things like that but i
just wanted to point that out because
you know docker can be a bit contentious
in the open source space but it still is
really good and solid and that is what
git pod is using okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at version control systems
also known as vcs so these systems are
designed to track changes or revisions
to your code and the most popular vcs is
git so vcs can also refer to managed
cloud services that host vcs so this is
why this term is a bit confusing because
really it means git but a lot of times
we are talking about get providers and
so get pod integrates with the following
git providers the first is github so
this is owned by microsoft it's the most
popular vcs offering due to its ease of
use and being around the longest github
is primarily where open source projects
are hosted and offer rich
functionalities such as issue tracking
automation pipelines and a host of other
features before github everybody would
put their stuff on sourceforge
but sourceforge was very slow i think it
was svn-based and it had a lot of ads
and so when github came out it was
extremely popular because you could put
repos there for free and had really
strong collaboration tools then came
along git lab so this was an emerging
competitor to github and at the time had
unique features such as ci cd pipeline
improved security measures i still think
it's easier to get a lot of things set
up in gitlab it takes care of that stuff
for you
but github has caught up with a lot of
stuff like github actions and and things
like that so they're pretty much on par
now then there's also bitbucket this is
owned by elazian and it was originally
only used for mercurial so mercurial was
a competitor to get but git became so
popular that bitbucket added git and
then mercurial became so uh unpopular
not that it's bad but just wasn't as
popular as get that they uh stopped
supporting mercurial so uh bitbucket has
tight integration with atlatian's
industry standard agile project
management software called jira and so
if you ever end up working for a large
organization they're very likely to be
using jira and because they're using
jira they're very likely to be using
bitbucket because there's tight
integrations between it it's just so
much easier so those are um you know the
git providers
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at version control system
permissions and to understand that we
need to know what oauth 2.0 is so oauth
2.0 is an industry standard protocol for
authorization and the idea here is oauth
doesn't share password data but instead
uses authorization tokens to prove an
identity between consumers and service
providers so oauth is about granting
access to functionality as opposed to
something like open id which is about
providing who you are but the only thing
i really want you to know is that it
uses oauth and that's where these fine
grain permissions are going to get set
and that's how it works for uh get pod
because you connect your uh your your
version control system and then you you
as the user are going to decide uh what
you want to set there so within your get
providers you can see they're connected
so there's my username there are my
permissions and if you expand it you'll
see all the options there and it's going
to vary based on the provider so the
idea here is that for github we have
user email read user public repo repo
read org and workflow
um so just understand that that's going
to be slightly different for all the
providers and the key thing to remember
is the fact that uh get pod is not
responsible for these permissions it's
on the get provider and the user okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at the git pod editor
support so get pod is designed to be a
provider agnostic cloud developer
environment and one way we see that is
the fact that it supports integrations
for a bunch of different git providers
but another way that it's agnostic is by
having support for more than one editor
and so gitpod currently supports three
types of editors so we have vs code
browser so a editor within the browser
and this is the default experience
desktop vs code so opening a workspace
in local vs code so a desktop
application and jetbrain so a paid ide
that extends uh the eclipse ide so if
you ever use eclipse you kind of have an
idea what jetbrains is there so what
we'll do is investigate all these three
types here but the key thing to remember
is that gitpod supports uh multiple
types of editors and i think they'll
just keep on expanding that because that
is their goal okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at jetbrains and before we
can talk about that we need to know what
is eclipse so eclipse is a free and open
source id created by ibm originally
intended for java through open source
projects have expanded to a variety of
languages so i think ibm authored it and
it's been managed by an open source
group now i remember using jetbrains
back in like 2001 specifically for java
so it's very interesting to see that
it's been around for so long and it's
still super powerful but then there came
along jetbrains and jetbrains is a
company specializing in creating paid id
so it's proprietary or an extension of
eclipse and so they just make the uh the
eclipse experience way way way better so
they use the same code base at least at
one point they did um but they have
grant greatly expanded that feature set
around specific programming languages
this brain is easier
more productive more convenient to use
in eclipse just brains was formerly
known as intellij
and if intellij sounds familiar it's
because it kind of sounds like
intellisense which is this whole kind of
auto-completion thing so
notice here as they're typing and
there's this auto completion thing that
was something i think that was invented
by microsoft originally or at least they
uh branded the idea of intellisense but
this was a big selling point where you'd
be able to type and it would auto
complete you could click through stuff
now we're seeing that kind of everywhere
like code editors have support for that
through extensions but one at one point
that was a big deal okay so jetbrains
has a variety of ids specialized for
different languages or frameworks so
let's just go through the list we have
phpstorm
which is for php lang for uh go land for
go the go language uh intellij idea or
idea which is for java data grip which
is for sql or databases in general
pycharm for python ruby mine for ruby
webstorm for javascript c line for c and
c plus plus writer for net and this
isn't the full list i know they have
something for
developing ios applications and
something for data science other things
like that
but the reason i'm listing these ones
out for you is because these are all uh
in the scope of what um git pod is
trying to have support for now what's
interesting is a thing called jetbrains
projector and this is a tool that allows
you to run jetbrains id within a browser
i don't particularly know if gitpod is
using that and that's how you integrate
with it because i just haven't uh given
jetbrains with vs code a go
but i just want to say gitpod allows you
to integrate with jetbrains to use it as
your gitpod workspace editor there's an
asterisk there because at the time of
right now it's in beta
and some of these are coming soon so
these are all on the roadmap and so i
just want you to be
knowing about this because probably in
the future these will be available to
you okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and i was
saying that there is uh support for
gitpod to use your desktop version of vs
code so you can open git pod workspace
in your local vs code if you open up
either file or go to the get pod
command palette you should see an option
that says open a vs code there's also
this option says open in vs code
insiders and insiders is just the vs
code unstable release version so it's
like the latest version but you might
not want to be using it unless you're
like they'd like to have the latest
features but you don't mind if there's
bugs or things like that so some vs code
extensions do not work in the browser so
opening in local vs code may give you a
better developer experience um and you
know you know some people prefer desktop
apps so that could be a reason there but
i ran into an edge case with my
co-founder where they use ubuntu and
they could not use the vs code vim
extension the browsers uh
specifically on their linux laptop right
so in this case they had to launch in
local vs code and then they were able to
use it so it was interesting to see that
edge case but it seems like you know a
lot's not the support on mac or windows
so there that could just happen okay
and also when i was using this on my
windows machine where i'm using windows
subsystem linux
it actually prompted me to install a
bunch of things like uh docker and
kubernetes and things like that where is
on my mac it didn't ask for any of these
things so it's possible that you have to
have docker and salt which would make
sense because um it is running
containers so there'd have to be some
way for it to do it uh and one thing i
noticed is that you cannot open a shared
running workspace that has been shared
with you so only the owner can open that
workspace locally
so that's just a thing there and i think
i repeated a couple times in the course
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at the get pod browser
extension and this provides a
convenience button within the version
control hosting provider and this button
prepends the gitpod url prefix to the
current url and this gitpod browser
extension is available for firefox
chrome microsoft edge and brave and so
it's important that you remember that
because i will ask you on the exam which
browsers it's for so just to kind of
show you what that convenience button
looks like in the different providers
here is github and there is the button
here is bitbucket and there is the
button here is git lab and there is the
button so nothing super complicated here
but it's a lot easier than having to
remember to type in the git pod url so
it'll definitely save you some time okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at git pod browser
bookmarklet so what is a browser
bookmarklet well it is a browser
bookmark but instead of pointing to a
url it executes arbitrary javascript
code and so the idea is that transform
is a bookmark into kind of a smart
bookmark so you'd have this javascript
code which we get from the gitpod
website you'd place it in the url
box when you make your bookmark and then
when you click that button it would work
just like pressing that gitpod button
assuming you were on a particular page
like a gitlab or github page so the get
pod browser bookmarklet when clicked
will open in the current github gitlab
bitbucket just what i just said there a
moment ago and the reason for it is that
it acts as an alternative to the browser
extension for when the browser extension
is not present for specific web browsers
so i didn't test it but i assume that
it's not for safari because safari is
not a chromium-based browser probably
opera as well would be in that category
there could be cases where you have
computer workstations that does not
allow the installation of browser
extensions because you know some
organizations they have a bunch of
computers and every time you shut them
down they always boot up a fresh image
so you lose your extensions or they just
they don't allow you to install
extensions uh as a as a security measure
so that you know people are installing
malware in their browser or it could be
that developers are extending the launch
behavior for more intelligent action so
you could probably take that javascript
code and add some extra stuff in there
maybe you want to um put in some
environment variables and so that gives
you a bit more flexibility over the get
pod button but there you go
hey this is andrew brown and what we're
going to do here is look at git lab
integration so what i'm going to do is
create myself a new gitlab account so in
the top right corner we have get free
trial i kind of swore they used to have
a free account here so i'm going to do
is double check here and yes they do
have one so i'm going to say free
and here we have two options where we
have git lab sas or get lab self managed
so sas is the one we want that's going
to be just like when you utilize github
so we'll go here and click sign up for
free and i'm just going to fill in my
name so we got andrew
brown and we'll just say
exam pro co
exam pro co and then we need a password
so i'm going to generate out a password
uh here paste that in
and before we proceed here i'm just
going to save this to my password
manager to save myself some trouble
so just give me a second here so get
lab.com exam pro co
i'm gonna put that password in there
okay and hopefully it will take it i am
definitely not a robot at least i don't
think i am you know there's a bunch of
options down here but i'm going to just
keep it simple by using email we're
going to go ahead and hit register so
now it wants me to confirm my email so
i'm just going to open a new tab off
screen here i'm going to make my way
over to my email
i'm going to try to do this as quick as
i can here
and so i have a confirmation email here
from git lab
okay so here it is and i'm going to go
ahead and get click confirm your account
and so here it's confirming my account
and we will just expand that here and so
here it says your email address has been
successfully confirmed please sign in
and so what i'll do is grab my password
here so i'm going to copy my password in
here paste it on in sign in
and it's going to ask me some
information i'm just going to say
continue
who will you be using this for the time
being it'll just be me okay because it
looks like i guess there's some few
different options here
i don't need to opt anything would you
like to create a project join a project
we'll just say create new project
and i guess we need an organization name
so
this is really just for
git pods i'm just going to say exam pro
exam pro co
and we're going to write git pod because
i'm going to be doing a bunch of repos
here and i figured we could do that the
group
and any public projects can be viewed
without any authentication so we'll say
create group because we'll make it
public facing
and so now we have an opportunity to
create a project this is a quite the
lengthy setup but i'm going to make this
public here and what we're going to say
here is
uh gitpod hello world
as an example here
and i'm going to go ahead and create
this
and we'll just give it a moment to set
up okay
and so it's all set up so we'll say okay
let's go
so now that is there the next thing i
want to do here is connect uh to gitpod
so what i'm looking for here
um is a button for the github project i
mean i guess this is the project here so
this is not necessarily repos
so
just give me a moment here and i'll
think about what i need to do okay
all right so i'm back and i was just
kind of looking around at what there is
to do here so what i want to go do is
create a new repository and so we'll
click that there
and then from here
we have an option over here repositories
on the left hand side so
um
let's go here and click on repository
and so now i'm over here and you can see
there's initial commit um by a fellow
here
i assume he works at get pod
so senior product uh a designer for
growth at gitlab um there and so here we
can see that repository it's been
unusual that it's like a commit uh on
the behalf of somebody else but that's
totally fine uh but the great thing is
we have our get pod button you will not
have this unless you have that stuff
installed i also noticed like web ide
here never looked at that so i'm just
kind of curious what's going to open up
here
i'm just curious because it's like you
know there's git pods so i'm just
wondering if git lab
had their own offering um so i can go
here and it's pretty simplistic so it's
not really like a full
full-blown developer environment i was
just really curious but what we'll do is
go back over to our hello world project
i'm just gonna go back here because
maybe there was two here
so let me click into gitlab is that the
one we were looking at yeah so that was
the one that we saw here
and then here is the public one that i
made it's a little bit confusing again i
don't use git lab on a day-to-day basis
so i'm just kind of learning uh just
like you are here but i guess if we
click the
icon at the top we can start seeing the
projects more clearly and so this is the
one that i created that i care about
this is new i don't know what this uh
this is i guess this is created by
default for you
um and so we'll go over to
uh repository
it's not really showing me a lot of
information because usually like github
will set something up for you so what
i'm going to do is just add a new file
so let's just say add a readme file
okay and we'll just say hello world
we'll go ahead and commit that
and we'll just say commit
and so now what i'm hoping is if we go
back to
um our project here we'll get something
that looks a little bit more normal
okay yeah and so there we go so just we
had to get that initial file in there
and so now we have that opportunity to
use git pod of course you'll need the
browser extension for that installed if
you don't we're going to just do it the
old-fashioned way so i'm going to go up
here in the top type in http colon slash
get pod uh dot io for slash pound okay
and that will open up that environment
for us
notice that i don't have a getpod
account here as of yet so what i'm going
to do here is say continue with gitlab
just because that's what we're using
right now and here it's going to allow
us to authorize so we're going to say
authorize
and we'll just give it a moment to check
out that repository but essentially when
we did that when we authorized that that
should have created a new account for us
and so here is um our project here which
is all great
and so essentially what you'd want to do
is kind of set up your environment so i
really don't like the look of this it's
kind of hard on my eyes so i'm going to
go down to the bottom left corner we're
going to go to color theme and i'm going
to just switch to something that is dark
so we'll say
um
actually i like monica quite a bit so
i'm going to go to that
like in terms of the editor or the
coloring there and so we have this open
and if we just want to kind of set up a
new file here i'm just going to go
getpod.yaml
okay
and we'll just set up something
initially so we have
tasks and i'm assuming that's how we do
it just trying to do for memory so we
have name we're going to say hello world
okay and then from there we'll just hit
space base
and it's the command that we want and
i'm just going to say echo
actually we don't have to put double
quotations there we'll say echo
hello world and i don't think we need
exclamations
exclamations here i'm having a bit of
trouble because i keep on thinking this
is a vim keyboard so one thing i want to
go do is go install
the vim
the vim hotkey here so we'll go vim
uh
vimvs code
it's this one that i want to install so
we'll say install here
okay and we'll go back and so now that
works as normal as i would expect it to
and so i believe that this is uh correct
with the exception that we just should
have a colon here and what i want to do
is just go ahead
and commit this so we'll go back here
and i'll just say uh hello world commit
okay
and we will add that file and we will
hit commit
we'll sync those changes we'll say ok
and so now if we go back to our original
tab here and we just give this a refresh
we should now see in a repository
this new commit but what i want to find
out is will this change uh take effect
so
you know we can just close this tab i
just want to show you like if you have
uh get pod gamble open and you're always
trying to figure out how to make your
way back
um and by the way i might just bump up
the font here i don't know if this is
gonna work let's just see if i can do
that
um here
it's not really bumping so sorry
everything's gonna be really small what
we can do is go down to the command
palette here and if we want to get back
to this repository quickly we can just
go to open context and that's always
going to bring us back here to the
project or repository in git lab
but what i'm really interested in is
actually going over to getpodio because
whether or not you notice you actually
created an account so if we were to go
over to the dashboard this would open
opens and up us up to the getpod.io
and so now you can see we have a new
account if i go over here and we go to
settings
you can see that for integrations i have
git lab and this is where our
permissions live so we go here
and
if we want to change these we can go
ahead and just change those things but
the goal is we're going to hook up
github and bitbocket just so that we can
see what they all look like
but just to kind of complete what we're
doing with this project here what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to go
ahead just close this tab here and close
that out and i'm going to go back here
and i'm just going to go and type this
in again
okay so let's say https colon forward
slash sport slash gitpod.io
pound
and from there it says invalid git pod
yaml should be an object so
clearly i've made a mistake so we'll say
continue with the default configuration
actually that's the first time i've made
a mistake with a github configuration
file and i think it's just because i
created from scratch normally i go out
and i find a reference but that's not
what i did here so if this is a problem
what i'm going to do is just cut that
out and we're going to open up a new
terminal
and i'm just going to delete this file
here
okay
and instead we're going to just do a gp
init to initialize a new file so i'm not
exactly sure what i did wrong there i'm
just going to paste that back in
because it looks correct to me
oh it's because i did that okay so
that's what i really wanted to do but
i'm just going to go ahead and do that
we'll get rid of these ports
and we'll just say okay let's
fix this get pod
the ammo file okay
we'll sync those changes we'll say okay
all right and so from there what we can
do is go back to our project so i click
back on the git pod yaml down below
opened in the dashboard
oops uh you know what i want to go to
open in the context here
and then we'll close our old tab
and again we're just going to go and
type it in here i will start using the
get pod button here but
i just kind of want to keep doing this
so you kind of see what it is that we're
typing so that you know it just becomes
kind of muscle memory for you okay
so what i'm expecting this time is for
our command to work and if that's great
what we'll do is proceed onto github and
bitbucket and get that all connected
into a single account
okay so it's just loading up here
and our echo works so this is all in
good shape okay so
uh this is good so i'm just going to go
back to our context i'm just going to
close back out the old one and so that's
pretty much it that we need to know for
git lab again it's not super complicated
but let's take a look at how we do it
for github and bitbucket next okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are on
bitbucket so we'll go ahead and create
ourselves a new account here because
it's good to learn all three providers
um because there's a high chance that
you'll end up using one of each at some
point so here it suggested we want to
add jira i'm good i'm just going to hit
next and i probably already have a
bitbucket account because i have jira
not necessarily a separate bitbucket
account here but we'll see what happens
if we try to sign up so it says i
already have an account which is totally
fine i'm going to log in here it's not
like a lot that you're missing here in
terms of the setup process you know all
these things are the same right you sign
up they send a confirmation email here
it's going to ask me for
a um
a username so i'm going to say exam pro
co
and we'll see if it takes that and it
does so we're all good here and we're
going to come in here and see what we
have so before you drop in a bit bucket
tell us some stuff i want to skip this i
don't care about any of that kind of
stuff
and let's see if i have any repositories
in here
and i have one for the lithium js is a
to do again that's coming from
jira
but we don't actually have any
repositories so let's go ahead and set
up a new one here
and so
what we'll do is create a new project so
the project name is going to be called
get pod hello world
and
oh this again this is maybe exam pro co
get pod and then the repository will be
uh get pod hello world
and we can make it public or private it
doesn't matter i'm going to leave this
one private in this case
do we want to read me sounds great what
do you want the main branch to be called
we'll call it main include a git ignore
file sure why not and we'll go ahead and
create this repository
so we are here and notice in the top
right corner there is our get pod button
and again i'm not going to click it for
the time being i just want to keep doing
this at the top here so that again it
becomes muscle memory for you to know
what to type just so it's
there but what we can do is go to the
top here and type in https colon forward
slash forward slash get pod dot io
forward slash pound and hit enter
it says authorize with bitbucket.org so
it already knows that we're logged in
with our github account
this is something to be careful because
you want to make sure they're all
connected to the same account
or you'll end up with multiple accounts
which might be annoying so i'm going to
say authorize with bitbucket.org here
it's going to ask me a bunch of options
i'm fine with all this we're going to
say grant access
okay
and we'll give it a moment to start this
environment so you can see that public
repos private repos the process is very
similar sometimes you just have to grant
access to be able to do things
and we'll just wait here for this
environment to set up
there we go and so here it is same
experience everything's the same and i
think i learned my lesson from last time
and so when i opened up this terminal
i'm just going to
create a gitpod file there and while i'm
here what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to bump up my font because it
might be a little bit hard for you to
see and so i'm just going to bump this
up to like 22.
okay while i'm here i'm gonna change
this to two
okay
and what we'll do is just go ahead and
close that and so now i'll type in get
gp init
all right and so we'll get that down
here this is still really small that's
kind of bothering me so i'm going to go
down below go to settings
and
um i'm looking for terminal editor font
size we have text editor
font size
terminal maybe
there we go
that's a lot better okay and so
uh from here we can just do the same
thing so i'll go ahead and delete this
out
we'll change this over to
um hello
world and then down below this will be
hello world here as well
and as per usual go to the left-hand
side here and i'm going to just go ahead
and add that file and say uh add
a knit uh get pod file
and we will commit that to our repos
repo save the changes
and as it's going we'll go down below
again clicking on this get pod button
here and we'll open the context to see
that commit there and so there it is
there
and again there's really no easy way to
like like
to completely terminate a workspace and
reopen it you can stop a workspace so
down below we have the command palette
here but also in the top left corner you
can go here and we have similar commands
i'm probably going to keep going up here
now because this is a lot shorter but if
you stop it that's not sufficient enough
because we want to terminate and start a
new one in order to iterate on this git
pod yaml file so what i'll do is i'll go
ahead and close this tab out and i'm
going to go to the top here again type
it in so it's
http colon
s
colon colon get pod dot io colon colon
forward slash forward slash what am i
talking about and we'll hit enter here
and so you know again it should just
work as per usual so we'll just give it
a moment there to spin up and just make
sure that is working correctly
and there it is so there you go that's
working fine oh it says command not
found so clearly i've made a mistake
if i go back here um i think it's
because i'm using single quotes instead
of double quotes
okay but that doesn't really matter per
se but i'll go ahead and fix that so
change quotes
from single to double okay
but what i want to do is go ahead and
check
the dashboard here so we'll go there
and from here i'm going to go to my
settings
and we'll take a look here again at
integrations
and we'll just see like
there are clearly different um settings
or permissions
uh per one here okay so just understand
that it's not one to one across them
it's going to be really dependent on the
get provider
so yeah i guess that's uh two out of
three and so the next video we'll go
look at github okay
[Music]
all right so now we're on the github
website to sign up for our last get
provider that is currently supported uh
with gitpod and so in the top right
corner i'm going to go to sign in
because i already have an account and i
do have one with the android exam pro
co but interestingly enough i never use
this account because i have an older one
but that is totally fine so what i'm
going to do is just go ahead and grab
the password for this
and we're just going to go paste that in
there
whoops we'll try that one more time here
okay i must have grabbed the wrong
password that's totally fine we'll sign
in
oh it's not giving me anything today
we'll try this one more time
there we go okay so it was a bit tricky
but i'm in there and you can see i
already have a follower even though i
don't know why they're following me but
that's totally cool and apparently i
have a very simple example over here
python docs hello world so not a lot
going on in this account which is
totally fine so what i want to do is
create myself a new repository and by
the way if you're creating account for
the first time it'll probably ask you a
bunch of extra things to ask you know so
you know whatever whatever is going to
be there that's fine and i guess my
username is exam pro hyphen dev so
that's probably what i called it when i
first created this account and so we're
just going to say git pod
um
hello uh world
as per usual let's make this one private
um and we'll go ahead and add a git
number file
and we'll say readme file down below
and it's private so i shouldn't have to
choose a license but we can go here and
just choose none
oh it really wants me to choose one here
oh for ignore okay so like ruby
ah we'll just ignore it we don't need
one that's fine
we're not doing anything serious here
and so now that we have it open again i
know that button's there but we'll come
to it soon enough so i'm just going to
type in https forward slash forward
slash get pod
io forward slash pound enter
and here it says something went wrong
and it just means that you have yet to
connect that account so we'll go ahead
and say authorize probably not the best
wording but that's just what it is and
you'll notice that github has like the
most robust
permissions out of all the three you can
drop down here and have a lot of options
i'm going to say authorize get pod i o
okay it's going to say repository not
found it might be private so please
authorize get pod access so again uh
nope it's not a bug it's just you got to
go ahead and hit grant access
and so it says okay what kind of
accesses do you want to give it we'll
say authorized goodpodio
and so what we'll do here is just open
up the dashboards on the top left corner
we're going to say open dashboard
and we'll make our way over to settings
i just want to show you again the
integration so this is what it looks
like
for github this is what it looks like
for um
bitbucket this is what it looks like for
gitlab so you can just see it's slightly
different for each one
um and same routine here what i'm
curious to see if if it's preserved my
font size and it totally did i think
this is all happening with sync settings
so down below see where it says settings
sync is on so this is on by default and
that's what's
causing all these settings to remain
available if we turned it off i think
it'd probably end up resetting i feel no
reason to turn off settings links to
show that so we'll just leave it as is
but what i'm going to do again is open
up a new terminal so in the top left
corner we're going to terminal new
terminal
and we'll go ahead and type in uh get
pod so gp and type in init
i'll open up that new file there and
we'll just go ahead and delete that out
as per usual
and we'll say hello world
and it's interesting this has single
quotes so it should have worked for the
other one i'm surprised it didn't work
and it was double quotes
but we'll try with single quotes again
we'll go back over here we'll add that
file we'll say uh add a net gitpod.yaml
file
okay
and we will hit changes sync the changes
we'll say okay
open the context so here we'll say open
context
and so there is that gitpod gamma file
updated
so that's pretty straightforward for
integrations
um and so i think the next thing i would
like to do
is to show you how to install the
bookmark extension
and how to use the bookmarklet so i'm
not going to close all this stuff i'll
close this tab here we don't need that
and
from here i'm just going to
go to my chrome extensions
okay so we'll say chrome extensions
and i'm just going to uninstall it so
here i have git plot i'm just going to
remove it okay
and we'll go back here and so now we
don't have that button
whoops uh let's refresh that one more
time
yep so that button is gone
and so i'll show you how to install the
extension next okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and welcome
back to another follow along here and in
this case what we're going to do is set
up the browser extension so what i'm
going to do is make a new tab here we're
going to go get pod i o i'm going to
type in browser extension
and so from here we'll go to this page
here it's under the documentation under
here
and so if we scroll on down we can see
that we have support for chrome and
firefox and we probably should try out
another browser but we'll just do this
for chrome for the time being
and i'm just going to go ahead and add
to chrome
we'll say add
extension okay and so already in the top
here it seems like it's uh turned on
up here
and so if you want to know where that is
we type in chrome forward slash sports
extensions and here is where you can see
it go to details i don't think there's
anything interesting here but you can
see there is some white listed stuff
here sometimes extensions have
additional options down below but
nothing uh super exciting here so we'll
just go ahead and close that and so now
what we have is this nice button oh
sorry i got a refresh wrong button sorry
and so again uh we can hit the get pod
button and so that's just going to save
us the trouble of having to type in git
pod i o i don't know if you saw it but
i'll close it again but watch here very
closely and click it and notice it not
bash hello world available be found
and i'm not sure why we're getting that
there must be something wrong here
it had the single quotes oh because this
is not name
okay
that's our problem so i kept on having
that init there and it was actually
trying to run it as a command so that
makes sense we'll say fix init commit or
fix
uh name of
task there
and we'll commit that
and so now i can just close that tab out
and from there i can just hit the button
again and that's a lot nicer because you
know every time you type it in at the
top it overrides that page where if you
click that button opens in a new tab
and that is a lot nicer
oh and by the way i didn't want to open
a running workspace i want to hit that
button and create a new workspace
okay
because we want to see if that git pod
yaml uh will work this time around
so we'll give it a moment here and we
can see there it is it's still saying
that do not commit that file
still says init
okay we'll save that maybe i did not
commit it
fix name of task
add that again
we will save that we will sync those
changes we will go ahead and close that
tab we'll hit the button again
and now we have two of those
environments so you can only run so many
environments in parallel and for the
free tier which i believe that we are on
we're going to hit that limit very soon
if we keep doing that but again those
environments will shut down after three
minutes if you want them to shut down
right away
um
you can go into your workspace and
terminate them i don't think there's an
option to terminate from here there's
only the option to stop
right which i think they should have a
terminate button but um you know that
might be something in the future
and so here it's
did is this not updating
am i crazy did i did i not launch a new
one so i'm going to go here and refresh
this page
it's still saying that okay
what am i doing wrong here
so we go here
name
save
right
we go over here on the right hand side
we're going to add it
i'm going to see what's been changed
init to name right and we'll just say
fixed name task
and i want to
commit
i'm going to go back here
refresh
and
there are no stage changes commit if
this happens because usually there's a
sync button i press it right away
so i'm just going to do git status here
um get push maybe
okay there we go so usually you hit that
sync button i'm so used to clicking it
so fast but just make sure that you push
it and then we'll go back here give this
a refresh
okay i must have not been pressing that
sync button if i go back to that video i
never knew what that that prompt was i
assumed it was like push or pull but if
that doesn't work for you just do the
push there and now i'm very confident if
we open this up it's going to have the
behavior that we want
okay so we'll just give it a moment here
and there we go okay so just be
uh
be wary of that i'm just going to want
to see if that actually prompts let me
say hello world again
we're going to add that and just say
miner change
and we'll save that yeah sync changes so
you really have to press that so this
action will pull and uh push and pull
requests two bits from origin so say
okay
and so that's probably what i wasn't
doing
um but yeah so we saw for chrome now
let's go take a look at firefox i'll be
back here in a second all right so i've
opened up firefox which is a different
kind of browser and what i'm going to do
is go ahead and sign into my github here
so what we'll do is just um type in
the username here is exam pro dev and
then i'll just put the password in there
we'll sign in
and i do not need that saved there so
we'll go into here and so notice we
don't have that button so on the gitpod
website we go to docs
and on the left hand side we are looking
for configure
or maybe it's getting started
oh integration sorry and then under here
we'll go to browser extension
and from there we'll click firefox and
we'll add that extension
we'll say
add and so now that extension is
available so we'll say okay
so let's go ahead and close that tab i'm
not sure what happens if we click here
so firefox prevented the site from
opening a pop-up we'll say options and
say allow pop-ups for git pod podio
and so it brings you to the login page
which is nice
but what i'm going to do is just close
out these tabs here and our button now
up here so we'll go ahead and hit click
get pod
and so we have the option so how do you
want to log in we're going to say github
and we'll just see what this looks like
i'm not going to be doing everything in
chrome but i just want to show you
uh you know that experience okay
so
there we go so we have hello world which
is uh very good same experience right
it's not going to be anything different
um you know it's just a different
browser um
and so you know i just want to point out
that
this will work in other ones as well so
maybe we'll take a look at microsoft
edge next okay
all right so now i have microsoft edge
installed this is the
i don't know if it's still the default
browser but it's the browser made by
microsoft and it's a chromium-based
browser so this extension work with
anything like chrome
microsoft edge brave anything it's
chromium based um and so what we'll do
is go ahead and sign into our github
account
so we'll go here and we'll just type in
example dev
because we just want to see if the
experience is slightly different and
then from here we'll just type in get
pod io
and from there we'll go to docs
and we'll go to integrations
and since we know that it's a chromium
chromium browser i'm assuming that if we
go here it should work
so it says you can now add extensions
from the the chrome web store to
microsoft edge which sounds really great
and so i go down below here and i'm just
looking for
um a place to add i don't see a button
here so allow extensions from other
stores
microsoft does not verify extensions
install from third party stores to get
um extensions verified go to microsoft
edge add-ons so let's go check out the
add-ons because this is the chrome store
and i'm sure it will work from here but
i'm just curious if it's in here
because it seems like if this is the
official way maybe we should go here and
see there so let's say git pod
dot io
and so i don't see it in here and so if
git pod if you're watching maybe you
might want to get this in here and i'm
assuming this is um
extensions because i see grammarly in
here okay but let's go ahead and just
say allow extensions from other stores
so it's permitted and so now we can say
add to chrome we're technically not
using chrome we're using microsoft edge
and so now we have that button there
notice that we actually get a button
whereas in chrome we don't if we do that
brings us just like how firefox does
and so what i want to do here let's see
if it's the same thing chrome
uh
extensions does that work ah it's edge
extensions which is fine so here you can
see it we turn on and off look at the
details very similar
but we'll go back over here and i want
to go to get pod hello world and we'll
click on git pod
and we'll have to log in with github
same story you know
and sure we'll launch the existing
workspace no reason to launch a new one
this one will launch really fast because
of it
and it's the same experience so yeah i
mean we could look at brave as well but
i think the process is going to be the
same
brave is just another browser um that we
can utilize okay but there you go
okay i decided to do brave just for fun
and so here i have the brave browser
open and we're going to make our way
over to github
and just see what we can do here and see
if the process is any different i'm sure
it's the same it'll be super unexciting
but let's do it anyway okay
so we'll say exam pro dev we'll go ahead
and paste that on in there
and so from here we can go to our
repository
oh and we need the extension right so
we'll type in git pod io
and from here we'll go to whoops docs
integrations
browser extension and we will click
chrome because it's a chrome based one i
don't know if like brave has like brave
add-ons
like their own extension store maybe
um
we'll go to extensions here
so maybe go to the web store here and it
just goes to google chrome so that tells
us that you know they don't have their
own store like microsoft does here or
add-on place you know we'll just say add
to brave we'll say add extension
there it is
looks the same
we'll go ahead and see if that button
exists there we'll refresh
we'll hit get pod here we'll say github
again
we'll continue with the same workspace
so it just runs a bit faster
and there we go so we've launched it in
chrome
within
firefox edge and brave
um i don't have safari on this computer
but
can we do safari on windows safari
windows
right
i think there is one so if there is
we'll give it a try but i mean we pretty
much exhausted all the browsers here so
you know if there's safari and i can
install it here i'll the next video will
be seeing if we can install with safari
okay
[Music]
okay i'm back and um i was thinking
about using safari but we can't install
it on windows anymore
and it'd be too hard to record on my uh
my mac computer so what i'm going to do
is just use opera instead and opera
has been a browser for a very long time
i'm not sure what they've been doing
with it but i have a strong feeling that
we will not be able to install
the chrome the chromium extension on
opera unless it actually is using chrome
underneath but let's go find out so the
first thing is let's just go to get
podio
okay
and
we'll first see if it
we install that chrome extension and
then we'll go log into our github as per
usual so we'll go to docs we'll go to
integrations
and from here we'll go to
extension
and
i think that it won't work here so we go
to chrome
oh
is
is opera
is opera a chromium browser let's go ad
extension see i didn't think it was
based off of chrome
well that messes up my whole example and
git pod you're going to have to say that
it works with
us and other chromium browsers so i
guess they kind of
got all those edge cases i was hoping to
find one that's not chromium based and
so now i really think that i really do
have to try it on safari to find out if
there is a use case there so i guess if
we go over to
our github now
i'm so disappointed that that that that
actually worked okay
um but we'll just type in exam pro
dev
we'll put the password in there
and we'll go see that there's a button
yeah the button's there great
so what browser
browser that is not chromium-based
uh windows
is there anything
see i don't know anymore like what's
pale moon best browsers that are not
based on chromium
pale moon web browser
never heard of this
really
film is an open source
browser
let's give it a try so what i'll do is
i'll just be back here in a moment and
we'll take a look at pale moon okay
because i just want to see a browser
that's not chromium okay
all right so unfortunately github does
not work with pale moon and neither does
git pod and so unfortunately we can't
use this cool new browser but we'll have
to do is go back to opera and pretend
that this extension never worked and
that we have a reason to use the
bookmarklet um and so what we'll do is
just bookmark this here in the top right
click here edit
say launch and get pod and then we'll
have to put that javascript here so
we'll type in git pod bookmarklet
all right and from here we have some
javascript we'll go ahead and copy that
make our way back here right click edit
if it seems like i'm going fast it's
because i've shot this video like four
times
and so i'm just hoping that it works
smoothly this time around but so we have
our button we'll go ahead and click the
get pod it might prompt us if we need to
authorize so just give it access if you
do and as that launches i'm going to go
ahead and copy this code so we can just
take a look at it
and so here we are i'm going to make a
new file here but you can see that it
worked no problem right um but i just
kind of want to show you the javascript
because it's really really simple
like you know it's just looking or you
get lab github get bucket and then open
this thing and so if we want to extend
this this is just javascript you can do
whatever you want with it so if we want
to do something fun like get pod and
vars
we can actually embed environment
variables into our url so down below
here we kind of have the syntax here for
doing that
okay
and so
i pretty much how that knows how that
works so we would just type in something
like
my env equals production
or maybe development
that make more sense
we'd have a forward slash because that's
how it works
and we go ahead and save that and then
we would go ahead and copy that just
make sure that's saved i'm going to
close that environment close this one
we're going to right click edit
and just paste in the new contents i'm
going to make sure that that is there so
i don't have to triple check and so
we'll hit save and now if we launch
gitpod that environment variable should
get passed along so it's just like a
kind of cool way to
modify it there's probably more
interesting things that we could do so
you could technically maybe write your
own contexts if you wanted to
um but of course get pot only supports
particular context so let's see if our
environment variable shows up here so
we'll just type in grep
my env grep is just a way of searching
okay and there it is we could type in
echo and type in my env and there it is
so there you go that is the bookmarklet
for when you cannot install chrome
extensions whether your browser does not
support it or whether your admins have
locked down your browser because it's a
workstation or what have you but there
you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at git pod configuration
files and so this allows you to
configure a workspace and so we say
workspace we're saying configure a
developer environment when it firsts
launch
so the gitpod configuration file is a
yaml file that must be named period get
pod period yaml so the period or dot
that's in the front there tells linux
that it's a hidden or secret file and
that's not so important but what's
important is that you remember to have
that dot or period in the front
and it needs to be present at the root
of your git repository you can only have
a single git pod yaml file so you can't
make a bunch of folders and then uh put
a bunch in there thinking you're going
to customize all those folders it's just
a single one and so here's an example of
a
gitpod configuration file we're going to
see a lot of different kinds throughout
this course but this is a very simple
one where it's installing dependencies
using yarn for javascript it's opening
up port 8000 and then it's going to
allow us to view the website inline in
the code editor so the following can be
defined in the gitpod configuration file
and so we're going to go look at a quick
list of the configuration options and
then we'll deep dive in upcoming videos
on all these options so the first is
checkout location so where gitpod checks
out the project's code which will
default to workspace git config so
defining a workspace git configuration
github.prebuilds configure the gitpod
github app specifically for continuous
pre-built and you can do pre-builds with
gitlab and bitbucket it's just that
github has some additional options here
we have image so define custom docker
image this defaults to gitpod forward
slash workspace full we have ports so
define ports exposed for public access
tasks so define a list of terminal
windows to be open and associated
scripts to be run when launching a new
workspace vs code.extensions a specified
list of vs code extensions to install
when launching a new workspace workspace
location so which path gitpod considers
the project's workspace default
directory and this will default to
workspace i could really use a comma
oops
i could really use a comma right here
but yeah those are the settings and we
will look at them in greater detail okay
hey this is andrew brown and we're
looking at how do we actually initialize
a get pod configuration file so to
initialize a git pod configuration file
there are two approaches the first is
very simple create a dot get pod yaml
file from scratch and just start filling
it in that's the way i generally do it
but they do have this convenience um cli
command called gpinit and this will
generate a
sample.gitpod.yaml file so this is what
it looks like um i don't find this
particularly useful but you know if you
find this easier to do than right
clicking and creating a file it's up to
you but i just wanted to know that both
options were available but in either
case you need to commit this dot
gitpod.yaml to your code base because um
you know it's not going to stick around
if you don't and we'll learn that as we
look at the iterative workflow okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and what we're
going to do in this follow along is look
at how to initialize a gitpod
configuration file of course we have
done this in a previous follow along but
let's just do it again for good measure
to make sure that we know how to do it
so i'm going to go ahead and create a
new repository i'm going to say git pod
and i'm going to call this
init so this will be to initialize
a
getpodconfiguration file
and then from here we can make it public
or private doesn't matter i'm going to
make it um
private
and we'll go ahead and add a readme file
and we'll create that repository
so here is a repository and i have the
chrome extension installed so i'll go
ahead and hit the get pod button
all right and so our workspace has
started now so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to open up terminal so i'll go
file up here the hamburger menu
i always say file but it's actually
hamburger menu terminal new terminal and
we'll give it a moment here to load and
so we'll just type in gp init and so the
gp init command is used for setting up
an initial get pod file and that's all
there really is to it again you can of
course just right click and create that
file you want and the key thing to
remember is that you need that period in
front of the uh get pod there for it to
work
um but you know we can go ahead and just
save this file and commit it just say
commit
initialize
a git pod yaml file
and that's all there really is to it
okay
so just say okay
and we'll go back here and just refresh
here
and we could launch this again just to
see the results here but you know
there's not much to here to see but just
remember that's gp init
[Music]
so when you're developing your gitpod
configuration file it is standard
practice to keep terminating and
launching new workspaces until you get
your ideal configuration so let's kind
of visualize what that workflow looks
like so the idea is you're going to have
this git pod yaml file you're going to
either be creating it or modifying it
and once you're happy with its current
state you're going to go and commit that
to your git repository once that is
committed you're going to terminate the
current workspace so that could just be
uh
telling it to uh delete or just closing
out the tab and then you're going to
launch a new workspace and you're going
to observe the start task did it do what
it was supposed to do we need to tweak
it and if it is uh requires more
tweaking we're gonna go back and modify
our git pod yaml file again and go
through this entire process until we're
happy with it and then we can just start
using our developer environment as
expected but what i really want to know
and this is what created a lot of
confusion for me initially is that
stopping and starting an existing
workspace will not produce the desired
results since the before and init
commands for a star task will not be
performed so there's an execution order
there's three things it's um
before init
and command and so the only way to
really make sure that your start tasks
like to be able to debug them or or to
develop on them is to always
terminate and launch a new workspace
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and in this
follow along we're going to learn about
how the iterative workflow works when
you are
trying to update your gitlab
configuration file many times to get to
the state that you want it to be in uh
because there is some confusion between
starting and stopping and terminating
and i want to make that very clear so
what we're going to do is create a new
repository here we're going to call it
get pod iterative
workflow
and i'm going to make it private for fun
we're going to call it a readme file of
course you can make it public but
you know doesn't really matter i'm not
going to launch gitpod right away i'm
just going to go ahead and add a file
just to save us a bit of time because
you know there is the stopping and
starting of those workspaces it takes
time and i just want to set up one with
uh tasks and we're going to just have a
task
for um
each state so we're gonna we're gonna
need it's before
a knit
and command and i'm just gonna do an
echo in each of these ones
okay so we'll do this
init
echo
before
all right so we have our three this
should all be fine we'll go ahead and
commit this file and now what i can do
is start up this environment and i'll
see you back here in a moment okay
all right so after a short little wait
there our environment has launched and
notice that it's ran before a knit
command so what is going to happen
if we um stop this environment so over
here we can do stop workspace
and what we'll do is we'll see what runs
here so just give it a second sometimes
it takes a moment to kick in for uh it
to stop
so just wait
and it looks like it's starting to do
something
there we go so it's going to stop
sometimes when i stop it might say
superficially like oh this workspace is
gone so just don't worry about the
getpod errors they're not always 100
percent accurate and they don't always
happen but you know just have confidence
of what you are doing
so this is going to stop and once this
is fully stopped
um and that doesn't usually take that
long we're going to start it up so i'll
just wait here a moment so i can show
you that i'll press the start button
again so here we go and we'll go ahead
and open this workspace again and i'll
see you back in a moment when the
environment has started up again okay
all right so after a short little wait
here it has launched again and notice
that it's running the before and command
so if we go back into here we have
before init command so anytime you
launch
a a regular workspace it's always going
to run
uh before a net command for the first
time but any restarts it's always going
to run before and command and you're
going to get used to this because when
we start looking at the execution order
steps between pre-builds
and without pre-builds you're going to
start to see this pattern
but what i want to do now is just to
completely terminate the environment and
so you know if you want to terminate you
can stop this current one if you're
worried about lots of parallel
environments running but what i normally
do is i just go ahead and close the tab
and in three minutes that environment
will shut down on its own
i don't know if gitpod really has an
option for
a terminating terminate i think you
always have to stop at first so if i go
here
i can i can delete it okay so if i want
to i can delete it here but again this
is nothing i ever think about i just um
close the tab and it goes away which is
really nice but what we'll do is we'll
launch a new environment so we'll just
click the get pod button
and see it thinks that this one's still
running we're gonna ignore it hit the
new workspace button okay
and sometimes i forget what i'm doing
and i might re-launch an existing
workspace so you just have to
be uh
considerate and think about you know
maybe i did this maybe i did that okay
and so i'll see you back here when this
is started okay
all right welcome back so you can see in
the case that we terminate it it runs
before and it command all right and so
this again is really important because
if you are trying to develop this and
you're doing multiple iterations you
really want to know that in it's not
going to run every single time so you
really always always always want to
just close the tab and then launch a new
workspace okay and so you know hopefully
that's clear and saves you some trouble
so there you go
[Music]
so the most important part to a get pog
configuration file in my opinion are the
start tasks because these define a list
of terminal windows to be open and
associate scripts to be run when
launching a new workspace so here is an
example
of and this is actually my marketing
website uh
of a git pocket configuration file and
so what's happening here is we have
three tasks defined we have one called
html so that's going to be running or
building out html files we have this
next one here for generating out
javascript and css and then it's going
to continuously watch
for changes and then we have a
task that will serve the website so we
can view it and then down below here
we're opening up port 3000 and then
we're going to
open it in the browser so when you have
that and uh
you start up your workspace you're going
to see these three tabs and notice that
the names match so we have html
js for css and serve and over here you
can see that it is a running
http server over here so a start task
has the following properties you have a
name so the name
that will appear within the terminal as
we can see there uh the before command
so a command that will run once at the
launch of a new workspace
uh the init command a command to run
once at the launch of new workspace
expects to terminate and i ran out of
room here but this one expects to
terminate as well but we will repeat
that multiple times in this course then
we have the command command which is
confusing to say when you say that out
loud but that's what it's called and
that runs at the launch of a new or
existing workspace and can be
continuously running so an example of
here we have that hp server it of course
continuously runs and then the npn run
watch that is something that
continuously runs then you have env so
this allows you to set environment
variables scoped for the task and we
have the open mode so how the terminal
window should be opened whether it's
going to be
tab after tab before split right
split left okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown we are taking a
look at executioner steps for tasks and
so a task has three possible steps in
its execution order uh and you could say
steps so you could say command i'm going
to call them steps because there is a
a step called command and then i'm going
to be saying command command that gets
confusing but we have before init and
command and so let's just kind of talk
about their application so for before
you're applying like configuration of
the environment before init or command
step runs and that will make sense when
we start seeing like how these run with
pre-builds or no pre-builds then we have
a knit so for heavy configuration
environments so compiling resources
installing packages
and then command so starting
continuously running servers like a
database or a web server
if that doesn't make sense don't worry
because we're going to look at these in
a few different ways and i was very hard
to kind of describe what these three
boxes are
but you know i think we'll just go
through that iterative process and we
will understand uh
absolutely before the end of this course
what goes in before a knit and command
so there is no guarantee of the order of
the execution uh for start tasks and so
when i say that i don't mean that
like there's a guarantee that it'll go
before a knit or command but when you
have a collection of those
like more than one task there's no
guarantee of that okay so you can have
terminals depend on the completion of
other commands via the sync await and
sync done and we will definitely look at
that in the course here uh there is a
guarantee of the execution order as uh
for before a net command for a task so
for the individual execution of of this
we just saw that will always be the same
okay so the execution order varies
in the case of when launching a new
workspace without pre-builds and then
when launching a new workspace with
pre-builds and we will look at those
right now okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and what i want
to do in this follow along is just to
kind of look at a practical example of
execution or steps so you can kind of
understand the context of when you put
something in the before the init and the
command and it's not like a perfect
science um and i think you just kind of
have to
figure your way through it and look at a
lot of examples but i'm just trying to
think of one where i know somebody is
using
um get pod in a more complex use case
and one would be something like forum so
i definitely know forum has a good pod
gamble file i think i was saying to them
earlier this week it was not working
properly but they may have fixed it
since then but we're not interested
really whether or not it uh like the
application works but more so the fact
that how are they using it like those
execution order steps so notice they
have a docket.yaml file in a
gitpoddocker file if you don't know what
form is form is this platform that
allows you to host your own
um
form essentially if you ever heard of
like dev.t.o like this here um this is
what this is so the great thing is we
can go ahead and hit our git pod button
and we'll just wait for this to spin up
and then once it's there we'll see if it
actually is working as expected if it
doesn't it's fine but what we're really
interested in is expecting that git pod
yaml file okay all right so after
waiting a little while here the
environment has spun up and so what
we'll do is just take a look at what is
going on there's a lot of things popping
up asking me to do stuff and so here we
can see that we have two tabs on the
right hand side so we have form server
bash open site gp
so what we'll do is go on the left hand
side here and take a look at the get pod
yaml file as soon as i can find it here
um
and if i can't find it that way we can
just hit control p i believe and just
type in dot get pod yaml
okay this is not specific to git pod but
this is just how vs code opens files
anywhere so instead of me having to look
through all these things i can just do
that so that is the file that i'm
interested in so we'll do is open it up
and so here we can see that they are
specifying a custom image which is
totally fine it's not going to make this
too confusing they have a lot of ports
open so 3000 30 35 5432 that's for
postgres i'm not sure what this is for
this is for the ruby on rails web server
this is for redis just because i know
these port numbers i just don't know
what this one's for so we'll go here and
we have some tasks and the first thing
they have
for this task is the form server
and they have a before and a knit and
command and so in there before what
they've decided to do is start up the
redis server uh then they are doing an
await port so they're waiting for 5432
to happen and then they're doing sleep
i'm not sure what the sleep is for
okay and so that means that um
until port is open then proceed forward
which is fine
and i'm not i'm not sure what a single
ampersand means unless i just remove
that by accident i don't think i did so
i'm kind of interested in what that does
um again assuming that you know i didn't
just introduce that mistake which i
don't think i did and then we have this
get pod init sh so they're running a
initialization script so this could have
a bunch of stuff in it let's just take a
look there
get pod
init sh
so here
they are copying an environment variable
installing a couple gems running been
set up and that's kind of nice where
it's like okay maybe you have a lot that
you want to run here so you just
abstract it out into there and then here
they run the bin startup command
okay and then down below they have open
site so it looks like they just do this
to force git pod to open it up and this
is kind of nice i didn't know you could
do this so i think when i did the follow
along i had something a lot more
complicated so i'm gonna have to go back
and
borrow that because that is definitely a
lot easier
all right so this one really just opens
up the site and this one is doing this
now what's interesting is that they
started the redis server here because
what they could have done is they could
have just made a separate task here
called redis server
right and from here
what they could have done is done this
on the
um
like command step
right and so
that's what i would have done i would
have said redis server and then if i had
a ruby on rail server i would have done
ruby on rails
okay
but that's not what they did so they
decided to put in the before command and
that's totally valid so that's just me
trying to say like it's not a perfect
science you have to decide if you want
to put something in the before or if you
want to make it a separate tab for me i
prefer to break it all up into separate
tabs and before is really designed for
um
you know like if you had to change ruby
versions or things like that at least
that's what i think it's for um but just
understand that you know it's gonna vary
for that kind of stuff and so you know
hopefully that gives you kind of an idea
for execution or steps we're gonna
iterate on this quite a few times so uh
we'll get it by the end of this course
okay
and by the way we are done here so we
can just go ahead and close that tab i'm
just gonna go back to my homepage there
and we are done
[Music]
so let's take a look at the execution
order steps when launching a new
workspace without pre-builds and what's
important here is that all steps will
run within the current workspace so
we've got before a knit and command so
let's talk about what we're going to use
these commands for so before
is great when we want to customize the
terminal install global dependencies and
we expect the commands to terminate so
an example here for the before would be
something like rvm or nvm so you're
switching to the ruby
ruby version that you want to use or the
javascript version that you want to use
so that's kind of an example there
and so for net we are downloading and
installing dependencies compiling source
code running your test suite
and again we expect our commands to
terminate so examples here would be
bundle stall yarn install rake db create
so what's happening here is we are
installing ruby dependencies javascript
dependencies creating our database for a
ruby on rails application possibly
and then we have our command so
the idea here is you're going to start
your continuous continuous running
servers you're going to run your build
scripts to build assets and this last
command can be continuously running so
here we are starting a rails server so
hopefully that gives you an idea what's
going on here but the reason why
uh these ones have to terminate is
because of pre-builds because
these will get pushed onto pre-builds
and you know you can't have something
continuously running or the pre-build
will never end but we'll talk about that
in the next slide okay
[Music]
so now let's take a look at the
execution order steps when we are
launching a new workspace with
pre-builds enabled so not all steps are
executed in the new environment so on
the left hand side it's going to look a
little bit different we're going to have
our pre-build environment which is only
going to run the before and init then
we're going to have the new workspace
that's going to run the before and
command and so the idea behind having
this pre-built environment at where it's
running the before knit commands it's
going to
create a snapshot that will be then used
later on when we launch our new
workspace environment to reduce our boot
time
so looking at our previous script there
we would do the before here so changing
our ruby version and then here we would
install our dependencies create our
database
and then down below in this new
workspace this is when you start a new
workspace with a pre-build it's going to
run the before and command so just
describing what we're doing with the new
workspace here the developer saves time
because they don't have to wait for the
length of the inits compile independent
libraries so that's just me redescribing
what i just said here after talking
about the reduced boot time so here we
would do the before again and then we'd
run our command
so it's really important to think about
the fact that these are isolate
environments because as you develop your
git pod configuration files you're going
to have to realize that
you know stuff is not going to carry
over to the next
workspace so if you do this rake db
crate and it populates a bunch of data
and you need that in your
workspace it might not be there
okay
so or like if you cd into
if you cd into a particular directory
right
um and you think that you're going to be
seated in that directory when you're
over here you might not be there so
that's something that you'll have to
play around with it's not too bad you
start to get uh get the idea but i i had
a script that i was using that was
before pre-build and it worked fine and
then when i moved to pre-build i had to
take in consideration that these are
isolate environments here and not
everything carries over okay so there
you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
talking about git pod configuration
files and specifically how to write
multi-line tasks so if you want to
perform a series of commands within a
task step there are several options
available of course you can do it as one
line and the way you would do it with
one line is you'd have to use double
ampersand i bet you could also probably
use a
a semicolon but double ampersand is
probably going to be recommended if
you're not familiar with double
ampersand the idea is that if this
command fails then it's not going to run
the next command okay but if you wanted
the next command to run
i suppose you'd have to use a semicolon
to denote the next line okay so if you
want to do multi-line what we can do is
use this uh
closing angle bracket and then followed
by the next lines you're going to have
to have double ampersand the reason why
is that when you use this uh closing
angle bracket it's going to take all
these lines and it's going to remove all
the new lines and treat it as a single
line so it's pretty much like writing
this but multi-line okay
and then we have this other one where we
use a pipe and the pipe will
add a new line so these will be
sequentially um
these will run sequentially in order and
generally in this case you probably
wouldn't use double ampersand because
it's not going to play well with that
new line and if you're wondering about
this like
angle bracket and pipe and you might
think that it is actually get pod
configuration file specific but it's
actually just yaml's multi-line syntax
so if you investigate on how yaml
multi-line works that tells you what you
can do here and there's actually more
you can do
um but you know i'm not going to show it
to you here because it's just start we
start to get in the weeds and it's not
use cases that are useful but just
understand that if you learn a bit more
about yaml you'll learn uh how you'll
have more flexibility with the git pod
configuration file okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and this follow
along i want to show you about
multi-line strings within git pods so
when you are creating tasks you can make
your life a little bit easier so i'm
going to do is go ahead and create a new
repo here and we're going to call it get
pod multi-line and i will go ahead and
make this a private repository
and so from here we will go ahead and
launch a new git pod and so i have this
tab open here called yaml
hyphen multi-line info because i want
you to understand that this multi-line
syntax is not specific to git pod but it
is part of um
it is part of yaml which is the language
we use
and so here on the left hand side we
have an example where it says replace
new lines with spaces keep new lines so
this is the difference between the
closing angled bracket and using a pipe
okay
so you know when we have a pipe it says
keep new lines so every new line that
you use will stay there replace new
lines with spaces meaning that it'll be
treated as one block of text so let's go
take a look and it looks like our
environment is ready i'm going to go
ahead and open up a new terminal as per
usual and we're going to run the git pod
init command to initialize a new project
so
there of course are a few ways we can do
this so the first is the fact that we
can just have and we're going to keep
playing with echoes because echoes are
easy
but we could say like hello and then
ampersand ampersand world
so this is a linux thing the double
ampersand and what it means is it says
oh nice it actually shows up here so get
fig a shell came in oh you know
what it's actually out of completing
this but double ampersand is a way of
um
running more than one command at a time
so they'll say okay i'm going to run
this command and as long as it doesn't
fail as long as it doesn't exit go run
the next command
okay so that would be that one there
and there's also uh the case of um and
you know what i'm going to do these all
under commands because i just want to
make sure this runs every single time
what i'm going to do is put command here
for this one i'm going to do another one
here where we're going to try to do a
semicolon so this uh this is something
you can do in again this is not specific
to git pod or yaml but like when you're
writing bash scripts
you can do semi semicolon to say this is
a the next command we want to run
all right
so we have this one where it should run
both
this one where it should run both and
the next one should succeed and then
here we will purposely introduce an
error so maybe if i just do uh x like
that which is not a real command it
should fail and not run the second one
all right and so this is multi
these are multiple examples let's do one
with a script so maybe we can load a
script so we'll just say um
hello world
okay so this might be another way that
we could do mult multi-line kind of
scripting here so we'll just say hello
world
as a file we'll say sh for a bash script
and then we'll do echo hello
world i don't know that will print out
to the screen but we'll see what happens
there i'm sure it will still work
and we'll just say sh we'll have to make
that executable down below so i'm going
to type in chamod u plus x
hello world if you're wondering like
what does that mean it means make this
executable so that we can run it like
that
and so
we have semicolon double ampersand
double ampersand with a purposeful error
and then we also can do
uh this way so that is the
angled bracket and so we are going to
want to
do hello here
and then ampersand ampersand world
because if we don't do that
if we don't put the double ampersand
when we're doing the double angle
bracket what's going to happen is this
is going to translate
into this right and that would cause an
error because it would think there's no
you can't have a second and third
argument think it's calling echo and
these are arguments to echo that
wouldn't work so that's where we need a
double ampersand whereas if we do this
okay
we can do that and this is going to be
the equivalent of basically doing this
up here where it's like this is a line
and that is a line of execution
so i think this is everything that
should work i'm not sure what kind of
problems we're going to run into but i'm
going to just close out the rest here
and we'll go ahead and commit this to
our repository here and the great thing
is because these are all commands
uh we can start these over and maybe it
might be smart to give these names
so i'm just going to go here and say
name this will say semi semicolon
okay we'll go to the next one here and
this one's going to be
double
ampersand we'll go to the next one here
and we'll say
double maybe just double amp because
it's getting too long here double amp
fail
i wonder if we could just do this
you know
i don't see why i can't be named that
that might just be easier
okay and this would just be double
ampersand and then we'll do semicolon
here
and then this one will be
bash script
and you know i didn't do a shebang here
i don't know if that's going to cause a
problem i'm going to put a shebang in
there just in case i'm going to say
where is um
sh or bash
okay a shebang just means tell the
script to run a particular way shebang
is the
is this thing so say run in the context
of that so i'm just doing that just in
case
and so we will name it that
and then here we will do this multi-line
so you can say multi-line multi-command
is what we're learning here and so these
are all the variants that should be
possible here
and i'm hoping they all work the first
time around here because that would be
really nice but this is our file right
so these are all the different kinds of
cases you could do
and so we'll go back over here and we're
just going to go ahead and oops add
these two files so we'll add that
and i want to stage that as well we'll
just say
commit multi-line
we'll go ahead and add that there
all right and so now that's all
committed and in order for this to
execute we can terminate this
environment or just stop and start it
since we know how it works so we know
command will run again so that's what
i'm going to do i'm going to
stop this environment
and then we'll let that shut down and
then we'll start it back up and
hopefully they all just work first try
i'm writing quite a bit so i'm not sure
if i'm making any mistakes there
okay so we're ready to go here it says i
didn't uh commit a change maybe i didn't
so if it doesn't run that's fine but i
think that it will because the file is
in there
okay so looking here it looks like it
didn't execute those so i guess the
problem here is we're really going to
just have to um make sure these are
committed so let's say git push here
okay and then we will stop it again
see i'm surprised that i would have
thought that it would have executed
um even if it wasn't committed if it was
just lingering changes but we'll see
here we'll open it again we'll see if
that's the case
all right and
did it work
so it didn't do
anything new
so i'm kind of surprised
i'm just double checking to see i don't
have any syntax mistakes so i'm really
surprised that stopping start didn't
work in this case
maybe it's because none of these uh
these are initialized so probably if we
had
completely terminated and started it
again and maybe starting stop it would
do it again so i think that's what i'm
going to do i'm going to just
um because the thing is that when you
stop and start it's it's
redoing the state right so if those if
those terminals don't exist it probably
doesn't have anything to launch into i
think that's just an edge case that um
until now because i'm trying this now i
didn't realize which is totally fine so
we'll go ahead and close this tab we're
going to just refresh here as a sanity
check to make sure that stuff is in
there we're going to go launch get pod
again okay
and this is the reason why it's not
working unparsable get pod configuration
yaml cannot be read block mapping entry
a multi-line key may not be an implicit
key
so the problem is
the problem is i have invalid yaml so if
that's the case i need to have a way of
validating my gamble so maybe we'll say
like validate yaml
vs code maybe there's like a plug-in
so there's this um i kind of feel like
this would already have it but let's go
take a look and see if we can find it
here
like do we already have yaml installed
like is this already installed see it's
already installed
and so i'm not sure
there probably is like a validate right
enable or disable this feature validate
it seems like it should be validating it
and um i already forgot what the error
was
so let me just take a look here
i wonder if it's just the indentation
here
okay i'm just going to carefully look at
this here
for this we don't really need the name
well i probably have the names i don't
know these are messing it up so
sometimes i'm using single sometimes
using doubles
i'm just going to do this here
and so i think it was that indentation
so what we'll do is we'll recommit this
file here
all right so
fix get pod yaml file and that could
have been the reason why it wasn't doing
that but i still think that um those
terminals aren't going to launch unless
you um already have stuff open there so
while that's going i'm just going to
read here a little bit okay
so here's validation detect whether the
entire file valid is is is valid
so like see here they have like hotkeys
so that you know if you're making a
mistake but like
there's nothing there that was telling
me that it was valid or not so
yeah there's something going on there
but uh oh maybe we'll just um we got to
stop this workspace so what we'll do
now this is saved we'll go back here
we'll give this a refresh we'll make
sure that our git pod yaml has been
updated with the indentation we're going
to launch this again we're going to see
what error we get if we get any error at
all
it looks like we don't have any trouble
this time so great so let's go take a
look
and see what our results are
so the first one is our first task here
where we're using the semicolon
and it is saying here um hello world so
we can use the semicolon works just as
we expected it to then we have the
double ampersand so again double
ampersand means if this one fails the
rest will not complete so that worked as
well then we go here
we'll notice that it failed on the first
one and then it didn't continue on to
the second one so that is really good
that's what we expect
and i guess like if we did the semicolon
one i really didn't show that there i
should have done this
like fail
and maybe we'll rerun it just so we can
view that afterwards then we have the
bash script so it's using the bash
script that is over here so that is
another way we could do it
then we have the multi-line this way so
that was valid so that worked out fine
and then we have this one here so i just
want to show you that if you take these
two out this is going to fail
okay so i'll just write fail and maybe
we can just add it in as an extra one
whoops
so what we could do is go here
i just want to show you if you do this
one this one will definitely fail okay
if we take that out like that
it should and we'll go back up to our
semi-colon one and this one should fail
as well so
we will give that a go one more time and
um
i'm going to terminate just just in case
so we'll just say
update gitpod.yaml file with more
examples
of multiline
i don't care if it's over the length
it's fine for me we'll sync those
changes very important to sync
we'll give it a moment to sync great
we're going to close it again and we'll
just look at those edge cases there just
one more time okay
and so it's just launching up here
all right so we have a few edge cases
let's go this one
so this one said hello x command not
found but notice that it executed world
so it didn't stop on the first one so
you go here look it stops on the first
one but with a semicolon it won't so
that's a consideration for you and then
we did the multi bash one and it we have
hello echo world so it didn't um
it didn't crash but it treated like this
was the entire string so you can kind of
see you kind of got a wonky result so
hopefully that shows you how multi-line
works and there's obviously a lot of uh
options for you there and we'll just
close that off and we are done
multi-line
[Music]
so let's talk about awaiting tasks
within git pod configuration file so get
tasks all executed in parallel so by
default there is no guarantee
of the order of execution of the overall
tasks okay but there are a couple of
ways we can force a guarantee of the
execution order and the first way is
when we want to wait for command
and so
get pod has a cli and they have two
commands called sync await and sync done
so here we have an example
again it's a ruby on rails app um and so
if we look through here let's just try
to find where we see synco weight so
we have this rails app that is starting
up and then we have webpack and it says
sync await for bundle okay
so it's waiting for this command up here
to finish because if bundle install is
not done we should not run
um this command here
right and the same thing for redis and
for sidekick until this command up here
runs should it proceed
but the way it knows that it's done is
that you run this um sync done over here
okay so
just erasing all that stuff because i
know it gets kind of messy but the idea
is the idea is gonna stop and it's not
going to proceed until this has been
triggered okay and that goes for all the
tasks and so that's a way that we can
force
uh the order of these tests now there's
another way and this is where we want to
wait for a port so this is where we use
a weight port and it doesn't have like a
a weight or like done port or thing like
that but the idea is that let's say we
have end-to-end testing that we want to
implement and we want to run those tests
but it has to have a running server on
port 3000 so the idea is that it's not
going to run mp on run tests until
there's something running on that port
and so when you start up npm run dev
it's going to ask you hey do you want to
open this port you're going to open that
port it's going to see that it's running
and then it's going to run your tests
and so those are our two options there
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and in this
video we are going to take a look at um
things where we can await for things
okay so what we'll do is create a new a
repository i'm going to call this one
gitpod await since we can await a port
or wait a command and so down below we
will go to private and we will choose
readme and we'll create this repository
and we'll go ahead and launch this uh
workspace we might pull up the
documentation here so like a waiting
command get pod here
and so if we go over here
i'm not sure if it'll show up under here
because that's where these commands show
up like a weight port and things like
that
so here we have gp await port 3000
things like that
so i'm not sure if they showed an
example here
um but we definitely saw one earlier
when we were looking at form so if we
just want to go back to form for a
second
which
had an example of a command i believe or
maybe it was a port
i don't think it had command a
which is not a big deal i have an
example within the course here so we can
down below this has a gp await port
so not necessarily the other one but
let's go over here
and so something we can do we'll just go
and open up our terminal as per usual
we're going to type in gpnet to
initialize a new task so we don't make
any mistakes here
and so
what i'm thinking here is
let's do a weight command and
what is it called a wait
uh sync await
and sync done that's what we want to do
apparently they have a real world
example so let's take a look here
actually i want to do a ruby on rails
application
so here's an example where they have a
ruby on rails application and they're
kind of waiting for that those kind of
steps i don't know if they have like a
quick start for this um probably would
have been good if there was like a get
pod example here but what we'll do is
we'll just kind of make up our own
example from this all right so what we
want to do and i think ruby's installed
here if i type in ruby v it is great so
with ruby you have a thing called gem
files
okay and that's just a way of doing uh
versioning
and gem files are done via bundler so
bundle generate gem file
i'm not sure what the command is i
usually just write it by hand and copy
out code but i wanted just this kind of
information
so that's all actually all i wanted for
the file i thought maybe like a
generation command allow
and so here what we can do is install
some gems
uh very popular gem would be something
like pry that's for like debugging uh
and we don't necessarily need to use it
for anything it's just the fact that
it's going to be here we're also going
to need a now we don't need a docket
ignore file it's totally fine so what
i'm going to do is do a bundle install
here oops
bundle install and that's going to
install our dependencies here then we're
going to get a gem file so we can commit
that to our repository
but the idea is that
i want something
to wait on the gem file first
so
and i wish i kind of had an idea of some
kind of
gem that would have been useful for this
case but
actually you know what would be useful
it would be sinatra so instead of doing
pry i think we'll do sinatra
sinatra sinatra is a micro framework for
um web applications for ruby sinatra
it's a really great way of learning how
to work with web servers ruby not the
singer but the singer is fine too
and we'll go here and so this is the
most simplest example of a sinatra
application so if we go over here
and we
paste in our sinatra application into a
new file here so just say
server.rb
we'll just paste on that code
and so we'll need to put sinatra in here
instead we don't need the pry and
there's some way to start it up on a
different port
i haven't done this in a while so i'm
not sure
um
[Music]
documentation i thought this would have
been like
different port different port
port support sports how do we change the
port
okay
sinatra
ruby port change
okay so down below here set port so you
can't you just set the port like that
note that this is another way to bind
the socket so configuration is what
we're looking for
um so
here it is okay so here we can change
the port
and i'm going to set this port to
stop pasting right now so we'll say set
port 80
80.
just going to double check to make sure
that is correct
the syntax there's a comma in between
okay
okay and so that is the port there
and we have our gem installed which is
great and so i'm going to actually have
to do a bundle install again because i
actually got rid of pry
i'll give that a moment there to install
and so what i want to do with this
task here
is
i want to have one i mean like you
wouldn't do this generally because you
could do it all one command but i'm
gonna do one where i install the
dependencies
so we'll say bundle here
and then this one will be like um
server run
all right and so here what i'm going to
do
is init
and i'm going to just say bundle install
and then for this one down below
instead of a net we're going to just do
command
and here we want to run sinatra so it
has to run in the context of bundle exec
because that's how it knows it's going
to run
that there and we'll do server.rb
and so this one we want this to be open
on port 8080
all right
and
that looks fine i think i might want it
to
also open
as well so
let's go over here we saw this in forum
earlier which i thought was really cool
i didn't know that you could use it this
way so i kind of want to give that a go
here
and we'll just say command
and so the idea here is i want this to
open this on port
um
i'm just trying to think if there's
anything else i need to do because this
isn't going to this server is not going
to go to that url so i might have to
also do
this
which is i need like a forward slash
here i'm not sure how i would i would
how i would join that
so i'm not sure let me see here i wonder
if i can do this
what's this do
okay but can i do
this
i'm not sure if we can just do that like
that
so just to make our lives a little bit
easier what i'm going to do is go over
to the server here and just change it to
frank says here
because that'll just be a lot easier for
our example
and
so we have the port open it's in preview
this one's going to launch it so just
open it up
open preview here
and i'll just put this on the same line
here we don't have any issues there and
so i think this is what we want um but
the problem is is that there's no
guarantee that the bundle install is
going to happen
before the server runs and so let's just
go even though i know this is going to
break i want to go ahead and add all
these files here
okay
and just say like init file
and i'm just gonna double check to make
sure that actually serves something this
is gonna serve text which is fine and so
what we'll do is commit all that
sync the changes
and while we're waiting on that what
we'll do is go ahead and close this tab
here and we'll go ahead and relaunch and
we'll see what happens
all right so here we are and so let's
just see what has happened here
um so we go to bundle install it did the
bundle install which worked out great
and notice here it says bundle install
to install is missing gems so could not
find sinatra 2.10 stuff like that so
it's possible that this ran
after this so this might have executed
first because this is a very lightweight
it would take two seconds to run and
this would take a little bit more time
to install so i just wonder if we were
to go back and execute this command
would it work so it is working so that
is where this sync awaits going to be
very useful for us this didn't open up
for us here unable to connect to the vs
code server error in the request
i think this is also because the port
wasn't ready
all right so what we're going to do here
is we are going to go back to our get
pod file here
and we're going to use this sync await
thing
so here
um
and we probably use port as well but um
it's gp sync await
so what we'll do is say gpsync await
and for this we want this to wait for
the bundle so i'll go here put this on a
new line
and we'll paste that in on there so that
will just cause it to block
and the way we decide that it is done is
we would go up here to the init
oh by the way we need to oops
i have i put the caps key on by accident
um
but we will need to make this multi-line
and then we'll have sync
done and we'll just say bundle
or
maybe like bundle
this would be bundle
to be specific we should say bundle
install so it's just waiting for this to
finish first before it does that and so
this should kind of resolve our issue at
least one of our issues so we'll go back
here we'll add this here assuming i
wrote this all right we don't know until
we do it so
add sync
await and sync done
and we'll go ahead and save that there
we'll go back over here
and
um we will sync those changes we'll say
okay
and what i will do here
now that i've synced the changes we'll
just go ahead and close that tab and
reopen and see what happens there
because we do have an init there so if
we were to stop and start we wouldn't
get exactly what we want
all right so it's starting back up here
so let's go see it actually all worked
which is great but we go over here to
bundle saw that worked and then that
executed and this happened to work
okay but if we keep on running this
there's probably a chance that this
might not
work because
the port isn't ready
so i was kind of hoping that this would
fail
um and i think the only way we could
make this fail probably is if we just
put it in a sleep here
so what i'll do and i think sleep is for
every single second is i'm going to just
write sleep
and put 10 seconds okay and so that
should sleep long enough that we should
see this fail
so we'll go back here we'll add it so
sleep a while
i wanted to say like hey this port isn't
ready what are you doing you know
so go back here
and then from there we'll go back close
that tab we'll open that up again
and we'll give it a moment and we'll
spin up here in a bit
great so
now that we are here um let's go take a
look and see what's happened and it
still worked
so it's it's still executing well
actually down below here it says unable
to connect to vs code server so i'm
wondering if it's because we have um
this option here
right so
it's opening
because when the port became available
it opened
so i'm thinking i'm just going to go
ahead and remove this
let me take out the on open because this
would notify by default
so what if we put this to ignore say
ignore here
again i just want to see that this
doesn't open and then we have this here
and then if if we take if we put in the
portaweight it will work properly
so say uh one more time
i mean clearly this is airing out so
that's no good but it's still open and
that just because git pod is smart
so we'll go there and we'll go ahead and
close that we're going to reopen our git
pod here
and so that errors out which is totally
fine that's what we kind of expect to
happen and now it's not opening up the
preview so now i think we have our
opportunity
to
put in the um that other command which
is the port await
so what i'm going to do is go grab this
command here
and we're going to go down below
and we're going to expand our command
here whoops
and so my expectation is that it's not
going to run this command until the port
is ready see i don't know if we need
like a double ampersand but i'm pretty
sure this waits until the port is open
so i'm going to say port 8080 here
and what we'll do here is go back
and we'll add this here and we'll say
update gitpod yaml
and we'll save that and we'll save those
changes
and um what we'll do is we'll go close
this tab again and we'll launch it one
more time
great and so what we're going to see
here
is this is a waiting till the port is
open remember this is sleeping right and
look now it works so we made a great
example where we're using both a weight
port and a weight sink so there you go
so that's that's what you'd use with
those things and we're all done here so
we can go ahead and just close your tabs
and that's it
[Music]
so to understand git pod ports we need
to take a look at computer networking
ports
so ports and and that's the short way of
saying just ports acts as a separate
channel for communication protocol so
you have more than one program using the
same protocol and tcp the protocol we
use for websites and web server has 65
535 ports and some ports are designated
for specific types of communication and
others are undesignated where we can use
them for whatever we want so for
designated uh ports ones we absolutely
should know is port 80 so hcp
443 for https
22 for ssh and the way these are used is
the port number is uh will follow an ip
address or domain name separated by
colon so here's an ip address and we
have port 8080 and so we have the ip
address here and the port number there
in a web browser you can write the port
number in the address but generally you
won't see it for websites because it
just shows up by default so if you're
doing http colon
slash it already knows that it's port 80
and if you're doing https colon slash it
already knows that it's port 443 so
that's why you don't see them there
usually so there are many undesignated
ports which can be used to view or serve
web applications for the purpose of
development uh and the popular
development proto uh ports being three
thousand three thousand and one eighty
eighty eight thousand eighty eighty one
and so three thousand and three thousand
and one is very popular to break ruby on
rails why is there 3000 ones just
because like if you're using 3000 you
need a second server you have that
that's why you see it with 8081 or 8001
as well 8080 8000 are very popular in
the uh
with javascript uh web servers but these
are the ones you normally see and
probably what you should use because
there's a lot of synergies with a lot of
technology that are already defaulting
to these ones so when we're talking
about ports in common language it's
common to say things like i'm listening
on port you know or i'm serving on port
what have you right so just understand
when you're saying listening or serve
it's pretty much the same thing
um
and same thing with like opening port or
exposing port means the same thing just
so you understand uh you know those
there okay
[Music]
so now that we know what computer
networking ports are let's take a look
at git pod ports so in order to view
websites or web applications in a web
browser running a workspace tcp ports
need to be accessible and goodpod allows
you to open ports so you can uh set
ports in your dot get pod yaml file your
gitpod configuration file so there we
are opening up port 8080 in that example
uh and so then once your workspace
launches you can go to the remote
explorer and you remember what the
remote explorer is because i definitely
will ask that as an exam question but
once
um the port is uh uh open then you can
go over the remote explorer you can see
that there's a port there so here we see
port 3000 it's open it's private there's
like a button to open in the browser or
inline in the code editor um but if you
don't define ports ahead of time and
that's totally fine if you don't if you
start up a service on a new undefined
port gitpod will prompt you if you want
to open the port and so you just press
the button and we'll open the port and
even after that it'll probably ask if
you want to launch it in the browser
um but yeah that's all there really is
to it gitpod cannot use ports that are
lower than uh 1.024 so common ports like
port 80 443 ssh you cannot open those
ports and really you shouldn't be
because this is a developer environment
and port 80 443 or for serving
production
websites or web servers and i just want
to reiterate you don't have to define
ports ahead of time you can open new
ports on the fly okay
[Music]
so let's take a look at some of the
configuration options when we are
defining ports so we can do a port range
so three thousand two eight nine nine is
uh nine this example here of course we
can have a single value as we saw in the
previous video
we have opening behavior so this is
where we define on open and has four
possible values so notify which is the
default and when it says show the
notification it's that notification that
says hey how how do you want to handle
this port do you want to
open it in a preview do you want to
expose the port like what do you want to
do with it so we have the open preview
option so open the preview on the right
open browser so open in a browser tab or
ignore so don't do anything
then you have port visibility and so by
default it's going to be set as private
and so we have private which is the
default this only allows users with
workspace access to access the port the
reason i highlighted that was actually
for my own notes because i don't know
exactly what that means but we'll find
out in the follow along because i want
to know like does it mean that only i
can use it or if we like if we have a
team and somebody's within my team only
team members can access it so that's
something we'll have to explore then
there's public so allow any everyone
with the port url to access the port so
there's an example of visibility so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at port forwarding so what
is port forwarding or also known as port
mapping is an application of network
address translation a nat that redirects
a communication request from one address
and port number combination to another
and that's basically the wikipedia
description but uh to simply put
port forwarding sends traffic from one
port to another essentially acting as a
port alias so using the getpodcli
command forward port you can send
traffic from one port to another so
here's an example of me uh forwarding
the port at 80 80 to 80 oh sorry it says
forwarding 80 81 to 8080 okay and so
some programs will start on a hardcore
coded port and will not let you change
the port so port forwarding is a way to
work around this issue so that's the
major advantage of port forwarding
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and welcome to
another follow along this time we're
going to be looking at all about git pod
ports of course we did cover a weight
port but we might just cover it again in
here just because we are going more
thorough into the
port section of the core so i'll go
ahead and type in git pod ports i'm
going to add a readme it could be
private and what we'll do is go ahead
and type in git pod ports here
and just pull up the documentation just
in case we need it so we can set ports
within a range we can set a single port
things like that and then we have a
bunch of different kinds of um
things that can happen like the modes
that should happen
so what we're going to do here is launch
this new get pod
okay
and we'll just give it a moment here but
you know just looking over the on open
ports you have notified so show the
notification by default open preview
open in the preview on the right open
browser so open in the browser tab
ignore don't do anything so we'll
explore um because this is part of ports
and so i guess we can cover all these
options here for fun
and so as always we'll go up to our
hamburger menu we're going to go over to
terminal new terminal and we'll go ahead
and type in gp init and from here
we're going to need some kind of server
so i'm going to go server.rb
then we're going to go grab sinatra
again so we'll say sinatra ruby
and from here um i'm going to go grab
this code right on the page that makes
it really easy
and we'll say allow
and then we're going to need a gem file
so just say gem
file and i'm just going to say like a
knit gem file
bundler because oh there is a bundle in
it
generates a gem file well let's let's do
that because i'm getting tired of
looking up the first command here
so we'll say um bundler init
all right and so that's where we get
that uh that front line that we wanted
there
okay and this is useful too to have the
github thing here so but we'll just go
here and say gem
uh sinatra sinatra
okay we'll do a bundle install whoops
bundle install i like doing bi it's my
shorthand for that and so now we have a
very simple web server i'm going to
modify this slightly because i want it
to take in environment variables
so i'm going to just go here and
make a double quotation this is
interpolation in ruby and so i can just
do env square braces and we'll say
message
and we'll say says
oops
i'm able to say port
so say frank says
from port
okay and so that way we'll be able to
pass that along and kind of set that we
also need to set our
port here so we'll say
port colon and then we'll just do env
for passing along a environment variable
um we should probably make this a little
bit more flexible just say app port
because i don't know if there's like any
underlying port so let's just do that
just in case
and from there we have a simple
application and so that should work no
problem and the way we can test that is
by typing bundle exec actually before
that we have to set our port so we'll
just say
port
and i will just put a space here or
maybe double ampersand
and we'll say
uh
ruby server
and so that started up on port 8080 just
double checking here to make sure that
it's not just the default port here
so that's starting up on port 8081
i don't think it's oh you know what it's
because i'm not setting app
port like this
okay still not taking the right port so
i'll take out the double ampersand
and there we go so sometimes you got to
play with it a little bit so that is how
we're going to be doing that so go over
to our git pod gamle file and we don't
know which port we want to have open as
of yet
well actually we might want to set them
all there
um so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to go up here and we're going to do a
bunch of different ports
because i want one for each of the types
of things we can open here so we have
notify open preview open browser ignore
i'm gonna go just grab these for here so
we can save ourselves some time
we'll drop those in there and from here
we'll have port
port 8001 port 8002
port 8003
and we'll have this on notify which is
the defaults
we'll have this one on preview
open preview then we'll have this one on
open browser
and then we'll have this one on ignore
okay
so there we have all the the cases there
and then up here we're just going to
have our ports we'll say 8 000
and our command we do need to initialize
this stuff
so
what we'll do because we need to have a
i think that's going to do bundle
install so up here we'll just do bundle
install
and we'll do an init here and we did
learn this um a moment ago where we had
the bundle install and then we
oops bundle install and then we had our
gp
sync await
and we'll just say bundle install here
because we these are all going to have
to wait for that stuff to be installed
for them to work
and we'll take out the command here and
then we'll do our app port so we'll say
app
port equals 8000
bundle exec
rubyserver.rb
and from here we also want to wait so
let's say gpsync
done
i guess this would actually be the wait
so that one would be the done
so we go down up here or over there
and so that's going to be on port 8000
this one's going to be on port 8001
this one's going to be on port 8002
and this one's going to be on port 8003
all right
so we have a bunch of different uh ports
there so that'll give us a four and they
all are going to launch in different
ways
so that looks pretty good hopefully i
didn't make any mistakes because we did
write quite a bit here
um but i think that's okay so what we'll
do is go over here
and we'll commit all these files
and they look like they're all committed
so we'll say um set up a bunch of
servers
and we'll commit that sync the changes
we'll say okay
and then from there what we can do is go
ahead
and we have a get get uh yeah there's a
lock file there so that's great so we'll
close that off and we'll go ahead and
reopen that okay
all right so there is should be a string
uh
so i really wish i knew how to validate
the yaml beforehand
so like i don't know what vs code
extension i need there but like maybe
there's like yaml validate
i can see like in this linter here maybe
i get this nice ad on the right-hand
side so i'll reopen that up and we'll
just see if we can spot the problem
let's say that's like my only
frustration it's probably there is a
tool involved and i just don't know you
know
so i say copy and then i'll paste this
in here and we will then say go
says it's valid yaml yaml so there's
something that
it doesn't like
so we'll have to just closely look at
this here so we have a net that looks
fine we have the command here
that looks fine
so i'm not sure what it doesn't like
so we'll do a sanity check and we'll
just kind of simplify it so i'll just um
go here and comment this out for the
time being
and same with here
okay so
oh you know you know what it is
it's probably um this because it starts
with a number
so i'm just going to do this and maybe
that will fix our problem because i
think it's it's like equating as a
number as opposed to a string
and we probably just wrap it as a string
whoops maybe not those
but that's probably our problem so we
will try this again
it's good to know
fix names of tasks
we'll sync those changes
we'll say okay
and from there what we'll do is close
this tab we'll go back here we'll say
get pod
and so we'll wait here so frank is open
up 4801 so this looks like it's working
correctly let's go ahead and close some
of those tabs so here's a thousand
here's a thousand one two three and so
one is opened up in here
um but like the other ones didn't open
up so maybe you just can't have multiple
ones it's like one or the other but like
i would have thought that um
if this was set here
open browser it would just automatically
open up a page maybe that's not the case
but if we go over to the remote explorer
here we just kind of hover over here it
seems like we can open it in preview or
this kind of stuff so i'm not really
sure why that doesn't work as we think
it does
but it's not really a big deal and i
don't even know if we ever saw that open
as the browser like that before so
anyway that kind of gives you an idea
like this one probably prompted us and
we didn't notice as we clicked through
there but just kind of showing you how
you could set them all let's now go
switch this to a range so instead of
doing this we can say port 8003
and i'm just going to switch them all
over to open browser i just want to see
if they actually do open here and so
this will allow us to do a port range
okay so that should work no problem
open up a port range
we'll go ahead and commit that we'll
sync those changes we'll say okay
and by the way like i think down below
here it actually shows you what ports
are open so if you click this down below
i know it's hard like look where my
mouse goes all the way down here you can
uh see the open ports but they're also
going to be down here in the remote
explorer and you can make it public or
private and things like that over here
these are all private right now
um so what i'm going to do here is just
close this tab
relaunch this and then we're going to
see make sure the range ports works of
course it's going to work delicious dude
anyway just to make sure
and so there we go we have
what went to those horse open
which are good again browser didn't open
so
i don't know what the point of
this is like if it doesn't open right
away i don't understand but um or it
could be you know what it probably is oh
so it has been this entire time we just
have to say always allow the pop-ups and
redirect okay
and so now probably if we were to
relaunch this they would all open up so
that's what i'm going to do i'm just
going to do this one more time
i'm going to make a new workspace
because we need to run the init again
actually probably don't we probably
could have done a start it would have
worked because they're all commands but
that's fine
and so
okay so basically because it changes the
url every time it keeps on blocking at a
so i think like what you'd have to do is
probably have like a wild star in here
so let me just take a look okay
so i think what we could do is we could
probably
go up here
and say add and then do wild card
and then do that
should allow us to do wild card
maybe like this
there we go we'll hit hit add
and now i'm going to do i'm going to do
it one more time and i think we can just
i'm going to just kill it even though i
probably can stop stop it uh stop and
start it again
um and i'm just going to say new
workspace
and so now they all open so that's
probably a good thing that we did there
for chrome and i guess i just never
noticed that and that kind of makes
sense now
but anyway so that is port ranges
um
you know there's a few other things we
probably can do let's just take a look
here so we did that there's private and
public i guess we never set that for the
ports
um and so we could explore that as well
i would probably have to go get another
account set up here to show you
um but maybe we can just will this down
to two so i'm gonna just take this down
back to two
and we can say
um private
but i guess it'd be visibility
visibility
which would be private
public
and i'm just going to get rid of that
port there we'll see go back to port one
and then this one will be private
okay
and so just looking at this here that
should work no problem i'm going to go
ahead and commit that so public and
private now
we'll go ahead and save that we'll save
those changes we'll say okay
and from there we'll go ahead and close
that
and we will
reopen the git pod and as that's going
i'm gonna have to open up another
browser so i'm gonna go get firefox here
so just give a second for firefox to
load
okay not now
nope just let me browse please and so
i'm just going to go off screen and log
into my github so i have more than one
github account and i have more than one
git pod here so
that will just take me a moment
you can see these ones opened here
and i'm just going to sign in off screen
here and i'll see you back here in a
second okay
all right okay so i have um uh firefox
open here on another github get pod uh
picapod account and so what i want to do
is see what i can share so if our
servers are running they are here they
both are
one is public and one is private and so
the one that is public let's go see if
we can bring it over here
so i'm gonna go ahead and paste that on
in here
so port 8000 works fine
and then we'll look at port 8001
and so i can't see port 8001 and so one
thing that's interesting is that
if
you have private they suggest here that
um only allow users with workspace
access to access this port
okay and so
what does that mean does that mean if
somebody is in the same project or does
that mean if you're just sharing it with
them so that's something we're going to
have to find out
so what i'm going to do in my gitpod is
i can actually create projects
here
and so i can create a new project
i don't list i don't think this will
allow for collaboration so i might have
to go to this one so
my new project here
and then from here i need to add a
member so i'll go here and give them the
invitation link which is on the other
side here
and then they're going to have to go
accept that
so i'm over here now
and did i accept it i didn't see like a
step to accept let's go back here and
refresh
uh
it didn't
oh looks like in my firefox i'm in this
account hmm
you know what i think it's because i'm
logged in the same account so what i'm
going to do is just log out here
because my github is another account
here and so what i'll have to do is just
kind of like launch any kind of
repository here this will take two
seconds
and i'm just accepting the
authentication there
okay and so now i'm going to try to
invite uh myself again
so we'll copy that
and we're just going to paste that there
and so i i just instantly clicked it and
i was added so there's no like do you
want to be a member which i think maybe
they need that but that's fine it's not
a big deal
and so we'll go back over here
and so now if i just refresh here
i want to find out is this one do we saw
this pod running yes we do
so if we go back over here in this other
screen here
this is i think the private one the 8001
does that work
no it does not and that's totally fine
so what i want to do now is i just want
to go ahead and create a new workspace
or sorry project
and we'll say um
or did we already have a project here oh
it's right here new project
oh sorry this is a team i called it my
new project i should have called this um
my new team so let me go ahead and
delete that team because that's just too
confusing
and we'll go here i'll say uh my team
my
i guess maybe these are unique names i
didn't know that so my
team exam pro co
okay there's no way that that name
exists and so we'll go back over here
i'm going to invite members and that
kind of makes sense why they might have
like the block lists which i didn't know
about before
um and so now i'm a member of that again
so we'll go here and we'll give this a
refresh
so i'm a member we'll go back over to
projects we'll make a new project here i
don't know why there's this e1777 but i
want to choose
any repository here the one i want
actually it's not any repository i want
this one here
so let's go back over here and let's see
why this isn't showing up search
repositories we'll say git pod
it's only showing
oh you know why it's set on gitlab so
we'll switch back
and we'll say github
and we'll authorize
and we'll authorize all
so now we can go and
bring in the reaper we want which is
the ports repo
and so if we go over to
the workspaces here there are no
workspaces so now what i want to do is
just close this off
and i want to launch
this
under here okay and if you do launch it
from here i'm pretty sure it's going to
open up in this workspace but just to be
sure i'm going to go do it from here
so yeah it is in the same workspace but
i'm going to launch a new one anyway
because i want to see again if i share
it with this account that's a member can
they see it
all right
so we'll go here and so 8001 is the one
that is the private one and so we'll
make a new tab here we're going to paste
that on in there and so they still can't
see it so just because you're a member
doesn't necessarily mean you can see it
so now what i'm thinking is that it has
to do with like sharing your screen
so what we'll do is we'll go over here
and we'll go to the share
and we'll say share
and now we're going to copy that to our
clipboard
and we're going to go ahead and
paste this on in here
okay
and so now i'm sharing so i have access
over here i'm going to refresh see if i
have access here
i don't which is fine but what i will do
is go to the left-hand side here because
these servers should be running
remote explorer
this one says it's private so i'm going
to open this in the browser
oh uh we'll say
is preventing this to open we'll go to
options here
we'll say always allow
whoops and so now it's showing up i
don't know if there's like a difference
between this one and that one if we go
back over to
[Music]
uh the one here
we open that in the browser
let me go back over here
okay so there is a bit of like
finickiness with this but you can see
that you know if you are sharing you
have access but just because they're a
member of that workspace doesn't
necessarily mean you can share that
private one so that's just kind of one
of those uh harder edge cases that i
kind of want to show you
um so that you just know what's going on
there
uh so now that we've figured out how to
do um
a lot of stuff let's do port forwarding
that'll be the last one here so imagine
you have a project where you have a
whoops
that's saying this this doesn't exist
oops
go ahead here and go back here so
imagine you have a project where you
don't have control of the actual
ip address and it's not showing me
anything here i'm gonna have to relaunch
this it's being funny
okay
and yes i want to just open the existing
workspace here
and so
that's great and so um it could be a
case i'm just going to stop the server
here for a moment
where
you need to
like we're not going to have this port
so if we don't specify any port it's
just going to start on port
8080 right so if i go bundle exec here
and actually i think we should probably
do this in our code
i'm just going to make a third one here
that's to a fixed port so i think it
starts on 8080. so we'll go here
and i'm just going to say default
i'm not going to specify any port
and then we'll go ahead and commit this
and we'll see if we can use the port
forwarding okay
so sync those changes we'll say okay
we'll wait a moment i'm going to go
close that tab we'll relaunch that
i'm not sure why it's doing a pre-build
because we don't have pre-builds turned
on at least i don't remember turning
them on
but for fun we'll take a look here so if
we go here to our project reports
oh it is doing a pre-build okay
so i guess as soon as we make a project
it becomes a pre-built i for some reason
i thought like pre-build you can turn it
on and off
and maybe you can but i don't see the
option there so
um the only problem with that is that if
it does a bundle install no it should
still work so that should be fine
yep so it's doing the bundle install
that's the pre-build
and here down below you can say don't
wait for pre-build i didn't know you
could do that but we'll just give it a
moment
i'll just see you back here when this is
done launching okay
okay so i'm just like sitting here
waiting for this to finish but i think
the thing is that it's already done
because it exited out of here so i think
if i just close that off and we go over
here we can see the pre-build is ready
and so now if i go and try to launch a
workspace
it should
work so we'll go ahead and we'll just
say new workspace and because that
pre-build is there it should load really
really fast
but yeah i guess i was just waiting
there for no reason
and we'll just give it a moment
and there we go so that was pretty fast
um and so i'm expecting uh this one to
go to the default one so if we go to
this tab here
we're going to notice that it's going to
start on it's starting
oh you know what because these are all
waiting for the bundle install eh
so none of them are going to finish
okay
so just to make our lives a bit easier
because this section is not about
teaching you about how to do pre-builds
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to go ahead and delete this
project if it's possible so we'll go
back up to the top here i'm just going
to go ahead and remove that project
okay and so that way that'll just make
our lives a lot easier so if i just
launch this it won't do pre-built stuff
and it will work as expected
so we'll give it a moment there
and so this one because it will do a
bundle install here
this should now
work properly
this task ran as a pre-build
oh
boy um
so i guess the thing it's not a big deal
i think the thing is that i just need to
modify this file because now if i modify
i don't know if it'll just like stop
using pre-builds so what i'm going to do
is just delete out these commands here
and we'll go here and just say
remove weights
because this will happen in the
pre-build right so we'll say this
assuming that it's going to do another
pre-build even though i've deleted the
project so there technically should be
no pre-builds now
and so i might have to recreate the
project which is totally fine we'll just
work our way through here and see what
happens okay
so we'll close that and i'm going to go
back here and just do git pod
because i don't know what it's going to
do
and so we have bundle install missing
gem so now it's not doing pre-builds
okay
so in this case that's where we want to
revert this file back to what it was
so i'm going to go back and write it in
because i i don't want to go back and
create the project so i'm going to say
um sync
done bundle install
sync
awaits
sync a weight sync await and so this
server is going to start up over here
and that's fine i just want to have one
for the port forward so
port forward there's not not going to be
anything going on here i'm just going to
say like command
echo
hello
and what we'll do is go ahead and commit
this file so we'll just commit that
update
and we'll sync those changes as per
usual
and we'll give it a moment then we'll
just go ahead and close that reopen this
and get pod
i think we'll have an easier time
all right so it's almost open here
now this is not even with pre-built it's
pretty fast but again it's going to
really depend on your use case
so um here we saw
these two up because the ports already
open they have the mode set up this
server is running
right so and this is running on port
8080 but imagine that you didn't want it
on port 8080 you wanted on something and
you know to be honest a better example
for this would have been port 80.
so i'm just going to do this
sorry i know i'll keep on modifying this
but if this is an accessible port that
doesn't make it a very good example
let's just say open on port 80.
and actually before that happens i'm
just going to start it up manually to
see what happens if it actually does
permission denied so i'd have to go here
and do like sudo
um
so we can't even start it on port 80.
i think we'll just stick with what we
have here so we'll go back and we'll
just start it back up again
okay and we'll just do port forwarding
so if we wanted to open up on a
different ports we'd just say
gp
port
or a ford port
i want to forward port 8080 to
8 999 maybe
and i think it's going the wrong way so
um port 80 is already in use okay maybe
we'll try that again it's just confusing
because to me it looks like traffic
coming from here should go there but i
guess that makes sense because if
traffic's incoming from port 888 send it
to 8080 okay to me the direction just
confused me but it's actually correct
and i'm just confused so um if that port
is open
let's go over to remote explorer here so
now we see port 888 and so if we open
that up we can see that it is forwarding
to port 8080. so there you go that's
pretty much all we need to know about
ports of course there was a lot here but
i think it was just worth making sure
that we were very thorough
with our investigation here so we'll
just close off all those tabs and we'll
see in the next video okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at git pod custom docker
images so git pod supports custom docker
images so you can configure your
workspace exactly to your needs and this
is really important if uh you know
there's security reasons like you need
to really lock down what it is that's um
within that container or you just have
uh wildly different use cases like maybe
you're doing a web 3 development or
machine learning and you just can't find
a quick start template so that's where
you have to start making your own docker
file so git pod supports uh debian
uh ubuntu based docker images but it
does not support alpine the reason it
does not support alpine is that images
do not include alpine images do not
include lib gcc or lib stdc
plus plus which breaks visual studio
code if you don't know what alpine is
it's just like really really really
small image and that's why people or os
and that's why people really like alpine
but i always found them very hard to set
up
debbie and ubuntu uh very very popular
hopefully we'll see support for things
like uh centos and things like that
later but this is the ubuntu logo that's
the debian logo and there's alpine
crossed out if that kind of helps cement
that information but you should remember
that it does not support alpine there
are two ways
to specify
i know it says specific but should say
specify an image okay so you can
reference an image from a container
repository like docker hub
if you can specify things outside of
docker hub i have not tried but i assume
that they all go to docker hub so here's
an example where we have an image and we
say node buster we know that's going to
go to dockerhub then you can reference a
dockerfile contained within the repo and
so what you do is name a file
called.gitpod.dockerfile
i don't know if you could just
call it dockerfile and then reference it
there but this is what it's always
called so
it's probably best practice just to
follow along there and then here we have
a very simple um docker file that does
basic basically does nothing but it's
just an example of us configuring our
own so for git pod images
it's recommended to not specify a tag or
use latest to make sure you're you
automatically benefit from the security
patches and fixes uh we release we
release meaning git pod so you can see i
kind of copy paste there from the
documentation
but what they're talking about when
they're talking about tags is that when
you have um like
this image here you can do like colon
latest or you can put a version number
stuff like that they're just saying
don't specify a version number or a type
just don't specify anything or type
colon latest okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
looking at the get pod workspace base
image so gitpod workspace base base is a
docker image that has a bunch of common
tooling installed and so you can find it
here on docker hub or you can get find
it on github so those are the two paths
there and so this thing if you start
digging into it it really relies on
something called build pack or build
pack uh
depths and the reason i went digging was
because i just wanted to know what was
installed on it so this is a docker
image for a collection of common build
dependencies used for installing various
modules it is similar to heroku's stack
image which includes a large number of
development headers packages needed
by various things so npm install gem
install pip install curl
wget get
and a whole lot more
so
what's the purpose of the workspace base
well it extends from build pack
depths with a bunch of additional
tooling and so we have a lot of stuff
like zip unzip h-top uh jq which is
great for working with json less
locals nano
pseudo
vim
all sorts of useful things and so this
is a really great base image but we're
going to talk about the full image next
because that is generally what we see
a lot of people using okay
[Music]
all right so let's take a look at the
get pod workspace full image so
every workspace launches by default with
a standard docker image called workspace
full and so just like base there's one
on uh docker hub and github so very
similar and workspace full extends from
workspace base but it's going to be
adding some additional stuff so the
getpod workspace full image comes
pre-installed with a variety of commonly
used programming languages and libraries
and system packages but really talking
about that coming from the base image
but just to kind of list the languages
here we got docker go java node.js c c
plus plus python ruby rust php homebrew
tail scale
nginx and several more
so when you're developing your own
custom docker images you can either
extend the workspace full or if you need
something lighter the workspace base but
we will obviously open these up uh these
these images up to kind of look at their
docker files so kind of figure out what
they're doing okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and in this
follow along i'm going to show you how
to set up a custom docker file if you
notice i tried before it didn't work so
this is going to be my maybe third
attempt to do it so what we'll do is
type in git pod custom
or get pod
custom docker file
and from there we'll go down below
choose private add a readme we'll go
ahead and create that repository
then once there we'll hit the get pod
button so all we're going to really be
doing is going through the basic custom
docker file here just to go through the
motions of it we can use hyphen base we
can use hyphen full it's just going to
be dependent on the use case so if you
use get pod fold image your docker
support built in your you get docker
support built into your environment so
full sounds pretty good to me so we'll
need a file here called dot get pod uh
docker file now does it have to be dot
get pod you probably could specify
docker file because it references it um
via the file so i would imagine you can
name whatever you want but it's just
good habit to follow what git pod has
there so i'm going to type in gpinit and
from here we have a file i don't need
any of that content we're going to have
image and then i think it's like type
or file okay so we can do file here and
then from there we'll just do git pod
docker file okay and so now the next
thing we want to do and maybe we might
want to put one task in there for fun
tasks and we'll just say um command
we'll just say
echo
hello world okay just something for fun
and so in this docker file we're going
to be now writing whatever format a
docker file is so do from get pod
forward slash workspace and again this
could be base but we're going to do full
because you get the full power docker
that way
and from there we can do run brew
install fzf now what is fzf i have no
idea so i'm kind of curious myself so
i'm just going to type that in
[Music]
command i just don't know what it is so
this stands for
fuzzy finder
so f c f set f is a general purpose
command line fuzzy finder it's an
interactive unix filter for command line
that can be used with any files so i
mean that sounds really interesting um
how it's used i don't know so i mean it
might be just interesting to see if we
can figure out how it works but um i
think this is it so
run brew install fzf if you see brew and
you're thinking isn't that a mac thing
well i think there's a debian ubuntu
like compatibility for having brew so um
yeah i'm not really sure let's see
ubuntu
brew
so homebrew on linux so i guess they
have a linux distribution and so that's
how we're able to do that normally i
would be like doing yum or apk install
app getting solved for debbie and ubuntu
but just to kind of clarify that i'm
just double checking to make sure
everything is okay there looks good to
me so i'm going to go ahead and commit
all this and say
build custom
docker image
okay and hopefully all that is correct
so we'll go ahead and commit that sync
the changes we'll say okay
and what we'll do is close that tab out
we're going to double check to make sure
those files are committed
they look like they are good we'll hit
get pot and hopefully we don't get any
errors
it's very easy to make errors at least
for me because uh you know i'm just
error-prone
but notice that it's building the
workspace so there's a little bit more
work it has to do that's building that
image
so this is where you might see
pre-builds come into play where
you know you want this to launch faster
because you know docker files just take
forever to build
uh and i say forever but i mean they
take a little bit of time right so just
imagine if you always had this that
really makes sense why pre-builds uh
become so important
but i'll see you back here when it's
done okay
all right so i think this is done i
can't really tell because it says
building image and says exit exit so
i'm going to
uh risk it i'm just going to close this
tab and try it again so i'm going to go
ahead and launch the get pod
um
yeah so it already has this one running
so i'm just going to click into that so
maybe i'll just jump into the
environment so yeah it was ready uh just
understand that sometimes that happens
you know if if you feel like you're
waiting too long just have the
confidence to go okay i think i think it
is working but for whatever reason the
feedback loop is not working as expected
so if this worked correctly we should
have fzf installed so if i type f set f
uh it does appear so that's great and
let's just see how it works so i know i
watched a short little video on it and i
know that if you do this it's a fuzzy
finder so you can apply it to anything
you can pipe anything to it but like
it's great for like going through and
finding files this one is a little bit
more complicated so it's not really
showing me the one the simple one that i
wanted to
use here
well let me see here just going to the
top here um
so
ah like
it's basically this so we copy this i'm
not sure about the selected part but we
go and we paste that in like allow and
hit enter
and
i mean we can search our files so
i guess it's only showing not or like
invisible files so maybe i need to go
find some files here
um
media is there stuff in there no
just trying to find anything
okay so here might be something that
might work
so i'll hit up but they're not files
they're kind of folders they
okay so see i can start typing utm and
so it's just a fuzzy finder an easier
way to find things it can be used for
all sorts of things but that's how you
build a docker file so just realize it
is a bit slow
but that's the whole idea behind
pre-builds right um now if we were to
launch this again would it try to build
every single time i think so let's go
ahead and just see that and i don't care
about seeing this complete i just want
to see if it is going to build that
every single time i believe it would
right
so we just give it a moment here
it's pulling the container image if it
doesn't that's great
right
that's what it looks like it's doing so
it looks like if you build it once
uh it's not gonna build it every single
time you launch a workspace
and then i guess my next question is is
like i guess it would know anytime
there's a file change i guess that you
would have you'd have to commit it to
the repository so that's how we would
know
so
that's fine so let's say i make a single
change here
small change
maybe just add another small change here
i just want to see like will it still
pull the image will it be smart enough
or is it any time there's a
change
small change sync
uh we'll go ahead and close that git pod
give it a moment there and so i just
want to see is it going to try to build
the image
it doesn't look like it
so it's really seems like it's smart
about that
and then what we'll do once we launch it
i'll just try to make a very minute
change
um i don't write docker files on a
regular basis so
i'm not even sure what we could install
i mean maybe we could do wget even
though it's already installed in that
file
okay yeah so it didn't rebuild it but
what we'll do here is i'm going to do
like run on a separate line
i assume it must be smart enough to know
run brew install wget again i don't care
if this works like i don't i don't care
to see it all the way the end just the
fact that it's going to start a build
step
so add wget which probably already is
installed
but uh we just need an extra line in
there so we're just going to do whatever
okay good
and we'll go back over here and
we will hit the get pod button and so
i'm assuming this time it will know
yeah there we go okay so it is building
the image so it is pretty smart there
and i really like the fact that i did it
that way
um
if you're looking for those we've seen
those works workspace full images before
but like get pod workspace full
uh docker hub might be something we want
to search for so here this is where
they're basically hosted you know so
just understand like whatever you want
you just take that name and that's what
you're putting in the image if you're
doing um
if we're going back to here like let's
say you already have an image hosted you
just do that right and you probably can
put tags there as well but again it has
to be a debian or ubuntu base so i'm not
sure if it shows yeah here it is on
github we've got images and we can go
find the full one here and from here we
can see the docker file and we can see
this one's based off the base so if you
wanted to kind of like crawl through and
that's what i was doing to kind of
understand what's going on there you can
go to the base and then open that one
you can see this one's based on the
build pack depth depth full call
uh
f-o-c-a-l i'm not sure what that stands
for we can go over here
and then from here um
like this sometimes i don't know where
to find the base file but there is some
kind of like base soccer file here that
would tell us where that comes from or
be written up so i'm just kind of
looking around for it i'm not super good
with docker i've been using it for years
but every single time it just takes a
lot of work here there are a bunch of
tags underneath so maybe the tag shows
up here it does
so we click into that one ah and here's
the file
and so you can see this one's based off
full call sem
here it's installing all the libraries
and you can just keep crawling back
until you find everything to see like
what's installed so we go to this one
here
and then this one's based off the curl
one like
it's just a little a little loopy how
this works we'll go to the curl one
and uh so now you can see it's ubuntu uh
focal right so then we can go from this
one
so you just see that you see that it's
ubuntu right so we go into this so that
i guess that stands for
focal uh
fossa
great that is not easy to say so we go
back and we go to docker hub
again just if you've never done this
before right
and so from here we might type in a full
call if it even shows up so then it's
here this is the latest
and so this is from scratch
um
and this is add this binary or this uh
this thing so it looks like i don't
really know this too well but it looks
like what it's doing is it's saying okay
take this um
uh
archive which might be in the same
directory here yeah it is take this
archive and utilize that as the
installation for it right um so that
must be like the way like setting up um
ubuntu like you know somebody was to
like have a disk or
uh a key or download the program i think
it's the executing the program so
you know hopefully that kind of tells
you how that stuff works but yeah that
is how you do
custom docker files okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at git pod quick start
templates so quick start templates are
git repositories that you can use to
launch an example environment or fork to
get started for a variety of different
run times so here's the search and
you're going to notice a bunch of
languages a bunch of frameworks like
ruby on rails larvarelle
things like that and so once you click
on one of these it's you can it will try
to
create a fork of course but you can just
go straight to the um
github repository and there you'll
generally notice that it will have like
a git pod yaml file and a docker file
and you can open it up and see how they
are doing it um but it's pretty useful
the quick start template generally
contains a custom docker file that may
extend the base or full so i tried to
like go through a bunch of these and say
okay what is the pattern here but it
seems like some are workspace based some
are full some are
uh get pod workspace there's like
another one um or some are docker
compose so there i guess a little bit
all over the place okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and this follow
along i want to explore the quick starts
that comes with git pods so what we'll
do is type in quick start
templates here and what we'll do oops we
got to put in get pod here because
there's all sorts of quick starts based
on different cloud products but if we go
here we can see we have some popular
templates we can search for a variety of
things so if we want ruby on rails that
is an example maybe if we wanted uh
larvarelle that might be an example
maybe if we wanted django do we have
django in here
not yet but if we don't have django
maybe we have flask yeah there we go so
maybe we have flask uh maybe we've got
next yes there we go
and so it might be fun to just kind of
launch these and see what they look like
and maybe there's even a wordpress in
here there we are
okay so we got all the major frameworks
and you know i want to emphasize that
this is languages and frameworks and all
sorts of things but what we're going to
do here
um is go ahead
and launch these so each of these have a
template so if i go here i can just say
get pod um
rails template and you know what we
don't even need to actually
i'm not going to clone those i'm just
going to open these up in a new tab like
this
and then just click on it like that
so that's the rails one now i have to go
back here and find all of them again so
we'll go here
and we'll open up that like that
okay so we got the wordpress that one
then we'll look at the next gs one
all i want to do is kind of just explore
these and just see kind of like what is
going on with them you know
and we said flask
okay
click on through that
and larva
and so the thing is is that um
we have quite a few repos here
i think i have one two three four five
so we're not going to be able to open
these all up at once because we can only
have four in parallel but we don't need
to do that all at once so that's fine so
i'm just going to close some of these
but not close anything but i'm just
going to launch them one at a time so
let's do larvae first
that's quite a big one so this will be
one that we launch
we'll go ahead and close that tab
and while that's going we'll go ahead
and launch the next js1 we'll just do a
couple at a time okay
and i'm not really sure how many
workspaces i have running maybe we'll
just kind of like
optimize our time here if we go over to
our dashboard
and we go to workspaces none are open
there
we have
two running workspaces which is fine so
i think we can just keep going here
we'll do the flask one and then we'll do
the wordpress wordpress one and then
we'll just leave rails up on on the side
there
and so we're just gonna wait for all
these environments to go green i'll see
you back here in a minute okay all right
so after a short little wait
our four repositories are ready so we'll
start on the left-hand side with
larvaral if you don't know what
lavarelle is it's a php framework that's
similar to ruby on rails
um and so let's just see what they have
done here to kind of provision this so
it doesn't hurt to go through get pod
yaml files to kind of learn something so
here they're loading a custom image and
probably all of these are going to be
loading custom images and so we're
opening up port 8000 for the lower rail
server and then it's also starting mysql
so it's all here in one place for you
and so down below um i mean both the
ports are open but in the init step you
can see that they are creating a
database example they're going to copy
the env file over here into one there
then there are updating the environment
variables with some default
configurations over in here so some
settings that are probably mandatory
that you need to update
then they're doing a composer install an
npm install a php artisan key generate
could any of this go into the before i
don't know this seems pretty much
correct to me and then you have the
command that's starting up the 8000 on
um for the public directory so let's go
open up the get pod docker file and so
here you can see that there's just the
thing that says workspace mysql so if we
wanted to understand what the contents
of that is we'd have to go look up that
one there so maybe we will in a bit here
so just say workspace github if we can
find it
sometimes i find these easy to find
sometimes i don't
whoops
like that
so like if we go to the get pod repo
because it might our github github uh
get pod repo there might be something
interesting for us to see there maybe
not but we'll try anyway so we'll say
git pod here
and we'll go to the repos here
and we will search for workspace
so these are workspace images see i
don't know if they're all in here they
probably are so we're going to mysql
this is probably the file that is
launching here so i'm just curious how
what is it what is it doing so it's
extending the workspace full and then
it's just installing mysql so a lot of
these are going to be using probably
workspace full underneath
okay
then we have next.js
so in here we'll take a look at the uh
the dot get pod yaml file here
and so
we have a single task it says mpm
install npm run dev so very very simple
and it's not even using um a custom
docker file because it just uses node
and i guess everything we want is here
so that's really simple and nice
then we have flask running here so if we
go over to this one
um
we have one that's starting a before
task so it's setting or it's exporting a
couple of flask options we're doing our
pip install we're initializing our our
database we're running it and then they
have that extension installed for python
for that highlighting so that's nice and
simple
and then the last one here well we still
have ruby on rails we might as well open
that up while we're waiting
um we got to go back to our limit here
we've reached one so we'll go ahead and
close
uh this one here so we'll say
stop
and we'll stop this one and we'll stop
this one i just don't want to touch the
wordpress and so if we go over to the
wordpress now we didn't see a website
because this one's a little bit more
complex in terms of its setup there is a
port open i don't know if this will work
because we probably have to pop in the
database nope here it is we can uh
create a wordpress and so if we go here
on the left hand side
and go into the git pod yaml this one's
kind of a curious case because it's not
using a docker file image it has a
docker compose and so basically you're
running
multi-containers within a container and
so we open up docker compose we can see
here that it's starting up mysql then
it's starting up wordpress and these
have separate images so see this one is
using the mysql image this one's using
the wordpress latest and so you know you
saw with the other example with
larvarelle it just ran it as a monolith
within the container like like a virtual
machine would and so you have both
options here and both are valid this
might be really useful if this is
actually what you used to deploy so this
would be more like one-to-one with your
production environment
so that is kind of interesting there
um
let's go back i guess we didn't relaunch
this so we'll go here and we'll just
launch a new ruby on rails file there
and we'll give that a moment
but you can kind of see that's kind of
interesting like all these files a
little bit different you can learn a bit
but the great thing is like you can just
clone these or fork these repositories
and kind of build off of them so it's a
really great starting point for a lot of
different kinds of projects
so
yeah we'll just wait here for the ruben
rails thing to start and we'll look at
this last one and we'll just wrap it up
here for quick starts okay all right so
after short little wait here we have
ruby on rails my favorite framework
that's why we made time for it but here
you can see it's loading its own custom
image file uh it has ports open on three
thousand five four three two means
meaning it's running postgres here we
have our initial bundle install yarn and
sol rick db create and then running the
server and then we have a nice extension
here
for ruby if we open up the docker file
we see again it's workspace postgres so
you can imagine it's going to probably
be similar to the mysql one if we go
over here
we go down to postgres and we click into
the docker file yeah it's the same story
um it's going to be extending workspace
full
so that's pretty straightforward there
um
and yeah we're pretty much done here so
yeah that's all we want to do for quick
start so i'll just close that stuff off
and i'll see you in the next video okay
[Music]
so let's take a look here at docker
compose which is a feature of docker uh
but what's interesting is you can run it
within git pod and so the reason why
this is interesting is because you can
run containers within containers or
technically docker within docker if
you've ever seen the movie inception
with leonardo dicaprio where he goes uh
deep into dreams a dream within a dream
that's what we're doing here it's kind
of crazy
so let's talk about what docker compose
is so it's a tool for running
multi-container applications on docker
defined using the compose file format so
we're not just running a single uh uh
docker container running multiple
containers at the same time so a compose
file which is going to be named docker
hyphen compose yaml which will sit at
the root of your directory um is used to
define how one or more containers that
need to be running and the communication
between them to run our application and
so within our gitpod configuration file
we can run docker compose poll and up uh
commands to get multiple containers
running so there they are of course we
don't see the docker compose yaml file
here in the slide but we will see it in
the follow along so it will make sense
there okay
[Music]
so something i want you to
consider is that you can build container
images and virtual machine images within
containers and so if you're looking for
some open source tooling or things that
might work
within a gitpod workspace
we have hashicorp packers so this is an
open source tool to build golden images
for virtual machines or docker or maybe
buildup
which is an open source tool to build
oci compliant images of course there are
other
tool tools out there so for instance
there's dazzle which is made by get pod
i don't know a lot about it i don't know
if we're going to
actually
give it a try within the course but
that's something that builds out
container images with some advantage
around layers okay
[Music]
all right so we're going to learn all
about git pod environment variables so
before we do we need to define what are
environment variables commonly referred
to by developers as and vars is a
variable whose values is set outside of
a program and it's composed of a key and
pair so here's an example within bash
this is generally how you do it so you'd
write export to set the environment
variable you have the key so
very common to set it to be all
uppercase um it's just tradition so
that's what we normally do equals
followed by string and if we want to
print it we could do echo is one great
way of doing that there and so
environment variables can be set in four
ways for your gitpod workspace you have
the getpodcli the gitpodio account
settings environment variables the
gitpod url and getpodconfigurationfile
per start task so we will jump into all
those variants okay
[Music]
before we jump into the four different
ways we can set environment variables
let's talk about the defaults and prefix
for
gitpod so
the default environment variables are
set by getpod automatically every time
you launch a new workspace so
there's a lot of them but two that
really stand out are get pod workspace
id so this is a universally unique idea
uuid associated with the workspace and
then the getpod workspace url the unique
url for the workspace if you want to see
them all we'll do this in the follow
along you can use
the bash command env to print them all
out and then you have a pipe followed by
grep to say filter out the ones that
start with get pod underscore because
they're all going to start with get pod
underscore and to talk about that prefix
it's a reserve prefix so environment
variables beginning with the git pod
underscore are reserved for internal use
by gitpod and are overridden on every
workspace startup so if you attempt to
set something with your own like
getpodandru it will get ignored or will
not be accessible
if you try to override one that's
existing this is just not going to
happen okay so just be aware of that
[Music]
so one way we can set environment
variables uh for gitpod workspaces is
within the gitpod yaml or the
gitpodconfiguration file at a per task
level so here is an example
of a
github configuration file and here you
can see we are doing env colon
and then we're following up with a key
and a pair and we can put as many as we
want in there um and so that's going to
set for the next time the environment
launches notice we have the dollar sign
this is not git pod specific that is
just how bash scripts work
and so you can do that to access the
value there
okay and so the environment variables
will be scoped only for
that terminal so that task that spins up
and other terminals will not have
that environment variable set and i was
i was very certain to test that out and
we will look at that when we do it in
the follow along okay
[Music]
so another way we can set uh environment
variables for get pod is via the gitpod
url so right after the hash or pound
there we can just start specifying
multiple ones there separated by a comma
you probably don't want to be putting
sensitive
things in there because you know there's
potential for those to be exposed like
it was access keys and secrets but it's
really nice to be able to do that so the
environment variable set in the url will
be available in all terminals within
your workspace so like where you have
pertaster scope for the um
uh you know per task right whether you
set it in the git pod yellow file this
these are going to be everywhere okay
[Music]
all right so another way to set
environment variables is setting them
through account settings and so if you
go there you'll have account settings
environment variables and this is ideal
when you need to pass along variables
that are sensitive so something could be
sensitive would be like in a bus
credentials so from there you can open
up a new end bar and set its name its
value and its scope and that's the thing
that's interesting here is how scope
works
so in order to set environment variables
for specific workspaces you need to set
the scope
and so if you wanted to show up for
everything
you could do what it says here which is
provide a wild card for both uh wild
card forward slash wildcard but let's
look at some of the following patterns
that we can set and it's going to be
basically owner repo or an alternative
way of saying oregon project but this is
based on what is in github get lab
bitbucket right so that's what you want
to consider not to be confused and this
did confuse me with um teams because you
can have or teams and projects within um
get pod and it's not based on that okay
so for example we have exam pro forward
slash example marketing it's going to
make the nvr available to a repo called
exam pro marketing owned by exam pro
right and actually mine on um github is
exam pro
co with all capitals right which is like
this over here i just wrote it lowercase
for some reason over here then we have
um and i'll just clear some of the
drawings here but then we could say
we could have a wild card on the end
here so wild card repo so make nvars
available to all repos owned by get pod
i o
um so maybe it's for across all repos
and then you could have
the
wild card in the front as well and so
this is really useful um it says for
it says because i haven't used it yet
for all forks right so you know it could
be like git pod io and then there's like
andrew brown at forward slash form so
that that stuff propagates there
so the scope is case insensitive so when
you enter the pattern it will be down
case so see how i'm up i'm entering this
with title case here exam pro co um it
will just down case it to exam pro co
like all like all the letters uh down
cased so you know you don't have to be
too sensitive here when you're writing
that stuff and it's just going to fix
that for you okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and this follow
along we're going to look at all the
options we have for environment
variables because there's a lot of ways
that we can set them so what i'm going
to do is go ahead and create a new
repository we'll call this one gitpod
env i'm going to go make that private as
per usual and we'll go ahead and add a
readme file and we're going to launch
ourself a new environment so we'll go
open up get pod here and while we're
waiting i probably have some code
already laying around from one of our
previous
repositories here so i think i'll go to
the ports one here because we're going
to probably just set up sinatra as per
usual
and that will be the means for which we
pass a long port so we'll give that a
moment to open and as that is going i'm
going to go over to the getpodio website
because what i want to show to you is
under your settings over here this is
where you're going to find environment
variables now i probably would prefer if
this was scoped at a per project level
but i mean of course you can launch
project like things that are not within
a project so i guess it makes sense that
it is global
but you know maybe in the future they'll
add it at a project
name space there which is totally fine
but this is where you're going to be
able to set one place for environment
variables another place will be in the
url in the goodpod url
the cli and i think there is a fourth
option in the getpodgaml file so what
we'll do here is we'll just get set up
and so as per usual i'll go to the
hamburger menu and we will launch a new
terminal and we'll wait a moment here
type in gp init so that we have a
git pod yaml file that we cannot mess up
which is something that i have a bunch
of trouble with but what we'll do is
create a new file here called server.rb
and we will go ahead and grab the same
code so it is just this very simple code
you've seen us grab it a few times from
the sinatra website if you if you're
looking for you just go to sinatra
sinatra ruby right and here and i'm
pretty much just grabbing that code okay
so and then we're putting this port here
with the app port again requiring
sinatra we'll go ahead actually we'll
type in bundle init to create our gem
file for ruby
and i'm just going to delete uh that can
stay in there that's fine we'll just
type in gem
cinatra
and then i'll do a bundle install so we
install sinatra our very lightweight
ruby web server there and so that is now
installed and so
i'm just thinking about this for a
moment um
because it's installed i'm just trying
to think like what would be the best
approach
um so what i'm gonna do
is
we'll do the get pod yaml file last
because we can set environment variables
in here but i think that's something
that we can wait for but we will need to
kind of set up this file so i'm going to
do a
bundle
install and you see me do this as a
separate task but i'm just going to make
my life easy by just doing a bundle
install here
and then we'll do a bundle
exec
ruby server.rb
okay
and so there is no port number being set
here so it's going to be whatever it is
i'm just going to get rid of the ports
because we'll just let it launch and
then from there we'll just expose ports
as we go
but i'm just thinking here for a moment
about what i would like to do
let's do it from the url first so that's
what i want to do i want to see if i can
change the port number via the url so
what we'll do
is i'm just going to make sure this
works
okay
just make sure that the server starts up
it does no problem there so we'll go and
do is uh commit these this uh these
files here okay
and i'm just gonna say uh initial repo
we'll go ahead and commit that save
those changes we'll say
okay so this should be everything that
we need to get going
so now i'm going to go ahead and just
close that and so
we're going to go back to example dev
and we're going to look for that new
repository that we just created
env
and so from here i mean we can click
this link but i'm just going to right
click and copy the link address just to
save myself some trouble we're going to
go ahead here whoops
copy uh copy link address
and again we'll paste it up in here and
so what we'll do is set the environment
variable up here so i'm gonna do app
port
equals
um
eight
eight eight eight okay and we'll put a
forward slash in there and so that means
that sinatra should start up on port 888
because we are injecting environment
variables that way so we'll see if that
actually works
assuming i wrote that correctly but i'm
pretty sure i did it's not like that
hard to do
and we'll give it a moment here
and it started up on port
888 so passing via the get get pod url
wasn't too
uh troublesome here
and so another way that we can uh
uh set environment variables
i mean there's something with the the
the get get
uh pod cli here
so here is control user defined
persistent environment variables and i
haven't really done much with this yet
so let's see what it does
i'm not sure we'll say help
uh and we'll just go up here and see
what it says so this command can print
and modify the persistent environment
variables associated with your user so
to set the persistent environment
variable to foo bar so we would just do
that so we'll do gpe env
and we'll just say
app port equals
and hit enter
and so that just sets the port number so
i'm assuming that's all it does
okay so we would do
echo here
hmm
[Music]
because here it's saying this
if we go here is it just because i've
already set one so maybe it's just
because it's already been set so it
can't be overwritten because it's
interesting that it's it's doing this
here
so i'm gonna try this again one more
time
and it's doing eight eight eight eight
eight
so let's go take a read up on what that
does we'll say get port
or
get pod
cli
and if we go here
we'll look at env because it just might
be that we can't overwrite it so
uh with gpe and v you can set an api
endpoint environment variable that is
accessible for the project even if you
stop the workspace and start a new one
to delete uh or unset environment
variable
uh do that so i mean it just looks like
it sets environment variable so but the
thing is that we sent through the getpod
url so it might never be able to unset
it
so what i'm going to do just to rule
that out i'm just going to open up a new
workspace here
and we'll try to set it and then see if
it actually prints out
all right so it's just starting up here
and it's starting on port
8765 which is
interesting because
i definitely um
did not set it so maybe what it did when
we did that is it actually set it up
over here so i'm just curious if we give
us a refresh oh
so that's what that does okay
so that's really curious
all right so because i thought it was
just going to be temporary like you just
did it within the actual workspace but i
guess what it actually does is set it up
in your account settings and here you
can see that it's setting it for the
scope so we have at app port 8765. i was
going to show you this separately but i
guess if we did it that way we don't
have to do that there but just make note
that you can do
wild cards here so if you wanted this to
be set for all projects so maybe you
always do port 3000 and you're always
using app or something like that you
could do that or if you wanted it for
every single fork you could do that so i
could update that it would still apply
but that's interesting i did not know
that
um so
i mean
that's great now let's take a look at
what we would do if we set it up in the
git pod yaml and i don't know which one
would override so like there's one set
in here but would get pot yaml have more
presidents i don't know so what we'll do
is just type in env i'm going to go here
and do app port
and we'll do
it's probably colon and here i would
just say
you got to be kind of careful because
sometimes these are reserved ports but i
don't think so i just again i've never
seen someone do that so
maybe like four three two one might be a
better idea
and so what we'll do here is just save
this and see what happens let's see if
it actually overrides with this port or
sorry this environment variable so
commit
env within
getpod file
okay
and we will save that
we'll
sync those changes
and what we'll do is just close this
and we'll go ahead and relaunch that
and then we'll see which takes over and
we might even go to the extreme and also
set in the get pod url and see what
happens
so here it's starting on port four three
two one so even though we have set it
um in here it looks like the git pod
yaml is going to have higher priority
here so now what i want to do is close
it out
and we're going to
then set it in the url and see which one
it takes
i'm going to assume it's always going to
be the getpod url configuration file
first
so or environment variable sorry so
we'll copy this address up here i'm
going to go ahead and paste it on in
here
and so what i want to do is just say app
port
equals four four four four
four slash
and so i wanna see if it picks up this
one
again i'm going to assume it's going to
be the four 4321 because the get pot
yaml should be
high priority
that's how i would code it and so it is
four three two one okay
so now i guess the next question is is
what happens if i remove
this
and we do the url is it going to pick up
the one from the account settings or
it's going to pick up the one from here
so we'll just say remove env
sync those changes we'll say okay
and we'll go back here and
we will just copy the link address again
we will paste it on in there and here
i'm going to say app port equals four
four four four forward slash
this looks okay to me we'll hit enter
we'll see what it picks up
and it's eight seven six five so um
unless i did it wrong but i don't think
i did
um it looks like that the priority is
um
git pod yaml then account settings and
then the url
is last in terms of priority okay
so i mean that's pretty much all we
really need to know about environment
variables there are environment
variables that are set for
i guess we could look at also the git
pod prefixes so if you type in env
and you go grep
um
get pod
you can see all the ones that are set by
get pod there so if we just scroll up
here for a second
they have repo root so that's the root
of the repository so that might be
useful if you need to reference it an
elix writer segment so i guess they're
using segment which is a
analytics tool the workspace id the
interval which is whatever i assume it's
how often it checks i guess that might
be for the timeout because it says three
zero zero zero and i know that it's like
30 minutes so maybe if we were to extend
our time that would increase
the context url so that's just where it
was referenced to the instance id so i'm
assuming it's the underlying container
or something like that
the url
dia i think he has something to do with
eclipse i'm not really sure
context so we have a bunch of stuff here
so you know
nothing that you would really be trying
to utilize but um you know there's a lot
of stuff here you can see my email uh
they get podcasts but um
and you can't obviously override these
so i'm not going to go bother to show
that but just so you know you cannot
override those values
um or set something with get pod
underscore i i'm not sure let's actually
go take a look and see if that's
possible so what i'm going to do here
i'm just going to make up one like
underscore andrew and just confirm is if
you're able to set it i like i would
think that it's just if there's ones
that they decide to set you can't set
ones with those but
i just want to see what happens so we'll
copy this link
and we'll just paste it up here
i'm going to just say something like get
pod andrew and i'm going to say equals
brown and it will do a forward slash
it's my assumption that
it will get set but it can get
overwrited
and we'll give it a moment here
and so we'll just kill the server and
what i want to do here is just type in
env get pod underscore
andrew
uh oops we gotta grab that
okay so it seems like if you set
something with pod underscore it just
gets wiped out won't even exist
but yeah there you go that's environment
variable so just close that stuff off
and we might just want to delete that
out there and we are good
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
looking at the open mode uh
configuration option when we are
defining our start tasks so open mode
allows you to configure how the terminal
should open relative to the previous
task so here's an example of me writing
a git pod yaml file and i have a bunch
of different tasks and they all have a
variety of different open modes and so
what you're looking for here and i know
it's hard to see but it's this box over
here so you're gonna just see some
interesting things where uh some are
split and so when you click into this
one it's showing all four of those and
so hopefully i can show that better um
in the follow along here but there are
four different options we can set so we
have tab after so opens in the same tab
group right after the previous tab tab
before so it opens in the same tab group
left before the previous tab split right
so splits and adds the terminal to the
right and split left so splits then adds
the terminal to the left okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at vs code extension so
what is a vs code extension well it lets
you install features themes programming
languages uh support debuggers and other
tools to your vs code editor to support
your development workflow and so you
know if i wanted to install something
i'd open up the extensions panel or
explorer and from there i could install
something like vim that's something i
really like for my keyboard there and so
vs code extensions are added to a git
pod workspace in three different ways so
you have built-in extensions these are
extensions installed by default by get
pod the open vsx registry so this is a
community marketplace for extensions
user extensions so these are extensions
not in the open vsx registry or we're
just saying like extensions that have
been installed by the user okay and so
vs code extensions are named dot v s i x
um i assume it stands for visual studio
integration extension i don't know if
the eyes for i could not find out but
they are vsix
and so it is essentially just an
archived file so if you were to rename
this to a dot zip you could actually
open up the archive and view the source
files so there you go
[Music]
so gitpod comes preinstalled with many
vs code extensions and you can view the
pre-installed extensions by searching at
sign built-in within the extensions
panel here so just notice this icon here
where it looks like uh four little
blocks and one is broken off here if i
type in at sign built in in the search
at the top these are all the ones that
are coming pre-installed and there's a
lot as you can see here almost looks
like
about 80 that are installed if you count
up the numbers there and so i just went
through it and mostly what's interesting
are the is the feature support that's
installed because that's going to change
the behavior and so here are ones that i
thought were notable or interesting to
show select git github get pod web grunt
gulp image preview microsoft account
merge conf conflict things like that but
you know if you want to know what's
being sold just take a look there you
might learn something new and improve
your workflow okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown and we're taking a
look at the openvsx registry so it is a
vendor neutral open source alternative
to the visual studio marketplace and
gitpod uses vs code extensions from the
openvsx registry as opposed to the
visual studio marketplace and so this is
kind of a a screenshot of the home page
of the openvsx registry which is at
openhyphenvsx.org very simple you just
search the name
and you can find whatever you want the
question is why are they using openvsx
registry as opposed to the visual studio
marketplace well vs vsix files
downloaded from the visual studio
marketplace should not be installed uh
in gitpod because microsoft prohibits
the direct use of their marketplace by
any non-microsoft software even though
most extensions are actually open source
and not developed or maintained by
microsoft so this is kind of one of
those weird things where you know
microsoft is not being as open as they
could be
for their own self-interest and so the
openvsx registry is there to ensure that
you know organizations that are
investing into cloud developer
environments are going to run into
licensing issues and also to make uh the
market uh fair and competitive so
that's kind of really interesting and i
looked it up uh like where this was
hosted and it's actually eclipse um that
is the one that is behind this and
eclipse has been an open source id for
forever and so it's really great that
they are doing this for the community so
when you search extensions uh within the
gitpod vs code ui extensions panel it
will search extensions in the open vsx
registry so if you can find it on the
openvsx website
then you're going to find it in here as
well and for ones that you cannot find
in here
or
ones that you need to install directly
that's where you're going to be
installing them yourselves which we'll
talk about
soon enough okay
[Music]
so when you are exploring the extensions
panel and you're quickly looking to
install some extensions you can right
click on this little cog here um right
here and what it will do is it'll open
up a context menu it's called a context
menu because it's opening
a menu within the context of what you
clicked that's it's just a general uh
programming term and so you'll have this
option to say add to git pod yaml so if
you click that that will just populate
your document for you which will save
you the trouble of populating that
yourself
um but you just have to remember you'll
have to commit that
code to your repository for it to
persist okay
[Music]
all right so let's talk about user
extensions so there are two ways to
install extensions beyond the built-in
extensions the first is for all users
for a project so git pod configuration
file extension vs code.extensions is
where we are going to set that value
which we'll see here in a moment or
there's the second case where you're
only installing it for the current user
and that's we're going to be using the
vs code settings sync feature which
we'll see in the next video so down
below here is an example of a gitpod
configuration file where we're setting
vs code extensions and so we're
installing ones that are from the
openvsx registry by giving them their
name and then down below we're
specifying a url of a i assume it has to
be public-facing self-hosted vs code
extension i think that this can also be
a local file path because when you try
to import a vi vs ix file um within the
gitpod
vs code interface it actually
first looks locally so that would be
interesting to
find out but you know probably in
practicality you're going to always have
it
online somewhere so
anyway um for the extensions i just want
to show you that if you were to open up
the openvsx registry you can see the
name there i know it's hard because it's
orange but that kind of helps you
understand what thing you are pulling in
and putting into that file okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at a feature of vs code
called settings sync so this is a
feature to sync your configuration such
as settings key bindings installed
extensions across your machines so you
are always working with your favorite
setup and so with the desktop version of
vs code the one you install locally not
the one in the browser part of git pods
you need to log in to a github or
microsoft account to store the sync
settings which is a json file so if you
opened it for the first time it says
sign in with microsoft sign in with
github but with git pod when you turn on
the settings things feature you're not
going to be choosing an account to log
in because you already are authenticated
with something like github gitlab or
a bitbucket but the settings data i
believe will be stored on the gitpod
servers and your configuration will
persist across all your workspaces and
when we say that we're talking about all
the gitpod workspaces not necessarily
the ones on your local machine okay
that's something else so you can set uh
extensions within your dot git pod yaml
file which we'll learn in this course
however some extensions which are
designed for developers personal
preferences should not be set here and
instead settings things should be used
so a very good example here would be the
vs code vim changes keyboard mode okay
because this could greatly impact other
developers so i use them i really like
vim and so i
had applied this here and then one of
our other developers said hey i don't
like using vim i want to turn this off
so it doesn't belong here and so that's
the reason i'm bringing this up and also
just to describe how setting syncs works
a little bit different okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and in this
follow along we're going to take a look
at um vs code extensions or
in the context of git pods so what i'm
going to do is just make a new get pod
and
there's not really anything special
we're going to do in this one it's going
to be more folks around the extensions
but we got to launch something so whoops
did i just launch an existing
environment i'm going to go ahead and
just create a new
repository so we can just play around in
something new and so i'll just say git
pod ext for extensions we'll make it
private as per usual create the new
repository
and we'll give it a moment here and
we'll go ahead and hit the get pod
button so what i'm going to do is just
go over to open vsx registry and we'll
just take a look at what this is so you
saw me talking about it and um
it looks a lot cooler in dark mode but
it's not uh flipping over to that right
now so we're in light mode but this is a
vendor neutral open source marketplace
and basically there's the other one
which is the vs code marketplace right
and there's a problem because you know
these marketplaces look really similar
there's a problem in the sense that
microsoft has problematic licensing or
rules around this thing and that's why
this one exists
so this isn't the problem this is more
so the problem or at least what
microsoft has done with this which is
kind of unfortunate but
the great thing is that you know if you
are somebody that is creating
um vs code extensions you can just put
them in both marketplaces but if you
could just put them in here honestly um
and so i believe this repository is
managed by clips if i just try to find
it here yeah so this service is operated
by the eclipse foundation if you don't
know
clips they are kind of a big deal
because they've been around for
such a long time
uh which is really nice here
and so the source code for open vsx is
managed by the openvsx team which is
very cool as well and so they have this
i don't think i've ever actually looked
at this but let's just take a look here
so yeah so there's that with uh eclipse
okay
but anyway so here are all of our um
but the great thing is is that if you
are over here
in the extensions panel here anything
you search is already going to look here
so if i look up something for
ruby
okay so we might have like
this one here
the reborn nix dot ruby
and you go over to ruby over here
and this one's not installed but i'm
gonna go ahead and install it i wonder
if it will pull up where it's from
let me just see here
marketplace so if we go click the
marketplace yeah it takes us to openvsx
this version of ruby extension was
published by openvsx this user account
is not verified from the publisher
of this extension okay but anyway so
here it is and so
uh you get an idea of
of what that is and so when you install
these extensions gitpod is going to
already have
um
they're going to have
the sink turned on it's here in the
wheel so
the great thing is once you install
something you like it's going to persist
to other things but if you're working on
a ruby project you might want to just
include that into your getpod.yaml file
so what i would do
is just create a i'd say get pod open in
vs code
and we would say whoops i actually want
to do that i want to sorry open a new
terminal
and i'm just going to initialize a new
file
and within here we're going to do an
extension i can't remember what it is so
i'm just going to look it up so get pod
extensions
like the syntax for it and there it is
so i'm just going to go ahead and grab
that little part there we'll go ahead
and paste it on in there allow and so we
know that this extension is called this
and it's already in the
open vs code or the open registry there
and so we can just do that i'm just
going to double check to make sure
that's the correct syntax notice that
you can also put that signed version on
it if you want or you can specify a vsix
file which maybe we'll try to do this
one here
but i guess to really test this we're
going to need a secondary account where
we don't have this already installed
so what i'll do
is um
maybe i can make a snapshot for this
because we haven't done any snapshots
yet
but anyway so i'll just create a new
ruby file here we'll just say hello.rb
and we'll type in puts
so
hello world
and we'll go ahead and just make sure
that works not that it matters but we'll
just run it for any reason
okay so that works fine and so we kind
of have this little basis of a
uh thing using that extension so we'll
go ahead and
run or commit that so
initial commits
and then what i'm going to do here is
i'm going to go ahead and create a
snapshot so we'll say git pod share
workspace snapshot now i could share
this in real time but i figured it'd
just be easier to take a snapshot and
then would be our opportunity to give
that a go
and i have firefox still open here on
the side here so i'll just share it with
this account over here
so down below it created the snapshot
i'm going to copy that url i'm just
going to paste it on in over here and
see what happens
notice that this person isn't
technically in the same project or
anything i could just share it with
anybody
and so here is that project um
and we'll give it a moment here
we'll have to look at snapshots in a
little more detail when we get to that
section but what i want to find out is
is this extension installed here on this
version here with firefox so now if i go
over to ruby
is it installed
it is installed okay so this firefox
one is my other
my main
getpod account and i did not install
this so you can tell that it came along
there with the getpod.yaml file didn't
like say hey we installed it other than
the fact that we checked it but that is
uh good to see
i think it can be interesting if we can
try to bring in a vsix file uh so that
will be something we'll give it a go
here so maybe what we could do
um maybe there's like something a little
bit more obscure that we could uh
install
just go back here
i was trying to think of something that
probably isn't installed
like maybe this thing here
okay don't know what it is
but what i'll do
yet another client cool but what i'll do
is i'll go over to
the extensions here and we'll just see
if we have it installed yet
just in case it's not good so what i
want to do is see if i can download this
and then reference it so we'll hit
download
and we're going to download that vsix
file and i'm just curious because they
say that you can rename these files
right you can rename these files
and from there if you rename them with
zip you can open them up
so that's what i'm going to do i'm just
doing this off screen here by the way
just because i have so many things here
i'm just going to maybe expand that here
there i'm just showing you the file i'm
going to go here and rename this to
zip
okay
we'll say yes
and i'm just going to open it up
and then here in winrar we can see the
contents of this file
and i'm kind of interested in its
contents i might uh go ahead and
actually download this
into our git pod
that's what i'm going to do
so what i'm going to do is go back here
and we're just going to copy the link
address here
and from here i'm just going to do
curl
maybe wget i prefer wget
and we're just going to download that
file within this here
so if we go over here we can see the
vsix file
and so now uh what i can do is i can
just copy this
and then we're going to type it again
and just change it over to zip
and then i think i can just type unzip i
always forget what it is but we'll try
it and it did it just unzip the contents
there so
we have this file here an xml file that
describes something
and then we have the manifest file so i
guess it describes
its manifest
and then we open up the extension here
is a bunch of stuff so it looks like you
can set uh the icon here
it looks like it's just javascript
though we opened up this package so
there's like a readme about it
i get i've never made a extension so i'm
just kind of poking around here to see
what there is
so probably like this code is
pre-compiled out so i can't imagine like
the developer works this way so this is
like a compiled uh version of their
their source code so you probably
wouldn't want to uh
like
um unravel this so it's not like it's
showing
all the details of it but you know just
curious to kind of open that up but
anyway now that we have the that there
let's go see if we can actually specify
now if you want to install this locally
i'm pretty sure if we go to
i saw it the other day here
i thought it was up here in the top
right corner people go extensions ah
here we go so you can install from vsix
and so here we could specify a
a path
all right
but i don't know if this would actually
take this from a
a local a local path here because they
don't show that in the example over here
see how it's a url so i think that we
would have to um host that somewhere so
to speak so what i'm going to do is i'm
just going to go ahead and
commit this
all this stuff
we'll just say git add all get commit
hyphen m
ext code
the only problem is repo is not public
facing
and if it's not public facing i'm not
sure how it's going to pick up that
extension
so
maybe what i should do
and we can commit all this stuff i don't
care what i'm going to do is just create
a new repository here that's public
facing
get pod whoops
getpod.exe example
and we'll make this one public
but this time around i'm just going to
upload a file so here we could say
upload an existing file
and so i'm just going to drag that file
on in
okay i'm just renaming it back to what
it was so we'll go there
so now this file is uploaded in this
repository
in a public repository and so now what i
want is just the raw version of this
file so
maybe we just
yeah we grab this link here so we go
copy link address and we go back over to
here
and get rid of this thing here get out
of here it won't get out of the way
i'm not sure how to get rid of context
menus that are like that
that's really annoying
okay there we go it just closed on its
own i didn't do anything so i'll paste
that on in there and i again i don't
know this is going to work but i'm just
going to try it anyway
and so what we'll do is just
update our commit here so
try and install
http yak
okay
and we'll save changes we'll say okay
and i kind of lost where we are so i'm
going to open up the context here
and we'll close the old tab and we'll
just hit get pod and we'll see if that
actually installs while it's going let's
go let's go take a look at what this
actually is get another client quickly
and easily send rest soap graphql or
grpc request directly in your editor
so i guess it's like kind of a little
convenience thing
yeah i've never heard of it
sounds cool though
and so this has started back up and so
what i want to know is is this installed
so if we go to our extensions
and i think that it's installing this
but we'll take a look here http yak
and click that it is now installed so
there you go that's uh that's kind of
interesting there
um
another thing that we can look at is the
built-in extension so if you type in at
sign built in
this is all the stuff that is um
installed by default for you
and so there's quite a bit quite a lot
of interesting stuff here so you can
just like scroll through and kind of see
the information so you got features lots
of themes
and lots of supported programming
languages but you know
is what it is and everything's really
snappy too with all the stuff installed
so
it's really great um but that's pretty
much all i really wanted to show for
extensions
so we'll just close all the stuff and
there we go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at git pod workspaces
which represents an ephemeral isolate
runtime system running within a docker
container on a kubernetes cluster so
there's a lot going on there and so i
just want to take an opportunity to
describe in brief a lot of these terms
so first of all what is a container this
is a runtime environment that includes
configuration for os so operating system
memory disk and network access what is
docker so this is an open source
container containerization platform to
package application or workloads uh into
containers we have kubernetes so
kubernetes is a open source container
orchestration to coordinate and maintain
many container images and then we have
ephemeral which means lasting a short
amount of time and then a runtime system
a piece of software that provides the
programmer a more convenient environment
for running programs in our case the run
time system is intended for development
in practicality you need to remember all
these terms not so much just the fact
that workspaces um are ephemeral so they
only last a short amount of time and
they're for development and they use
containers okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
talking about the underlying git pod
resource size because this is a question
that my co-founder came to me and said
what is the power under the hood for
these workspaces and when i looked into
it i discovered that gitpod does not
allow you to choose the power of the
underlying instance and that might sound
like a negative but it's actually a very
strong positive because they're
abstracting away a decision for you so
you can just focus on the business value
and that is what we call a true
uh serverless offering okay and so um
you could say gitpod is a serverless
cloud developer environment
so the underlying computing power is
unknown but we generally know the limits
of an individual workspace because if
you go into the
discourse the the forms for gitpod
we've seen
engineers at gitpod describe what limits
there are
and so the generally known limits is
like v7vcpus
12 gigabytes of ram 30 gigabytes of disk
and you can see there are some
explanations as to what that is
but the idea is that you shouldn't
really have to worry about it it's the
idea is you just pay a fixed cost and
whatever size you need is available to
you
um but you can always self-host right so
if you do need more direct control of
the underlying computing layer i think
that would be an option where you would
have to self-host but there's so much
you can do with git pod and you don't
have to worry about uh picking what
virtual machine you need to launch it
just works okay
[Music]
okay let's talk about workspace
lifecycle or just features of a
workspace so the first is workspace
timeout so after a period of inactivity
a workspace will be stopped the default
timeout is 30 minutes timeouts can be
extended to 60 or 180 minutes with the
unleashed plan and there is a few
caveats that we're missing there but
that's okay we have a slide dedicated uh
or video dedicated just to timeout okay
then we have our
ephemeral storage so this is storage
that will be on a virtual disk available
to the workspace when a workspace is
stopped the data on the affir
affair removal storage is persisted and
saved so when a workspace is deleted or
terminated the data on the storage is
lost so only the data located in that
ford slash workspace is going to be
persisted so
anything out there when you stop it
there's no guarantee that it's going to
be there then we have garbage collection
so get pot allows for a certain amount
of stopped workspaces to remain for
reuse
and this is really useful if you ever
have to go back a few versions there i
don't know if it stops at 200 but i just
know that we have a range selection of
50 to 200 so it's my assumption that
there's nothing beyond 200 why you need
more i don't know but um i'm just
stating that number's there for you so
get by will begin deleting workspaces
beyond a certain number uh uh
based off of days of non-use so
currently it's hardcoded for 14 days so
if you have like 50 or 30 workspaces and
you haven't touched them for 14 days
they're going to get permanently deleted
and you won't be able to spin them back
up and i mean generally the idea is that
you don't really want to be leaving
workspaces with code lying around for
that long so i think that's okay
[Music]
okay so let's talk about the underlying
life cycle and phases for a workspace to
distinguish from like when i said
workspace lifecycle earlier i meant
let's just say like features but that's
what the documentation called it so now
we're actually talking about the actual
lifecycle of a workspace here so when a
workspace is created it will go through
a fixed life cycle separating phases
these phases are currently not
observable by the end user within
gitpodio
however i would imagine that if you are
doing self-hosted gitpod uh open source
version so on a managed kubernetes
cluster this information would be
somewhere available in the logs uh we
might discover that as we do the
self-hosted
um follow along to see what we can see
there but um it's still useful to go
through these states so we understand
what's happening under the hood so the
first is unknown so indicates an issue
within the system and that it cannot
determine the actual phase of the
workspace we have preparing so this is
where it's building the docker image for
the workspace pending the workspace does
not yet consume resources in the cluster
creating the workspace is currently
being created initializing the phase in
which the workspace is executing the
appropriate workspace initializer
running so the workspace is able to
actively perform work either by serving
a user through
thea or as a headless workspace
interrupted the container should be
running but it is temporarily
unavailable it should sir it should self
resolve or
running or just running or stopping
sorry and so stopping that's when the
workspace is currently shutting down
then stopped the workspace ended
regularly because it was shut down so
again uh you know we might not see this
until we do the self-hosted section here
but i always think it's useful to kind
of pull this information uh up up front
here so we know what's going on
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at workspace instance
types so within a workspace cluster
several types of workspace exist the
first is regular so when a user launches
a workspace with the visible code energy
ui this is considered a regular
workspace or just as we call it a
workspace
other types of workspaces are
headless because there is no code editor
ui for the user to interact with the
first being ghost so ghost workspaces
are placeholders in the system they are
used to scale up nodes ahead of time and
are replaced by regular workspaces when
needed they are a custom implementation
of preemptable kubernetes pods then you
have pre-builds and you will encounter
this in the getpodio
and so pre-builds are triggered
automatically or manually performing the
before init execution order sets within
a git pod conversion file task so a
pre-build will generate a snapshot and
upload their log output for later
consumption i haven't figured out where
that log output is but it says that they
do it and then builds i had to surmise
are when a user manually takes a
snapshot for sharing a workspace uh
you know via a snapshot okay so there's
that i think it's called snapshot but
when you opened up the
get pod
command palette there's like an option
to
do that there and again these are those
headless workspaces okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
looking at timeouts for gitpod
workspaces and there's five things i
want you to know so when you stop an
instance the workspace will shut down
instantly deleting instance will delete
the current state of the workspace
stopping it will persist the data okay
then when you close a browser tab the
workspace will shut down in three
minutes this is really great to know
because i i never knew when i closed the
browser tab what would happen there but
it reached out and said don't worry
andrew after three minutes it will shut
down so that's nice to know
then there's a case where you might
leave a browser tab open so by default
after 30 minutes it will turn off
but if you need beyond 30 minutes what
you can do is upgrade to the unleashed
plan and that allows you to set a need
new default of 60 minutes or you could
just say one hour there um and then
there's a case where you can even have
it even longer than that so maybe you
need a timeout because you're doing like
a long build so you can boost the time
of the current workspace up to three
hours when i say up to i think you just
choose three hours uh and uh that's
again with the unleashed plan so here's
kind of an example where somebody has
the default of 60 minutes and for
whatever reason they need to extend it
so they press that button um and the the
idea behind boosting is it's useful when
you have a computational task that is
going to take a long period of time so
you're going to be inactive maybe you
need to leave for lunch and ensure it
remains running so you're just like okay
i'm going to press that button like
maybe i'm going to a meeting and i have
and i just want to make sure my
workspace doesn't shut down for whatever
reason so it's not interrupted
so you know those are the five cases
that i want you to know okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and what i want
to show you here in get pod is a a
feature of the unleashed plan or
actually two features so what i'll do is
make my way over to settings
and go over to plans just to show you
that i've temporarily upgraded here so
we can show you timeout and three hour
timeout boost now i don't think there's
an option to choose from 30 minutes to
one hour once you are on this plan it
just is one hour timeout uh and it's not
something you have to really worry about
because you have unlimited hours at this
time so it's not something you have to
like try to conserve where you are
trying to worry about this meter up here
but let's showcase what the three hour
timeout boost looks like so what i'll do
is go back to my workspaces here you can
do this with anything just launch
whatever you can here so i'm just going
to open something that i was recently
working on so that was gke
i'm not sure if this one was even
successful i think i might have been
making a video for it and it didn't work
out which is totally fine but i'll just
launch it anyway again doesn't matter
which one you launch i just want to show
you how do you do that timeout boost
and i was saying like that timeout boost
is really good if you have some long
running tasks uh and you know that
you're going out for lunch and you just
want to make sure that that that thing
keeps running so um i believe that it's
down below here so i'm just looking for
it if there is a boost so down below
here see it says workout timeout 60
minutes click to extend and so you can
do it here i'm not going to click it
just yet but i just want to see if it
shows up under the command pal so i
clicked on the get pod logo in the
bottom left corner it says extend work
space timeout so what i'm going to do is
click the one in the bottom right corner
i know it's really hard to see but just
know that i'm clicking it it says work
timeout has been extended to three hours
now would that be reflected anywhere i'm
not sure so we'll just go to get podio
we're going to go look at this workspace
and there's no reflection that we know
that it's currently being extended so
you just have to know
if we go back here let me just see here
what happens if i hover over it so it
says 180 minutes click to extend can i
extend it again i doubt it
okay let's go over here again
so yeah it just says 180 min so 180
minutes is is three hours so the thing
is you would just assume that you would
keep this tab open and if you saw the
the little yellow icon you know that
it's still there so let's see what
happens if we close this
okay and then we reopen it
i just want to see if that yellow
little icon still stays active so that
you know that it's still there so we're
opening it up again here
and yeah it's yellow so if it's yellow
that's how you're going to know that
it's extended to three hours um so yeah
there you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about the workspace
directory so when you launch a workspace
the contents of your git repository will
be copied to a directory or folder
called forward slash workspace so here
you can see
i have a project called exam pro
marketing it's my marketing website and
so i've opened i've opened up this git
pod and you can see that that folder has
been cloned into that workspace
directory so when a workspace is stopped
the contents of only workspace is saved
so when you start the workspace again
it's going to have that content still
there and even in the um the gitpod io
it'll even tell you what changes are
there like you have 132 files changed so
you have some kind of indicator between
different
um stop workspaces the difference there
so here's an example
of a gitpod configuration file because
we actually can change some of the
defaults here so you can change
what gitpod considers the workspace
location and in some cases with legacy
go length projects you might need to
change the checkered location there's
not really any reason to ever touch
these options but it's just the fact
that they are available to you i
wouldn't even know outside of that
golang project use case why you never
touch these things but they are here
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at context and gitpod url
so a context represents a state within
your git source code and with a get pod
url you can quickly load an environment
for a context so here we have the git
pod url it starts with this gitpodio
forward slash pound and then it's
followed by a url and that is what
gitpod is going to try to figure out the
context of when it launches
our workspace so the first is repository
con context and so this is just you
provide a repository it's going to open
it up for you to work in then you have
branches
or branch and commit contacts so this is
really useful if you are doing feature
branch workflows or that's how you do
that kind of stuff or you just have any
kind of branches that you have there
when you have commit contexts that's
when you are digging back in your old
code maybe you are trying to revert code
back to a previous state or there's a
deep rooted issue and you're just trying
to rule it out by going to a specific
version uh there so here is a branch and
here is a commit message with its shaw
there that's the code on the end
then you have issue context so feature
development or bug fixing so this is
where um you know like github
has a project management tooling
and you can say okay somebody opened up
this feature this bug this whatever
request and you can then open it
in the context there
then you have pull and merge request
contacts so this would be for like code
review before merging for deployment so
here we have a pull request and so get
pod url support github get lab bit
buckets so if they have integration
they're of course going to support the
get pod url for that okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
share snapshot workspace so this will
let you take a snapshot url of your
current uh workspace at any time and
share them with others so the way that
would look like is you drop down file
you go to get pod share workspace
snapshot you can also open it up in the
command palette and from there
it will start to create a snapshot and
so i think this would show up as a build
phase underneath in kubernetes we talk
about those underlying phases somewhere
in the course here
and from there
it's going to say okay it's generated
you can go copy that url to your
clipboard and that's what it looked like
so notice it has the pound
snapshot forward slash and then a big
long uuid
uh there and so
that's pretty much the process not too
complicated so anyone clicking on such a
snapshot link will get a complete clone
of your workspace including the state
of the workspace and the vs code layout
so workspaces created from snapshots are
treated as restarts so you can configure
them to launch differently than if you
had created a fresh workspace from git
unlike sharing running workspaces
snapshots workspaces are full copies
this means developers can do whatever
they like with the content no access to
your credentials or environment
variables are shared and we will double
check to make sure that is true um but
yeah that's that's share snapshot
workspace okay
[Music]
so the other way of sharing git pods is
via the share running workspace which
allows multiple developers to
collaborate on a single workspace in
real time and the flow here goes as
follows turn on sharing for the current
workspace copy the current link to the
uh to the workspace share the current
workspace with other developers so the
idea is it'll be a share button down
below you press it you turn it on you'll
get this link
and then you'll just share that with
other developers so a shared running
workspace cannot be opened in the
desktop vs code unless you're the owner
of the shared running workspace so if
you are used to using the desktop vs
code and somebody shares a workspace
just understand that there are those
limitations but i have to be uh very
careful here to tell you that when you
share a workspace you are literally
giving access to someone else to act as
you within your workspace they can
access sensitive information such as
access key secrets stored in the
environment variables
the commits in the workspace will show
up as you instead of the guest developer
they can share that link with other
people and you wouldn't even know it
it is not easy to tell who is currently
editing in your current workspace so
it's generally recommended to avoid or
be very careful when sharing a running
workspace and it's just that it's just
the state of this this feature for the
time being so getpod has made sharing
available to you they're going to
continue to develop this so that you
have more visibility over time but just
understand that there might be some
limitations there so if this is the
future just review this and see if it's
still true uh because some of these
might have been mitigated by the time
you were watching this video but just in
case uh be on the side of being wary
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at getpodcli so this
allows you to perform a variety of
utility commands useful for day-to-day
use in your gitpod workspace so
getpodcli comes pre-installed in your
workspace and is accessible via the
terminal so let's take a look at the
commands that we have available to us so
notice that it always starts with gp
okay so that is the name of the cli but
we have help so help about any command a
net so create a git pod configuration
for this project env controls user
defined persistent environment variables
url prints the url of this workspace
open opens a file in git pod
preview opens a url in the ides
preview
forward port so make a port available on
0.0.0.0
so it's exposed to internet um but you
know i don't really understand what
they're saying there because the way
i've been using it is just to forward
one port to another and we saw that in
that section earlier when we were
covering ports so maybe it has more than
one purpose here we have a weight port
so waits for a process to listen on a
port sync a weight so weights an event
triggered using the sync done
and then sync done notifies the
corresponding sync await calls that this
event has happened so a lot of these
we've actually already encountered in
the course so i'm not going to cover
those again here but we will cover the
ones that we have yet to
explicitly
uh uh talk about okay
all right let's take a look at the uh
get pod cli open command and this will
open the target file in the code editor
so the idea is you're gonna say gp open
and then give the path to the file that
you want to open
and so here i'm just doing gp open gem
file and then it opens the gem file
there uh and so that's just a a very
convenient way of opening files okay
[Music]
all right let's take a quick look here
at the gp url cli command which will
turn the gitpod workspace url so there i
type in gpurl and then i get that there
and i just wanted to show you that if
you type in env and you do a grep get
pod workspace url that's going to return
uh the same values so i'm just showing
you that it's a convenience for
uh getting the getpod workspace url
environment variable okay
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at the preview command for
the getpodcli so gpreview
command can be used to open a web url in
line with the vs code editor so here you
can see me using the gp preview command
using some fancy um uh bash scripting
with it to open up the current uh
machine and so you know you can see that
it's completely in line within the code
editor so you can use echo
echoing out the gpurl and modify the url
to include the port number and so
originally when i was doing this and you
can see this in the example here that i
was doing this like weird sed thing
because i didn't realize you could just
do this down below so you could do gp
preview and then do gp url 3000. i was
doing like some weird stuff there
but i found another repository that had
a more convenience method so
um once i discovered that i had to go
back and reshoot this video so i just
want you to know that that's the way you
would do it this one down below the ones
above here is totally acceptable as well
but this is what you'll probably want to
do and what i'll be showing uh in the in
the follow alongs okay but there you go
hey this is andrew brown and in this
follow along i just want to cover some
of the cli commands i haven't really
been using that much like open url and
preview
just so that you know what to use them
for so i'm going to go here and type in
git pod cli and we're going to create
ourselves a new private repository out
of remy file and we're going to go ahead
and get this going here um and we are
going to launch ourselves a new git pod
here and we'll give it a moment
and i really don't think if you go to
the cli here and they really should add
this in the documentation um but i don't
think that the preview at least i didn't
see it had a very good example
so it says gpurl8080
oh i guess they did and i just never
noticed
so that's okay i'm going to go back to
the preview you're not going to notice
it but i'm going to reshoot the cli
preview to show this more condensed
example
but what we're going to do here is
create ourselves a new folder called
oops i want a folder not a file a new
folder called public
and in that folder we're going to create
a new file called index
dot html and within that we're going to
say hello world
and then from there we are going to go
and open up our terminal
and i'm just going to install
http server globally
okay and then we'll just say http server
and leave it where it wants to be and
say port 8080
and so it's going to ask us if we want
to open that port i'm going to say make
public
and
from there
i didn't see it pop up
but we'll go over to our remote explorer
here left-hand side just make sure that
the website is working there it is so
you know if we wanted to open up let's
say we close this file here and we
wanted to open that file from the cli
i'm just going to type in clear here
what we could do is type in gp open
and then i could type in relative to
where i am so public
index.html and it's going to open that
up
oh sorry it's gp not gh i'm thinking
github it will be that'll be the way we
can open up files and that's for the
convenient when you're trying to uh
when you can locate things easily
through here and you want to open them
up
in the top there
and then we'll take a look at um clear
so i'm going to see if we have two
bashes running we don't so i'm going to
at this top one here can i rename this i
can so we'll go here and just say like
http server here
and i'm just going to start up our
server again so we'll say http server
port 8080
and then down below here where we have
our little playground i'm going to just
type in gp
open 8080.
oops uh sorry i meant to say gp oops
clear
gp url 8080.
and so notice what it did is that if you
just type in url
it's going to give you the plain jane
url which is actually just the url up
here if you put in 8080 it's going to
add it over here and so then what you
can do is take this url and you can
paste it up into here which is great
and so now we could use the gp preview
um
which will uh open something over here
so if i was to do something like and i
don't think it'll work in here but i'm
gonna just type in google.com
okay for whatever reason it doesn't like
things that are outside the scope of
this project but just showing you an
example of opening that window there
what we could do is type in get
gp preview and then do this so this is
like a bash thing for encapsulating uh
stuff and we just type in gpurl8080
and so now we can open it up here and so
that would be the convenience way of
doing that so you know that's gp open gp
url and gp preview if we just want to
look at all them that are there i think
we've pretty much used everything the
other one we haven't used is stop
um so
i guess for fun we can just do it so
we'll just do gp stop
and that will that should stop this
environment so we'll give it a moment
see what happens
is it stopping uh it doesn't look like
it's stopping
oh it did okay so there you go so that
is all the cli stuff uh covered okay
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at the get pod palette
commands so the gitpod palette commands
is a series of commands you can use
within vs code to perform gitpod actions
and so this is in the command palette
within vs code but if you click the
little orange button in the bottom left
corner you'll get all the possible
commands so let's just quickly go
through them to see if there's anything
that you might like to use uh during
your workflow and through the follow
alongs you'll see me using some of these
because they are useful okay so the
first is stop workspace so stops does
not terminate but stops the current
workspace open settings so it opens
account settings for the current
gitpod user open access control so it
opens gitpod integrations page open
context it opens the context this is
really good when you need to go back to
the repository i use that one quite a
bit open dashboard so it opens the
gitpod io
platform default page so it's going to
take you to projects documentation
follow them on twitter which doesn't
hurt to have that in there i suppose
open community chat so that's going to
be on discord open community forum
that's going to be on discourse
report an issue that just takes you to
github issues
upgrade subscription this isn't going to
upgrade your plan if you click on it
it's just going to take you to the plans
page so you can choose a plan so don't
be afraid to click on that
extend workspace timeout so only works
with specific plans
share workspace snapshots so this is
when you create a snapshot and it
returns a snapshot link for sharing
share running workspace so turns on
sharing i don't i generally don't do
from the command panel there's like a
little share button down below
um open in vs code so open the workspace
in your desktop
version of vs code so the desktop vs
code
or insiders and that's just the beta
version of vs code it's just another one
okay so that is the command palette or
palette commands for git pod okay
hey this is andrew brown and in this
follow along we're going to just take a
quick look here at the get pod uh
palette commands so if you're not
familiar with uh command palette within
visual studio code it's a way of
executing a lot of uh easy
scripts i suppose you could describe it
as so the way you would access that is
you go to the hamburger menu here in the
top left corner and you go to i believe
view you'll see command palette notice
it says ctrl shift p so i'm going to
type that instead and if we type that we
have a bunch of different commands here
that we can enter in and this is really
dependent on what extensions you have
installed or just uh you know the
defaults that come with it
i don't use visual studio code a whole
lot so i don't even know what the most
common ones are but i do know that there
are git pod ones if you type in git pod
these are the ones here and notice that
there are a few extra things here that i
typed in that will not appear if we just
go click on the other area so just
notice that you might have some
advantage there if you just type it in
but we click off and you open that
hamburger menu again there are some of
them the most commonly used ones here uh
down below but if you want all the
command uh palette or or git pod uh
palette commands if you click this
orange button down below here it'll pop
them up okay so you know just so you
know how to get to those
again if you click any of these and
you've seen us do this a bunch of times
within the course i go to open context
it'll open up where this repository is
things like that but i just wanted to
make sure you understood uh what command
palette was and how to access all the
get pod command palettes okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at teams and projects
within gitpodio so getpod team allows
you to invite people to collaborate on
your project
and so you can create multiple teams and
and uh one thing i noticed is that if
you try to name your team
something like marketing it won't be
permitted because getpod is utilizing
something called the big username
blocklist so just understand that there
might be some limitations around the
naming you might have to be clever
but probably you won't run to the issue
i just choose to choose the name
marketing i just happen to hit that
block list
within a project you can have members
and sign them roles and so you have two
types of roles member and role
and then projects has the main advantage
of allowing you to utilize pre-builds
and i want to point out that you have a
personal account and you can think of it
as a team of one and so within your
personal account you can create projects
and that in turn will allow you to use
pre-build so pre-build is not
exclusively
for just teams okay just understand it's
specific to projects
[Music]
so let's take a closer look at um get
pod
roles so within a gitpod team a member
can be signed either the owner or member
role but the key difference between an
owner and a member is that a member
cannot manage team members or delete the
team and so this is the full matrix here
and while i'm just getting my pen tool
out so we have manage team members
delete
delete team invite team members add
projects remove projects add project
view branches view pre-builds trigger
pre-builds and so at this stage of the
product you just have those two roles i
would imagine in the future they'll
probably open it up so you can choose
exactly what you want but for the time
being that is what we have and it works
pretty well
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at pre-build so pre-builds
is a continuous build server that will
run every time you push code to
repository so here is an example of a
bunch of pre-builds that are happening
for a workspace and so these are
really convenient let's talk about what
a pre-built workspace is so pre-builds
will execute the before internet
commands within your
kidpod.yaml files on a git commit and
produce a snapshot and we saw that
earlier in the course when we were
looking at execution order steps where
we have kind of a visualization there
the snapshot can be launched uh which
will save your development team time
waiting for lengthy builds
okay
um the idea here is you can trigger
pre-builds automatically so a pre-build
will trigger on the default branch for
pull requests and merges from the same
repository i have yet to see options to
allow you to kind of customize that i'm
sure they'll do that in the future you
can also trigger pre-builds manually so
a pre-built can be manually triggered by
adding the pound pre-build to a git pod
url if that's one way you want to do it
i also think that there's a tab in a
project that lets you do it like
configuration or the file itself but i
don't think that would be a way that you
generally do if you wanted to do it you
probably use the get part url
prebuilts have a timeout of one hour of
the combined time of the before init
before failing so if you know if it
takes too long it will just fail here
you can see i have a failed example uh
in that page there so they took too long
for whatever reason get pod does not
cache artifacts between pre-built each
pre-built is a clean environment
what's interesting is that they do have
something with dazzle which will
actually
cache layers and stuff like that so i
think that you know this
might be an option in the future that we
might have that functionality but there
you go that's pre-builds
[Music]
so with tail scale you can automatically
and securely connect your git pod
workspace to other development resources
whether in the cloud or on-prem such as
a production database behind your
company's firewall so the idea here is
that you have your laptop it's going to
connect to
tail scale and through tail scale you'll
have a secure connection to git pod when
you're on the go so let's just define
some of these terms like
vpn so a virtual private network or vpn
extends a private network across a
public network and enables users to send
and receive data across shared or public
work networks as if computing devices
were directly connected to the private
network then the question is what is
wireguard so it's a simple yet fast and
modern vpn that utilizes
state-of-the-art uh cryptography and so
then we have tail scale so tail scale is
built on top of the uh the point to
point open source wire guard protocol
which powers an encrypted mesh network
or tail net gitpod has an official
partnership with wireguard so if you
need to have point-to-point vpn access
um then just so you have a secure
connection this is what you can use okay
[Music]
this is andrew brown and this follow
along we're going to learn all about
projects and the features underneath it
so probably cover pre-builds as well so
what i've done is i have a one git pod
account here and i have another one over
here on the side i'll just pull it up
here i had to do this one in firefox and
in the course we might have set up a
project before i'm just connecting here
uh to my my gitpod account here so here
is one i know they're both named andrew
brown but they're on different emails
here and so the idea is i want to create
a project and then once i'm in a project
we want to kind of explore the feature
set that is there okay
so uh from the chrome account here what
i'm going to do is drop down the top
here and go to new team we're going to
name that so i'm going to name this uh
my
um get pod team
or maybe exam pro code team and i might
have named that one previously in
another video that's totally fine and so
now that i have my team i need to start
inviting people so we'll make our way
over to members and from here you can
see i have the exam pro co i'm gonna go
ahead and invite one and grab this link
and i'm gonna go over here to my other
browser firefox we'll paste that in
there
and now i've been added so there's no
prompt to say hey do you want to be in
this group it's just if you uh click
through the link you'll be added to it
so we'll go back here and we'll just
close and we'll give it a refresh
okay
give it a moment
and so if i want to change them to a
oh sorry a member i can i don't see why
you'd want to switch yourself out from
owner um i don't know what happened if
you did that because if you had two
members
that could be disastrous but i don't
even want to try because i just don't
want that to get stuck
um and so
there's this option here remaining owner
so i think maybe you're not allowed to
at least remove one but again i'm not
going to test that functionality there
they have a filter here you can only
remember there's only two roles there's
not much going on there let's take a
look at settings
under here all we can do is delete the
team
i imagine the future will expand that
and then we have workspaces um so as we
add projects here that will go there so
let's go ahead and add our first new
project
and so uh here we have a
you actually have to select the context
here so
this is where you might select a
different repository so up here it says
git repository git lab so you can change
this out to gitlab or github i guess
bitbucket is not an option here as of
yet
but i'm going to switch over to github
and so now here are all of our
repositories that we could collaborate
on so here i might want to launch up um
hello world i might have like a hello
world one in here so we'll select this
one here
and from there we can go ahead and
create that new workspace
all right and so here's student
pre-built so as soon as you use
as soon as you use
projects
pre-built are going to happen so i don't
think there's an option to turn
pre-builds off it's just like if it is a
project it will always do pre-builds and
in that case you might run into
some uh scenarios there or some issues
there
but we'll we'll address those maybe in
this fall along here
but anyway so
uh this project has launched which is
really great
uh and that is running but now if we go
back to get pods so we'll open up our
hamburger menu here and go back to our
get pod dashboard
and we go under the workspaces we can
see oops notice here i'm not in um
the right project so we go here go to
project so there it is so we can see
that we're on main it started a few
seconds ago it has pre-builds
and if we go to view all
we can just kind of look at some of the
options here so here a pre-build was
successful
and we go to configuration here and so
we have some options here so
configuration already exists in git
run a pre-build or open the new
workspace to edit the controls so i
suppose you can edit this and then run
or pre-build i've never found any reason
to do this um but i guess it could be a
way of like forcing a pre-build for you
to test things
we'll go back to our branches here and
apparently you can do things with
branches as well
um so i'm not exactly sure what we would
do here
but um
i guess like we could just go ahead and
create a branch and see what happens so
we go get check out hyphen b um
we'll call it development here
because i'm just trying to think like
how that would affect workflow maybe
staging might be a better branch i'll
just say git push
and then we'll have to push upstream
here which is totally fine we'll say
allow and hit
enter okay we'll make our way back over
here
and if we give it a refresh i'm going to
see if that registers that other branch
okay and so i guess from here this would
be a great opportunity for you to launch
a new workspace so this will do
pre-builds always the main branch will
always do it
and so i guess here
we can run it manually
so i don't know i don't know if you push
to a branch if it will actually trigger
it i'm not sure if that pre-build is
running i don't see it running let's
just give it a refresh here i i don't
feel like i clicked it so we'll go back
here one more time we'll say run
pre-build
okay so i don't see anything happening
here um unless it's delayed or something
but from the documentation remember you
can only really do it for the main
branch so maybe that functionality is
just not there yet but we can launch a
new workspace for that staging
environment that or maybe there's
nothing to pre-build because
it is forked off that other one so maybe
it's based off the the main pre-build so
what we'll do is we'll just make some
super minute change to the code here and
then maybe that is what we need to
trigger it so i'll go over here and
we'll just say hello world and we'll
just add an extra exclamation mark here
and what i'll do is i will go back to
um
we'll commit that here
so we'll add it and say minor
commit because i'm really curious that
the pre-build will trigger
and uh we will go back here
to uh this oops i guess we'll have to go
back to the dashboard and then close
that tab
and so now what i want to know is it
going to trigger
that pre-built because i don't think it
will on this branch here right so we go
over here no pre-branches or pre-builds
what if i do run pre-build
okay
ah so now it's running so i think that
was the case was the fact that i had
forked it
and or not forked it but i had created a
branch but it was like there was no
difference between the main ones so
there was no reason for it to run a
pre-built
now will it run and pre-build every
single time i'm not sure so again we
will go ahead and launch
this new workspace
and we'll just make a test see here if
it
automatically runs
because maybe once you've done one
pre-build it will just keep triggering
but as far as i'm aware it shouldn't i
think it would just be it wouldn't do
that so go back here add another
exclamation mark whoops or net sign
that's totally fine too it doesn't
really matter we're going to go ahead
and commit that into exclamation
and we'll say okay
and we'll give it a moment to sync we'll
say okay
just making sure it syncs because it's
doing this funny thing here so i just
don't have confidence that it's doing
what it's supposed to be doing
and while we're waiting on that i'm just
going to open up the dashboard again
here
and i'm also going to open up the
context
because i just want to see did it push
that change right so i go over here and
we have uh we need to go to the staging
branch right we are in staging no
so i don't know it's acting kind of
funny here so what i'm going to do is
just launch it again
and that's the nice thing when these
environments are
temporary you can just keep launching
new ones so i'll just launch a new one
we'll give it a moment here
and so um
if we go over to
[Music]
our our code here again i'm just going
to try one more time to change this
and we will go back here we will add
this file we'll just say miner change
and we'll commit this
and we'll sync the changes again
okay and that worked no problem this
time so i'm not sure what the issue was
before but that's okay and so just to
confirm back in the staging here i'm
just going to double check to make sure
that change has been applied remember i
haven't told it to manually run so
that's what i'm really interested to
find out here so we'll go back and open
our dashboard
and we are going to
wait for that to load we'll click into
that it says ready
a few seconds ago i'm going to go to
pre-builds there's only two here so i
think again like if you want to build
these minor ones you're always going
like the other branches you're going to
have to go here and uh trigger that
though it's not saying there's anything
new
there's no available actions
we'll go back over to pre-builds here
it would probably help if i had a
different name but that's four minutes
ago so
um
yeah i'm not sure
give you a refresh here
so a few minutes ago so for whatever
reason i can't seem to trigger
a new pre-build so but anyway i guess
the thought is like really the the stuff
you're going to be focusing around is
the main branch okay
um so i think that's pretty much it with
uh projects not super complicated but i
think i might want to just run through
pre-builds a bit here and just look at a
scenario where i ran into where i was
confused and like there wasn't an issue
but i just wasn't uh realizing that the
pre-build was the part that was kind of
difficult okay so i'll just make that a
separate video and we'll just pick up
here in a second okay
[Music]
all right so what i'd like to do now is
just to kind of show you some friction
you might run into pre-builds because
you need to kind of adjust your script
to work in a pre-built environment and
it's not hard it's just thinking about
pre-builds personally i would recommend
if you can to always have a pre-built
environment or project-based environment
so that when you engineer your git pod
yaml file you don't have to rework it
but let's see if we can run into that
case so maybe a good example would be
just to try to
build out a very simple project that has
um sinatra and we've done that a few
times so maybe we can just pull from our
existing examples so what i'm going to
do is just go to
getpodgitpod.com here and i'm just going
to kind of look through
some of my examples here um we'll go
show more
so we have google play drive init cli
example website
is this the one where we use uh sinatra
no this looks a lot more complicated
that's me forking their website so
that's okay we'll just start from
scratch it only takes like a couple
seconds to do i just can't seem to
remember because it's been a few days it
looks it's for you it seems like i just
i just recorded it's been a few days
since i've made the sinatra one so what
i'm going to do is create a a new
repository here i'm just going to say
pre-build
sinatra
sinatra pre-build example
and i'm going to make this private
and we're going to go ahead down below
and
add a readme file i'm going to create
that repository we're going to give that
a moment to get created we're going to
go ahead and launch that git pod we're
going to go to sinatra
ruby just so that we can get a little
bit of code here to work with and that's
all we're going to really need so i'll
go back here and give it a moment to
load we're going to go ahead and make a
new file i'm going to call this
server.rb whoops
server.rb
uh
rename
we're gonna go ahead and paste that on
in there so we'll say allow and so we're
requiring our sinatra we'll need a gem
file as well actually i'm gonna use
bundler to do that so we'll go to new
terminal and we'll say bundler init
and that will give us a gem file to
start off with i need sinatra so i'll
copy the contents there down below we'll
just type in jam sinatra so that's fine
we'll do a bundle install to install
sinatra
and so once we have that there um we're
going to just take out the that part
there so we don't have to worry about it
and so now we need to create our gitpod
file so we'll say gpnit they'll get us a
starting script here port 3000 is okay
for me i'm fine with that and so i need
a few things here i'm just looking off
screen to
this code here to see
what it is that we can do here so i
don't have to forget
but we don't need a before command
because we don't really need to change
the ruby version
uh rvm list so we are using ruby version
2.7.4 which is fine
um
but what we might want to do is to run
something so it might do things like
bundle install something we definitely
want to do
and for the command we're going to want
to start this uh the servers up saying
bundle exect
ruby
ruby um
it was a port
3000. i can't remember how we set the
sinatra ports
go the docs here
ports
uh configuration settings ports
port sports ports
it's like setport like that eh
so let's just say um whoops we'll go
back to our code over here
where's the code oh we're in hello world
whoops
so go back to this one up here and we'll
go into our server file here
and we'll just say
set environment
actually it's set port
and that's where we do the 3000 right
so
what i'm trying to get at is that um
let's say we want to actually set the
we'll just say env
and we'll just say app port here
and as an example we might want to
set the
um
in here the port number so we might go
like
export
port app port
and actually i don't even know what it
starts on by default so that's not going
to check first just case it starts on
that port by default server.rb here
so this starts on port 8080 so let's say
we wanted to be on this port it's going
to look at like export um environment
variable
as an example here
i always forget how to do it so i just
double check i always feel like there's
like a dollar sign i'm missing
so it's export name equals whatever okay
so we'll go back over here
and so this would set the app port there
and so this app down below should pick
it up right if i just do
server.rb
that should
technically work port 3000 that's
totally fine
so what i'm going to do now is just
restart this app and just put that there
so that doesn't error out
but i'm going to commit these
okay so attempt to or sorry just initial
commit
okay and then we'll just sync those
changes we'll say okay we'll give it a
moment
i'll close up some of these other tabs
here
and so what i'm hoping for
and we'll open up the context here what
i'm hoping for here is that when i
launch this get pot it's just going to
work right it's going to do the bundle
install it's going to export the
environment variable of course we could
just set the environment variable in the
task but i'm trying to stage an example
where when you move over to pre-build
you have to kind of consider how that's
going to change
so we'll give it a moment
and it's opening the tab it's good it's
starting on port 3000 and it works right
so
this part here
whoops
um
this part here worked right so what i'm
saying is like when we move this over to
pre-builds this init step is going to
run
but the problem is is that it's not
going to carry over the state over to
this one so it might install but i my
expectation is this export option won't
be there or another thing it might be
like cd into the directory so one thing
that we might do that might be a better
example would be to make whoops to make
a subfolder here so we might make a new
folder here and we'll call it um
you know application or sorry project
here
and from here i might take uh these
files here and just move them
into yep let's say move it's okay
we'll take the gem file here and move it
into this project here
okay
and actually i might call it app instead
so we'll say rename app
and so instead of doing this you might
say like cd
app right so we're going to cd into it
first
and so let's see if that works
because again i'm just trying to stage
that example to show you what i'm
talking about because i remember that's
where i ran into seeding where i thought
i would be already seated in so if we cd
in the nit will it do in the command i
believe it will
so uh small changes here
put things in a folder
and we'll go ahead and commit that we'll
say yes
we will sync those changes we'll say
okay
and
what we'll do here is we'll wait a
moment and i'll go back over to this
i'll close this tab out and we'll launch
git pod again and that should cd into
that directory and work and then we will
go then make it a project and see how
that changes with the pre builds
all right so we're waiting here a moment
so it's working so it definitely seeded
in and so
i don't know if it shows sometimes it
shows the script of what it ran so if
you look at the script this is what it
did it said cd app bundle install export
and then it did the the next thing which
was the command so it's treated like in
one go in the same environment so now
what we're going to do is we're going to
go make our way over to get podio
and i want to make this actually a
project so i'm going to make a new
project here
and then i want to choose this project
here when it when it gets a moment here
and we're going to choose the um
it's on git lab again so that's fine
we'll just change that to github
it really likes to default to that
gitlab which is totally fine and this is
called sinatra
so we'll type in sinatra here we'll
click here
we'll select
we'll create a new workspace
and now it's going to do the pre-build
and so my expectation is this is going
to fail right because
when it goes through there it's going to
cd
in the one thing and the other one's
going to start not in the cd directory
so give it a moment here
all right and so notice it says could
not locate gem file or bundle okay so if
we scroll on up
you can see um
we are seeing that there's stuff that
around the pre-built so it says cd app
bundle install export stuff this is
stuff that happened in a separate
environment right it didn't happen
um
i'm just trying to see if it shows it
very clearly yeah so these are the
pre-built logs that it ran
right but the thing is is that um
that was in the pre-build environment
we'll bring back up the slides here to
make it more clear okay so here
right it ran before and init so it did
it went seeded into the app directory
and it set the environment variable and
then when it became over here it's
starting from scratch so it's not in
that cd directory
and i don't even know the environment
variables there let's see if that
persisted because that might be
interesting so i'm just going to say env
grep and we'll say app
port
okay
and it looks like it is set because it's
saying it right there
let's just say echo app port
maybe dollar sign goes to show like i've
been doing links for years i can
remember this stuff so it's not set so
the environment variable got set in the
pre-build environment and it's seeding
that directory and that's where before
becomes very useful because it's going
to run twice
right so
um this is where we would take our
script
and
um the bundle install is totally fine
there but we'll just go and we will add
a before step
right
and we will just take the cd out of here
and the app out of here
okay and so the idea is that that's
going to run
both times in each environment right so
this should technically fix our problem
we'll go ahead and save this file and
we'll just say fix pre-builds
and we'll commit that
we will sync those changes we'll say
okay
we'll give it a moment
great we'll close our tab
and i'm going to open up
pod again
and so you notice the pre-build's
happening so it showed us the screen if
our pre-builds had already occurred we
wouldn't see it apparently you can stop
waiting for pre-build which i would
never do that but there could be a case
where you have a very very long
pre-built you just want to get into the
environment
so we'll give it a moment and see if
that fixes our issue
apparently there's a way to trigger
pre-builds from the url it's not
something that i have found a
requirement to do if you're really
interested you could look it up
um but there's that while we're waiting
there we might want to look at pin
projects it's something i haven't done
with gitpod yet
so
you can i guess not projects but
workspaces
so as far as i understand if you have
pinned a workspace it will remain there
longer i believe so that is one
advantage there is that if you have an
environment that you want to stay you
can just pin it okay and i don't think
it will get deleted see unpinned
workspaces that have been active for 14
days will automatically be deleted so if
you have pin an environment and i don't
know if you can pin multiple ones can i
pin this one can i pin that one i have a
feeling there's not like a pin limit so
you could pin as much as you want i
wouldn't probably recommend that
but that might be something you need to
do i haven't found a used to pinning so
far here down below it says exit so i
have a feeling that the pre-build is
done sometimes it gets stuck on the
screen so you can just close that out
and go back over to your projects here
and um just launch it again okay if you
ever see that it's not a big deal just
because it's ready right so
it's not perfect right like you just
have to kind of like and there's no
different than like using aws cloud
service providers you just have to kind
of be watching and aware and just being
like okay i've waited too long let's see
what we can do here and have confidence
so we're waiting a while here for this
to start up
and um let's see what we have so it says
here
uh could not find sinatra gems so bundle
saw to the install missing gems so
it didn't work
as we thought it would
we are cd into the correct directory
we'll do grep um
or we'll just maybe echo it so we'll say
echo
app env or app port
so the port is set so that definitely
fixed it
why the install failed i don't know
because it did run it up here as you can
see
and sinatra 2.1 is installed
um
let me do bundle install here
you know it probably is
it's my script so if you go over here
because i changed it maybe into the cd
directory
because here it cd's into it right but
it would see into that one as well so
that shouldn't affect it
let me just try running bundle exec here
bundle exect
rubyserver.rb
okay so that runs no problem
there's nothing to change
so i don't really trust what happened
there so i'm just going to throw this
environment away and launch a new one so
we'll open up the context we'll close
this out we're going to wait a moment
here we're going to go ahead and launch
a new one i'm just gonna see we're gonna
make a new workspace there and we're
gonna just see if it works this time
around because i'm not sure what it's
complaining about
but once you're used to using pre-builds
and you have the environment working
it's usually not a problem but sometimes
there's a bit of friction moving from a
non-project to another one and that's
why i say like if you start with a
project it's a little bit less painful
someone says this task ran as a
workspace pre-build could not find
sinatra
um things like that so
run bundle and salt to install the
missing gems
so i'm just going to scroll up here and
just see what it ran
so again there shouldn't be
a problem so i'll go back over here
allow
yeah so it's acting like the gems aren't
installed is the gem file there
the gem file lock is there
hmm
this is what i'm trying to figure out
like
hmm
i'm not sure i'll be back here in a
second okay all right so i had a little
bit of time to think about it and you
know what i think is happening is that
when you install ruby gems they're not
installing within this workspace
directory and since anything outside
this workspace directory gets blown away
i think that's the reason why i'm having
this issue now if you're using node node
installs in the current directory so
here like if i wanted to fix this
problem i would just have to look up
like okay how do i install uh the gems
in the current directory if i want those
to be cached and in place so i think
like for ruby workflows it doesn't take
too long to install gems but i think in
this case for like ruby you have two
options you can install based on the
vendor so like
bundler install gems in current
directory or something like that
so i could do this
right and that would probably solve my
issue
um or
you know i could do
you know something else but that means
when i run the uh uh
bundle of stall i think i'd probably
have to specify
um where those gems are but you know the
simple solution here would just be
saying okay
every like to this and put this here
right
but it really depends like if the bundle
install takes really really long time
then maybe i would want to
uh move my uh gems to a vendored like
directory like doing the path so it's
really going to be up to you and the the
constraints of your language but i think
that is the reason that is happening
there so again not a big problem i move
that there and we're okay but yeah i
think we're all done here and uh you
know hopefully you understand how uh
pre-builds work okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at git pod pricing so for
good pod they have four
uh possible plans available to you so we
have the basic uh which is free personal
at nine dollars usd per month
professional 25 usd per month and
unleashed at 39 just deeper month of
course uh always make sure you double
check the prices because they may have
changed um but you know generally they
should be this if you go look online
they don't have
the option to pay annually at least they
did not see
through the checkout process there but
if you do need annual maybe just contact
their team again i don't see anything
describing like an annual discount i
know some organizations care about that
kind of stuff that's why i mention it
but good pod is really uh
nice and easy to reach out to so you
know they probably can make those kind
of accommodations for you
but let's take a look at what changes in
terms of the feature set for these plans
so no matter what plan you're using you
get unlimited private and public
repositories which is really nice in
terms of the amount of workspaces you
can run in parallel
it's for for free and personal
i don't feel like i'd ever be running
more than one workspace at a time
but you know maybe you have more than
one tab open and you're toggling between
uh maybe
different domains
of a microservice app so that's totally
possible
so that's something to consider for
professional you have eight parallel
workspaces unless you have 16 parallel
workspaces
in terms of timeout it's by default 30
minutes between basic and professional
and on unleash you extend it to one hour
as the default right so every time it
launches up it will do that
um then the next thing is how many hours
do we get per month of
of runtime or consumption so for the
basic you have 50 hours for personal
it's 100 hours a month uh and for
professional it's unlimited hours and
then just for the unleashed plan you
have the option to do a three hour time
boost so what they're saying here is
that imagine you are
just you're just about to go for lunch
and you are running some kind of
operation that you know is going to take
a long time to run so you know you don't
know it's going to finish but you have
to let it run for a long time and so
this is your opportunity to boost it so
that your workspace doesn't time out
after an hour and so that is the reason
for that option and so that could be
extremely useful okay
so let's take a look at some of the
other um
plans they have that are outside these
four here so there's the pro open source
so this is a special plan for
professional open source developers with
unlimited hours on any public repository
so you know this is just to help out
people that are developing open source
to help them reduce cost because it's
a lot of work to give out
open source stuff uh right so then
there's a student plan so this is a a
special plan for students so you provide
an email uh with your uh domain of the
institute educational institution so it
probably have to be dot edu
or what have you but the idea here is
you get unleashed for nine dollars a
month which is really nice then there's
git pod for startups so this is eligible
startups that can get unleashed plans
for up to two years on git pods and
there are some particular requirements
so you do have to read into that but if
you are a startup that is a great
opportunity for you there then there's
get pod self hosted professional so
these run get this runs the github
platform on your own uh private networks
or managed uh uh like manage kubernetes
clusters within your own aws azure
account what have you and this is at 35
dollars per month starting with the 11th
user okay
[Music]
so let's talk about how you can monitor
your hourly usage so as you use gitpod
you consume in a lot of amount of hours
based on your plan and so if you go to
the plans page it will show you this
remaining hours things and so here you
can see i have 78.5 hours for the
remainder of the month and so this is
the way you could keep track of your
current usage
is there any way within the gitpod
workspace
uh i didn't find it um but if there is
i'd love someone to tell me but this
this is great too so just if you want to
keep on top of that okay
all right so this follow along what i
want to show you is where you can track
uh your current usage so here i'm on git
pods to go to getpod.io it should
generally bring you here to projects and
so what we can do is make our way over
up to here in the top right corner or i
think this goes the same place as long
as you're in your personal account but
if you go to the top right corner and go
to settings and if we go to the left
hand side to plans
what we'll see is this kind of bar meter
here so it says open source but this is
actually the basic plan so there's a bit
of inconsistency with the naming here i
believe you know if we go to
uh maybe here if we just open this in a
new tab
um it doesn't show it here if we go here
to this pricing tab so this says basic
right and so it says 50 hours and just
going over here notice it just says open
source so
for whatever reason there is just that
minor inconsistency but understand that
is the basic plan but if you notice here
it says upgrade your plan to get more
hours parallel workspaces those
remaining hours
43.6 and so i've been using this quite a
bit and it hasn't been running out which
is really nice um is this present
anywhere else no so i was looking
through like the get pod interface or
command pals and things like that to see
if it would be displayed somewhere else
it isn't uh anywhere else uh as of yet
um i'm i could imagine that they might
want to do that in the future but for
the time being uh this is where you're
gonna have to find it but honestly like
again i'm just running this and never
really knows so if you are uh hitting
this limit then you probably do want to
upgrade because you're using it very
seriously uh but there you go okay
[Music]
so gitpod also offers team pricing so
team pricing uh or a team plan is for
organizations to pay on behalf of their
team members to centralize billing to a
single account so the idea is you say i
need x amount of members
uh for uh this type of plan and that
will be for your teams and so you can
also set the currency there's nothing
else that is um available around team
pricing it's just a way of centralizing
your billing maybe in the future they'll
add more particular things just for
teams but for the time being this is
what it is okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at self-hosted git pods so
git pod oss or
open source that's what the oss stands
for allows organizations to self-host
their own gitpod platform on their own
private networks so getpod is built on
top of kubernetes and the short form of
communities is k8 so and it has
deployment instructions for
a various amount of managed k8 services
so to list a few we have google
kubernetes engine so gke
lightweight kubernetes so k3s elastic
kubernetes service so eks
azure kubernetes service aks
rancher kubernetes service rks but i
think that it's going to work on
anything that has kubernetes so
you know if digitalocean has an offering
or vaulter has an offering
or you're running your own kubernetes
cluster you know on a virtual machine i
imagine that you could probably do it
for self-hosted offers
what you're going to get are the public
and private repos integrations will get
lab github and bitbucket unlimited
pre-built shared workspaces snapshots
admin dashboard so basically everything
if there's something that's not in there
i'm not sure what is not being listed
but it seems like everything you get in
get pod i o self-hosted is offered in
two tiers the open source so the first
registered users are free and then
professional exceeding 10 users you need
to pay for professional plans so to
upgrade to professional you need to
obtain a license and one question i have
and i have this question because this is
the same thing with
terraform cloud where they have
something similar after you exceed a
certain amount you are paying
but the thing is do you pay for the
first 10 users i don't know i could not
definitively answer that question for
you i'm going to lean on the side that
yes when you are when you
cross over to the 11th user you've got
to get your professional key you're
going to be paying for 11 users which i
think is fair because it's not like it's
going to be super expensive and at that
point you should be able to pay for them
but i don't definitively know okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
looking at get pods security so gitpod
employs a variety of security controls
and security best practices so let's
take a look at this so the first is
compliance if you're not familiar
compliance it's basically compliance
programs that are industry standard or
best practices and you have like a
third-party company that does a
testament to say yes this company is
meeting those requirements and then they
get a certificate to prove it that they
they are doing that stuff so one thing
is git pod is sock to compliant and so
this ensures your service providers
securely manage your data to protect the
interests of your organization and
privacy of its clients so this is a
really good thing to have it's also
really
expensive so you know that they're
taking security very serious a lot of
times you'll see the iso 2701 with this
as well but you know this is good the
other one they have is gdpr so
um the gdpr is guidelines for the
collection and processing of personal
information from individuals who live in
the european union
so basically everybody is being gdpr no
matter where they are in the world
because it's the internet and anyone can
be from uh from europe coming onto your
website so this is pretty common so it's
good to see that they just mentioned
that there
so we have environment isolation so get
pod workspace or prebuilds run on a
secured single use container separate
user
pid
mount and network namespace for each
gitpod workspace stress test namespace
layering implementations by third party
company kin can volkswagen companies
specializing in kubernetes so i think
namespace layering is very important
because it just it is virtual isos
isolization between clients okay
then there's the fact that gitpod is
open source so open source allows for a
faster security feedback loop allows
gitpod partners customers or the
community at large to identify disclose
or contribute fixes to critical exploits
we have authentication and authorization
so getpod uses version control systems
uh single sign-on and you can apply
granular or fine-grain permissions based
on the providers integration options so
they're basically offloading that that
concern over to get lab github
bitbucket and you know those are very
large companies so you know their
practices are going to be very very good
uh we have integra or sorry uh
encryption so they have at rest
encryption so all data including
workspace backups and environment
variables are using advanced encryption
standards so
aes256 and then we have uh in transit
encryption so gitpod uses transport
layer security so tls so there you go
hey this is andrew brown and we're
talking about the security vulnerability
disclosure policy so if you believe you
have discovered a vulnerability privacy
issue exposed data or other security
issue relating to gitpod you can report
it via the security vulnerability
disclosure policy and you can read all
about it here it's a big document if you
want to have a fun time to read the
policy outlines the steps for reporting
to gitpod they pretty much say like hey
if you do report it you can do it and
you're not going to get in trouble
because a lot of people are concerned
that if they find a problem and they
report it that they're going to get in
trouble for doing that um just because
and so you know they kind of outline
that and just also give you a lot of
extra information there to report you
need to email gitpod providing as much
detail as possible to security at
getpod.io
uh some companies will have a form and
the language of this document suggests
that they do have a form but it turns
out it's just email so i imagine they
might have a form of the future but it's
you know email's fine too so there it is
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and i'm just on
the get pod website because i just
wanted to show you here at i o forward
slash security the kind of stuff that
they have here so they just say like who
is using get pod so you know it's safe
how many uh developers
companies are using so you understand
the scale of it
some of their principles uh that they
are uh considering or they are
implementing i should say uh so they're
secure by design uh about their
compliance the things that we already
covered in uh the lecture content um but
the thing that i just wanted to show you
here is the security vulnerability
disclosure policy because there is a bit
more there that just couldn't fit on the
screen so there's a bunch of stuff here
that you might want to read about the
interesting part is like safe harbor a
lot of people are concerned that you
know if they report a problem that they
might get in trouble for it but getpod
saying uh you know if you find a
vulnerability and you share with us
don't worry you're not going to be uh
getting in trouble for it uh and we just
want to make sure that you understand
that so that we encourage people to
submit things as you can see here it is
at security at get pod io if i click on
this there wasn't a form before
still no form it's just going to the
same place here so maybe eventually
they'll have a form but honestly all
forms do just kind of give you some
additional fields here uh you can just
basically write whatever you want in
there i guess they have uh thanks some
contributors here like sneak and get lab
and stuff like that but yeah that's
pretty much all you really need to know
for security okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at get pod support so git
pod has a wide range of
support options and so we're just going
to quickly go through the list here so
that you're aware of them nothing super
exciting but just making sure you know
what's there the first is documentation
so technical documentation describing
the various features of git pod we have
a change log so historically release
changes so it shows you features and bug
fixes there's a community form which is
just a discourse form
with community and official support we
have the discord server so this is a
chat server to interact with community
members and get pod employees in real
time we have the gitpod roadmap so this
is a github project which is basically a
kanban board showing planned
and upcoming features based on annual
quarters there's a status page so this
is an atlatian status page showing up
time and service interruptions for the
underlying infrastructure so like maybe
the k-day uh the kubernetes customers
running gitpod workspaces and the
getpodio platform that's probably what
it's for we have git pod or is our
github issues so open tickets for bugs
or feature requests directly on the open
source project
account settings so change email
settings notification settings nothing
super exciting there
obviously you can change your plans so
that's another option as well and then
there's the sales support form so send
an email to gitpod's sales team about
self-hosting educational discounts
reselling or other gitpod does not have
a paid tier support or direct toll-free
number for individuals however
enterprises may inquire about additional
levels of support after contacting sales
because if you're a bigger company
they're probably going to roll out the
red carpet for you but they just don't
say like explicitly hey this is the tier
that we offer and things like that okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are on
the support page here ford slash support
because i just wanted to show you some
of the varieties of support that you can
utilize so the first thing is we have a
status page here so we go ahead and open
that up we're going to see it's kind of
an uptime uh here they're using the
atlatian status page so a pretty common
one here to just kind of show you
what's going on here so if you look at
workspaces we see operational here's
some part partial outage
and more of some partial outage here you
can see the duration here
um says in the u.s region so clearly
they're operating in multiple regions
here i've never ever ever experienced
any kind of problems uh working with
github but it's really nice to see they
have this status page uh here a
workspace stuck uh stuck in stopping
okay so you can see that there's some
information so that's kind of
interesting
um you know if you go to contact support
i don't know if this is just email so oh
we have a form here so you can see
report reviews billing educational uh
discount verification subhosted git pod
it looks like some of the context
changes a little bit here so you go
ahead and fill that in and send that
over
um we have the change log we just go
ahead and open that up so this is gonna
just tell you what they've been uh
adding to the product so here on october
14th we have introducing teams and
projects so these are basically linking
to blog posts just talking about what
has been released down below you can see
the fixes and improvements so it's not
just features but it's also bug fixes
there if you open that up you can see
that it is all on github so again it is
an open source project so that's really
great there too
if we go to the community forum that is
in discourse um now i've yet to sign up
for oh sorry this is discord um and i do
actually have that this is over
[Music]
um i'm just gonna pull it up here in a
moment so this is over here i'm not sure
what i'm looking at here but um you know
here is the get pod so i'm actually uh
sitting in this here as well and talking
as i work on this course i've been
updating the uh build in the open here
so they're very active and this is a
great way in real time to connect with
um get pod employees developer advocates
and get help there or get directed to
different kind of support options
um
the
uh the form is really good too this is
community forum this is discourse
oh i thought i clicked this does this go
to the right place let me click that
oh i think i found a bug i think i found
a bug so in this case what i'm going to
do is just take a screenshot here
and i think someone just has a missed
link here so we'll go down below and
we'll go to support i'm just gonna say
here
you know i think this is supposed to
link
to the discourse
but it's going to the discord
and that's a fair that's a fair uh issue
there just because like discourse and
discord are very similar so it wasn't me
what happens if i go here
no see that's goes the chat so that's
going to the wrong place
unless i got rid of the discourse
get paw discourse
let me try this again
discourse form
oh okay so i think maybe they retired it
which is totally fine um honestly
it doesn't say here but honestly like i
found that like i didn't really have a
use case for the discourse i'd rather
just be in the discord where is real
time
i'm not going to go back to my course
and update that because i'd rather just
leave this in here just to kind of show
that that is
a edge case there so i probably what's
going to happen is it'll end up just
changing that wording here to discord
and then that confusion will be gone but
there was a discourse at one point and i
was pulling some kind of information
from it but you know honestly again i
prefer just to do everything on discord
let's go take a look at the get pod road
map so this is just a project here
we go over here to the top notice this
git pod io road map you go here you can
see all of their
getpod repositories did not know you
could put a readme there that's really
nice but down below you can see all
these here right
and so if we go back and go to the
getpod product roadmap you can kind of
see what's being worked on at the
current moment so we are in uh q4 and so
we see introduced project level
environment variables team pricing
jetbrains remote development support
image layers faster workspace startups
which honestly they're really fast to
begin with but if they can make them
faster that's great and future stuff so
that's a great way to just kind of see
what is coming
down the road
in terms of git pods so that is really
nice as well
we saw the status page if you want to
report a bug it's going to probably take
us to the github yeah that goes there so
if we open that up i think it might just
pre-populate some text for us yeah so it
has some nice boxes for us
um this is not the discussion these are
just forms so that looks really good so
we'll go back here and um we'll go all
the way back
and then you get to self-hosted thing or
your account settings not so much to
look at the account settings as we've
seen this quite a few times in this
course so really they're just like
talking about like notifications like
what do you want to turn off which there
aren't a lot of options there or
managing your plan right there's not
really support within the get pod i o
per se you always have to reach out to
the discord and stuff like that click on
help this just goes back to the support
page but that gives you an idea of the
level of support and honestly it's a lot
it's really great so and i said this
also you know in the in the lecture
content but you know if you are an
enterprise
i would imagine you just reach out and
you know if you're if you are large i'm
sure you'll get a direct phone call with
git pod and they probably would create
some kind of custom
support plan for you
but they don't you know they just don't
say it here on the pricing okay so i
just talked to them i said yeah if
you're if you are an enterprise would
you do some kind of deal and they're
like yeah of course we would do
something you know um but they just
don't show it as a as like a lot of
places we'll have like a fifth box
saying like contact us okay but there
you go all right so i just want to show
you the support in action so it was
actually really great that uh this uh
this happened because i can just show
you like i just went here into the
discord i opened a ticket it became a
thread i went into here you can see
pauline said check out the announcements
over the announcements and i i assume
that it was rolled into it and so we go
over to our announcements here and you
can see that uh you know they've said
that they've um they've they've uh
you know
have archived the discourse and so now
they want to make the discord the future
home and again i think that is the right
place for it so i'm really happy with it
if you're looking for the old stuff
because there is some stuff in there
that is good but probably by the time
you watch this video you might not be
interested but they did go and archive
all the old stuff here so it is still
accessible it's just read only on the
wayback machine uh but yeah it was a
great opportunity to uh see that in
action so there you go
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at git pod open source so
get pod open source is a combination of
open source projects built by get pod
and so you know when i was looking at
the uh github repos i just noticed that
there's more than just one and so
there's one called
werft
and this is a kubernetes native
continuous integration system we have
leeway this is a heavily caching
build system for go yarn docker projects
dazzle this is a experimental docker oci
image builder its goal is to build
independent layers where a change to one
layer does not invalidate the one
sitting above it and then there's open
vs code server which is a fork of
uh the vs code
project there and so
um you know we don't really need to know
much about these here
but this is the one that we really care
about because this is pretty much
what powers get pod i o okay that's what
get pod io's it's it's a um
a managed version of this and so we're
gonna give extra attention to that one
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and i just want
to uh poke around here on the get pods
um team or organizational page that is
on github so that's at github.com
forward slash get pod hyphen io and it
just shows to show like how much stuff
they're doing with open source so they
have 159 repositories that you can see
who in their organization is there if
you want to reach out or just kind of
learn more about get pod
you can even sponsor them if you want
because again it's open source projects
so that is an option to you uh get pod
does make uh money on their uh platform
side but you know helping in either way
can always help out uh there is projects
i think this is like a new feature of
github which i don't really understand
as of yet so here's a project and they
have a bunch of itemized items like a
road map here don't fully understand it
but that's kind of interesting there but
we
go into the repositories and there is a
lot you can see all sorts of things i
think the reason why there's so many is
because all of their templates live here
so we looked at the quick start template
so just understand that's why it's so
large but the main one here is get pod
here at the top so we'll open that up
and we'll take a look at the website
here um
and we'll just go and take a look so
here's git pod so get pod automates the
provision of ready to code developer
environments so this is going to be for
the actual platform right so i believe
that when you want to uh self host this
is the repository you're going to be
using
this is the same experience you get when
you go to getpod.io so it will give you
that gui and also this interface here
this thing the underlying thing is based
off um the open vs code server which
we'll look at separate uh in another
video because i actually want to show
you how to run that on your own um but
yeah this thing is here how you use this
i don't know i guess we'll have to look
that uh look at that if we do show the
self hosted git pod option i'm going
over to the website basically anything
that you see on the website in terms of
the documentation you can absolutely
contribute to so like let's say we go to
get pod i o uh forward slash docs i
believe
and we go to some page like configure
here um if you go and click edit and get
pod
this will launch this environment if you
look up here you can see
oh it went too quick there but you can
see it's loading up the website here so
we'll just give it a moment
okay
and actually this might be a great
opportunity for us to correct that
discourse option right because
they
no longer have discourse which is
totally fine and it's discord so maybe
through here we can help with that
language so we saw it on the support
page
and i'm just wondering how we could go
find that so
[Music]
and you know i'm not that familiar with
it but i'm good enough that i can kind
of make my way around here
so if i go to
let's say
contents
there's probably a global way we can
search
so we'll go here and i'm going to go to
find in files and we'll just type in
discourse
we found the discourse logo support ts
so i feel like it is here
okay and
if i go over here
oh look it's oh no it's not missing it's
just me so this is community forum if
you're looking for help with common
requests connect with our community on
discord
okay
and then so from here i'm going to just
change that so
use discord instead of discourse
okay and then we're going to go ahead
and commit that
and we will sync those changes the thing
is is that we can't push to main we'll
need to have our own fork which is
totally fine so i'm hoping it'll
prop up and say hey you need to
have your own fork so
is not accessible please grant necessary
permission so let's say open access
um
so i guess we kind of have to make our
own fork here i think that's what we're
gonna have to do
so what i'm gonna do here is go back and
i'm just gonna go and fork this uh
here so where's my fork here we go fork
but just kind of show you like how you
can contribute to get pod which is kind
of interesting so now we have the
website ourselves and we are going to go
ahead and just close these out and
reopen this here
now if you're watching this of course
you don't have to do this just because i
would have already made the change but
it doesn't hurt to go through this
process to show you so again i'm going
to go to the top left corner here we're
going to go file
and we're going to say find in files or
whoops edit
find in files
discourse
we'll go to support here
and there are a few here that still say
discourse but we really want discord
so we'll just switch that over to
discord i'm going to go over here to the
right hand side and did i save that file
i did
there we go so we'll just say
change wording from discourse
to discord
and we'll save that
and we will sync those changes and we'll
say okay and before we open or like we
submit our pull request we should
probably open a ticket so here on the
main one
we'll go over to issues we'll open up a
new tab
and i'm just going to open a new ticket
here and we're going to file a bug
report i'm going to open up get pod io
forward slash support here
actually i want to keep that other tab
open so just keep it there for a second
and
oh sorry we want to go to get pod io for
slash support
and i'm just going to take a screenshot
here
okay we'll go back over this ticket
and
um
so i'll just paste that in there so
we'll just say
um
gitpod is no longer using
using um discourse so the wording
here needs to be changed
to discord
all right um and sometimes i'll say like
show the example so what we'll do is
just go ahead and grab that link here
paste that on in um
it requires all the other ones here i
don't like that they i mean this is not
uh git pod but like they've kind of
forced these parameters
so say um
git cloud support page should say
discord instead of
discourse
okay and then i'm just gonna grab
flamingo emoji i'm gonna be like the
worst person ever and just kind of like
phone it in
the whole point of those boxes to make
sure you do it right so we'll just say
that
we'll put in those
anything else
okay
and we'll go ahead and submit that
ticket because i just need an issue so
when i submit it i can tie it to that
right so now i have this uh pound seven
one one three and so what i'll do is go
back to mine and so now it says uh you
know your branch is up to date
and i want to go to pull requests here
um
you know what i didn't make a fork
that's what i should have done so if i
go back over here we're gonna just stop
this here i'm gonna go get checkout
hyphen b
and we're gonna just say uh discourse
old wording
and then i'm just going to push it
allow
and uses a good habit to put the id name
in there but i didn't do that which
which is totally fine
and so we'll see if it allows us to just
push
seems to be doing some kind of
diagnostic i'm not exactly sure why not
sure what that is for but what i'm going
to do is go back and refresh here
because i did this recently but it seems
like there's been a few changes here and
so i'm just not exactly familiar with it
just yet
so it looks like the branch was pushed
if i go back here and give this a
refresh
the branch should show up um
[Music]
so say old and notice like that some
people are putting the numbers in there
so that's a good thing to do but we'll
just say uh disc discourse old wording
and so i want to
uh
merge this in so i think if i go back to
the original git pod here
and
uh we make a pull requests
let's say new pull request here
and notice this is main and main so
compare main and
um i want to do it for mine so we'll say
old
uh compare cross forks we'll click there
okay i could probably done it from here
again it's just it's always a little bit
confusing you just have to kind of be
doing this on a regular basis if you're
not doing open source a regular basis
can get confusing so
compare the base to here i think we want
the one on the right hand side here so
we'll say old
um get pod or discourse
oh i have to change this to my
repository
so oh and i'm in i'm in the wrong one
i'm supposed to be in website
okay so we'll go back here lots of
mistakes on my part here but not a big
deal because usually it'll it'll pop up
sometimes and say hey do you want to
make this pull request or something but
we'll say new pull request
and
it's not showing my old ones but what
we'll do is
compare across forks again
and i'm going to say for that branch
there discourse
oh i'm not choosing my darn branch
there we go okay
let's just me creating so much trouble
so i don't want to do it against maine
because that's not proper you're always
supposed to do it from a feature branch
or whatever kind of branch you want to
call so we'll call discourse here
there it is
and so now what i'll do is go ahead and
create a pull request
we have some text in here and so what i
want to do is link the related issue so
it fixes if we go back to did i open
this in the right place
oh i opened this to the wrong
place oh
sorry
this is supposed to be
open on the website okay
all right that's embarrassing so now
what i got to do
i'm rolling my eyes if you can't see it
but what i got to do is go back to the
website here
i can do the second take of this so this
is the take you're going to get for this
video
but
we'll go ahead and we'll open this issue
again we'll say um
doc feedback
okay this is a lot easier to work with
here
um so we'll type in https forward slash
forward slash get pod io forward slash
support
i'm just gonna go grab that again so
we'll say
get pod i o four slash support
okay and we'll just paste that on in
there like that
and we'll just say um
uh gitpod no longer
uses discord or sorry discourse so the
text here needs to change from discourse
to discord because that's where it does
actually redirect to
and uh
change wording
from discourse to discord
we'll submit that
and so there is our ticket now we have
our issue so we'll go back to our pull
request and we'll say this fixes that
so we'll go over here they'll link to
that
renaming
discourse to discord
on support page
there are still
other lingering cases
but i was just showing
this for the purpose
of a video demonstration
okay so go ahead and create that pull
request
and so there i've contributed to the get
pod open source um so you know hopefully
that gives you kind of an idea of like
the ecosystem here and why it's valuable
because you don't have to wait on get
pod you can start to take action or dig
into things but uh yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at openvs code server so
openvs code is a version of visual
studio code that runs a server on remote
machines allowing access through a
modern
web browser so git pod and github code
spaces uses the same architecture at
scale so open vs code server can be run
on a linux machine so a virtual machine
or on a docker
as a container so here's an example if
you wanted to start it on a virtual
machine and here's an example of you
wanting to start it on docker and
actually uh when git pod first came out
before they had the i o offering this is
what i would use to try to launch
my own
vs code on aws and it worked i just
wasn't able to figure out how to make
the space the the server turn off
reliably where getpodio has clearly
solved that in a very intelligent way
so just to clarify you have the vs code
as open source you have open vs code
server which is a fork that's built on
top of the vs code open source code base
then there's the open vs code which is
used within git pod and other tools
which that's where we get gitpod.io the
gitpod platform okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're
taking a look at openvs code server and
so this is a fork uh developed and
maintained by gitpodio so here you can
see the original fork is vs code by
microsoft and so this one was modified
uh just to give you a bit more
flexibility
and the key thing is that this is what
gitpod is using so if you want to
run your own uh openvs code server it's
not too hard uh but you know if you
really do just need an environment to
work with your team strongly recommend
just using the getpod
platform itself but you know for
whatever reason if you want to know how
to do this i figure it doesn't hurt to
show you how so there are two ways to
run it via docker and linux linux is the
easier way to get going so that's what
i'm going to show you here today so i'm
here in my aws account and i'm going to
make my way over to ec2 and you can do
this for anything whether it's azure or
gcp or any platform as long as you can
run a virtual machine but i'm just going
to use a best because that's what i'm
most comfortable with so i'm going to go
ahead and launch a new instance here i'm
going to choose an amazon linux 2
instance which is generally recommended
i'm choosing a t3 micro here but any
size will do these small sizes work
pretty great here and the key thing that
i need to do here is make sure that i
have an i am role that has permissions
to sessions manager i'm just going to
open this up really quickly if you're
not familiar with this stuff here
i just want to show you if you go ahead
and create a role
all i'm doing here is typing in ssm
whoops uh maybe uh sorry create a role
here i thought i already clicked it
and so you'd say for ec2 you go next
and we would go ssm here
and in here we would want to get access
for um
amazon ec2 roll i think this one is old
so you have to use this one instead
which is not a big deal i think i'm
using that anyway so you create a role
with that permissions and that's what we
are attaching here
uh as our role and that's gonna allow us
to do sessions managers so we don't have
to use um ssh keys or things like that
but once you have that there we'll go
over to our security groups we're gonna
have to open port 3000 i think that's
what it runs on default actually i think
it's port 8000
so we will open that up um and we'll go
review and launch we'll say launch we
will launch with no key pairs so proceed
without a key pair because we do nee do
not need one here and we'll give it a
moment to launch so we'll go here and
click on the instance itself and so
it'll take a little bit time to launch
they're not too long but what we're
going to need to do is go get the latest
uh downloads if you just open this up in
a new tab under linux
you scroll on down you'll notice we have
arm64 arm hf x64 or x64 is for the i
guess the intel chip and these are arm
chips so uh since we launched a virtual
machine that's uh on the x64
architecture that is what we're going to
be using so here i'm just copying the
link address because if you look at it's
a raw raw link directly to the tar atar
is like a zip file or an archive
but once this is running and usually we
wait for the two status checks to pass
but i'm just going to go ahead and
connect because i think it will work
we're just going to connect with
sessions manager that's why we set up
that i am role with um
ssm the
simple systems manager access to
sessions manager and so this is going to
open up a black screen
and from here i'm just going to type in
sudo hyphen ec2
uc2 user just because oops sudo su
hyphen ec2 user just because it always
starts us off as
a different kind of user and we want to
be the ec2 user here but what we can do
is type in wget space and we'll go ahead
and paste that link in and hit enter
that's going to download that tar there
i'm just going to type in clear just to
clear my screen to make things easier i
know the fonts a little bit small so
i'll try to bump it up here
um and so if we just have to untar it so
i always forget what to type here so
let's go ahead and copy that and we'll
paste that in there
and we will follow up with openvs code
server hit enter
and that's going to expand the archive
so we can go cd into that directory and
now it's just as simple as running this
period forward slash server sh so sh is
a bash command or bash script and so if
we do period it's equivalent of saying
like sh
like if you did it like this
but uh it's more popular to run an extra
cable like that so we'll hit enter and
that's going to start on port 8000 and
here it's going to give us a web uri so
we want this part of the url
whoops i didn't mean to click it through
there hold on here it doesn't make it
too easy to click but if we just
shrink our font there go back to our
instance we want that public ip address
i'm going to go ahead and grab that
paste it on in here and then i just need
the end so just go ahead and grab that
and try to copy it it doesn't make it
easy to copy so you might have to open
your browser like this
and
we'll go back over here paste that on
there and it should hopefully work
fingers crossed
um port 8000 cannot be reached so just
double check make sure that is correct
looks okay to me
we grab the public ip address so that
should be fine
oh i think we stopped the server by
accident
okay
i'm just seeing if it changed yeah it
did change i'm just gonna click that
again
okay so we just got to be really careful
there because i guess it's very finicky
still running okay good
and i just need to delete out
this part of it here yeah we know why
it's forbidden that's totally fine
okay and i think it's working we'll just
give it a moment
there we go so here's vs code it's or
openvs code
uh and so you know that's a way of
self-hosting i mean the thing is is that
you have a lot that you need to solve if
you do this like how are you going to
persist
uh your data so like you don't lose it
or how do you back it up how do you make
it intelligent so that it knows to turn
off when you are not uh using it i guess
there's a lot of things here you'll also
notice that it's a little bit different
from the one that uh um get pod uh uh
gives you so like notice it doesn't say
get pod on the bottom or have the
command palettes and things like that so
this is really just being able to run
the um
open vs code server okay like if you
needed this kind of editor here um but
anyway you know it is something you can
do and it's part of the get pod project
so i just wanted to make sure
uh that i showed you there let's go
ahead and shut down this ec2 instance so
we'll go ahead and just terminate that
instance there so let's say terminate
and
i'm pretty confident that it's
terminating so i'm i'm confident that is
going to be destroyed not worried about
it so yeah there you go openvs code